Hey, hey, hey.
Hey,
hey,
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Heat. N.
Heat. Heat. N.
Hey,
heat.
Heat.
Hey, heat. Hey, heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Hey. Hey. Hey.
3.
Hey. Hey.
Heat. Heat.
Let's
go.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Hey, heat. Hey, heat.
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah.
Want to join me? Come and play.
But I might shoot you in your face.
Bombs and bullets will do the trick.
What do we need here?
Do you ever
feel ignored?
So can you try a little harder?
I'm really getting bored.
Come on, shoot faster. Just a little bit
of energy. I want to try something
better now. I get some people going.
Let's move this into my shirt and see
what
it's pathetic.
But not for long. You'll get kinkedked.
So much better.
So much fun.
Let's scratch
blow up the sun.
Come on, shoot. Just a little bit of
energy. I want to try something better
now. I get some people.
Let's move this
and see what papa thinks. It's such
neatness, but not for long cuz you'll
get
When darkness falls,
you are my light.
You take my hand.
and hold it tight.
You are my home.
I know it now.
Don't let me go.
We're safe and sound.
I see your beauty shine.
You radiate with light.
Our hearts dance and twine.
You're one of a kind.
and feel my heart.
We're never lost.
Even when I'm gone,
I circle around
from near and far
above the flower bed.
As we watch the stars, I'll never be
lost.
You are my home.
You feel my pain.
My soul is yours.
Two souls the same.
With you, I'm everything.
You never asked me to change a thing.
They set our world on fire, but our
hearts will burn for miles. I see your
beauty shine.
You radiate with
our hearts dancing.
You're one of a kind.
Stars shining with us. Your fire is
contagious.
I feel the moon on our skin. Love glows
out. Love your eyes shining through me.
Light the way that we can see.
Feel the warmth of my love.
Shine
and feel and feel
even when I'm
cles
from
above the flower
as we watch the sun will never be
Can you see my hand?
Oh,
hey.
Welcome everybody to day two of the
regional qualifiers for Riftbound here
in Bologna, Italy. It is a beautiful
city and a beautiful day to be
determining a top eight and then a
eventual champion here for the first
European regional qualifier for Europe.
I am James joined by Leonard Kunig here
to walk you through the beginnings of
the day for day two. Uh Leo, it was a
great day one. Uh what are you looking
forward to today?
>> Well, can I say everything? There are so
many great players. have already been
going through the top tables of the
first round that I have seen. There's so
much diversity still, but there's of
course also so many talented
Riftbounders with Metadex live Dravenet.
I just can't wait to see them perform in
perfection. Yeah, we're down to 264
players currently in the tournament.
We're going to be whittling our way
through to uh you know a top 64. I
believe that's where the qualifications
for regional championships will end up.
Uh the other thing we're doing today of
course is five rounds of Swiss to
determine a top eight and that all
important champion of the event. Uh
there's a lot on the line today, a lot
in the way of prizing that we'll get to
as we get further through. So five
rounds of Swiss and then a top eight in
order to determine a winner. So we've
got the format there. Now we need some
players. We need to know who we're
watching for the rest of the day. So we
can take a look at our top players
coming out of eight rounds of Swiss
yesterday and uh not that many eight nos
left in the tournament. Only five so far
and there is uh quite a lot of Draven on
this list. Yep, definitely might be the
best deck. But on the second place you
see Ezreal, the Prodigil Explorer.
Wonder who that player might be. I think
that is one player that most of the
dedicated rift bounders already know.
Marcus Patel on the first place after
swift after day one. What else do we
have? We have some Aurelia and Kai'Sa is
not really having the best conversion
rate.
>> Yeah, that's a matchup that we're going
to I'm sure talk about a little bit
later. The Kaiser and the Aurelia uh
kind of when they head to head that does
tend to be a difficult matchup for the
Kaiser. So, not too surprised to see a
little bit of diversity just on the
outskirts, but the fact that 8 and0 in
the Swiss Draven dominating so far. Um,
I think as we get higher and higher up
the standings up through the the the
tournament. We might start seeing a
little bit of a struggle there, there's
I'm imagining a lot of Draven mirrors
about to hit us. So, we are likely to
whittle the pool down. But, we'll find
out through the rest of the day. See who
ends up in that top eight because there
is a lot on the line for players,
especially if you're not playing Draven
as well. If if you're looking for a best
of champion card or legend card, uh
there's quite a wide openen selection at
this point. So, when we look at pricing
for the event, of course, everybody is
trying to win the event. Become the
first regional qualifier champion. Take
that Blade of the Ruin King alternate
art card and playmat. Secure yourself as
the top of this the standings for this
event. But there's a lot still on the
line. Top eight promos, uh, prizes all
the way through to 32nd and of course,
best of prizing that we've talked about
all weekend. Absolutely gorgeous. all of
these cards, promos and playmats, but
yes, the best of There's only, I think,
three legends that are not in the
running anymore. So, we have so many
different legends that are still being
played in day two that still do have a
chance to make the top eight cut and so
many players going for these crazy metal
cards. We have seen different builds of
basically everything. Some people said,
"Okay, I can play some chaos decks and
I'm going to go for a more miracle
version of my deck where I have loads of
card draw. I'm playing Ezreal Prodigy."
But we also have had some dedicated
legend decks and I just I'm just excited
to see more. Yeah, that's been really
interesting. And you know what I I would
say one of the most interesting parts
about it is the fact that there are some
decks that we were like, well, Rumble,
you're only playing for a best off card.
You're not really playing for too much
more. Well, we cast a rumble yesterday
that made it through today, too. Uh, and
is looking pretty good. So, I saw a Lux
on the top table. Uh, I know we had
Renato Glask on the featured match
yesterday as well. So,
>> depending on, you know, who your
favorite legend is, there's no reason
not to try and get to the stage here at
a regional qualifier. And the way to do
that, oh, mine, I'm an AR player right
now, but I I'm sure when more and more
legends come out, some of my favorites
from League of Legends and Wild Drift
will end up having decks for themselves.
But if you want to get to the regional
qualifier stage yourself, there's a
couple ways to do it. Uh, and the best
way to do it to get yourself a little
bit of sleep extra on day one is to
enter a summoner skirmish. Uh, get the
win, get a round one by in a regional
qualifier and you can uh, you know, find
yourself here among the best players.
And also, it's first of all fun and
second of all great practice as well
because these are the more competitive
events of the two. Nexus, it's for fun.
Of course, you can try hard. Nobody is
stopping you. But in these skirmishes,
your local area rift bounders, they will
find each other there. And it's, you
know, it's going on there. I wish I
could say I'm an Nexus Knight, try
harder, but I'm I'm the person that lets
like a lot of takebacks happen and then
I go to time on my rounds. So, I'm I'm
the guy slowing down the tournament.
People like, "No, it's it's okay. You
I'll be nice. I'll be nice. Soon as the
summoner skirmish is on, I'm playing to
win." And it hasn't happened yet. So,
it'll be fine. We'll we'll make it work
uh at some point. But, you know, it's
not all about necessarily our
competitive prowess. Sometimes we do
look into the crystal ball of what we
think is going to be played at the
event. We did some predictions coming
into uh Bologna to to look at, okay,
which champions do we anticipate being
at the top. And I will say after day
one, I feel a little bit vindicated in
my Draven pick. It was the easy pick.
Like everybody expected Draven to be
good. Uh unfortunately, I would say we
haven't seen the the success for the
Fiora that you were expecting, Leo.
Yeah, thanks for the
>> Sorry, I know. I I couldn't I couldn't
really soften that blow a little bit.
No, I think the deck is still great. I
have been looking through those top
tables and I did not find too many Fiora
players. Actually, you're right about
that. So, maybe my point was a little
bit off that I made. We are seeing a
Kai'Sa that is almost still undefeated.
So, in those top 10 players, there's
still one Kaiser, which is not a lot
considering that, you know, it was the
second most played deck.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And I I was going to say
maybe it's actually that you've seen
something in Fiora tech that the players
haven't. So maybe next event grab
yourself that round one buy, go out onto
the floor uh and you can best off and
prove us all wrong. Uh at that point I
think I I'm hoping we're just about
ready to get ourselves into the action.
So you talked about Kaiser and Civ. That
was Medic and Amy's choices for the
event. How vindicated do you feel
knowing that both of these decks have
somewhat made it to day two?
Yeah, overall pretty vindicated. I'm
going to be honest. Civ bringing 10
players into day two here at RQ Bologna.
I still am quite sad that no or players
made it through. I do think that Barrett
when he reached out to me and asked me
to cast knew that I would be the on
player that made day two and so was just
trying to bring on down generally as a
as a meta as a a staple in the game.
>> Yeah. But yeah, I mean, you know, when
when someone as as prevalent and
fantastic as you as an or player uh
steps into the room, you have to expect
that something needs to knock you down.
They can't let you just waltz into the
event, win, and go home. Right.
>> Exactly. I'm Or is a great walter as
well, like the Cha 2. You went for the
Kaiser, I believe. Yeah. 31 players have
made it into day two overall.
>> 31. And they're in a really strong
position as well. We've got some Kaiser
players doing really well. I'm really
proud. I still think that having the
advantage of having that much practice
with Kaiser through set one uh through
to set two here in Spirit Forge is where
she shines. And I I'm still really
confident that the Kaiser players can
bring it home.
>> I definitely see a Kaiser making it into
our top eight. I I think that would be
pretty expected at this point. Wouldn't
be surprised if we have about half
Dravens as well. I believe our games are
ready. Round nine of the regional
qualifier here in Bologna getting
underway. Players with 18 points from
day one qualified. We have 246
players I think making it through. The
exact correct math would be 252. And on
your screen you can see the Civ
extraordinaire himself not playing Civet
for this tournament. Said he doesn't
like it playing only best of two in
rounds. So is moved over to Draven. It
is Randy.
>> It is indeed. And we've seen much of
this glorious executioner across the
weekend thus far. But they are no short
of tricks up their sleeve as we go into
this interesting matchup which I wasn't
expecting to see today. And I'm very
pleased because I'm not quite sure how
Draven will react. Draven has a lot of
kind of recursion and a lot of buffs,
lots of ways to make units bigger, lots
of surprises, but I'm not really sure
how it fares into this matchup when
you're looking at the loose cannon of
Jinx.
>> Yeah, Leela Eisman here on the Jinx.
Something we did see at the end of
yesterday using that last rights later
on into the game to try and recycle out
of your trash. The edge of knight as
well, a really nice hidden card that can
allow you just to play some tricks on
your opponents. But we'll see how
effective it can be. We talked a little
bit yesterday. Jinx Legend immediately
puts your mind into a very specific
position. It says, "Oh, I want to be low
on cards in hand." But when you have
this chaos core, when you have all of
this card draw, you don't actually need
to be in that spot. you use the Jinx
Legend as a bonus rather than a
requirement to play the deck.
>> Yeah, there's no point in pigeon holing
yourself. You might as well say, well,
it's a nice effect if it can happen, but
it's not the be all and end all. It's
the most important thing. But I think
that's where, you know, where Draven
does have the slight advantage when
you're looking at this matchup just on
paper is that that legend effect is so
strong with being able to do lots of
combat. We love combat and Jinx does
fall into that trap a little bit. Jinx
plays a lot of little units at the
beginning and Draven's like, "Ooh,
delicious." And they they really can
take kind of a bit of a lead with that,
draw lots of cards and hopefully get
into what they need to just ramp up. So,
when I'm thinking about how this would
work out on paper, my brain does go to
think, oh, okay, Draven does have the
advantage here. But then again, Jinx
does work in these es and flows. You
need those kind of small units just to
score a couple of early points and just
get the ball rolling. and then you take
those big popoff turns.
>> 100% agree. I think the risk for Jinx is
you are playing into a miracle variant
Draven here. One Rasa in the list, the
VI as well for that, you know, really
finishing moves. So, it's hard when
you're playing into a deck list that is
a little bit more aggro focused, a
little bit less consistent generally
miracle over mid-range, but the ability
to get a lot of units out early really
shines and get through your cards really
quickly in this Draven deck. And Randy
obviously an experienced competitor. We
saw him over in the Chinese regionals.
Made it to semifinals over there on his
civil list here. Bringing out the
Draven. Something a little bit more
consistent for him. Something where you
don't have to memorize your entire deck
in every round, which makes things a bit
easier when you play for 12 hours
yesterday.
>> Yeah, it's a they're long days and our
competitors have been doing such a
fantastic job so far. We were in here
quite late last night and so coming back
this morning getting back into the fray
is honestly very very exceptional for
all of them. And this just goes to show
how high level of competition really is
a endurance battle as well as knowing
your matchups and your deck. It's
actually a lot about kind of the
physicality of being here in person. But
let's jump straight into the game as
David goes in starting us off with the
loose cannon jinx and of course just
with a treasure hunter there to start
things off which is a very typical play.
That's exactly kind of what we want
those low power units and hopefully
Draven won't be able to draw too many
cards off of defeating them.
>> Yeah, we have resource down towards the
bottom side. Forge of the fluffed as our
top side battlefield. It's when you
control your legends have tap attach and
equipment which is very strong when
you're looking for things like edge of
knight uh in this Jinx deck. It also
works with long swords, can work with a
spinning axe as well if you do control
that battlefield. Turn one for Randy, a
stacks deck into a noxious hopeful for
might really early on. And this is what
this deck does so well. You have these
very cheap spells that let you cycle
through your deck and then afterwards
you can get things like the noxious
hopeful out just to have great power
early doors. Treasure hunter down onto
Zorn Warren have the draw discard
and we'll see where David decides to go.
Discard draw is the ordering on it.
We'll see where David decides to go with
that discard. Yeah, it's a tricky one
here because again you you you kind of
don't want to give easy
KOs for Draven. You don't want to really
leave things in there, but you need to
get the ball rolling. You need to score
points. So, we have to move it really.
We go for the stack deck there off the
cool shot. Okay. Oh, okay. We're playing
the super mega death rocket, which I do
like in this matchup because it does
allow you to have some removal, but it's
quite expensive and a little too early
to be employing those. Yeah, it does
mean you can recycle them as well or get
them back into your hand. Recycle
obviously being a key word doesn't
really mean the same thing here, but the
ability to do five damage to a unit,
discard a card, get it uh conquer, then
discard a card, get it back into your
hand allows you to get through things
like these noxious hopefuls as the game
goes on. We see the Siren coming down as
well to avoid those combats that you
were talking about. In the Aurelia
decks, we see it used to get that extra
might onto the Aurelia and get her into
strong positions. But here, getting the
treasure hunter off the Zorn Warren
means that Randy will get himself his
first point and then go through his
discard draw as well. You can tell both
these players very experienced going
making it very obvious what triggers are
happening, at what point, discarding the
scrap heap to get another card in hand.
We have
>> Ezreal. Ezreal. A nice shout right here
again getting that draw engine on board.
both players kind of opting for this
kind of Ezreal draw engine at this stage
and it it's really strong. We we know
it's strong. Ezreal in their own right a
great deck but actually just employing
it in so many others. The flexibility of
Chaos is kind of shining through in this
matchup as both players employ this
engine.
>> It's just so good the ability to get
towards that one of Rasa that Randy has
in the main has the boots of swiftness
in hand right now. The uh I like that no
sofa was kind of stranded a little bit.
Obviously things like fight or flight
can can negate those combats. You can
just leave it out there. Traveling
merchant will be the play though instead
for now. So we're just going to have
that noxious hopeful on its lonesome.
Very hard for the treasure hunter to get
through it. David, you don't really want
to invest a lot of resources into
killing something like a noxious hopeful
this early on. And we'll see where he
decides to go. Is running demolitionist
as his champion unit. We saw Jinx rebel
a couple of times yesterday. But
Demolition is still a great chosen
champion in their own right. So we've
got a lot of kind of flexibility there.
We did see I think once yesterday we saw
Demolitionist like near the end of the
day. I think it's becoming a more
popular pick.
>> Yeah, we're going to rocket the Ezreal
here.
>> Ooh, okay.
>> I I really like this as a play. Uh one
of the strengths of Ezreal obviously in
these chaos decks is the ability to get
cold shot out for one power. You get
those repeat costs in really easily.
Also can work through accelerate costs
like Kaiser uh survivor when she comes
into the battlefield. So get rid of the
Ezreal, avoid some of that extra card
draw that comes from the cord shot or
the extra pressure that can come from a
survivor. Treasure hunter going to the
forge. Ferris 4runner being discarded on
the conquer allowing the super mega
death rocket to come back
>> and go again. We can just going straight
back.
>> I think he was showing. I was going to
say I didn't think we have enough for
that.
>> Yeah. So recurring the super mega death
rocket. And that's why I like this in
this matchup is because you can at least
deal with those slightly smaller units.
does five damage to a unit which is very
substantial when you're into when you're
looking at Draven because it does take
out all of those slightly smaller units
even the Nox is hopeful.
>> Importantly doing it outside of
Battlefields as well because one of the
risks when you play into a Draven deck
is they attack and you have four damage
that you can put onto it and it's like
oh well on the attack trigger I'm just
going to recycle a fury rune. I go up to
six might
>> and then that's no good.
>> Yeah. And then you're not able to
actually kill off the Draven. So really
like the fact he can do it outside of a
battlefield. Another stack deck being
played by David. Looking through going
to Siren back to treasure hunter again.
We talked about avoiding combat.
Avoiding combat. It's exactly what you
want to do into Draven. You are a little
bit low on units for David. Been playing
a little bit more removal in this early
game, but has has gone through a couple
of stack decks. So, will be getting
towards the cards that they want for
later portions of the game.
>> Okay, we managed to grab the last rights
there. Not super useful right now, but
honestly not a bad time to start
thinking about the recursion of the deck
kind of with the removal that has taken
uh place on David's turn. It was, you
know, a little bit a little bit scary
for early game Draven, but again,
there's just so much card draw here.
You're able to kind of just cycle
through and get your get yourself out.
We get the whole Oh, we get the conquer
point there from the movement and kind
of just storming ahead if you're Randy.
>> Actually, really interesting here. Randy
taking forge of the fluff means that he
can avoid the equip cost on last rights.
That recycle that you have to go
through. Going to cold shot first might
be looking towards that last right. So
that's cost three energy. So needs well
three of the four that he has remaining.
The cord shot here costing more because
that Azure was removed. That's two power
having to be invested. Another cord shot
going to the bottom. I wonder if I do
you really want a last right on
something like a hopeful?
>> I just don't think so. I don't know
>> if I'm going to put it on anything and
hopeful at least has four might. So at
least we're going in with something a
little bigger than sort of the tie
turner we saw yesterday with the last
rights on. But yeah, in this instance
it's looking like a possibility, but do
we want it now? Like are there is there
enough in the discard to bring back?
Ezreal obviously kind of feels good when
you want that extra card draw. You want
to keep going. The hand is looking okay.
We've got removal. We've got some fight
or flights. I think I saw in there and
we've got units. So, I mean,
realistically, card draw isn't the most
important thing right now, but
definitely important into a deck that is
trying to push you back.
>> Yeah, bringing back the Draven, uh,
bringing out the Draven and then back
the Noxious Hopeful. Just playing a
little bit more on the defensive, always
the risk that you lose the hopeful later
on and the ability to have 12 might with
which you can conquer, bolstered up by
that second ability on the Draven for
Randy on the next turn. David here one
point behind nothing too consequential
can try and trade into that traveling
merchant but problem with treasure
hunter is it has one might you can go to
those on warrants you have drawn quite a
few cards so the discard draw isn't
going to hurt you too much even look
towards discarding something like the
seal
>> is he he's looking at a a super mega
death rocket again
>> I think it you you're almost quite
strapped here you've got the last rights
but that's not super helpful right now
in any of your units. I think you've got
to kind of deal with the with the threat
that you were talking about earlier in
the base before Draven has the ability
to kind of buff itself up and make
itself bigger. You've got to deal with
that. And being able to attack a unit in
a base is such a powerful ability. We
quite often think that something is
safer in base than it is on a
battlefield. Well, not when Jinx is
concerned.
>> Yeah, Super the recursion on it as well.
Just so powerful in this position. And
honestly is why I was really surprised
we didn't see it yesterday. Um, you
know, if I was building Jinx, I'd be all
over those rockets. I love that you can
bring them back. You just have to
discard one. And I think that's I think
that's quite powerful. It's an expensive
>> kind of cost, but I mean, at the moment
for David, there isn't a whole lot else
going on. I'm going to be honest. Like,
we can play this Draven. We The last
rights doesn't really do much without
that. So, I feel like at this point, you
just need to start building up that base
while doing exactly what he's doing and
taking down the bigger threats on the
other side before they can advance and
get larger.
>> Yeah, I think the risk for David is if
you discard the Draven to get your two
mega death rocket back that can kill one
unit, right? You then you can play out
your last rights, but I don't think Oh,
you do have the uh the energy available
to play the last rights right now. And
then put the last rights on the treasure
hunter. Retreat it with the siren. You
have just enough energy to do that. Next
turn your treasure hunter goes in as
three. But if these Noxious Hopefuls are
split up across forge of the fluff and
across the Zorn Warren, then you don't
you can kill one of them and then
conquer get back the Draven. Kind of
makes sense. It's going to be a little
tricky to decide exactly how we want to
play it. There is the last rights.
Are we looking for the equip? You're not
going to equip and hold cuz you know you
lose out on that trade. You don't have
enough energy for super mega death
rocket and it's a slow spell. Can't be
played on your opponent's turn anyway.
Recycle the two to equip it to the
treasure hunter. Then we'll siren it
back. And then we're looking to see what
Randy does with these hopefuls. If they
both go to one battlefield, you can go
to the other. You now outmite the
traveling merchant. But if Randy buffs
up that traveling merchants battlefield
with the two noxious hopeless on the
other side, then you are struggling a
little bit cuz you have three might into
four. I guess you death rocket
whatever's sitting on the weaker side of
the board and hope that you are just
playing into that traveling merchant.
>> I like what David's done here bringing
the traveling uh sorry the treasure
hunter back with the last rights
probably trying to get the last right
effect on a conquer rather than a hold
point. Hold point is way too dangerous
against Randy right now. you just lose,
right? You're out of energy. All that
happens is a noxious hopeful comes in
and your unit dies, right?
>> So, you brought that back, protect it,
kind of
>> hold your stance a little bit more, and
then maybe super medic get death rocket
next turn if anything is in a
battlefield. But then if Randy doesn't
put anything in a battlefield, that is
just open and you can just go for the
conquer regardless. So, it kind of puts
Randy in an interesting position of
having to respond to this, knowing
there's a super mega death rocket in
hand. Having that hand knowledge in a
game like this is so imperative and it's
why we see cards that allow you to look
at your opponent's hand quite often
being incredibly powerful, but even
recursion effects like this do give it
away a little bit.
>> Yeah, it's about how Randy decides to
sack the battlefields and if he does as
well because in the end like the last
rights is recurring a Draven. Yes.
>> Right. That that's really all that you
want to get out of there. So he's like,
"Oh, can I deal with the Draven? If it
comes out, it's not the end of the
world. just still spending the four
energy off the last right. Going to play
our own
>> using the three there. Control forge of
the fluffed as well. So we can tap the
Draven to immediately equip. This is
what we were talking about a couple of
turns ago.
>> Go in as six towards this bottom
battlefield which gets you out of death
rocket range. Huge. And then the noxious
hopeful can bolster the defenses on the
side of the traveling merchant as well.
Uh but still the treasure hunter would
go in with the death rucker on that
noxious hope for to take the victory in
a combat allowing uh David's last
strikes to trigger.
>> Exactly. And that's what we're trying to
avoid here is just allowing David to
kind of bolster up units and have those
bigger turns with Jinx. We've got a lot
of gold tokens on the board. We got a
lot of what the resources we need, but
we just don't have the units right now
to back it up. And Randy does. That's
the thing. We we know that. Uh Randy
obviously has a lot in hand as well. Of
course, we're going in with the Ezreal
from the last rights, bringing that
back, getting that card draw. Absolutely
illustrious when you play discard one,
draw two. You really could not ask for
better.
>> Yeah, reducing the cost of those core
shots and accelerate units as well. If
you want no cord shots in hand right
now, I think it was an overzealous fan
sitting at the back alongside the Fizz
Batting Ram, Piercing Light,
>> uh the Swifties, and the was it a ride
the wind, I believe. Yeah, ride the wind
there as well. So, we have a couple of
uh tools. No energy up to use them right
now. So, if you're David, you are kind
of you're thinking, well, if this Noct
comes up to the top battlefield, can I
just uh death rocket it? We're going to
hide the fight or flight. Obviously, we
know exactly what that is. Could still
be something like a tide turner for
Randy that you need to be a little bit
more cautious around as David and we're
going to put the notches hopeful there
as well. So, really trying to mitigate
that ability for the treasure hunter to
take one of these battlefields.
Okay, David. Moving on. As David here,
it is now a little bit scarier. We've
we've kind of we've still got the super
mega death rocket, but and with a hidden
card, it kind of feels bad taking out
the Nox's hopeful, it becomes a little
bit trickier to sequence this turn in a
way that allows you to kind of get that
last rights trigger to be able to get
something back. And maybe we're thinking
too linear with that. Maybe he's got a
different plan and he's thinking about
kind of the long-term goals of the turd,
but I think realistically you have to
start getting units that are going to be
able to deal with this Draven deck in
its full ferocity. And that's what we're
seeing come alive now is the units are
getting bigger. The last rights is on.
We're looking for that whole point.
We're looking for the trigger and the
Ezreal in base. There's a lot going on
and we need to respond. So, we are going
to go for the doc's hopeful, but it
doesn't quite leave that battlefield
open yet cuz we still have the hidden
guard.
>> Death Rocket going down. David David
having a think about her. I you kind of
expect it to be a fight or flight. If it
is a tie turner, the Ezreal can come in.
You then trade with the Ezreal, but you
lose your treasure hunter. The only unit
you have right right now. Edge of Knight
being played just raw to get that extra
might on towards our treasure hunter.
Now we go in
just gives the plus two can usually be
hidden. Uh I think Randy asking exactly
how many runes do you have available
right now? It's three. Only one card in
hand for David and not the easiest thing
to do here. We're going to fight or
flight it back Randy.
>> I think that's the biggest treasure
hunter I've ever seen. Yeah,
>> like that is he's got so much equip.
He's hunted a lot of treasure and he's
put it all on.
>> Huge play though now for Randy. The
ability to hold both these battlefields.
>> Only one card in hand for Davy. He will
draw more on his turn obviously with the
Jinx Legend trigger. But
>> Randy wins the combat as well through
the fight or flight. So draws a card.
And now for David sticky situation.
Demolitionist going to come out.
>> I just don't know if it's enough. I I
think Ry's in such a dominating
position, especially taking these whole
points going up to seven. Like that is
phenomenal for him. And David's just
kind of sat on this back foot at the
moment. He might be able to make some
meaningful plays next turn, but if Randy
can build up this base even more, and we
know he's got some great resources in
hand to do so, some really big units.
Maybe we're a bit lacking on runes, but
I think at this stage it doesn't matter
too much. you're kind of in you're in
quite a gushy position right here to be
able to kind of push forward to those
eight points especially when David
doesn't really have a lot going on still
and I think that's what we saw from Jinx
yesterday where we kind of ran out of
steam we were able to keep up in the
early game the points were kind of
flowing and then as it got towards the
end of the game unfortunately the bigger
units from decks like Draven were just
able to overpower them and the death
rockets just weren't enough. Yeah, David
just hasn't really got the units this
game. We've seen that travel uh
traveling treasure hunter in fact just
on the board for the majority of the
game. You might wonder why it took Randy
a little bit of time to get his two
whole points there. The last rights
triggers goes off before you get the
points from the hold. So he needed to
pick what he was going to bring back.
Look through both the great uh the
trashes. Brings back the Draven. Didn't
play it to a battlefield. Interestingly
going for the well if I lose these
battlefields I can just conquer next
turn.
>> And I think that's the risk. David,
Randy just
rocket where it can target the base. So
Randy does have a little less
flexibility with that. So maybe pushing
into a battlefield isn't that bad
because it feels um almost just as
risky. Like it doesn't matter where they
are, but at least you're giving your
opponent more hoops to jump through and
that's all you're trying to do here.
>> Yeah. You don't want to give them the
combats, right? There's there's no
point. David's on three, you're on
seven. You only need that either a hold
point or two conquer points to win out
on the game.
>> Randy, it is going to chuck an
overzealous fan down on this noxious
hopeful. Very powerful in combination
with any other unit of the battlefield.
The ability just to sack it and bounce
something back. Especially when your
opponent only has two units, only has
two things that can push incomes very
hard for David.
>> And that's the thing. Rady's just like,
"It's okay. I'm on seven points now. All
I need to do is take these two
battlefields and the more units I have
in base to be able to be flexible with
next turn, the better. These guys don't
have ganking. They can't hop from
battlefield to battlefield.
>> So, if he leaves kind of what he's
hoping to move around next turn in base,
that's better. We're moving Ezreal up
just to pose a larger threat up there in
the forest fluff.
>> Yeah. It's also about making David have
to conquer two places. Yeah. Like if you
can hold one, you win the game. You
seven, you go to eight. That's how you
win. for David now he has to say well
this bottom one I kind of need to super
mega death rocket take something out and
then I I can play around this
overzealous fan but if I only go in with
two units I then lose the combat and
then I have to take out the top
battlefield as well forge of the fluff
so really difficult position here for
David kind of unfortunate in terms of
how many units they were able to get out
this game but it's one of those things
you know
>> it is and I feel like with this matchup
specifically as well like with Jinx you
are wanting to have that flurry of early
game units you want those really low
cost units that you can just swing out
on the board and you kind of you kind of
go in with this like just explosion of
units early on. But unfortunately that
benefits Draven.
>> Yeah, it does.
>> Draven loves combat. That's all he
wants. He's ready pretty early out of
the gate and with some bigger units as
well. So, it just feels disadvantageous
for David at this point because not only
did we not get the early game units to
score early easy points, but we also
then just kind of have lost our pacing
at the end of the game as though Randy
was just able to ramp up too far and now
he's left a lot of hoops for jump David
to have to jump through to now bring
this back. I'm not saying it's
impossible. If anyone's going to be able
to do it, it's a jinx on 611.
>> Yeah, it's very improbable though. Like,
let's be honest about this for David to
get out of this situation. does draw two
cards. Well, one card in beginning and
one card for the card draw for turn. So,
haven't quite had a look at exactly
what's going on in the hand. You need a
conquer if you're going to get that
super mega death rocket back from your
trash. And then you also have to discard
one of your cards. So, you're
>> thinning out your resources pretty
heavily.
>> And that's the thing, that's where the
the kind of legend ability does come
into play. You are discarding more so
you can draw more up again. But when
we're this late in the game, those card
draws at the beginning aren't that
helpful. You kind of need a bit more
push than that.
>> Was that a sundisk and a noxious
hopeful?
>> Oh,
>> that is I mean it's not great.
>> It's not great.
>> They both have Legion, but we need to
play one before the other.
>> I mean, Sundisk does mean the Noxious
Hopeful will come in ready. We tap it.
Hopeful then gets ready when we play it
for those two energy, but it we reveal
all of our cards. Going to go in here
looking for the last rights trigger to
get the card from our trash out ready.
Randy just having a quick read of
Sundisk. Maybe hasn't played into many
Rex size this weekend cuz that's kind of
where we see it mostly. I like the tech
from David. Uh the idea of well, I'll go
in, I'll get my unit out of the trash
and then Ezreal dies.
>> Okay, cool. So, we did manage one. Now,
we need to get the other battlefield as
well. I think it's a bit more of an
uphill battle here, but we will get the
last rights trigger.
>> Mhm. for the conquer. But
>> what do we have is the Draven or the
Ferris 4Runner. A ready Ferris 4Runner
is big. Think about that being discarded
earlier on.
>> That is really big cuz what we got going
on. We got 4 6 7 8. So we've got eight
going on right now. We would have enough
power to take that down. But it looks
like yep, we're going for the Ferris
4runner.
>> I think that's a great play right now.
If we're going to be able to make a
comeback, this is the sort of big tanky
unit we were talking about. The David
was just missing for a while. We needed
that last rights trigger. We finally got
it.
>> Maybe this is the turning point.
>> And Jinx as well, demolitionist has
assault too, so it would uh take us up
quite a lot on the attack.
The problem is the overzealous fan
exists. So we need to get through the
six of the noxious hopeful. No energy up
for Randy. So we know there's not a huge
amount we have to play around.
>> No, we don't have to worry about any
surprises from Ry's side. But it's about
David being able to sequence this
properly. Yeah,
>> about knowing what resources are left
and then kind of dealing with that. And
I think this kind of separated
battle style is where you have to go.
You push something in kind of allow for
the possibility of the reaction of the
overzealous fan and then go in again.
>> Mhm.
>> I agree.
It's an interesting if you do go in
again, overzealous fan bounces your jinx
back. Then you go in 6v6 onto this
noxious hopeful with that last rights
equipped. Your ferris 4runner dies,
>> but then you get the two mech.
>> The two mechs in base, but that doesn't
help treasure hunter defend this top
battlefield. Oh. Oh, nice. Because we
control forge of the fluff, we can move
the last rights across.
>> I love that.
>> One of the few times that you can
unequip an attached equipment and put it
somewhere else. Other ones being weapon
master and quick draw. Not quick, just
weapon master. But uh last right here
will go in and then you get the conquer
trigger as well when it attacks into
that noxious hopeful.
>> That would be absolutely spectacular
even if Randy could come back with
something which they can't because
they're out. But
>> the Dven I told you here's the turning
point.
>> Yeah, it really is. It really is for
Randy falling lower on resources.
Noxious hopeful going to sorry first
fourman are going to go in and kill off
the noxious hopeful last rights will
stay on the battlefield but on the top
side we have a treasure hunter sitting
at three no energy available now for
David as they will look to pass the tone
it's a long sword in hand from the draw
a discard draw on the zorn warren
>> but we're going to discard it to bring
back the death rockets and now that's
the only card in hand but again you're
posing threats and you're saying okay
well even if you were to attach that
last rights to the traveling merchant
that's just not big enough for my big
super mega Death Rocket
can get the
I mean, you go in with the merchant on
the treasure hunter. You win that
combat. Draw a card from the Draven
>> cuz it's it's a three into a four. You
also get the last strikes trigger on the
conquer. We have a Draven in
>> our trash if we so desire it. Haven't
seen the hand in a little while. You can
see there's the equip cycle two
>> Noxious hopeful
>> and the Ezreal going back to the bottom
of our main deck. Now we go in on the
treasure hunter knowing there's no real
combat traits available for David.
>> So we get a clean sweep there. That's
out of here. So we're one step away. We
need to take that bottom battlefield for
the win or manage to bulk this
battlefield up enough to hold it.
>> So what are we bringing back? Had the
discard draw from the traveling merchant
move. Then from the glorious executioner
winning the combat, we get that extra
draw as well.
>> What are you bringing back, Randy?
I I feel like bulking out this
battlefield if possible is great. Fizz
is a good choice.
>> So bringing more back from the discard
pile.
>> I'm trying to think if we have something
we could accelerate cuz fight or flight
the first 4erunner back. Accelerate here
does win us the game.
>> Ride the wind. Ride the wind.
>> The wind for the win.
>> Beautiful. Really good line there.
Making sure that you can clean up that
bottom battlefield. Get the first four
runner out of the way and then ride the
wind across. Vandy takes game one of
this six one-on-one match up here in
round nine. The sideboard consists of a
beast below which is not something you
talk too commonly see outside of sealed.
Double mind spplitter the first
forrunner a hard bargain a Kaiser and a
seal of discord.
>> An interesting mix. I don't know what
I'd bring in here if I'm Randy if much.
Uh, but I'm more curious about kind of
how how that would affect a Jinx
matchup. As we've assessed a few times
before, we think that Draven is the kind
of more
overwhelming unit in this example in
this pairing. Uh, but that doesn't mean
that we didn't see quite the comeback
there from Jinx. It was a really uphill
spike that we were able to see. So, I
actually think that maybe there is an
argument that some good sideboarding
here. Getting some more units in play
would be great. There's plenty of them
in here. Maybe some more of those Ferris
4unners for a bit of extra bulk.
>> Yeah. The I think the issue is is
nothing has deflect. No.
>> And you don't have counters, right? You
have a you have hard bargain, but you
haven't got it in main. I can't quite
remember if it was in the sideboard. So,
if you are looking to play these big
units, you just risk fight or flight.
you risk them getting knocked out as I
look to put in another Darius for that
pseudo accelerate with the ready
but we'll see where David decides to go
for the fluff used very effectively by
both players there in game one I really
like the uh the tech of taking the last
rights off
>> yeah that was great and we that I think
that's the thing we've seen we saw
yesterday and we spoke about it a little
bit where actually choosing your
battlefield is really scary because you
could be quite advantageous towards your
opponent so almost playing a battle
Battle attvantageous
to both of you, but it's worse for your
opponent than it is for yourself could
be a good thing. Choosing a bad
battlefield on purpose.
>> Could be good. We saw it yesterday and
we could see it again today. Well, now
we have the obelisk of power and forge.
>> Or did make it today, too, everyone.
>> Or lovers unite. The forge is there
reducing the cost of the first friendly
non-token gear you play each turn to by
one. Now, if you are controlling that
battlefield, Randy having a think about
their first turn. I believe I think
we've gone through the mulligans
already. You can see a couple of runes
already channeled.
>> Not looking too happy. The body language
isn't giving it.
>> Yeah, it's one of those like well uh do
I play do I get, you know, a traveling
merchant out early? Do I want to start
discarding my cards? You do want to be
on the board early here. Those points in
the first few rounds really helps you
accelerate to the ride the wind turn
stuff like that. is three runes as you
say because of the obelisk and Randy
already counting out.
>> Okay, so it's a seal.
>> Want to be using that power on your
first turn if possible.
>> I don't know if there's anything else we
can play. There is just
>> hopeful. Thank goodness.
>> Yeah. Okay, so didn't use the power from
the seal, but no hopeful does mean you
have a four might unit really early on
and David is going to be struggling to
match that on their first turns. Well,
David knew exactly what they were
playing straight with the Darius and
honestly not mad at it at all.
>> Yeah, D so good in these match. No,
they're brothers. You're allowed to get
them mixed up super easy. Uh yeah,
Draven just so good in these matchups.
Gives you so much power and matches well
into a noxious hope for because of the
ability to use that buff during
attacking and defending here. A couple
of options obviously not going to go
towards the forerunner. Kaiser and
Ezreal really the two that you're
looking at. Ezreal out into a cold shot
will mean you're only you don't even
have to recycle a room because you have
that seal out. Instead, we are going to
play a Draven of our own matching on the
other sides of the rift. Adoration for
Draven pretty high in this matchup.
>> Understandable. A very strong unit.
>> Said opposite sides of the rift, didn't
I?
>> Yeah, you did.
>> Oh, leader at heart.
>> Oh, understandable. Okay, here we go
with the first Draven moving into uh our
forge
and scoring that early point. And that's
kind of what Jigs wants to do. But
recognizing that David needs to go in
with larger units in this instance to
not allow the easy extra card draw from
the other side. Recognizing that these
smaller units I tried with last time
aren't really going to cut the mustard.
I'm going to need to go in with
something bigger. So, I'm going to play
you at your own game and we're going to
have more Dravens in play. There's an
interesting little thing here as well
with the stack deck, you already have
one long sword in hand. It is going to
be the super mega death rocket, but on
forge does read each turn. Yes. So, when
you have equipments with quick draw, you
can actually reduce the cost of a long
sword on your opponent's turn as well,
only having to pay one energy and a
power. So, you could long sword on a
turn, next turn your opponent's like,
well, there's there's no way they'll
long sword again. Then you just long
sword again. And uh there's more fury
runes on David's side of the board as
well. So, it is a Draven into Draven
matchup. the Draven would win. David's
Draven that is if you uh go for the full
power sacrifice also as a uh
attacking player I believe you get to
put your trigger on the bottom of the
stack. though Randy could buff up, but
the super death just used to avoid any
semblance of doubt around those Dravens.
Randy sent to the trash.
>> Again, just avoiding that combat
fantastically and being able to get the
death rocket kind of in play. So, we
have that constant recursion of it early
on is really imperative to getting Ry's
units kind of under control.
>> Yeah, thank you, Randy. The decision is
now, do I just get through my deck a
little bit? I play the Ezreal, play the
cold shot, use the seal, look at the top
four, draw two without actually having
to pay any power. Uh, apart from playing
the Ezreal's power, obviously for that
first turn,
>> I don't know. I I just feel like you
don't have much of a choice in this
instance. Like, looking at the hand,
>> we need more.
>> There's no fight or flight,
>> nothing.
>> There's no ride the wind. There's no
real combat tricks right there. Not at
all. And that's kind of what we're
looking for. That's what Draven wants.
And at the moment, I feel like you need
to cycle through. We need to start using
cold shot. Looks like we might y move in
first for the potential of a response.
Just waiting on that. But I think we've
only got one. We are going for it.
>> We're going to long sword on the forge.
We talked about this reduced cost.
>> Get that onto the Draven early doors.
>> Let's get him up to six. And it doesn't
really affect anything at this modern
battlefield at all,
>> but it is a reaction. So, we are allowed
to do that on another battlefield in
response to the Noxville kind of joining
the obelisk of power there. Gaining that
first point, getting on in there,
knowing there's not really any real
threat from David's board. It would just
be a death rocket.
>> Mhm.
>> Ezreal, here we go with that card draw.
It's exactly what we want to be seeing
at this point. So, we really do need
some more going on. a few more units,
maybe some card tricks. Those fight off
flights would be great in this
situation. We saw them to perfect effect
last game.
>> Yeah, dunking the Ferris, getting that
first two card draw. Now we'll think
about whether we want to uh play the
cord shot or the stack deck. Stack deck
slightly cheaper in terms of power at
least does cost that one energy. But
we'll look at the top three double fight
or flight in there.
last rights will go to the bottom
though, which makes it a little trickier
>> for Randy to find that tool to recur the
Ferris forun later. You can see Randy
something he did a ton with his civ deck
is taking notes. It's like I I need to
know what's near the bottom. Usually you
can use like a short hand as well to
make sure that your opponent can't see
across the board exactly what you are
writing down. The overzealous fan going
in to defend this noxious hopeful. And
overall, that's kind of all she wrote
for Ry's turn. Could use the core shot
right at the end here. Uh but instead
just decides to pass across.
>> Yeah, I like this kind of putting the
overzealous fan in with anxious hopeful
because it backs it up beyond a removal
spell. Super mega death rocket could
take one of the two out, but certainly
not both. And being able to kind of deal
with that in a sense of a spell or
combat just by having two guys in there
rather than one is really powerful at
this stage.
>> Yeah, Simon reduced again by forge of
the fluffed allowing you to play it just
for one instead of two. Very happy there
for David. The hidden card is an edge of
knight. We know that Randy does not.
Could be a fight or flight. Could be
something to bounce his units back. But
uh the edge of knight obviously very
effective when you are playing these uh
more equipment focused decks in in the
form of the jinx.
>> Forgot about or you went with forge of
the fluff. Can't believe you betrayed or
like that.
>> Oh, it's orn's forge, not forge of the
fluff. Yeah, you're entirely right.
Yeah, sorry. Or forge. You're entirely
correct. Uh my mistake.
>> God, the the self-professed or fan.
>> I love but you know who plays for
disappointed. I I play the on variant
that is no one can score points.
>> Yes. You're trying to stop everyone from
having fun.
>> Yeah, exactly. That's my entire You can
still like conquer and you can still
hold. You just can't score many points.
>> The game will never end.
>> Exactly.
>> We'll always be playing Riftbound,
right? Let's jump in here. We're going
for the four cost. We're recycling two.
What are we doing? Are we death
rocketing?
>> All right.
>> No. Oh, we're jinx demolition and then
discarding.
>> Yeah.
>> Going in with the accelerate. No cast in
hand though. I don't like that.
>> I mean, you are going to draw two on
your next turn, right? With the with the
Jinx legend trigger and the draw
trigger. Jinx going in here just trying
to get rid of the overzealous fan. When
they stick around, they can just become
a little pesky, right? With Randy being
entirely out of energy. It makes sense
to try and utilize that. Now, I think we
might see a cold shot repeated reaction
here from Randy just to cycle through
his deck. It's uh really all that they
can do for the moment.
Yeah, it's a sticky situation for David
still. I don't love the whole kind of
again living in top deck city with just
like having two mysterious cards. You
can't plan for your next turns and I
think that's a that's a really scary
part for a Jinx player who is playing on
this low hand size like we see here.
This is kind of how we expect the deck
to run. It was very different from the
build we saw yesterday. We're expecting
to be on the low hand size here, but
then your top decks are so crucial.
>> Yeah, it becomes really tricky as well
when Randy knows you are out.
>> Yeah,
>> like Randy just drew two cards, is going
to draw another,
>> can look for the uh combat into this
as well. Yeah, cold shot cuz now you can
play the not just hope for and it just
comes out at two really cheap.
>> Take the Fizz here. Uh,
it's possible you have a fight off
flight in hand. Trying to think if
there's anything you could fizz and then
get another cold shot back, but ride the
wind does give you more of a win con.
>> Uh, and you drawing so many cards. Yeah,
another cord shot. So, yeah, you don't
need the fizz. You can just play another
cold shot.
>> And we saw that happen so many times
yesterday. It was just drawing cards was
always trumps.
>> Mhm.
>> It is very solid indeed.
Is it the hopeful or are we just going
to go for another cord shot and keep
going through that deck?
>> We're considering maybe hiding a card as
well here.
>> Yeah, fighter of flight makes sense,
>> but we'll see.
>> I think we'd be good on that top
battlefield. Just kind of protect that
even more. Kind of get those whole
points as we go along.
>> Top battlefield is currently controlled
by David. Remember, you don't actually
have a
>> Not yet.
>> Yeah, not yet. But you can go and
control the bottom stack deck to keep
cycling. We still have a we still have a
a cord shot that we can play. Take the
sack deck. Take the battering ram.
Battering ram basically free now with
how many spells we have cast this turn.
A stack deck into the noxious hopeful
into battering ram is beautiful at this
point.
>> I I can't believe how many cards we're
drawing. This is the power.
>> A beast below comes in for this turn.
>> Are we going to take it? I kind of want
to see it. I kind of want to see it
played, but I think we might go for more
card draw. I'm just so pleasantly
surprised at how much we've been able to
combo those card draw kind of options
into one another just to really make the
perfect hand.
>> In case you don't know, Beast Below when
you play it, you return another friendly
unit and an enemy unit to their owner's
hand. Kind of a pseudo rebuke with eight
might, which is really nice. So,
>> literally roars in the face of your
opponent goes, "Get back there."
>> Yeah. And also like you can play it
here, target the Draven and there's no
response for David
>> other than to just kind of replay it.
But we're really low on runes. We got no
cards in hand. It would be kind of a
scary situation.
>> Randy is one rune short of the uh of the
beast blow for this turn. Vi coming out.
We have the VI ride the wind combo. Very
early on to to do that because we're
sitting only on one point overall, but
no hopeful. Do we put down the battering
ram as well for free of course?
>> Oh, we love a freebie. really really
strong on units now. I love that Vi has
natural ganking as well. Really
fantastic to be able to have that
utilization alongside the File Flights
and alongside these battering rams just
for that extra power. Really impressive
play to build up the base here. Kind of
saying I know that you've got limited
resources. Even if you death rocket one
of these guys, I've still got three
more.
>> It's a seal in hand.
two card draws. Not too advantageous for
David. We'll go to three with a hold on
the F forge.
>> And I think that's my problem with this
is that you can't prepare for your next
turn.
>> Yeah.
>> You don't know what you're doing cuz you
don't know what you're drawing until you
get there.
>> And then you're at the beck and call of
whatever those two cards were and the
only thing you can do in this situation
is take back that death rocket. But
again, there are so many units on the
other side that that is absolutely not
going to be of any help here.
>> Yeah. You also don't want to give a
combat to the Draven player, right? You
could siren back your own Draven
reacting with the with the edge of
knight to get that equipped onto the
Draven and then you could go for the
conquer on the bottom battlefield. But
even at that point it's like well
>> you look at the might on the other side
there's 11 represented and a VI which
you can just recycle not infinitely but
all of the cards into your trash into it
right and your Draven's never going to
be that big. So if you do Simon back,
you have to reveal that hidden card.
Otherwise, it is I mean it's going to go
back as a gear into your base.
>> You can get the equipment onto Draven if
you do use it as that reaction.
>> It's a really difficult situation,
David. I I just think again we've run
out of steam.
>> We started off hot. We were doing well
and now we again we just haven't seen
the draw cards. Where are they? Like we
have not seen any of that engine. We've
not been able to get kind of a higher
hander. We're we're on that back foot of
being like the Jinx legend ability was
my fall back and it hasn't paid off.
>> Yeah. And when you're sitting on a
treasure hunter seal, it's not a great
feeling.
>> Not the best feeling at all.
>> Maybe just needs to turn to uh
redistribute to get back into base just
to reset a little bit. Obviously, you do
want to try and keep ahead of this
Draven deck cuz when it starts to get
control, it's really difficult to rest
it back out of its hands. But
you can't really be losing this Draven
right now. Treasure Hunter down, one
fury rune available for D David, which
would
>> put this Draven up to eight. And then
the Edge of Knight trigger would put it
up to 10, but 10 is not enough.
>> Really scary when it's not enough at
all. When we're looking at Ry's board
state, it's so much more frivolous.
We're looking at so many units with so
much flexibility in their might, and
that's where it really comes down. And
like you said, David just can't really
let up that battlefield. He's got to try
and keep control cuz once once Draven
does go in there, it's really hard to
gain it back. You really don't want to
just let him have it. We're going to
push one or two units into the obelisk
of power. Looking like we're considering
a second just to kind of give that extra
beef over there so that David can't do
much about it. If they do use a death
rocket,
>> uh, death rocket wouldn't be crazy
effective right now because it's a slow
speed, right? So, you wouldn't be able
to use it now.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But next turn it would
make sense. But you have two runes up.
So, David could ride the wind the Draven
across. True.
>> And then you want to make sure that you
are avoiding the um the potential.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh, but we know there's a seal at hand.
Randy does not know this. He has to play
around fight or flight, ride the wind, a
few of these like combat tricks,
switcheroo as well. Can't quite remember
if that's in David's list. But the
conquer comes down. Beast below now
targeting the Draven.
>> Y
>> I assume the Ezreal for the discard draw
>> and back it goes. Yeah, GG. David knows
cannot win from this position. Two for
Randy.
>> I think I saw the fist bump.
>> Yeah, I think Ry's beast was too much
and David unfortunately could not beat
the beast below. The writing was on the
wall and as far as we can tell, looks
like we've wrapped that up with a 200
win for Randy. I think there's just not
enough that David could do to bring that
back. So, admitted defeat, have a little
rest and go on.
>> I mean, it's one of those things. Yeah.
What What's at some point you have to
say, okay, if I really tried to win this
game, maybe I have 10% odds, but I
played for 12 hours yesterday and I have
another bunch of rounds today. Let me
just keep myself in a strong position.
It might be that we continue to play it
out a little bit.
>> Yeah, let's go for it. I again, you can.
You absolutely can. It's about that
fortitude and whether you can bring it
back to a point of being able to win.
Maybe David just wants to see what the
next couple of top decks are to see if
maybe that just kind of saves us.
>> It's a disc. It does not save us.
>> I don't think that's going to do much
unfortunately. But I really respect
David for playing this out here. Let's
see if anything can bring it back. We
did see quite the comeback in game one.
We saw that, you know, was able to
remove a lot of units. So maybe just
like holding your own here is enough to
to consider the fact that we might be
able to bring something back. Maybe just
enough.
>> All right. Seal into Sundisk. Cap. Tap
the Sundisk.
Do I think we have enough runes to play
the Draven? We do. There's a couple
hiding under there. So Draven will come
in readied,
but even then like you chuck the Draven
onto the battle ram, it just gets fight
or flighted back. Good old F on the
other side. There's way too much might
for you to deal with. 15 sitting on that
obelisk.
>> We can attach the long sword. Oh no.
Okay, not the long sword.
>> Well, I think we um we had only the
seal, the purple seal, the tail seal. So
you can't use the long seal to equip,
right? Could you? We could of course
actually recycle a rune to get there cuz
we do have a fury rune sitting there.
But I I think David is just realizing I
think they they already realized I'll be
honest that they don't really have too
many ways back into this game. The lines
aren't great. wants to get this uh fight
off flight off the board and Randy it's
like David immediately passes focus uh
not activating any triggers on the
Draven and uh
yeah Randy yeah he's going to say oh
here's a fight or flight I'm actually
going to bring back my battleing ram you
can have you can have the combat
>> no energy up for David means he can't
siren his Draven back either
>> no that's not that's not coming back
that's staying at that battlefield and
again it just becomes is really
vulnerable then to Ry's attacks and I
think that's why Ry's like yeah okay you
can sit there for a minute that's fine
I'll take my seat back in a moment
>> yeah it's just you know it's a free
combat win as well
>> we love drawing cards
>> we do we do David goes four passes a
turn across to Randy who'll go to for
himself immediately with the hold here
on the obelisk power has a full grip
more full than full you have to say you
start off with four cards in riftbound
and Randy immediately accelerated to
almost twice that draw for turn and uh
yeah, it really feels like a pretty done
game.
>> I think the ganking is uh being
considered here with that VI, which is
kind of why I was really glad to see it
cuz we didn't see Vi yesterday in any of
our matches that we saw. So, I'm excited
to see it come into play here. A really
powerful late game unit. You can recycle
cards from your trash to be able to
buffer up as far as you can go. Just
making us so colossal that Draven just
won't be able to stand the power.
>> Deliberately putting the V to nine
because the Draven already has six on it
and there's one Fury available for
David. So if David recycles the fury
rune goes to eight, it's still too
short. Draven now dead. Only a treasure
hunter available for David. Randy will
go up to five. a couple of turns away
from claiming their seventh win here in
Bologna.
>> And essentially that VI can just kind of
keep going with that effect. So you
don't want to spend too much on it. You
want to be able to have more things in
your trash. But equally, like you say,
that nine was the safe number there.
>> Yeah, makes the most sense.
>> No. Gone is the treasure hunter. We've
got nothing left on David's side of the
board.
>> I It feels merciless from Randy, but you
must be merciless. That's how you make
sure there are no possible outs for your
opponents in games like this. David,
>> yeah, just really doesn't have anything.
We'll get I believe the two card draw.
Don't think they have anything in hand
at the moment. So, we'll get a couple of
cards to look at on their next turn.
Retreat comes out from Randy. Don't even
need to look for the holes. Can just go
in for attacks on their next turn, but
as we said, still at five a couple of
turns away. Uses a seal for the Ezreal.
Will discard and draw. Only playing one
of Rasa in this deck.
So still doesn't really need the trash
to be too big.
>> No. And again, because we've got the the
V in play, we've just recycled some in
anyway. So kind of that wouldn't be a
great timing, but honestly, the hand is
looking good. We've Yeah. Okay. I was
going to say that we were going to hide
that fight off light just to give a
little bit of extra backup. Try and hold
that one base and then it's easy to get
up to the eight points for the win.
>> Yeah, the VI buff on the mic will fall
off and can't be activated on your
opponent's turn. at slow speed, so you
uh you can't do it in a in a combat, in
a showdown, reaction speed or anything.
So, that's why you want to make sure
there's a little bit of extra protection
there. The final
>> see what was drawn there from David, but
it looks like something big might be
coming our way.
>> Oh, David's just like, "How many runes
do I have?"
>> What have I got left?
>> It's going to be three.
>> Okay,
>> where are we going? David right.
>> It's really powerful when you have a
unit to put it on. And David will have
one in a moment. It's going to ready
this noxious hopeful. Go to the obelisk
of power.
>> Okay.
>> With the last rights equipped. Has the
seal to do so. Needs to recycle two.
Believe it has to be the seal of
discord. Oh, he's going to equip the
long sword first. Okay. But the seal of
discord will need to be used if you want
to get that last right on. It is a
purple power. Chaos power. What are we
recycling?
Don't really want to chuck any of the
units back cuz you kind of want those
back yourself. And the small units are
fine. and a treasure hunter and a a
stack deck going to the bottom.
>> Yeah, that makes sense. We we we need to
be able to have the last rights trigger
available to us cuz that's what's going
to get us back in the game. We saw it to
great effect in game one. So maybe this
is just the extra little bit we need the
extra push and you're making a really
big unit for Randy to have to deal with
which
>> you kind of have to. You don't have a
choice. We see a lot of power in base
and I'm not sure that anything's going
to be enough. But if anything will be it
will be this noxious hopeful with all of
the weapons. I don't know how he's
holding on to all of those. He's only
got two arms. Two arms, one strapped
onto your leg, you know, one held
between your toes, shovel strapped
across your back.
>> It'll have to be. We don't have a
choice. It's like a oneman band.
>> It's 10 might sitting on the noxious
hopeful treasure hunter might be played
here as well just for that extra little
bit.
Uh we didn't Oh, we did play the
treasure hunter cuz from the last rice
trigger, but we didn't have enough runes
to actually play anything bigger was the
main issue. The problem is here Randy
has a ride the wind and David has tried
to play around it. Uh we have four in
the trash I believe for Randy which puts
that uh Vi up to seven if you do want to
ride the wind across. You also has a
have a beast below and the noxious
hopeful sitting in base which is 12
power in and of itself.
>> That's the thing. Vi's already got the
ganking so you don't even have to use
anything to be able to move her across.
She can just jump on over when she
fancies. And that's one of the big
powerful moments of that unit and why I
enjoy the utilization of it here so much
>> is that you do punish those who don't
respect that it's already on a
battlefield because you can just recycle
from trash and go okay anyway now it's
massive and then she's going to jump
right over to where you're at and
there's just so much power in base
already that you can go for that
multiple attack line. You can go for one
combat and then another.
So we're going in with the beast and the
hopeful. Yep.
>> It's 11 into 12.
>> And that's all she wrote there. That's
the conquer.
>> Yeah, that is. Take us to seven. Still
need one more turn here for Randy didn't
even Yeah, I mean you didn't need the
ride the wind or anything, but
>> I think David having no cards in hand
for the majority of the game has made it
relatively easy for Randy to decide on
their lines.
>> Yeah, unfortunately again David is just
at the beck and mercy of that top deck.
Go. Wow. Yeah. Okay. just bulking out
that lower battlefield as well. Going
for the hold there. David would have to
take both of these away now. And with no
units currently in play, I'd say that
pretty much just Yeah, Ry's going all
in. All in. I'm going to put hidden
cards. We're going with big guys. You
got to take both of these. I can't see
it happening. So Ry's just putting all
of their balls in every court.
>> Yeah, fight or flight on either
battlefield as well just makes it so
difficult for David to do anything.
We'll see what the top decks are.
There's a couple of them.
>> Are they good enough?
>> Uh, no. No,
>> there's a cold shot and something else
>> and that isn't really going to do
anything for you.
>> I mean, you can go for the cord shot.
You get another chance to look. We'll
recite. We'll repeat it as well.
>> I think you have to, right? You don't
have to play seal in another shot. Take
the take. Take the shot. But
>> you just keep comboing them. But I think
at that point you you know the writing's
on the wall. This is the card draw we
wanted earlier. Yeah,
>> this is what we needed earlier to be
able to get back in here. I think it's
too late, unfortunately.
>> Yeah, I must agree. I didn't see
anything good. I believe it's Is it two
treasure hunters in hand?
>> I think so.
>> Yeah, not not nothing too impressive. I
guess we just go for another cold shot.
>> Yeah. And just I mean, I think No,
there's the Randy taking it home.
Bringing the power of the beast onto the
battlefield was just too much.
>> Beast Below I love. Uh, it's really
good. Plays well as a sort of rebuke
replacement at times as well. And the
ability to bounce back your Ezreal, so
you get more card draw. Really effective
play there from Randy. Like for David,
obviously unfortunate. Didn't really get
the card draw that they were looking
for. Played really well in game one to
try and fight back, but as soon as they
were really buffing up a treasure hunter
and such, you know, you know, it's going
to be a little bit of a struggle
>> unfortunately. But we have to highlight
they are still best of Jinx right now.
They are I believe they're still best of
Jinx. Um so we're still looking at a
really fantastic position for them to go
all the way and take that title.
>> Oh that they're the highest Jinx. Okay.
I thought you meant they were the only
Jinx left. No currently highest jinx.
>> Oh well still doing very well for
themselves. still in a fantastic
>> honorable thing to win. An honorable
thing to win. I think we have our round
two in the feature match or second game
of the feature match. Oh, we have an
interview first. We're going to hand it
over to a winners interview. Randy,
let's hear from what he has to say.
>> Hey, James here with Randy after a
successful game in our feature match
area. Randy, congratulations on the win.
How are you feeling now after round
nine?
>> Uh, feeling pretty good. I'm feeling
pretty confident about this day. Seven
more to go and we win the event. So,
that's pretty good.
>> Yeah, that's that's good outlook on it.
So, remind me, what's your standings
currently now after?
>> Uh, I'm 711.
>> Nice. Okay. So, in a good spot to to go
towards that top eight. Um, running
Draven, which I think people have known
you recently for playing Civ. How do you
feel about Draven specifically now?
>> Uh, I think Draven is pretty strong. I
like Civia a lot. The issue with Civ is
time. Uh this is the first weekend of
the release. People are naturally going
to play slower and that just C is a
control deck. She needs combo/cont
control, but she needs to go the long
game. Um and you put the opponent on the
top deck and if they do top deck
multiple times in a row, they're going
to close that game. They shouldn't be
closing and you have to go to game
three. That's like very very advanced in
the in the timer on the round. So it's
very difficult then to close that game.
You don't really lose. just draw and
draw is kind of losing in a tournament
that long.
>> Do you do you feel like the the
difference between the two Draven decks?
I mean, we have the Miracle Drag and we
have the the the the mid-range deck. Do
you feel like time is a difference in
either of those matchups?
>> Um, I mean, obviously mid-range is quite
faster because you don't have that much
action to take in your turn compared to
to mid-range, but I I do um I do still
think Miracle can finish games in a
reasonable amount of time. It's I play
pretty fast, so I'm not worried about
that too much. Uh I don't like to press
my opponents, so I I I'm like I'm very
unlikely to do it, but I will still do
it if they are taking way too long.
>> Right. I I I get that. I get that. I I
think when you speak about interactions
like that, about time and understanding,
I think it's I think it's fair to say of
all the players in this room, you
perhaps have played the most highlevel
Riftbound at this point, having spent a
month over in China playing in the
regional qualifiers. like how important
for you is that that you now have
multiple tournaments for Riftband
specifically in your expertise?
>> Um I think it's pretty interesting. Uh
to be fair
I I I considered severe for this event
for a long time. My friend convinced me
on Draven. Um because people in China I
I felt were playing pretty slow already
but I just think that's naturally just
player taking their time and thinking
but it's way way longer here because
it's new. So I like my my expertise
allowed me I guess to uh get to know all
the decks better but that's from testing
mostly just overall tournament
experience. Um knowledge has improved
but it's very similar to other TCGs I've
played into. So I I don't think the
difference I'm trying to make comes from
the expertise but more from testing and
improving and deck building and all that
stuff.
>> That makes a lot of sense. Well, thank
you so much Randy. Uh look forward to
seeing the rest of your results and best
of luck in the rest of the talk. Thank
you
>> and welcome back to RQ Bolognia. Great
to hear from Randy having a great
performance so far. I will say never
expected Beast Below to be that near the
top cut. Like what a card, what an
inclusion, giving yourself the mic while
having that rebuke on top of it. Really
fun stuff I would say from Randy.
>> Honestly, I've got to say that that
isn't the only time I've been pleasantly
surprised by an inclusion in a deck this
weekend. And I could not be more
thrilled because that really shows the
innovation and deck building that has
gone on. Even since the last event that
we saw in Houston from then to now, the
meta has developed and people have
thought of their own ways of defeating
and overcoming obstacles. And I love
that.
>> It's so much fun. We are going to get
into round the second game of round nine
here as we are jumping into game three
of this second feature match.
>> I got to say, I'm really jazzed for this
one. Uh yeah, I I really love this uh
this combination of decks and I'm
interested to see how they interact with
one another. I have played this uh this
interaction once before and I had a
blast. So, but I think I just really
enjoy playing Riftbound. So, maybe I'm
biased.
>> I mean, I don't know. We all do, right?
Uh Inbo Slice here on the Draven side of
the match. We'll have a look at their
deck list. Uh again, relatively
mid-rangey. Uh you've got less of the
miracle package. No, none of those uh
cool shots, but things like the mind
spplitter for top end for 4Runner as
well. You're looking to control the
board early and then really overwhelmed
with quite high mites later on and with
control of your opponent's hand. On the
other side though,
>> I'm pretty I'm pretty jazzed about this
one. We have just uh playing Renata.
Something that I haven't yet been able
to talk about. we haven't been able to
feature yet, but a really fantastically
imaginative way of working with a deck.
It's got its own kind of purpose. It's
got like an alternate win condition, and
I love that. It's so fun. It's like
you're working to a different goal to
everyone else. And then they have to
react to that in an interesting way to
be able to get around it. You don't want
to let Renata get all those gold tokens.
You don't want them to be able to score
extra points outside of the usual realm.
>> Yeah. And especially if you can get to a
forge god pretty early, you are
generating quite a few gold gears in
this deck, meaning your forge gods get
very big very quickly and can be quite
hard to deal with unless you have
targeted removal. Uh just is our final
Renata player in the tournament. So they
have won that best of metal card for
Renata. Aren't playing it here. I think
you have to wait until you're out of the
tournament before you can claim your
metal card prize, which does make a lot
of sense. could even be looking for the
top first place prize as well with that
blade of the ruin king one of one card.
Let's get into it. At the bottom we have
a vile moor's lair at the top. It's a
targon's peak. I mean just will be very
happy getting the onto vile moors if
they can. Renata if you don't know what
it does cuz you don't often see it when
you are holding or an ally if you're
you're playing 2v2. uh you can exhaust a
gold gear. Uh exhaust Renata Cambaroness
to make a gold gear. Pretty effective.
And then when you're within three points
of whatever the point total is here,
it's eight. Your gold also add an energy
when you sacrifice them,
>> which is pretty crazy. And we've seen
kind of the way that these decks like to
work is they jump really quickly from
three points to eight just out of
nowhere. So allowing them an early lead
in points is really scary. you want to
try and avoid letting them do that cuz
then they're able to make that jump
really easily once they've got their
resources high. So, this is where Draven
actually come kind of comes into a
really great effect in this is that
Draven does have that early game push
and power and actually we're seeing that
in hand already. We've got a really good
split of kind of cheaper units with the
Nox's hopeful. We can play the stack
deck first to get that Legion effect so
it's cheaper to play. So already we're
looking at a lot of kind of those early
game powerful units that should be able
to slow Renata down just a little bit.
>> Yeah, we'll see where they decide to go.
Could also just play out with the Kaiser
and look for conquers.
>> Very true. And again, that's not a bad
thing. We want to be getting that on the
board and just slowing Renata down,
putting some threats out there.
>> Going to put the Kaiser down. One of the
big things you have to play around here
as the Draven is singularity.
Singularity so powerful in these decks
that do like to ramp up the gold tokens.
Things like hidden blade call the weak
as well. There's a lot of removal for
the Renata player. Wages of pain also
really good. Doesn't work too well into
Kaiser obviously cuz three into the
four. We got a hostile takeover in hand.
Blood money as well can be pretty
effective. Plundering power going down.
Blood money sometimes you are just
looking to use it on your own units and
these like plundering to get that extra
gold to accelerate yourself towards the
towards the hostile takeovers towards
those later game portions where you can
uh actually manage to have a little bit
more control. But it is going to be
Renata
Mastermind coming out here. Again, a
card that you've probably seen in your
pools. You probably open being like,
"Ah, no one likes blue Renata."
Apparently, apparently, it can work
pretty effectively. If you can generate
enough gold, you can get that score one
point. That can be your winning point as
well. If Ranata is out of battlefield,
>> and that's what it's all about. You're
wanting to have this alternative win
condition or aside the regular win
condition, you get a bonus way of
winning. Yeah,
>> that's so powerful in its own right.
Your opponent has to take note of it.
They have to be afraid of it. They have
to respond to it. You can't just ignore
it. It is literally gamechanging. And
that's where Renata does have some
power. And I think that's what we like
to see at this day too actually is that
every single every single champion can
have a chance to be up here. Even if you
were thinking I'm just going to go for
best off prizing. Uh hello. We're seeing
Renata up here. And I don't think anyone
was expecting that. And I love that that
innovation has come to our top tables.
>> Yeah, it's really cool. The the vessel
of surprising does just allow that meta
to be a little bit more flexible. Means
that you do start to see matchups like
this higher up in the standings. And
some people were playing Himerdinger
alongside the Renata because Himedinger
doesn't copy the I must be at a
battlefield for my abilities to be
activated text. Just copies the
activated abilities. But no him in this
list as far as I saw from just it. We
see the sacrifice on the plundering
poke. Kaiser is going to go in. Uh I
think it was the hidden blade, right,
for the extra card draws there from onto
the Plundering B. Looks like it. Kaiser
goes in, conquers, get the card draw,
and then traveling uh treasure hunter
going down towards the bottom side as
well for that gold generation.
>> Again, really important that you just
kind of start to push ahead here. If
you're uh imbusted, you want to be able
to be pushing forward.
>> Interesting. Okay. Go for the hard
bargain
>> on something like a blood money. super
interesting because like blood money is
kind of in incon inconspicuous by
itself. It's inospicious like oh I'll
make one gold you know for killing your
treasure hunter but because you are
trying to deny these resources away from
Renata. I actually really like the hard
bargain early there just getting
yourself it's a one for one in terms of
card trades but you're also denying just
the ability to get towards that later
game portion where you do really want
those gold gears and
>> that's exactly what you got to be doing.
You've got to be able to take that away
from them otherwise they're going to run
away with the prize. Okay, back over to
Justin now. And I liked that we saw the
fight off light there to kind of remove
a hidden card because hostile takeover
is such an expensive card but can be
hidden and then kind of played for
cheap. So they manage to avoid uh that
situation. It wasn't the hostile
takeover. So that was a shame but I
appreciated the the nottoriization of
the threat.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I agree. And going in
getting the Con Vos layer is going to be
stuck there. Units can't move to base
from that battlefield. We now look
towards I believe just playing an orn
out here. It's a little unprotected in
terms of you don't actually have any
gear so it's not getting that buff but
deflect two is so difficult to deal with
for a lot of decks. You're playing a
rebuke and you have to put four power
recycle four of your runes to deal with
this on really tricky overall. It's just
going to be a kind of voltron style hide
a card as well. And immos slice now
needs to work out when do I deal with
this forge god.
>> It's a really big threat especially with
that hidden card knowing that Renata
does have a lot of really fantastic
hidden cards that they can employ. I
think having those hostile takeovers is
so scary. Like that's certainly
something that I'm afraid of when I'm
playing into a Renata deck. I'm not very
pleased about them uh taking my unit and
using it against me. That's not my uh
not my favorite thing I got to say. Uh,
so I think it really does pose a big
threat now on this Valor's layer. Really
kind of making Valor's layer work for
you in that I can't move back to base.
Okay, well then my guys here are going
to be so strong that I'm going to try
and just keep them there no matter what.
>> It looks like and this is us with
perfect information. Of course, it is a
wages of pain hidden there, not the
hostile takeover in the end or a hidden
blade. So just going to be able to do
three damage to something coming in,
making sure that you trade effectively.
also makes you a gold gear which makes
your orn stronger. Fire one. Yeah, I
mean I I love it when I get to see
>> this blue orn. Even if it's not the
forge god himself leading the charge
that fire below the mountain. For now
though, in both sides going to do what
Dravens do, which is look through their
deck. Mind spplitter so strong,
especially if you want to get rid of
something like that hostile takeover
from hand
>> in this matchup. But is it too early?
It's not too early. They're going for it
and I think that's the right decision.
Yeah, the other option was overzealous
fan to try and add a little bit of
protection to your Kaiser on this top
battlefield, but I think getting more
information makes a huge amount of
sense.
>> I think that's exactly it. You want to
be able to know what your opponent has
in hand, especially against a maybe
something you haven't tested against,
right? If I'm playing Draven, I'm
probably not testing against Renata. I'm
going to be honest with you. And so, if
I need to have a little peek at my
opponent's hand to know exactly what's
going on in there, then my is a perfect
way to do that. Looks like we're just
testing the water here. Just saying,
"Okay, are you going to use that card?
What's the response? Yes, of course it
was a wages of fade.
>> So, we're just going to resolve that
now. Of course, no is hopeful does.
>> No, it survives through it cuz it's only
three damage from the wages of pain. So,
it still trades in with theata. Four
might into four might, which is I mean
nice for slice getting rid of one of
them. Buffs up the though for just and
then the Darius used as the
>> second card for the turn after that
stack deck earlier. Darius can now go
into the orn only has five might and now
on down as well. Nicely done by Imbo to
take back that battlefield and deny a
couple of the big threats that just had
developed.
>> Yeah, and honestly, I'm really impressed
that that came through that quickly.
Being able to take back that Valor
slayer was very impressive. And now we
know obviously they've got that threat
of uh mind spplitter in hand as well.
And they can kind of keep that pressure
up now that they have kind of made
justice board just kind of really quite
lackluster. And losing that Renato is
absolutely huge at this stage. going to
have to spend the gold as well going in
here of course to Singularity just to
try and turn the tide back in justice's
favor.
>> Yeah, just slow down in Slice as much as
possible.
>> Singularity coming out. Reaction from
Imbo is going to be the spinning ax to
make sure Draven Darius in fact now
you've got me doing it.
>> Make sure Darius sticks in there with
the plus three might.
>> And so Darius will survive through it.
Kaiser will go down but for it's like
well I'm at four, you're at two. I hold
to five and then I can accelerate out
another Kaiser. I can play my own
vanquisher if I want. Just try and
control this board just investing his
entire turn in killing one Kaiser.
>> Yeah, and that's the thing like it's
just a high cost and for little reward
at that point unfortunately with the
spinning ax coming.
>> I think it's mine split time. I think
it's really deny.
>> Yeah.
>> Do you want to know a fun fact from this
event?
>> Yes.
>> Uh spinning axe is one of the most
purchased cards from our vendors.
>> Oh, what a surprise.
With Draven being like 83 of the top 240
decks, I'm shocked shook. Hostile
takeover here most likely to be removed.
>> Having a read there going to, as I said,
understand that. And is definitely one
of the bigger threats there. We have
things like stupify as well, which you
know does help with the card draw for
your opponent, but I think the hostile
takeover is just too scary, especially
when you've just put the mine splitter
itself down because that's like the
perfect target or a great target
>> for this hostile takeover. a hidden
card, which then is so much cheaper to
play. You just need to recycle one to
hide it, and then you kind of play it
essentially for free when it's used as a
reaction. So, I think it has to be the
hostile takeover, but I can understand
not wanting to give your opponent more
card draw.
>> Yeah, there's the interesting like maybe
you take away the hidden blade cuz it is
just a direct kill spell. It would get
you two cards from it, but the hostile
takeover does have to target a unit at a
battlefield. So you could target the
Darius and ready it, but then it's still
kind of stuck at the battlefield, you
know, and
>> go for the hidden blade. Yeah, I think
that was a really good tell, but at
least they're aware of the threat now.
And that's the great thing about being
able to see your opponent's hand, right?
>> Yeah. And knowing that the hostile
takeover is there, but without any
units, just is going to be struggling.
>> And I suppose that's the thing as well.
There's no units. So hostile takeover
currently can't do anything cuz you need
to have things out of battlefield. And
that's just not possible right now
without an accelerate unit, which we
don't have. Oh, so take over on the dar.
You gain control of it. It does get
ready, but it's stuck on Vmore's lair.
Anyway, if you've drawn a hidden blade
though, you can kill it yourself now or
look for death grip, which gets you a
card draw anyway. So, it's kind of a
>> it's a way of hidden blading, but having
to use two cards to do so.
>> It's an expensive hidden blade. It's
hidden played with extra steps. Um, and
I like it,
>> but also frustrating. But going for the
stupify for the draw for the draw and
then likely death gripping here for the
final draw in the end
>> which I like it. It's removed the Darius
from the board which
>> oh decides against going for the death
grip.
>> Okay.
>> There's the scoop.
>> There it is. Just realizing that we've
lost too much momentum there. And yeah.
>> Yeah, that's interesting to me. I wonder
if maybe I'm misreading a hostile
takeover and you doesn't count as a
friendly unit cuz Death Grip has to
target a friendly unit, but
>> yes,
>> I mean, as as you said, it could be that
uh the players don't know much about the
Renarda matchup, and it could be that
perhaps we don't know as much about it
as we would like as well, but the scoop
comes out in the end. Death Grip not
going to Oh, is it because you uh Ah, I
I I know what it is. It's Death Grip has
to have another friendly unit to target,
right?
>> Yes, it does. And so you can't death
when you only have one unit. Yep, that's
entirely on me. You can't death grip,
guys. But we've got there. We worked it
out.
>> It's one of those scenarios where there
just weren't enough units. We just
didn't have enough. Even using hostile
takeover just wasn't quite enough. It
just wasn't there. And that's what we
saw with Jinx earlier and we've seen it
with Renata. And that's I think where
our more aggressive builds of decks that
we've seen do so well over the last few
days have really shown is that actually
just having units out doesn't matter
what they are. You just need stuff to be
able to target.
>> Yeah, I I like the line. I think if you
did have maybe a little bit too much
investment in the and the Renata without
too much backup there on the Varslay,
but overall great play from our Draven
players as they continue to make their
way up the standings. We're going to go
to a short break as we get ready to swap
in to the second set of casters. We've
been Medic Amy. Thank you so much for
watching. We'll see you in a couple of
minutes.
Heat. Heat.
Welcome back everybody to day two of the
Bolognia Regionals for Riftbound here.
Uh we're heading very quickly through
our five rounds of Swift today. We're
already in round two now, which is
technically uh round 10. That's how that
works of of the tournament. James Liry
joined by Leonard Kernick here to take
you through all the action here. And I'm
looking forward to this one. We just saw
some interesting decks. We saw Randy on
stage as well. So now we get to see the
names.
>> Yeah, definitely. And now in the next
few matches that we're going to see for
round 10, we have some players that that
I have been wanting to feature for the
entire tournament. We have spicy deck
list. We have big names in TCG
communities. We have big names in the
League of Legends community for this
one. So I really just cannot wait to get
the action started.
>> And this is fun because anytime we see a
spicy deck on day two, it means they're
actually performing with it, which is is
different. I mean, day one, I think we
got some good results with like a rumble
that made it towards day two, but now
it's like we're we're getting ever
closer to determining top eight, and
you're like, "Oo, Blade Teemo that is
actually competing up at that top
level." Uh, makes for quite an
interesting story. So, I I can't wait to
get into this matchup. And we've been
looking at the metagame through day one
quite a lot. Uh, I think now we get this
important break point of like how did
each deck do with getting into day two
cuz that was of course the big moment.
you were playing for six wins. You were
trying to get through into today's play.
You can see no surprises that Draven
does make up uh the majority share just
over a third of decks within the uh day
2 pool of champions, but then behind it
there's, you know, a good breakdown of
quite a few other champions.
>> Excuse me, what is Jinx doing there in
the top eight decks? There's also quite
a bunch of Ahri players. Civer I
expected almost a little bit higher to
be honest because Civer usually when
great rift bounders take that deck to a
tournament the conversion rate is
usually very very high but look at these
numbers 83 Dravens and then it goes down
to 33 and 31 on Aelia and Kaiser and
then all of a sudden the big drop to
Ezreal only 14 players and keep in mind
we had one player undefeated yesterday.
>> Yes. Uh touching on the Civiver, we I
actually spoke to to Randy a little bit
in the interview following Ry's series.
He was saying that
>> kind of going to time is really painful.
You don't want to end up in that draw
bracket uh very frequently. So a lot of
players kind of moving away from Civet
in that regard. But when you do get a
player that is able to play either the
Miracle Civet or the Aurora Civet, we've
seen results on both. So not too much of
a surprise. And I think looking at
Draven, Aurelia Kaiser does make sense
for me. Urelia and Kaiser kind of like
playing rock paper scissors of like
Kaiser wants to dodge Aurelia at all
costs and that's kind of where you get
through. Whereas Aurelia is looking to
feast on any Kaiser matchups that they
can play up against.
>> It's really a hard counter match up and
there are so many different matchups. So
many miracle decks as well. I think the
burst of Jinx that made day two can also
be explained by the mere fact that this
deck can also just run miracle versions.
We have seen ones that are slightly less
miracle and even go into the discard
version of the deck with a super mega
death rocket.
>> But yeah, I think that many players
wanted to go for metal cards just
decided, hey, put three seal of discords
in my deck, Ezreal Prodigy, and then
we'll see where we're going from there.
>> We're not playing the champion so much
as just uh you know, playing playing the
archetype of the deck and making it
work. Uh we'll keep tracking best of
stories throughout the rest of the day
and we're heading into our round 10
match, our first series here on the
feature match together for the day. Um,
and we got an interesting one. As you
said, a a Teemo player on board. Teemo
on duty for round 10. I believe it's
going up against Ireelia,
>> but we'll take a look at the the Teemo
deck list first. That is the good old
Specimen, a TCG caster as well. I've had
the pleasure to work with him a few
years ago. He is incredibly talented,
not only funny, but also a really strong
player. And he has decided that it's
time for some miracles as well in the
Teemo deck. plays triple Ezreal prodigy
seal of discord and is also playing
nocturn horrifying but now I want to
mention one thing usually in origins
that did not play scout but the other
team the mind teamo forgive me I don't
know the name by heart those were the
deck list that were playing nocturn
because you could look at the top five
cards of your deck when you're defending
but this deck actually just goes for
cold shot and stack decks and tries to
get the nocturn out that way
>> but also like looking at this as like
this version that has pit crew as well.
We'll touch on it within the game too as
we look over at the Urelia. So Urelia um
I know we've had some on broadcast. It's
actually yours my first time casting
Aurelia. So Aurelia is essentially a
deck that
>> revolves around making sure Aelia can
score as much and be as mobile as
possible. Same with Lonely Parro uh
relies on things like Guardian Angel and
Combat Tricks Hourglass in order to keep
Aurelia alive. Uh, and really important
to just move around the battlefields,
get as many points as you can. Uh, and
then just kind of like defy, uh, hold
through things. Not so fast is great.
And Defiant Dance is signature spell key
for that big swing of might in a battle,
like in a showdown situation.
>> Defiant Dance is it's it's like a spell
Thousand Tailed Watcher, right? It's
>> strong. If Thousand Tailed Watcher also
made your unit stronger.
>> Yeah, that's true.
>> It's it's so bad. like minus two for the
opponent and you get plus two, you're
like, "Yes, I'll take a four might swing
any day."
>> It's really, really good. GG easy, says
Specimen with the bling bling chosen
champion, the Teemo Scout.
>> Wow. And if you want to get a GG easy
Teemo, uh, what you have to do is attend
a lot of Nexus Knights, uh, and get a
lot of Nexus Knight promo packs and be
lucky to pull one out because it is one
of the most coveted cards that comes
from those Nexus Knight promo packs, at
least from Origins. cuz I actually don't
know whether it comes inside too.
>> I'm I'm not too sure about that. But
also about the Teemo deck, you have a
builtin two drop. It is phenomenal. It's
not really in the Draven meta. I will
give you that that two drops aren't that
important anymore, but it's really cool
that you can just play your chosen
champion unit on curve.
>> Yeah, it's a good two drop. Another two
drop we've seen a lot of is the lonely
parro on the other side for Aurelia. Um,
for me I I've been wondering like how
good is it compared to like Watchful
Sentry and Ahri. I'm like, do I want a
two drop that is going to draw me a card
every time or a two drop that's slightly
stronger that might draw me a card? And
I think I'm leaning on the side of
Lonely Parro. That extra might can be
quite helpful. Uh, not such a factor in
this matchup cuz this is not an AI
match, but Teemo is going to go over to
the battlefield for the first point of
the game. And the candle at Sanctum is
also another trigger that you can use to
find that Nocturn. In this case, of
course, it did not happen, but you're
looking at the top cards.
>> Yeah, of course. Cuz uh players that
maybe haven't used Nocturn too much. If
Noctturn is revealed, you just get to
play it.
>> Yeah.
>> If it's revealed from the top of your
deck, you just get to play it.
>> I don't even think it's revealed. It's
if you're looking at this card because
that deck doesn't reveal the cards.
Sorry. It revealed to you.
>> Yes. Yes. That that is a very good
differential that it that makes sense.
uh why it works.
>> We're going for a card sharp now. Ulia
of course kindly declines the offer to
take one gold to just not give this deck
so much ramp. And now card shop is
looking and I'm quite curious to see if
we're going to see my favorite card from
the Urelia strategy, the Stellacorn
Herder
>> anytime soon. Yeah, which is a card that
I think is is
very well placed to just be annoying in
in the meta game where it's like I'm
just going to move around and and draw a
ton of cards. Um, it's a card that I
think people really highly rated and
then moved away from. Uh, and I actually
think it's going to come back in a
little bit of popularity, especially as
more people play things like um I know
this sounds weird, but playing against
Kaiser, obviously you want the Aurelia
match up and Selicon Hunter is a great
way of just making sure you continue to
draw cards. There's a lot of like
>> bolted on card draw in this. You have
discipline card drawn her. You're
playing on the dreaming tree. Like a lot
of things allow you to draw one or two
cards throughout the game.
>> Especially with the dreaming tree,
Stellon Hera can be completely broken
against some matchups because every time
you move a Stellacicon Hera into the
dreaming tree, your opponent tries to
remove it and you have something like a
fight or flight or a flash. You just get
more draws from the card because of the
dreaming tree and then also from the
Stella corner herder. And that's where
it's miserable against like matchups
like Kaiser that rely on like somewhat
location based damage at times. It's
like you can you can defy, you can do
any any kind of thing to say, nope,
that's actually not going to go through
and I'm going to get the massive value.
>> But for the Aurelia player, if you're
dodging a spell with a Celicorn Herder
and you get extra draws, it's like
instant John Ham meme. It's it's this
instant you're you're standing in the
club and you're just enjoying alive.
This is what it feels like to get free
draws dodging spells with Celicon
Hurder.
>> I wonder how it's going to go in the
Teemo matchup. I will say this is not a
matchup that I'm as familiar with. Um
just it's not one that we see at a
competitive level very frequently. I'm
Aurelia. I'm more familiar with some of
the other matches. But when I think
about it, not a lot of what uh what Teao
wants to do,
uh you know, is the equivalent thing
that Urelia is is strong against. Yes,
there's some things like fight or
flight. There's a lot of the purple
cards that move, but not many of those
cards actually kill. I I'm looking
towards the the uh mind side of things
from Teeos deck to actually remove units
from the battlefield. So I wonder
whether there's extra value from things
like Guardian Angel because there are
fewer ways to actually remove a unit
from the battlefield or from the base
for Aurelia.
>> I think Guardian Angel is always great,
right? The card is so incredibly strong
if you put it on one of your important
units. This is a card why people just
side deck so much gear removal in their
decks. some things like factory recall
or in other decks thermmo beam because
you just got to get rid of this. But I
think the good thing about Ilia is
>> you have plays into almost every
matchup, right? Your deck it tries to
just ignore the other player, right?
You're trying to score your points with
your audacious. You're trying to just
defend. You focus on your own Urelia as
you should if you're playing top lane.
You focus on yourself. You ignore
everything else that's happening and you
just try to get your Ireelia through
>> or Draven Audacious.
>> Uh I believe it was stack deck. We're
seeing three cards. There's an edge of
knight, a card that we haven't talked
about too much yet. Um, an equipment
from spirit forge that you can hide at
battlefield and reveal. Again, anytime
you're playing against Teemo, you always
have to to to make a lot of kind of like
calculations of, okay, if it's if it's
Teemo that's hiding, what's my best
play? If it's Edge of Knight that's
hiding, what's my best play? If it's
Switcheroo that's hiding, what's my best
play? If it's Fight or Flight that's
hiding, what's my best play? And the the
key thing I'm getting to here is it's
really difficult to know the exact line
that you have to calculate past. It
really is a headache. We get the Azreel
in play. But by the way, that's the best
thing about Teemo in an closed deck list
format, right? If you're playing open
deck list, your opponent actually gets
to just see which card they have to play
around. But here, you also have to
factor in cards like consult the past.
>> I was going to say sometimes it's just a
consult the past and you don't care so
much about it, but it doesn't change a
fight. But one thing I wanted to to kind
of talk about, we were talking about
ways of removing from the battlefield.
Um, from from what I can see, there's
nothing in the main board of like a
singularity to to kind of go through.
But again, when you're trading that
against a G, you're like, is that how
you want to play that? This is going to
be like a very mobile game with a with a
Teemo that wants to use Pit Crew and
call and move it around compared to an
Aurelia who is like, yeah, I'm I'm going
to be able to survive for a while.
>> Very interesting.
>> Teemo might try to outv value at some
point. Europe. Also, playing cards like
Rebuke
>> can be incredibly important there.
dodging guardian angel after side
decking. I think Urelia always gets a
little bit weaker because the gear
removal is just coming in. So, it's
always very decisive if you're seeing an
Aelia match who wins game one because
you're on the back foot on on Elia if
you're not winning game one.
>> Yeah.
>> Of course, some people have also
dedicated some main deck slots to gear
removal. I mean, every order deck that
I've seen this weekend has played
salvage in the main deck.
>> Yeah. And while this isn't relevant to
this matchup specifically, I think that
comes from like the strength of spinning
axes and a few of the other like there's
a lot of decks that have very very
strong equipment in them, whether it's a
guardian angel, a spinning axe, um you
know, whether it's the Lucian deck that
relies on kind of the combo of going
around with the Skyfall uh and Trinity
Force. So, I think right now there's
there's value in running equipment
removal uh gear removal uh in the main
board, but then it's about like where's
that fine line? how how how much you
cram into a deck for for a game one
>> because if you're playing versus Kai'Sa
then all of that is useless. However,
I'm a big fan of cards
>> that can help you make it easier to side
deck, right? In some decks you play
something like traveling merchant.
Sometimes you have zone warrants in your
as your first battlefield. In those
decks, it's incredibly easy to side deck
because you just play risky cards in the
beginning. And if you're playing
salvages, for example, and your opponent
is playing Kaiser, you're like, "Yeah,
I'm going to discard them game one." And
then they go into my side deck. That is
very true. So options in hand. We see it
in dance. He is on his hourglass
as uh there's a Stellicorn header there.
We did just have the Aurelia Fervent
played to the base and does now have the
G. So Aurelia feels pretty pretty good
at this point. As you said, like there
is a rebuke there to deal with uh the
moment that Aelia does go aggressive,
but it's not that costly. You you're
you're actually not so unhappy with it
going back to hand. It does slow you
down, but it's it's much better than
when it goes into the trash and you have
to try and figure out ways to play
around the rest of the game.
>> I mean, you're you're losing some of the
tempo, but then again, there is so many
defies, there is so many not so fast
that a rebuke, if it's one of your like
the less targeting spells you have in
your deck, the less likely it is
becoming that they are going to resolve,
you know, because if you're only playing
those power spells that are basically
drawing those counter spells to them,
>> you're barely going to get everything
resolved. I'm I I can even see unless
your opponent is completely exhausted on
runes, I can see those cards not even
being played even if they would help
you.
>> Yeah, that that's totally fair. You can
see right now in this situation from
Crow as the Aurelia player. Um rarely
will you see an Aurelia tap out.
>> Like rarely will you see all runes
exhausted. A lot of the time at least
two stay up because there are options.
You have discipline, you have defy, you
have not so fast. Like there's a lot of
cards that can be played from here. So
you you some players might say, "Hey,
you have other plays you can make on
your turn." But know that half of this
deck is in the safety reveal of the edge
of knight.
>> This would indicate that that the card
chop is coming back to base.
>> Um, and they're afraid of losing the
edge of knight because if you move the
card shop, you you lose control of the
battlefield. So,
>> oh, and we're going to hover over the
drop border. We're not going to hoard
over the drop border. This card can come
in ready when you have gear or when you
have equipment.
>> Oh, then then that's the other half of
that, right? is uh
>> in fact you need to reveal it in order
to get it ready uh and contest the
second
>> two or more gear. All right. Okay. So
that
>> so we had the seal and then we had the
edge of knight. That's a that's a really
good read. It's actually nothing to do
with the card shop and then everything
to do with the drop border and
>> I think you could push the Ezreal into
this lonely porro, but you don't want to
give your okay, you just do both.
Specimen really wants to conquer there.
So also is willing to risk losing that
Ezreal. However, if you're losing that
Ezreal, your opponent is uh going to be
exhausted on all of the runes. So far,
there are two open.
>> Yeah.
>> And and you have another Ezreal in hand.
That's a unit heavy hand if I've ever
seen one. I don't think you want that
necessarily as team.
>> I guess you have to play around a few
things like discipline would be, you
know, plus two and and a draw a card. Uh
two ong guards would make you six. So
then you you trade.
>> No, there has to be a noturn at some
point. hasn't happened yet, but you can
just take more spells that let you look
at the top of the deck. Um, so I guess
at that point it's like, yeah, I'll put
that Israel in. And then doesn't force
out uh anything from the hand of
Aurelia, which that's Crows playing
probably quite conservatively, quite
carefully. Wants to say, okay, well, if
there is a rebuke or something on the
back end of this, I I still want to have
my counter available. I don't care so
much about the lonely power, I will get
the draw from it.
>> Yeah, the thing is rebuke only removes
from battlefield.
>> Oh, yeah.
would still be absolutely safe in the
back, but I can still see that you don't
want to necessarily trade here with your
opponent. It's not it's not units you
really value too much. Also, you don't
necessarily want to lose your GA, right?
If your opponent has some removal
spells, which is unlikely in this color
combination. Singularity is a good card
in Ezreal, but also
>> mainly because Ezreal draws you a card
off of it, right?
>> Yeah.
>> I I can't see Teemoex not playing that
card necessarily. maybe siding it in
>> now. That could be a GG easy Teemo.
We're already at four points on the side
of specimen. So, we are reaching I think
we have entered the mid game.
>> I think that's very fair to say as uh
hopefully my brain will enter the mid
game at this point.
>> I think you're I remember what cards do
for a moment. Uh, I do think there's
perhaps this is a misread for me on on
the game, but I do feel like Aurelia
does need to start contesting
battlefields, but it comes very
difficult um cuz for instance that could
easily be a switcheroo, could be a fight
or flight, it's going to delay you and
only having one unit to to contest a
battlefield that has units at it. It
becomes quite difficult at that point.
Um,
>> I agree.
>> Also, Teemo is incredibly good at
holding.
>> Yes. But maybe that was the case in
Origins when you were playing like every
single height card that you could
possibly think of. You were playing
Ember Monks, all of those cards that sit
there at battlefields and swiftness.
>> That might be the first big push for
Aurelia Blade Dancer deck.
>> And this is where it becomes scary. This
is where so we have perfect information
on the game to the point where we, you
know, have seen the cards in hand. We
know what the options could be. But if
you're sat across from a Teemo and
there's a hidden card there, you have to
calculate like, okay, what is the worst
case of this card? What what is the
worst possibility? And then work from
there. Do I have enough things to work
around the worst case or, you know,
anything else? So, Aurelia gets
targeted, will get um, you know,
additional might. We'll be able to end
up using the Aurelia blade dancer.
Legend ability now with ganking from the
boots of swiftness is going to go to the
battlefield. So, here we go. We're we're
going in, but also with still five runes
open for Kra, this is looking good. Team
O GG is going to be flipped over. The
question is, how are we going to see
some of those combat tricks happening?
We are already
>> at 3 6.
So, here comes dance. That will even up,
I believe. Yeah, should there's a four
difference between 11 and seven. So,
mathematically, if I've done everything
correctly, it should be uh the way that
it is. I think we are now at 12
>> target as well. Yeah,
>> then we're at 13 actually because we
have the guardian angel and the boots of
swiftness.
>> I missed the GA as well. There's a lot
more above what I what I calculated. So,
>> so I think I think you're very much in
the driving seat here if you also have a
counter spell because we know that there
might I mean we assume that there might
be other cards or are we just deciding
for damage here? Oh no, we're going to
respond on the side of specimen. Taps
out. Switcheroo. That's not even
massive.
>> Yeah, that could be massive. But do we
have anything in in hand forelia? I
didn't
>> Okay, it is a not so fast. I I was going
to say I I didn't get a full glimpse of
it. But not so fast going to come
through and at least deny the
switcheroo.
This is whereex play really well into
single target spells.
>> Wow, look at this. It's just completely
clearing off the entire field there.
Trading so well on the side of Urelia.
Momentum has swung now. Ulia has forever
ganking now because of the boots of
swiftness. This is looking fantastic for
Kra.
>> We're we're in the mid game. The runes
do not resemble that, right? It's right
now 5 to four. So, we are constantly
recycling those runes to go for more
power plays, to get some more tempo. The
Urelia is in the prime position. This is
where you want to be as Aurelia. Now we
actually get to stage
>> fast. Right. Right. It's surely at this
point you just used one to refill that
off the candlestick sanctum. But I guess
the the problem is
that leaves you with shields down a
little bit for for the turn. I mean not
that boost of swiftness does anything
different and just deciding the order on
it. But there is a moment now for
specimen where potentially this Aurelia
for a a turn is is more vulnerable.
since uh no not so fast in hand.
>> But I mean you need more removal there.
I'm quite surprised actually. Wow,
another zone. Yes,
>> I'm I'm quite surprised that in the last
turn specimen decided to hide the Teemo
in there and not the Switcheroo because
the switcheroo therefore cost a lot
more. And I mean it was kind of to be
seen that the Aelia can really get big
in that turn and and go in there because
you have to expect at least 85. I mean
you can't you can't I was going to say
Switchery is not so fast or nobody's
really running Wind Wall main boards. So
and that's quite a blowout at that
point. I was going to ask like at this
point how how important do you think for
for Teemo the the rune recycling economy
is because there is a seal. So that did
at least account for one of them. um
which then means you're either recycling
one to hide the switcheroo or or the
tee. So you're kind of going neutral on
that in some ways.
>> Like do you think that affects it too
much? Is our team player like worried
for economy on runes?
>> I mean as a team player you generally
just pay pay energy to to hide your
cards. So I I do not think that that is
>> the biggest problem unless you want to
have some runes open in the end game
there. Okay. So I I think that Specimen
now after being so on the back foot with
this last turn, you know, the not so
fast really took away a lot of the
advantage that he had built up, I think
we're going to try and build up a lot on
the base there. I do not think you can
afford to push the KH into the Dreaming
Tree right now because just going to
take
>> ganking. Yeah, exactly. It'll come
across.
>> So I think you're going to try and set
up this turn for another push later on.
But I have been looking at the list of
specimen that you've been seeing in the
beginning. I do not know how many pushes
he realistically has. However, cold shot
repeated could find one or two knocks
because at some point you will have to
find
>> hasn't found one off the first now.
Looking for what the option is. Cole I
think we already have one in hand.
Doesn't do too much. So uh probably the
cold shot. I think that is what indeed
went. Okay, there is one.
>> There we go. That means the other card
naturally goes to hand, which we're
quite happy about going into the next
turn. Although um
won't be able to accelerate the watcher.
We'll go up to seven runes on specimens
next turn.
>> I mean, your opponent is going to get up
to six next turn with Urelia that has
ganking. Pig pocket is gear removal in
the main deck, but pigpocket
exclusively,
almost exclusively works on seals. I
mean, there are some cards like Warbox
armor that you can pop, but
>> for the first time for me in Bolognia, I
get to say, "Oh, pit crew." And we get
it. Moving to the dreaming tree with the
call. This interaction uh just has
something that has tried to be worked
out by by players at the top level where
you get a pit crew, you equip a call
because when you conquer, you're going
to create a gold token. Pit crew is
going to untap, you're going to be able
to move it back and and keep it safe.
It's something that a lot of people were
playing against Draven early on just to
try and say, "Okay, well, if I can avoid
combat, especially in Ezreal decks, then
uh tends to be good. So, uh this time
just going to go sneak a point and move
back. At least that that means that
Aurelia sitting on the battlefield is is
not the end of the world on things.
>> We've jumped into another game.
>> We're getting a look into the future
here." Uh
>> we're back.
>> There was a little teaser, by the way.
You saw Rocklo.
>> We like casting time warp.
>> Exactly. on in every game as possible.
We are of course running with a little
bit of a delay. So just a glimpse
potentially into what is coming later,
but you know an amuse bush if you would
to uh wet your appetite.
>> It's a nice teaser for all of you League
of Legends fans, fans of professional
play. That was actually Prime League
player Rocklo from Prime Cray. So uh we
got some stars in the house,
>> but here we we've got a Teemo still
going with specimen. So we will continue
to focus on this. So Aurelia moves
across to pick up the six point goes to
uh kind of you know that that winning
stage now if you're able to unt untap.
And here is where it's significant
because the one of the ways of dealing
with Aurelia at least in some way for
this turn would be to watch her and can
you reduce the might without actually
targeting her.
>> Not going to be able to play the watcher
even to base nonacelerated.
>> Yeah. I mean, you said it. This is one
of the winning turns you're setting up
with six six points. And I'm very
confused that Krauss has developed a
Stellicon Herder because that card is
very unlikely going to have an impact in
this game. Right. You have a double
protected irrelia, you have a zona's
hourglass, you have a guardians angel on
your Ireelia.
>> There is a I think there is always a
world in which you want to keep up as
many runes as possible to threaten your
opponent. is the thought process here
that like
>> I'm looking at what my opponent has
economywise in this. They're gonna have
to throw a lot to go through a GA and a
ZAS and then on the back end if I can
just equip things to a Stellicorn with
like the the boot swiftness.
>> Stellicorn will do the job of going from
battlefield to battlefield potentially.
>> I get your point.
>> Yeah.
>> However, I think Elia is so great at
pushing because every time you choose
Aurelia, you get one extra might.
>> Of course. I I I'm just saying like is
it a backup strategy? It's like, hey, if
I need it, the teleon is here.
>> I I I think it is. And I I agree with
the backup strategies sometimes, but
>> also sometimes
if you're playing for your backup
strategies, you lose the main most
convenient way of winning the game.
>> So, but we're going to see. I mean,
Krauss is so far ahead. I don't know how
many cards there are in hand for them
because maybe there's also like
completely bland in cards in hand then
there's no reason to keep all of those
runes up, right?
>> Um really really sounds like a small
thing that might be a big thing. Um is
it also to do with the fact that there
is only one green rune and therefore you
can't represent having both defy and not
so fast.
>> Yeah.
>> So it's like hey okay why bluff when
it's not even possible?
>> I think so. There's a few things. This
is always the fascinating thing for me
watching the the players at this stage
in the tournament is like it's
impossible for us to know the exact line
that results in the plays that that are
happening. We can speculate on what we
think is indeed the case as pit crow pit
crew goes up to the candle sanctum and
will of course now kind of put specimen
also up to six. This is quite intense
situation to be at.
>> We found a cold shot on top of the deck
and a stack deck. So more cards to cycle
through. So, we put this stack deck on
the bottom of the deck, which I
definitely agree with. You do not want
to reveal a stack deck with your cold
shot. You would rather want to find your
cards that have an impact. Specimen not
really happy with the situation
apparently, and I think that has to do
with the your foresight before.
>> This is not a watcher turn. And watcher
is a card that can get you out of sticky
situations. Even though in this state of
the game, if you're committing to a
watcher, there's nothing else you have.
>> Yeah. And that's the thing is like
watcher maybe if you can if you can
survive this turn watcher will probably
win you the next turn like win you the
game on the next turn but how much do
you have to expend from this now? I mean
there is I believe a seal and there's
one untapped gold gear. So there's a
little bit of a leeway on the power side
of things. But it's it's energy that is
is the problem here because you only six
untapped uh awakened runes available.
Makes it not even an option to play.
What can you do on the side of specimen?
So there is an Aurelia with seven might.
There's zona's hourglass. There is
guardians angel and there's probably I
mean Kra does not look like he has any
cards in hand to be honest. the way he's
sitting there with the hands on the
chair. That is not a usual TCG position
to sit in when you have cards.
>> I'm pretty sure there's a not so fast in
hand. Uh we I don't think have seen it
since it was put to the top of the deck.
>> Um I'm trying to think what else we had
seen earlier cuz I knew the Cicorn was
there. It's been a little while since we
actually saw I think obviously the
Defiant Dance was used.
So I think Spessie has a decent chance
to go for a push here that takes out the
Aurelia is not going to just take it for
free. So there is going to be trades and
it's also going to just trade away the
guardians angel.
>> And I think again it leaves leaves you
in a situation where you have to assume
there's at least one counter here. So
you need to win this trade just with
units.
>> Yeah.
>> And then hope that you have something up
potentially for the next turn. If you if
you can have hidden cards, maybe you're
using the gold, maybe that'll allow you
to maintain control of this battlefield
next turn. But this is a a very complex
situation for both Specimen and Crows to
play out.
>> There's actually three cards in hand. We
just haven't really seen them before. So
that's quite a bunch.
>> The more I think about it, the more I
agree with developing the Stellacicorn
Herder. Specimen hasn't revealed too
many cycling cards from his hand. So the
hand has been sticking around quite a
bunch. There were so many cards like the
pick pockets that have been sitting
there for ages. If you play low
attention, if your opponent isn't
playing too many different cards,
>> nothing used, just the zas.
>> Yeah, that there won't be too much
flexibility. I I like just using the zas
before because you keep the might.
>> And importantly, again, newer players, I
know that we've got people watching that
that perhaps haven't played a lot of
Riftbound because Aelia doesn't
technically leave the field of play. The
the status of the unit doesn't change.
So all of the the equipment stays
attached. The GA stays there, the boots
of swiftness stay there. You don't have
to do anything else. Next turn, you'll
awaken, be able to use that Aurelia
going into a battlefield, and then gank
across using the legend ability.
Specimen is putting that Azreel onto the
dreaming tree, trying to hold there. Kra
is going to have a decent push in the
next turn. You can easily take out the
pin. Look at the
>> no hidden cards. So, wait, what is in
hand? It's a watcher. It's a knock. I
didn't quite see. It looked like all
units. So,
>> yeah, it's double pickpocket.
>> Okay. And then Watch. Yeah.
>> So now Aelia awakens which means she's
getting ready getting one more might.
You have
>> five might on Aurelia. Eight might in
total. 11 if you count in this Delicon
Herder. You can just push the pit crew.
Then you need something to choose your
own Aelia. Make it ready be able to gank
and then I think you should be golden.
>> Yeah. Speaking of golden, I think there
was a Zas that came off the top which
for League of Legends players will
understand what I mean by that. uh that
effect
being uh prevalent for many many years.
So there's the first battlefield scoring
up to seven and that must be relieving
to see for Krow because specimen did not
think for a single second if he wanted
to respond to that.
>> There's a defy out of the candle sanctum
and then potent you didn't see the
second card. I don't see what's going on
top. So essentially you're setting up
what am I disciplining if I have one in
hand like what am I what am I getting
and also dreaming tree. Oh, sorry. It's
not a Zagnas. It's a guardian angel that
came up. There is a discipline. So,
there is discipline not so fast in hand.
I believe that's another Stellicorn
Herder underneath. Um,
>> and I think that should be soon came on
board because you can just choose this
Aelia once more with the Guardian Angel.
>> And here's the other backup strategy.
Stellicorn Holder moves to the the
battlefield of the Candleit Sanctum
because when you all in here, you're
going to try and clear the battlefield
and just in case it's an even trade,
you'll be able to go to your turn
potentially with a teleport. Now, we
know there is a watcher in hand, but uh
that doesn't necessarily pan out. But
this Aurelia, I would imagine, will be
strong enough to go over the line here,
>> especially with the top deck discipline.
Top decking discipline into a dreaming
tree field that is being occupied by the
opponent is so huge. huge. That is two
more and specimen picks up the card
says, "Yep, that's GG. You got it." And
Urelia takes down that game. And I think
we all saw when it went downhill for
Specimen when Kra took over the game.
That was this pivotal not so fast on the
Switcheroo.
>> Yeah. And and it felt like we we you
know, we were saying it's about time
that Aurelia needs to start contesting
and then turning the corner at exactly
the moment in the game where you can
turn that advantage for yourself. I'm
interested to see the sideboard come
through. Now we got Adaptatron. I mean,
there's not too much gear in there to do
hard bargains there. What would you be
looking at from this sideboard of of
what you want to bring in? I mean, I
think versus a deck like Teemo, it
sometimes becomes a little bit iffy to
conquer. So, Adeptron is not the easiest
way to get rid of those seals.
>> Yeah, sorry. I I I was bringing up this
in the sideboard. I actually don't think
it's is what you're looking to sideboard
in. I was uh I set you up for me
sounding silly on that. Uh I was more
just looking for your opinion on on
what's a sideboard.
>> No, I I think adaptron is actually it's
actually decent because you saw cards
like drop border in the deck list.
>> Sure. Yeah. Of specimen. So he is kind
of relying on gear as well. So gear
removal does make sense. However, if
Teemo wants to, you can make it really
hard for your opponent to conquer
especially in the mid game. But if you
find if you go second, you drop the
adapter early, your opponent starts with
something like a seal, they don't
necessarily it's tough. On the other
side,
>> hate it.
>> Do you think gear is more important then
with like factory recall? Like where
where do you think you go here? Because
obviously fight or flight and switchery
we saw kind of run into canes quite
heavily.
>> You go factory recall and hard bargain
in this one. You have seen how your
opponent plays keeping up two runes
often times. Maybe that was just a game
one situation for them. But uh when you
hard bargain it's just a fantastic
counter spell if your opponent is on two
runes and then goes for something like
not so fast. While we're here, I want to
draw everybody's attention to the bottom
line power nexus as a battlefield. We
don't see it very often. So, my
interpretation here is on a game where
you're able to get the pit crew rolling
and get a lot of gold, you can just kind
of dump uh dump that uh recycling power
into getting additional points. We very
rarely see it. This is not a battlefield
that that many decks can actually
utilize. And I'd be interested to see
whether Specimen picks it here because I
would imagine that's like a going first
battlefield because you need to get the
pit crew out and get that gold really
early is my my interpretation. Again, we
don't see it.
>> I mean, if you're going second, you can
develop the pit crew immediately.
>> Sure. True.
>> And I think what's kind of cool is that
>> But you can't play cull on it.
>> Sorry.
>> You can't play the cull on pit.
>> That's true. You just do it next turn.
>> Yeah, true. But okay, maybe you want to
go for K pit crew in the second in the
second turn if you go first. That also
does work. But I think it's really good
that it's your not giving your opponent
any advantages. That is the candle at
Sanctum was also able to stack Crow's
deck while Specimen was never able to
find noturns off of it. So there was not
that much of a benefit. So your opponent
got the same amount of resources out of
it as you did.
>> Fair. There's uh I I will admit the uh
the math there is taking me down a a
line that maybe doesn't quite add up.
Sneaky deck can going to sneakily take
an early point. This is something that
we uh have seen a lot out of Aurelius is
playing directly to the battlefield. It
is Arena's greatest
>> that we're playing so quick.
>> Yeah, that is that is also interesting
to me to see the sneaky decant there. If
you see a Teimo developed on the first
turn, I I mean sneaky decant might be
able to hold here.
>> Yeah,
>> that is good. But then again, you could
also just play the sneaky deck into your
base and then look at your opponent and
go, "Hey, do you really want to move
that Teemo into a battlefield?" Also, if
you're on the four turn, you talked
about it before. Pit crew plus Kull
would be of tremendous value here. Then
you would have no unit. You would be at
only four, five runes on the side of
Urelia. You would have very little place
to accelerate your own units. And then
Specimen all of a sudden would hold with
a Teemo and a pit crew, go up to three
already, get some gold, move in the next
turns. You know, that could be kind of
strong.
>> I must admit, we're in the hypothetical
realm where I feel like what I said
might actually just not work out. So,
here is a pit crew. Here is a a seal to
untap it cuz
that is also incredibly strong just to
have the pit crew ready here to take out
the sneaky deck hand and then the Teemo
might be able to hold in the sunken
temple. That is tremendous value getting
just to get it out of a Teemo. So, nice
tempo plays. going to see why this deck
of specimen is playing the arena's
greatest. Again, I I understand that you
want to hold, but versus a pit crew
deck, I think playing sneaky deck hand
into the base and then at least forcing
your opponent to spend one energy to get
the Teemo back to hand.
>> Mhm.
>> Could have been a play you can think
about.
>> Now, do we have a follow-up to untap the
pit crew and bring it back to safety?
They're not the biggest concern because
Aurelia with no units out probably isn't
going to contest the pick crew on this
specific turn, but Aurelia does um later
in the game, you know, have have options
to to kind of punish plays like this.
There is a factory recall. We saw it
come out of the sideboard
>> um will now go to hand. So very adapt at
uh you know, taking care of things like
guardian angel at least for for the
moment that you need it, I think, is the
is the key point. The card is so
incredibly important in that matchup. I
mean, that's what you're citing it for,
right? You want to take care of this
irrelia with a guardian angel on action
speed. You want to have this blowout
turn where your opponent then basically
realizes they lost because they have
played too bravely with their Ireelia.
And I think what can you actually do
with five runes up? You can play a
Stella Herder, but can you even choose
it with too many cards?
>> You know,
>> oh yes, you can.
>> You can. Yeah. And then it's going to be
an on guard. I I was I feel like I uh
had a total misread on this cuz of
course Aurelia is going to untap the the
Stella like whatever unit is played but
with targeting. So
>> I mean I mean you need to find something
that only costs one energy, right? You
were at at five. So I think that is it
is reasonable to predict that this deck
is not going to find something there.
Silicon Herder now moves into the GG
easy Teemo and Teemo unfortunately will
find his way into the trash. So you
can't really rely on this constant
resource anymore. But so far the deck of
specimen, it looked like it was just
more of a miracle deck. So I do not even
think that you're profiting that much of
hiding Teemo again and again and again.
>> Yeah, I I wonder this is one of the
considerations that we've talked about
is like how much of playing Teemo is
wanting to try and aim for the Teemo
best off card and how much of it is uh I
think Teemo's the best
>> Yeah. uh champion and legend to be
playing in this domain. I mean so many
decks running purple just playing a
version of the miracle shell.
>> I mean I love the fact that you can
versus non-draven decks just play a two
drop from your chosen champion zone.
>> Yeah,
>> that is I think a massive upside for the
team strategy. Also very interesting to
note with the ong guard stellacon herder
play. You got to mighty status with the
stellicon her got to the sunken temple
but then there was not enough energy
left to draw a card from that. So that's
maybe a slight bullet dodged for
specimen there even though he lost his
oh so precious Teemo.
So there's some sequencing that can
happen
like looking to see whether there's a
way of getting uh that second
battlefield to to be contested if you
wanted to. I mean that hidden card
always makes it a little tricky. Um
our card spotters are are showing us
fight or flight. So, uh, I'm going to
make the assumption that that was what
we saw got put down by, uh,
>> fight or flight, by the way, not the
card you want to use on the Stellcon
herder.
>> That is that really does not feel great.
Going to see an Estri being played into
the arena's greatest battlefield. So,
>> yeah. So, no, it's okay. I I was just
looking at at how maybe uh Ooh,
>> it's a disc that's a discard. Ku is
quite the high value card, especially in
this matchup. But you do not want to
play into defies. You do not want to
play into those not so fast, especially
not by spending two power cost. Play out
a cull ready the pit crew. Do you
actually Okay, you are going in here.
You're not playing around crazy hidden
cards. Pit crew is being pushed into the
Stellacon herder on the sunken temple.
There's one energy left up. What is the
hidden card that Kra has? I think that's
what the the fight or flight that's my
assumption of of what it is, which you
can use, you know, on your own Celicorn
Herder and then you're like, "Oh, that's
fine. I'll I'll take a card and trade it
for a card." I'm I'm trying to remember
what else this Aelia list actually runs
for hidden cards.
This was kind of what I was wondering is
like cuz Pic will go to the battlefield
from, you know, playing the call untaps
it. Uh go to the battlefield. If you
conquer this, you'll be able to untap
and awaken the ready, sorry, the the
picker again, move it back to the base,
and you'll be you'll be safe.
>> Does leave your Ezreal a little bit
um vulnerable on the other side, but
there is a hidden card there, of course,
and we've already talked in game one of
how many decisions you have to make to
try and figure out what that hidden card
is going to be and and you know, make
the least costly play. There is a fight
orflight on the Stellacicorn Herder,
which is of course,
>> let's let's call it a one for one trade
on the side of Kra. You're losing a
card, you're drawing a card with Stellon
Herder. You're keeping your Herder
alive, but also you paid a power cost
for this. You are so dram.
So, the D- ramping will not happen in
the next turn for Specimen. Now decides
to get the pit crew back to safety.
Sunken Temple. You would need a lot of
investment to get a draw out of the
sunken temple on the side of Kra. But
Krauss now at five has a unit developed,
has a bunch of cards in hand. It's a
Stellacic Con herder. You can get quite
the draws off of it. You can set it up
for success and then combat your miracle
deck with some draws there. Yeah, I I do
just worry though that the dramping has
it done too much to kind of slow down an
Aurelia at this point where the pit crew
is just like doing the loop just going
around the track picking up everything
both point like two points every single
turn. I mean
>> sadly for for specimen we actually end
in a situation where they're they're off
uh the even tick of the game. It's not a
24 68 game. You're you're at five uh by
the looks of it now. So you kind of have
to spend a turn getting it up to six and
then go for another one.
>> Stacon her on the guardians angels being
pushed into the Ezreal. I really I
really got to go back again like the
turn of specimen to push the GG easy
temo into the sunken temple because that
forced Krauss if he didn't want him to
double hold to invest so much into the
Stellacicorn Herder leave the
Stellacicon herder there then also pay a
power cost to put the fight offlight
there. So that's also another power card
you're losing, right? And then he was
completely out of resources to get
another good turn. That is a factory
recall on one energy left. Is this going
to be combated by something like a not
so fast?
>> Yeah, I I'm trying to remember whether
we had one in hand or not. Uh isn't
going to be used if it was. Um
>> of course the the reason for that not so
fast does count enemy spells that target
gear. Yeah,
>> that's a very specific thing. It's units
and gear. Uh,
now is the question. How much do how
much do you sink into keeping this
teleorn herder alive?
>> I think you really need to use it. I
think you need this Stacon Herder. Your
opponent is already at five points. Oh,
we're going to go for the on guard,
>> which is the cheapest option at this
point, which is good. It gets it done.
It gets the work done. It will uh keep
the her alive depending on what this
hidden card is. Obviously Teemo here is
a problem because you can't counter the
Teemo. Okay, fight or flight on the
Ezreal.
>> That is huge.
>> Can't be not so fasted because it
targets the Ezreal, not the Stella. So
that is another significant point of
this. You'd be looking for a defy would
be basically the card here that that
would deal with this, but it's not going
to happen. We'll bring the Ezreal back.
>> Giving the point over, realizing you
don't have to panic for points in this
situation. Your opponent is still far
behind you. And if Krauss wants to play
the guardians angel now, you're going to
have to pay another power cost. You're
going to have to again dramp to three.
He is keeping the pressure up while
Krauss constantly has to damp recycle
runes and stay out of the mid game.
>> Oh, and it it will be dramping
again. And now you kind of have to
represent again options on two two
energy available. Options with two runes
up like what what is there? I mean, we
know the divine dance is in hand. No, I
think it's two copies actually.
>> Yeah,
>> that is there.
>> If you just push into the Stellacon her
and two defined dances happen,
>> then there's no runes to play with,
right?
>> There's no counter coming. So, you can
fight or flight or whatever version of
uh of spell that specimen has to turn
the tide.
>> I like that the players are having fun
though. Oh, another pit crew is being
played. That's massive for tempo. Pit
crew is being pushed into the sunken
temple. Getting a gold gear token
exhausted. But your own pit crew, the
second one that has just been played,
can be
>> ready. Yeah,
>> if you have another gear, you can even
retreat the pit crew from your the
sunken temple, then make it ready again
and then two.
>> It's like, is there an edge of knight?
Is there another seal in hand? Anything
like that that would uh potentially give
you now two pick crew on tap? No, it
doesn't look like it for now. We're
going in with a single pick crew to play
on an even playing field between the two
cuz you know if this is fight or flight
well then you just send something else
in. You you have other options going one
unit at a time. Defian dance is going to
come through.
>> So investing the first one. So now this
turns off the knowledge that it could be
a not so fast at any point in this
matchup. It could it could basically be
a defive but down to two runes.
>> But I I mean down to two runes is
absolutely crazy, right? You have used a
power to hide a card in the arena's
greatest battlefield just to use the
defiant dance from hand. You're going to
go down to four. You can't even play
your own Aelia fervent next turn. Now is
is it time for a switcheroo because you
know that you cannot be Yep. There is
switcheroo coming. Pit crew is on five.
Stellicon Herder goes down to one. What
other cards can you use on the set of
crows?
You if you want to D ramp down to one,
you can use the other defiance dance,
right? So you switch and then you're
going to even trade. It'll you'll both
be three. But do you even want to do
that? Is that even
>> Oh, the fighter flights. Sorry. Yeah, it
was uh was hidden. So we'll react with a
fight or flight before switcher and
switcher is people at the same
battlefield uh units at the same
battlefield. So that that of course is
the uh the easier way out of that.
>> That is that is really well played for
him with the immediate reaction of the
fight off flight. And that now means
that a a subsequent uh showdown is
harder to break through because now the
Celicorn header is five already.
Switcher is gone. You kind of assume
probably harder to get through. No, no
reason to to kind of rush into it.
>> Thing is, you're already at six on the
side of specimen. Just retreating the
pit crew here could be a decent spot
here. your opponent is not going to go
anywhere with holding to five,
>> which that's an interesting conversation
cuz as I was saying, we're in a game
where Specimen was at five, only needed
to get to six from the hold. So,
actually, was it was there maybe
presence of of just saying, "Okay, I'm
not going to throw anything at Cicorn
Hoer this turn or or is it in this
situation useful to burn the Aurelia
resources and say a pick crew for UD
ramping twice is actually worth it for
me?"
>> 100%. I think you want to starve your
opponent out as much as you can,
especially when you're up on points,
right? Then it's really worth it to just
slow your opponent down the most. If
you're getting closer and closer to that
victory,
and it certainly feels like Specimen is
getting closer and closer at this point,
looking on four
four runes, what is available? There is
a charm in hand, but you know, that's
that's not exactly the spot that you
want to be when your units aren't on a
battlefield. It's going to be d ramping
now into looking like an untap.
>> Wow.
>> Like ready the Stellorn Herder and equip
the G. Move to a battlefield. Maybe
>> this is so difficult.
>> Another energy is being used by specimen
to respond. Are we going to stack deck
here on
declaration?
Are we going to use it on action speed
just to get full use out of our energy?
You just
>> will pass priority. let it resolve. But
I mean, I think you're you're just
absolutely fine with two runes being
open on your opposing side. Krauss has
managed phenomenally so far in this
game. Du is always avoid the big pushes,
but he's keeping himself low on the
resources.
>> He has so many cards in hand. I mean, if
this was an Aelia or even a Stellicorn
Herder, but he would be at eight runes,
this would be impossible to win almost
for a specimen. to be pedantic, but just
as uh somebody who loves Celicorn Hoer,
um just whenever you go into a showdown
with a Cellorn Herter, remember it's a
move trigger for the draw. Yeah. Uh so
>> could have been significant. Not in this
way cuz if say the top card is like a
Defy or something like that changes that
before you pass priority, right? You
don't want if your opponent like has
something and then you're like, "Oh, oh,
the top card was defy." Actually, you
want to sequence that properly is like
get your move trigger done first before
the the showdown becomes uh active. And
of course, you then get priority as the
active player. So, just I know the
players are shortcutting. Of course,
we're in a feature matchup. It's just
something for that I I always like to
try and say for people who are at the
nexus knight and stuff like that. Like,
there's these little reminders that are
useful to keep track of
>> as uh I I don't think I can I don't
think it's possible to understate the
amount of pressure that goes on as a a
feature match. I mean, you've played
many in your time in in other car games
on a national level. Uh, so you you very
much can speak to that of like the
pressure of being in this moment where
you're looking for top eight and every
single decision in interaction is like
highly scrutinized by both yourself,
your opponent, and everybody watching
like us. We're just chatting about it,
but
>> there is a lot of pressure. There is a
lot of things you have to Oh my
goodness.
>> That timing on finding a factory recall,
not even from the stack deck. Sometimes
the deck is stacked already.
>> Yeah, exactly. So sometimes you just
find everything you need now stack deck.
Are we going to see a Noctturn? Is
Noctturn perhaps a card that you side
out in this matchup?
>> I was also wondering whether you side
out things like the rebuke, some of the
copies and a little bit of the the fight
or flight because of the counters, but
Noctturn in very Mile could be one. Um,
>> there is a defy and that is something
that I kind of like. You want to give
your opponent to a hard time, right? You
you want them to not find another
option, another out to your Stellicorn
Herder there.
>> Yeah. Although the pro so I guess wow
are you going to zero if your only card
that's castable right is
defiant dance I see a charm in hand as
well there so
you're basically saying well I don't
want you to have any options
>> but I basically don't have any options
for myself. Uh yeah, exactly. And I
think Oh wow, using this immediately. I
allowed this play from specimen to not
go into the combat there, but to say,
hey, if you have another Defy,
>> you can use it now and then take Yeah,
exactly. The combat becomes a whole lot
easier. Uh and also, you know, we talk
about this in card game. Sometimes you
just have to make them have it. And if
they're using a stack deck, searching
for an answer, maybe the other card in
hand isn't as useful. A lot of the time
you do use your least useful card first,
but a card like stack deck, I don't want
to let you see three cards. I really
don't want you to be able to look at
more.
>> That's absolutely true. Now, honestly,
when we're looking at this possible game
shot from specimen, I I know he needs to
play, we know he needs to play around
the defined dance. I think he's very
well aware of that. This opponent has
sequenced his plays in a way that there
is only one rune left available, but
it's open. There is so many cards in
hand. The thing is, is it enough to push
with three units? Let's count.
>> Well, as much as let's count, I agree.
Uh there is only 9 minutes left on this
round. Just under 10 minutes. And this
is of course an extremely important game
and for specimen needs to be able to win
this and then potentially win the next
game. Uh for for Krow looking obviously
to close this out as a 2 and 0 have to
consider time at this point. Yeah,
>> you can't spend too long adding up. If
you are specimen
>> thing is if you clear the stellic corn
herder somehow if you push every single
unit you have
there is defined dance can only do so
much right.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You know it's a four might
swing. So you just need to be above
four.
>> So if you push all of the units in there
you go to seven and then how are you not
going to hold against three runes? What
what is happening from three runes that
is threatening you?
>> Yeah that's very true. So, it's three
36.
>> I think it's very understandable that
the players are taking their time. Of
course, sometimes routes to victory seem
almost too easy, right?
Also, there's always the option that we
are missing something.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm wondering what we're
missing cuz isn't it
>> All right, I think.
>> Wait, but hang on. Isn't this a way that
you trade down? Am I missing something?
That Ezreal plus the equipped pick crew
or the other pit crew plus the Ezreal
was seven and defiant dance math would
be three. It would
>> Yeah, maybe it would be even trade and
you lose both. So maybe at this point
>> and that is a little bit annoying
because if you're trading I mean you're
not trading down afterwards, right?
You're not losing the might so you can
push the two pit crews into the Stellon
Hera. It's basically still the same
thing but now you know what you're
dealing with. There is no
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. And you get the other
side of it. Yeah, there's no rune left
open. Your opponent is going to
basically start the game from scratch at
only six points with two runes and a
full full bunch of cards in hand.
>> Wonder what we're discussing here right
now because that seems like a
>> minusing the might. Okay, this is the
other way is if the divine dance doesn't
have to target the Ezreal.
>> Oh,
>> so you actually
the pick crew that's in base and now
>> so now it's still even. So you you lose
everything if you go in on the
battlefield here. But this the teleon
her eyes dies to push everything there.
>> That that was I guess this is the the
the the the real fine detail here is I
was wondering about just moving with one
unit if that was enough. I didn't see
the line of uh targeting the pick crew
in the in the base and that does then
force you to go elsewhere.
>> So get up to seven. Now you get another.
I think you're definitely trying to hold
here, right, with the seven because
otherwise your opponent is going to go
to seven, push back into the base, and
then play just something to target.
>> Crows can't even boot the swiftness cuz
that's three.
>> I think specimen is really still just he
just needed to get this rune out of the
way to push seven might into the arena's
greatest and then try and hold. And now
it is on Crows. Wait, what can crows do
in this scenario to get rid of this
situation?
>> The answers just aren't aren't great
because it's like
>> I think it's on guard define dance,
>> but you have Yeah, I guess cuz you can
untap the the
>> Stelicorn Hesy bring it back legend and
then a pump spell
>> potentially gets you over the line.
>> I think if you defiant dance one of the
pit crews, they're only at five might.
You will be at five. I'm pretty sure
they were counting how many there. We
know that at least two have been used.
So, this is going to have to be a great
top deck. What is it? Didn't quite see
it.
>> There are two card combinations that get
Kra out of this sticky situation. Oh,
come on. Show us the cards you have in
hand.
>> I think that's discipline hiding.
>> Oh, there is a charm. Oh, picks up the
boots of swiftness. Those won't help. I
think charm would also be a way to get
this game one. But you also need another
one.
card,
>> right? You have to then target the the
the Celicorn
>> Herder.
>> And that is also Yeah.
>> the pick up and Specimen clutches this
game out here.
>> Yeah, that that one got quite down the
rabbit hole on like in the tank on on
calculating. Ultimately, I think the the
the headline of of how that goes is I
crow damping so much like forced to damp
so much through the game really just
left you with very few options on the
Aurelia to actually play that out.
Definitely. I'm baffled by the fact that
Kra stuck in this game the entire time
and with so little runes that he still
had left, he kept pushing and pushing
and even had some win conditions in his
deck on two runes in the last turn
because if that would have been Defiant
Dance and On Guard, I think he just wins
that game. He just gets a double pointer
there.
>> Yeah, that's that's fair. If you if you
had it, that would have uh very much
have been it. I uh I think as well that
defiant dance clearly uh clearly crows
has having a lot of these situations
where you're like, "Okay, my opponent's
only moving one unit in, but I can
target the backline. I'm thinking about
the second showdown that's coming." Um
>> always interesting to look at that. It
It's one of the things I find
fascinating in this situation is like I
can think of a line that that I know and
then you can think of a line that's
probably better than my line, but uh
it's never always the same line as as
what the players have in games. So, it's
always really interesting to see these
adaptations that players make in a spell
like Defiant Dance where you do get two
different effects that are happening uh
on the resolution of the spell. Very,
very interesting game. Um I I feel like
I've learned a lot, but I need to like
decompress and let it soak in.
>> I think at this point I'm not ready yet.
>> I also find it funny how many different
ways of winning the game there is. Of
course, you can try to push out your
opponent. you try to force a big conquer
or you did it like specimen did it and
just say hey I'm going to let you use up
all of your protection on your one unit
in your battlefield but then I am going
to push in the other battlefield and I'm
going to hold there so I'm going up to
eight so not necessarily searching the
fight but avoiding that fight sounds
like we are ready for an interview
following round 10. Hello everyone. I am
joined by Crows. Congratulations on the
win. Nine and one now. The top Ireelia
left in the tournament. Everyone else
has either drawn a game. So there's an
8-1 and one or has lost two. How does
that make you feel?
>> That's that's incredible. Honestly, I
did not expect to be the top Aelia, but
I I guess at 91 it kind of makes sense,
but people are right behind me, so I I
can't really let up here.
>> Is it a deck that you've practiced a lot
with or did you like take some time to
decide what you wanted to bring in? No,
right away I was I was on Aurelia
playing on on uh TCG Arena online and
practicing a lot against a lot of decks
and the deck just felt really good. It
fits my play style relatively well. So
yeah, I'm pretty happy.
>> Oh, awesome. I mean, you should be none.
You're definitely looking at those top
eight spots. Is there You have a couple
more matchups still left to go obviously
on the day. Is there anything that you
think would really ruin your chances of
getting into the top eight?
>> Yes, there is a deck called Rexi. If I
hit Rexi, it's going to be rough. I've
practiced a lot against it. It is not a
good matchup. So hopefully I don't hit
it.
>> Do you mind elucidating to the viewers
about exactly what's making that a bad
matchup?
>> So the problem with the Rexai matchup is
that they draw they see so many cards.
They're very fast and they have the best
removal spell possible against Aurelia,
which is co the week
>> and they they almost always find it
because they they see so many cards with
Rexi with the signature spell as well.
And they have so much might in the
backline with the phoenixes that come
back. It just creates a point tempo for
them and a card advantage cool for them
as well. And if you lose Aelia, usually
the game is pretty much over.
>> All right. So, if you're teching into
that, and you can tell me if this is too
much, right?
>> I can reveal it as well.
>> Yeah. If you're taking into it, how
would you be side decking? How would you
be sideboarding?
>> So, for sideboard, I just try to bring
in uh more counter counter magic. So,
hard bargain for example, another defy
in the sideboard. And uh in my main deck
is is definitely a little bit tuned
towards Rexai. So it's not as bad as
like uh the list I was starting off
with. I have uh Porros in the main deck
for example. That's definitely a good
card against Cold of the Week cuz you
draw a card off of it if it's in a
different zone. So that's been very nice
for me the whole tournament. I have not
faced Rexi, but
>> All right. Well, we're going to let you
go get ready for your next round. Is
there anything you want to say to your
friends, to your fans out there before
we do?
>> Honestly, shout out to my opponent, uh
Joe from Into the Rift Podcast. Very,
very cool guy. It was a really fun
match. If you haven't seen it, I mean, I
guess probably if you're watching this
interview, maybe you you caught the
match. Really awesome game two. Game
three, unfortunately went to time, but
you know, it is what it is. I still
squeaked it out.
>> Well, good luck on the rest of the day.
Hopefully, we see you back in the top
eight. Maybe even for a winners
interview.
>> I hope so.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Thank you very much, Mic. Uh, and just
to clarify, uh, unfortunately, we
weren't able to bring you game three
from that series, but as you can see,
Crows was able to advance uh, in that
match against Specimen. We're actually
going to utilize our second feature
match here to get one more game from
round 10 at least and hopefully we can
see some more players advancing
throughout the day. Leo, that was uh you
know, as Chris said, a fun game, but uh
from broadcast perspective, I'm I'm just
going to hold my hands up and say there
were so many options in front of the
players for what could happen. But we're
going to go into a totally different
matchup here as it's going to be Azia
versus Ezreal. and Azir, one of the the
decks that came into the tournament,
people were saying, will it will it be
able to um you know, it will be Azir
versus Ezreal? This is a Kaiser, but
Azia coming into this one. Um a deck
that people said, will it have the same
success that we saw in a second place
final in uh in regionals for China?
>> Yeah, I mean the deck is quite strong.
Here we are seeing a Kaiser deck list,
which is also a great deck, but of
course, Ezreal plays a little bit
different from Kaiser. utilizing similar
spells like for example the singularity
just Ezreal has the upside that you're
drawing a card because you're targeting
two units in the same turn with
singularity the downside of having to
pay a power cost of two mind runes and
there we can see Rocklo's deck of Azir
and this is actually a very very similar
list to the one that got second place in
China you're seeing the sacred sheers
which is a card that is
>> not the best in Draven matchups but it
is phenomenal in every other matchup
because this card wants you to lose
combat so you can get draws off of your
tokens. Draws are rare in this color
combination, but this uh also granting
Draven draws, but now we're not playing
this as Draven, now.
>> Yeah, exactly. It's a very different
situation at that point. Running two
copies of it. We'll see whether it has
an impact on the game. Um we'll have to
just uh be on on the lookout for which
version of Ezreal it's going to be as um
>> there's a couple. There's P crew Ezreal,
which we kind of just saw a Teemo take
on that. Yeah.
>> the miracle Ezreal that we've seen and I
love the new Ezreal where it says like
playing big stuff and flickering it with
pack of wonders and that kind of thing.
I would love to see if it was that
version but uh
>> it's actually Kaiser.
>> It is actually Kaiser. Okay, cool. All
right. So, the deck list we saw was was
correct.
>> And it is Kaiser and it's against so the
death nail still quite important then
from those shears.
>> That is true that we we're seeing a
Raven Bloom conservatory as well.
That might be there's the battlefield. I
actually dig that Raven Bloom
Conservatory in Kaiser. It is more of a
greedy version where every time you
defend you look at the top card of your
deck. You have a bunch of fury runes by
the way. Look at the top card of your
deck. It's a spell. You can add it to
your hand which is in I call it we call
it spell stinger Kaiser. Okay. Is a very
consistent version of drawing cards. Now
Kaiser being played on four. Is there
going to be some immediate removal? I
want to say this is Brave versus Order
decks because K the week is a real card.
>> Yeah. And now you get a little recruit
token from the Eye of the Herald. You
get an, you know, the option to call the
weak just off something really really
like insignificant at this point.
>> Oh, that's a card. It's a brutalizer.
Okay.
>> Okay. So, that's that's the one moment
where you really really really want to
have the cull the weak.
>> Yeah. In this matchup, I would say that
the vile mos layer is going to be quite
important. A lot of what Kais' likes to
do is, you know, take at least from
Origins is take us Okay, it's it's not
as efficient as color week, but it is
brutalizer equipped turn.
>> Oh, that is crazy. You just reduced the
Raven Bloom Conservatory. You're
becoming a defender because you're in
there char the Kaiser in you find the
death grip because quite frankly, yes,
you're playing lots of gears, but you're
also playing lots of spells. You don't
play a single unit in your deck.
>> That's nuts. That is so efficient at
this point. And I was like, it's not as
efficient as K of the week, but you
know, it does the job. Does everything
you need.
>> I mean, you lost a lot of power. We're
going to say it like this,
>> but Kaisa lost chosen champion and lost
a big unit for the early game tempo
where you're like, I want to be able to
draw. I want to be able to get early
points. I want to contest and then
ultimately keep my Kaiisa as safe as
possible.
>> Yep. There is going to be there has to
be another push. You're going to try and
have to start removing those Soldier
tokens otherwise Rockler is going to
just hold everything. You're not at a
watcher turn quite yet, but you also
don't want to damp so much.
>> Yeah, Falling Star then, you know, it'll
do the job, but it's going to damp at
least one. Um, I do want to note we are
going into this is game two of three
between these two as Azia has already
won game one.
But now I want to mention that this is
going to be perhaps
if you do not have any more equipments
because you already have played two
equipments of yours. This might slow you
down a lot with the falling star
clearing off two units. So Richard maybe
not even too sad about losing a possible
watchot turn on the next one going down
to then seven runes in the next one.
Mind and fury. So Rockllo now has to
consider what he can do. I mean there is
there is equipment. Oh, that's the best
friend sword.
And uh there's a friend there.
>> It's Yeah, I was going to say Azir BF
sword is in hand. But Azir
>> going to be played from the champion
zone. Uh Azir sovereign falling star is
going to deal with that. You're like
great, you had both of them. Cool. Azir
is so not sovereign anymore. He's
actually quite dead if you will.
>> I will say this is the uh origins feels
bad where like do you have falling star?
Cool. Do you have two falling star?
>> Cool.
>> Not cool. Like I'll give you one. The
second one is uh is bad mannered at that
point.
>> We're seeing another eye of the herald
sand soldier weapon mastering the eye of
the herald. And this is something that
Azir sometimes suffers from and that is
not success but it is hey you have a lot
of runes open. You could go for big
power plays, but in the end, you can
just make one sand soldier token. So,
while you're getting a lot of free value
with these sand soldiers, you're
sometimes losing a lot of tempo if you
can only make one. But there are plenty
of spells in the deck, power spells that
will give you more and more and more.
>> How important do you think that the Azir
Sovereign like chosen champion staying
alive is in this matchup? Is it as as
influential as other matchups?
>> Uh, fair. I think that answers the
question quite succinctly. I'm going I'm
going with a very consequent
>> cuz cuz some legends and champion
combinations are like really
specifically strong. So here comes a
piercing light is going to get the card
draw cuz you'll uh deathnell your own
>> won't death nail your own watchful
sentry anymore because the defy comes
through. So obviously Felix uh valuing
keeping that sand soldier on the board
more so than giving the card over to uh
to Richard. I don't even think I can
remember when I saw someone piercing
light a unit of their opponent in the
battlefield any anymore. Feel like it's
always just push one of your units into
the battlefield. Most of the time the
watchful sentry and piercing light it to
snipe something from the back row. But
now of course we have
defy of that. Apparently we don't need
our runes because we've seen that in the
last turn. Question is now do you even
push into the Raven Bloom Conservatory?
I don't know if you want that because
you're going to just trade for the Eye
of the Herald. Oh, not even giving your
opponent the draw. So, perfect choice
there. Plundering Cororo is going under
the deck. Still going to grant a draw.
>> And the shortcut there is don't even
bring the token out.
>> Yeah,
>> just just trade it with the sentry.
>> I like that. So, now we're going to get
another Azia token that is going to
equip the BF sword. And we're passing
again. So, we made a five might unit.
Yes, with the sand soldier. That that's
BF sword is so important for Azia. I
want to say BF sword is way more
important than the Azia sovereign
because every single turn you make a
sand soldier token and that lacks
strength at some point, right? When you
have a
>> please.
>> No, you you were continuing. I was
getting ready to follow on.
>> So it you make a three drop every turn.
You make a three might as soon as you
have one BF sword in play.
>> Boom. Fivers every single turn. You have
a fight might token that is so much more
efficient. So now how much of this game
becomes thermmo beam and wind wall?
>> Yeah, thermmo beam is incredible in
that.
>> How much of that is uh you got to hold a
wind wall if you have it from sideboard
to
>> basically counter the thermmo beam which
blows out the entire board you have. I
mean, I think if you just keep your wind
wall. The good thing about the Azir deck
is you don't need to spend that much
energy, right? You don't use your runes
that much. You have your your equipss.
You want to play one equip per turn to
make a sand soldier. You want to have
the wind wall ready for a thermmo beam.
So, it's going to be quite tough for
Richard to actually resolve it if there
is a wind wall in hand. I think this is
something you would want to mulligan
for. But also you want to thermmo beam
before a rise happens before because a
rise gives you infinite value almost.
>> I think there was a progress day they uh
dropped as it was picked up and thank
you to our our team that are here using
the card viewer that we can see showing
what we were talking about with thermo
beam and wind wall and the importance of
both as uh
>> we're into a showdown now. Discipline
comes through onto the sand soldier.
That is a big old sand soldier at this
point. Oh, Rocklo wants to get not only
a draw, but also wants to keep the sand
soldier around. Yeah, that that one has
10 might now, right? Goes down to nine.
That would still be more than enough to
clear, I feel like. Or was the
brutalizer not equipped this turn?
>> I think it was equipped on Felix's
previous turn.
>> All right, that would make a lot more
sense then, unless Richard just wants to
cycle through some cards.
But we're picking up the draw from
discipline. And now it's back to who is
going to use which priority. Do you want
to commit even more to this? Nope. We're
going to take the even trade. At least
that's not a hold anymore. That's what
Rockllo can say to himself. Now thing is
if you had an arise, would you drop it?
Get all of those equipments attached or
do you say, "Hey, I need to kind of
always
have the wind wall available because
that is a massive Oh, wow. Going for
two." No. Oh, maybe sorry. Maybe it was
equipped on the previous turn. I I
misread where we were in the turn. So,
there is going to be a sand soldier
equipping the BF sword is uh
so we have another five drop. BF sword
makes this deck infinite times better
because every single token just imagine
you're playing Victor and all of your
drops are five drops. All of your
recruits are five drop tokens. That is
the power of BF sword which is why it
also costs you know for okay progress
day that is oh my goodness we already at
12 runes on the side of Richard he has
been ramping up he has gotten more
points than rock it's a very slow game
in terms of points but that's exactly
what Kaiser wants right slowing down
your opponents so you can have those big
clearing turns yeah and the the progress
day we talked about this a little bit
yesterday uh a lot of decks were
bringing this in for Kaiser basically
because Draven was drawing so many cards
you're like well just won't take combat
as often. This should be okay. Yeah.
Okay. I was going to say it's another
unit coming out for the Legion cost of
Nox is hopeful as uh Plundering Parro as
well. Just trying to reassert a little
bit of uh control for the following turn
by developing that board. You know what
I would like to see from Richard?
Richard I I don't know if it's
pronounced German or English, but
Richard should go for a double thermmo
beam turn.
Oh, so you can get the wind wall with
the first one and then thermmo beam if
well I mean if you can get there you
progress date so maybe there's maybe
there's one or two in hand.
>> I think there is very little chance that
Rockllo is ever going to leave up less
than three runes right so there's always
going to be wind wall available and I
think you need to cycle through your
deck as fast as possible to just
capitalize on that and say hey you know
what I am at 12 runes I am going to drop
double thermmo beam on you so that your
precious wind wall turn has done
nothing. Then we see the sacred shears
which is going to make this match up
much harder for because then we might
actually find a double wind wall.
>> Richard had the same response I think a
lot of people will have seeing that is
uh can I just read that for the specific
text? Three, four, five extra sand
soldiers are going to be spawning as
going in. So we get seven free units,
two of which are ready. Oh, what are we
going to see? Stupify
>> draw a card. See what we can get for
potential next turn.
>> All right. And now the the craziest
thing is they have weapon master, right?
So you get seven units and almost all of
them will get to attach an equipment to
themselves. Now you can choose which
ones are the most important for you. I
think the ones that are getting ready,
they will get the eye of the herald,
right? Or the secret shears,
>> right? Yeah. Just to get extra value.
Yeah, it's going to be I we we'll see
where it actually ends up being because
there's a lot of sand soldiers coming.
Looking at following tent, I think for
for Richard, one of the the
less than
good parts is uh isn't the Kathleen Rain
in hand. And that normally would deal
with, you know, multiple units on a
board, lots of units, but these now have
additional might coming from equipment.
That's the importance of the the the
weapon master part of this is like
you're not going to be able to deal with
this with just one swift to cathon rain.
I also saw I think it was a rocket
barrage um if that is the correct name
of the card in hand. It's the one where
you basically have two modes you can pay
for and either deal damage or or destroy
a gear and you can repeat it.
>> Um
rather than a thermo beam that does tend
to be a a sideboard card. So looking for
utility.
um
our spotters.
>> I hope that that is the card that has
been played. If there's an unchecked
power in deck, then uh that would be a
significant significant card to play for
Richard.
I mean there there's he definitely needs
something.
>> I mean that would do it if uh if there
was check power.
>> If you clear with a thermal beam all of
these equipments, it's still going to be
quite tough to handle all of the sense
soldiers with the new iteration of the
Kaiser deck. By the way, I have to
redact what I said earlier. Rise does
not give you two scent soldiers plus one
for each equipment, but it's it's one
for each equipment in there.
>> And then ready to Yeah, exactly. Um,
>> so Watcher is going to be able to
obviously reduce a lot of the might that
is sand soldiers on the battlefields.
Then, you know, if you can get rid of
the equipment, the Athenian Rain can
help. A Cathium Rain can also pick off
some of the ones that aren't getting
additional might. So, maybe there is
something there, some recruits as well.
feel like a Cathion Rain is also a card
that has seen less and less play. So, so
some people have put it back into their
decks, but with so many more counter
spells in the game, like hard bargain
and especially not so fast, gets really
hard to drop this card sometimes.
>> Yeah, that's a really not advantageous
trade. Uh, also that was that minor
adjustment with the Ratata. Some people
do think it has reduced the power of a
Cathian rain a little bit in the way
that you have to select everything uh
and have it resolve uh kind of up front.
um
>> having the death grip now as a chain to
the thousand tailed watcher before the
minus three applies.
>> Yep. So you can actually get those five
might transferred onto one of the eye of
the herald sand soldier tokens
>> on the Valor's layer.
>> So that would make it much harder to
clear there because I think we're still
at then nine might then. Wait, let me
check. Your eye of the Herald does
nothing when it comes to your might. So,
we have one, two, three, four, and you
Yeah. You're still at nine. You get a
five extra.
Yeah. Oh, and that is so good. This this
equipment distribution from Rocklo is
phenomenal because
the one Sand Soldier token that you had
in the Raven Bloom Conservatory at the
Sacred Cheers. You're
>> killing one of your own units at the
conservatory to boost your VO slayer
tokens and then you force your opponent
Yeah. to to to get you the card draw.
>> There's a hex tech right going to just
deal with a little recruit dealing with
>> just one of the units. So now we're down
to
>> I mean can seven on we we'll we'll have
them figure out the math. There is a lot
of uh of calculation to be done on this
one with this many units all being
affected of course by the thousand tail
watcher and then the death grip on top
of it plus all the equipment
which it is going to go in and take out
the recruits will be able to take
control of vile mos's layer that
thousand tail watcher is now there so
aside from having a retreat or something
like that in hand it is now stuck in
Vmore's layer and
>> I mean now you're in a decent position
on the side of you're getting Another
point for conquering the vile moors
layer. Now Rockllo, he still has a lot
of runes open. There is still quite a
few sand soldier tokens. I think there's
two more in base, right? And if you have
those two in base, you can just equip
any amount of gear equipment to them. I
think we're now currently discussing how
much might we had. I was kind of curious
because I figured Oh, wait a second.
No, you pushed for five might, but that
five might got reduced in the end. So,
you had four tokens there. Two were sand
soldiers, which is four might after
watcher, but you got five to it. And
then three of those got reduced.
Then again, it was only minus three
because the sand soldier token was at
two. Oh my goodness, this is hard. I am
not wondering why sometimes the players
need a a second to just uh get the math
done. But of course, we are finding
correct game states here. Sometimes, you
know, I'm really bad at math, so
sometimes I get confused in in the
process, but we got it done. We have a
Sun Soldier with the brutalizer
attached, which is not the best one
because this is primarily the one that
you want to attach to something.
Wondering if we're going into the Raven
Bloom Conservatory. Richard is now
completely exhausted when it comes to
his runes. Raven Bloom Conservatory is
going to reveal a lecturing yodle. That
is not only a card that you don't get to
add to your hand from the conservatory,
it's also a card that you would have, I
think, like to draw.
Yeah, that was uh quite a turn in uh
deep in the tank of
math across the last two. So now we we
we'll see where Felix goes with these
sand soldiers. There's uh of course
Felix now at this point one and zero up
in this matchup as we go through round
10. So we're floating
to order runes.
Therefore we can equip the sacred shears
and the BF sword to those two sand
soldiers. And I think now we have to
crash them into the thousand tailed
watcher.
So what one has one and when one has the
other? The watch is just going to trade
against
>> I think.
>> Oh, are they both equipped to the one
soldier? Okay.
>> Yeah, that makes
more sense. Wait, sacred sh
How much additional might do you get?
Was it one or two?
>> It's one.
>> I think it's one.
>> So if you put a BF sword, you get to
five, you get to six. So you actually
have to push another sand soldier. That
one is not equipped with anything, but
you get the draw still, of course,
because you put both equipments on one.
And now you're going to play another
sand soldier.
The desert's call
weapon master immediately. Such big
units on the one side and on the other
side you have another free three drop
that is going to have death kneel draw
one card. So, the value you're getting
out of this deck if you play it
correctly is absolutely phenomenal.
>> Yeah. And there is a lot to kind of
moving all of these equipments around.
So, a couple cards to note in hand.
There's a not so fast in hand for Felix.
There is also the wind wall that we
talked about earlier. So, any moment in
which a big spell is looking to resolve,
whether it's an Athenian ring, which we
know is in hand for for Richard and uh
potentially a thermmo beam, although
we've not seen it. and the fact that the
rocket barrage is there. I do wonder
whether it's e either of them are kind
of mainboarded for for the amount of
equipment that we've seen in the
tournament.
>> So, we uh we'll continue to take a look
as we get through the deck of Richard.
15 minutes just under 16 minutes left on
the round for these two players.
>> I mean, Rocket Barrage, I think, is it's
a cool card.
>> It's very expensive.
>> Yeah, it's in Germany we say it's a top
of the Heisenstein. So, it's a drop of
water on the hot stone.
>> Okay,
>> that really doesn't make too much sense,
does it?
>> I have the visual of what's happening
when you put a drop of water on the hot
stove.
>> You pay eight energy to power to get rid
of what? ABF salt and a brutalizer and
then your opponent is still sitting on
four equipments that are chilling there
and you spend your entire turn
>> exactly
>> getting rid of barely anything.
>> I I mean, when you're playing against
like some like an Aelia with G, maybe
that's the way maybe that's the tech
here to to step outside of this matchup.
Kai'Sa has such a miserable Ireelia
matchup. Maybe this is like just to
attack like if you get a G and AS with
that. Oh, you actually suddenly feel a
lot better if you're spending a lot.
Even if it's just I'll pay it once
without the repeat. Take care of one of
those things that are there. May I I can
see where that would be like I I need to
try and tech for my worst matchup first
that I'm going to hit more often and
then you know maybe it'll help in the
Azir matchup.
>> True. I mean Azir doesn't have the
biggest meta share, right?
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> So the deck is not everywhere. It's a
force to be reckoned with, but you
cannot there are so many decks in the
room. You cannot have you only have
eight cards in your sight deck. You
cannot have a side deck plan versus
every single deck or
>> you got to be got to be slim on that
one. You got to
>> you can have a plan, but you cannot
prepare your side deck specifically for
every one of these decks. You can have
some cards that do help you generally in
the matchup. You would sight in the
rocket bares, of course. Singularity,
time warp, cath rain, some big big
spells in hand. It's about getting there
to the uh to to being able to use them.
We're at five. So, Richard is nearing,
okay, his units aren't, but Richard is
nearing the the point at which a time
warp would be like a way to close out
the game, but you have to get to the
point where you you control
battlefields. Is there a way of getting
up to seven?
I I'm I'm looking at it. Is there any
way to kind of on Felix's turn retake
both battlefields or is it just that'll
untap going to seven and then time warp
to eight? Is that possible? Oh, I mean
you've spent so much energy already with
the thousand tailed watcher this turn. I
think it's going to be tough to to time
war there. What you I
>> not this turn obviously, but on on the
following turn. I think you're you're
very easily going to be able to to clear
those battlefields unless there's some
crazy combat tricks that I have not
heard of in in in Rocklo's hand. The
thing is with I'm
>> there's a discipline, a death grip, uh
two double wind wall as well. That's uh
so actually time warp is a dangerous
play in this situation. You get blown
out heavily by that. But the thing is
that Rockler will need to take two
fields and he only has one sand soldier
token in base. You can use your
discipline here to take care of the
Noxus
>> hopeless sanctum first
>> and it's the conservatory. Sorry. Yeah.
Yeah.
>> It's actually good that you revealed the
Doran Blade because that's not the card
you want to draw in this situation. This
card barely does anything for you. It's
one of your early drops where you can
make one sense token when you're
starting with two runes and you have a
three drop. That's phenomenal. But now
let's see. We have discipline.
Discipline makes it so that the Noxus
hopeful is weaker than the sand soldier.
Is there going to be another card that
is going to be used by Richard to take
care of this situation or are you not
going to conquer there? I think if you
have something like a void seeker, which
I think we have seen, you need to use it
just so that your opponent does to hold
there.
>> Yeah, it was a desert's call that came
off the discipline.
>> I think you I think you really want to
void seeker this and then push the
lecturing yodel in there. So you go to
seven points and then hope that your
thousand tailed watcher survives or
you're just playing.
Okay. So, apparently that's
>> I was going to say brutalizer doesn't go
to the to the trash the uh GA.
>> Okay. So, the guardian angel was on that
sand soldier token. All right. The
shears. All right. So, this was also in
the battle phase. There's still the sand
soldier with the shears. Got a little
bit got a little bit full at that
battlefield there. I'm not going to lie.
What a complicated game state. Another
hidden card, hidden blade this time to
keep
>> the units low for Richard as uh
>> Rocklo knowing that if you can just
control the battlefield, you have the
wind walls available to kind of deny the
hold from seven going to eight on time
warp. And we know with perfect
information that Rockllo has the ability
to stop.
>> Oh, the rocket barrage. There's the not
so fast. And immediately handshake
offered by Rocklo just to win this game
here versus Riyad. He is going in with
the rocket barrage. Tries to get rid of
some of those units, but nope, not so
fast.
>> Yeah, we didn't even get to the time
warp. Didn't even get to the denial.
Well, I wanted to see the wind wall on
the time warp, although it feels bad if
you're a Kaiser player for that. But I
think, you know, Kai'Sa was so dominant
in set one that I'm I'm fine seeing some
some some other legends rise their way
to top. But congratulations to Rocklo on
the win here in round 10. It of course
we are still playing in Swiss rounds, so
this is not elimination moment um for
Richard. We'll we'll have to keep a
track through the standings as as we go
to see how that goes. But Rock is on his
best way to win the best off for Azir. I
think there's one more in competition
and that win definitely helps and that's
an
>> how hard is it to play versus Azir if
all of those sensor tokens are sitting
there. You have to keep track of so many
different pushes your opponent can have.
>> Well, you know who we should ask about
how difficult it is to play Azir? Maybe
Rocklo. Uh let's hear from him now.
>> Thank you so much, Felix.
>> Thank you.
Oh,
>> that's really exciting.
>> Great energy.
>> Hello there.
>> We we would have heard from Rocklo. Amy
heard from Rocklo. We'll uh we'll see
whether we can get that interview
perhaps for you later. Uh it was quite
the the board state in that was kind of
intense and messy for my liking. I'll be
honest, it's one of those things as a
player I'm like, whoa, that is a lot to
keep track of. You need a you need a
full minute to really understand how
many sand soldier tokens are in which
battlefield then how many are in the
other and of course how many are in
base. Plus if you remove one or two sand
soldiers from a battlefield, you just
know that the equipments are going to go
back to your opponent's base. So they
can move over to the other sand soldier
tokens. You have to keep in mind that
costs of course some power. But how is
the math working out for you then? Which
energy will they have open in the next
turn? In the turn after that, are they
still going to have a rise pushes? It is
so tough to play versus the tech. And I
think some players like Rocklo are
capitalizing on it.
>> Well, please know when win this time war
because let's go to our interview with
Rocklo.
>> Hello. And I'm back with our feature
batch winner, Rocklo Felix coming in
with currently the top Azir list in our
day. Why did we choose Azir? Uh, I feel
like the funny thing is everyone I talk
to always ask whether I play for a metal
card, but honestly when I um I think
everyone plays for a metal card.
>> Yeah.
>> But I chose the deck to win out. Like
that is uh my intention, but everyone is
like so surprised why I play as here.
They're like, are you only playing for
the metal card? So, uh, yeah, I feel
like the deck is great and I feel like
the skill expression is very different
than other decks because you just have
to do math all the time. And since I'm
good at math, I thought Azia is a
perfect choice where I can combine math
and skill. Uh, and the strongest
signature spell in the entire game, like
uncontested. If anyone I will fight to
death that Azia is the best signature
spell in the game. So, um, yeah, I
always tell everyone
>> it's great.
>> It's great, especially if you draw a
rice. If you draw a rice, it's the best
deck in the game.
>> I love the confidence so very much in
your deck. You know what you've got
going on. You know your matchups. It's
clear that you're a very, very skilled
player. You came over from League as
well, playing a bit of League of
Legends. Is there anything that inspired
you to come just a little bit? Is there
anything that inspired you to come over
to Riftbound, or was it just a natural
progression for you? Um, I always played
like TCGs. Uh, I'm not dropping names,
but uh, beforehand I also played
competitively some other TCGs.
>> Great.
>> Um, and in between I always was a
professional player for League of
Legends.
>> And when I I've heard the news that
Riftbound is coming out, I knew from
that day when that game comes out, I
want to be like the first professional
player in that game. Like if anyone uh,
like
>> that's you.
>> I I love the IP. Yeah,
>> I love TCG and I believe in right games.
They did a great job with League. I'm
pretty sure they're doing a great job
with Riftbound. So, it was pretty simple
and clear for me that um
yeah, I will put my life into this game.
>> You were like straight away, I'm in that
cooking pot. That is a bit of me. I am
absolutely in there. I love that.
>> I played like 22 skirmishes.
>> Wow.
>> In um two like in the first season.
>> That's that's a lot. Like we haven't had
a lot of time for those yet.
>> Yeah. With a friend. We won more than
75% of all of them. So we
>> were you playing Azir in all of them?
>> No, no, it it was Origins.
>> Oh, of course.
>> We played Kaisan set.
>> Oh, I love set. That was my deck for
Origins.
>> Yeah, I played a lot of sets and um
>> I won all of my buys with set.
>> Amazing. That's incredible. And you
Yeah, you're going really strong into
these competition now with those round
one buys. So, you can feel confident
that you've got that kind of rest in the
morning. How's it feel to have those
kind of banked up and ready to go?
>> Um, the funny thing is like even though
I can sleep longer,
I I'm here around like 9:00 a.m.
>> Anyway, ready to go.
>> Yeah, because I I talked to one of the
uh info point guys. Yeah.
>> And they said it could be a problem at
10 10:00 a.m. yesterday. So, please be
here at 10:00 a.m.
>> And um yeah, I like to be on time. So, I
was here like at 9:30 or something,
>> as you should be, honestly.
>> Yeah,
>> you know, prompness is always helpful
and you get yourself ready for the day
and it's a really fun environment to be
in. Anyway,
>> I've got a little bit of an Azir
question for you if that's okay. If you
have six runes open, right, do you
prefer to play like more equipment first
or do you just want to go aggressive
early with your rise?
>> It really depends on how many equips I
have. Yeah,
>> if I have six runes, that should be turn
three. So, I have two equips, that's not
the point where I should play a rise.
Um, especially game one,
>> but I will think about it on game two
and three because people sight and tmo
beam.
>> Um, and the thing is as soon as I
activate a rise and I can clear the
whole board, I will do it because then
he's forced to tamo beam again and turn
skip himself and I get four points from
it. Um, so I think uh it really depends
on game one, game two, do you play
against red or not? Uh, how does your
hand look or uh can you play as a
champion unit for free in your base? I
think those are like all the factors
that you need to take account take in
account or for example if he goes to
seven and can mind splitter maybe just
drop the arise um
>> or for example if you have to conquer
because you're he's not allowed to hold
then you have to drop it and just run
over a bot
>> because then you either have BF sword or
brutalizer and you can always go in with
seven and no no bot on earth that
>> yeah like this early.
>> Yeah. No, no, absolutely. No. That
honestly that's such good insight. Thank
you so much. It's very clear that your
mathematical brain is so attuned to a
deck like this. I believe that you could
take it all the way if you you having
that feeling right now. Could you take
it all the way to the win?
>> I just try every game.
>> Yes. That's what I'm talking about.
>> Of course, I'm confident, but
realistically,
um yeah, I'm I'm very close to the metal
card. Oh,
>> I already won with my friend two metal
cards from the prize wall.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah, we got Kai'Sa and Teemo.
>> Oh, good choices. Good choices. There
any others that you would go for
>> if you if you could get a third right
now?
>> Yeah. The problem is always the price
>> because I wanted to I wanted to take
Azio to play Azia today?
>> Of course.
>> I I I wanted to like maximum aura farm
and and and and and unlock the gold the
gold medal with the N medal. But
>> but the problem is the Azas. Let's say
sadly it's too cheap. Yeah, it's not
that popular.
>> You can popularize it. That's what's
going to happen today. Everyone start
getting your Azir right now.
>> Well, thank you so much for joining us.
Your insight is unimaginably useful for
any Azir believers out there. You've got
your champion right here. You've got
someone fighting your corner who truly
believes and is exceptionally good at
the deck. Thank you for joining us. I
wish you all the best of luck in future
rounds. Very good luck to our top Azir
players so far.
>> Bye-bye.
>> What a wonderful opportunity to talk to
one of our champions today. Still taking
it far in the competition. And we've got
so much more where that came from. I am
Amy and I'm joined by the wonderful
medic once again to bring you the action
at this regional qualifier in Bologna.
>> Yeah, round three of the day. Round 11
in total I want to say as we get into
the action soon again. And but before we
do that, we're going to have a look at
some of our favorites and MVPs from
yesterday. Now, some of these I think
perhaps haven't had as good a showing as
we would have expected them, but let's
have a quick mossy at what we all
thought was going to be great. Well,
okay, here's the thing, chat. Here's the
thing, everyone. Horn with fire below
the mountain and speller is a really
cool combo. It's one of the favorites.
Just cuz it didn't get to day two
doesn't mean it's bad.
I'm leaving you with the silence there
on that one. I'm sorry. I can't I can't
back it up. But my my pick Okay. Yes.
Jace Mana Progress with Vanguard Armory,
I think, is a really fun combination in
those kind of Victor style decks that
we've seen come out. I think Vanguard
Armory on its own is a very powerful
card, but just being able to mitigate
that cost.
>> It's so good.
>> Yes, please. Yeah, you and I kind of
went for the ones that are our favorite
combos.
>> And then James and Leo kind of went for
the ones we expected to see a little bit
more, I think, here. The uh the pit crew
cull from Leo. Such a powerful
combination. The ability to go in with a
cull, make a gold, retreat the pit crew
out after readying. It gives you a lot
of ability to dodge those Draven
combats, which is what most decks have
been trying to do. And then obviously
James coming in with the Fizz and the
Vex, the ability to reduce the cost as
much as possible from those Fizz
triggers.
>> Yeah. And I mean I to be honest with
you, I think the one we've seen the most
is Leo's pick.
>> Yeah.
>> But I think that was also to be
expected. Now on the other side of the
coin, we of course have our picks for
the meta MVPs, the ones that we thought
were going to go all of the way. The the
cards that we think we're going to see
kind of in our top eight firmly. And I
think you you're pretty on the money.
That's looking pretty good.
>> I mean, I think picking any of that sort
of purple core, the chaos core does make
a lot of sense. Ferris 4runner just such
an easy include in any deck playing
Fury. I think you really hit the nail on
the head though. Draven and Aurelia we
are seeing topping the lists all over
the shop.
>> I I got to say like it felt like obvious
choices, but they're great cards and I
just kind of thought, you know, I really
should go with the cards that I think
are just going to really make it
difficult for people to execute their
game plans. And I think Draven and
Aurelia in their own rights in very
different ways kind of do establish
that.
>> Yeah. And I think when you look at Leo,
Ezreal, we've seen it ubiquitous in any
deck that has chaos. You want the Ezreal
for the extra card draw for the
reduction on the cord shot costs. And
for James overzealous fan is such a
stifling effect. The fact that you have
to play around Noveis fan often with a
fight or flight hidden next to it with
another unit at that battlefield. It's
like, okay, even if I attack with two
units, they're both going to get bounced
back to my base. And it's such a
devastating effect for such a lowcost
unit that actually it's got much more
swing in this meta than we would
>> think of something that's kind of
>> cheap and cheerful of a card. Actually,
it has so much sway in what's going to
happen.
>> I think one of the big things that we
are seeing across the course of this
weekend is the ability to stop your
opponent from doing stuff. Yes.
>> Very powerful in Riftband and we all
quite kind of knew that as well.
Brinhill Thundersong coming in in
Origins wasn't really looked at as a
card that was an MVP. Now with Spirit
Forge, the ability to stop Aurelia
popping off, the ability to stop people
fight or flighting on your turn,
rebuking on your turn, all of these
things really allowing her to do a huge
amount of work. We are ready for our
next game though as we get into this
round 11. We're going to be watching
this matchup. It's Aurelia up against
Fiora. Only four Fioras making it into
day two. A lot of Aurelia. We'll see how
well these two players can fight up
against each other looking for those top
eight spots.
>> Yeah, not a lot of Fiora love generally
across the event, which surprised me
personally. So, I'm glad to see it here.
But against Ireelia could be a little
bit of a sticky situation. This blade
dancer does not make it easier for Fiora
to make their game plan clear.
>> Having a quick look across the deck
here, three Stellon Herders. We have
seen some Aurelas going down to one or
even none of those in the main deck. I
like it. I think the extra card draw
really does give you a lot of work
running the one ride the wind. Nothing
too surprising overall here. Only a
couple of tie turners, but overall
you're building up towards a big Aelia.
I like the rosters there as support for
that Aurelia cuz often we do see when
the Aelia fervent is gone. You then
don't have the units to back it up.
>> No, the drop off has been very clear and
that's been the the downfall of the
Aurelia we've seen thus far and it gets
to deck like Fiora, you're going to need
some beefy units to really close out
those games. Fiora, of course, relying
on buffing units, having really big
turns, a couple of combat tricks here
and there with punch burst, but
ultimately lots of gear, lots of big
guys. We're buffing things. We've got
the set brawler as well from Origins.
We've got a lot of really kind of techy
units for getting big damage on the
board and keeping it there. So Aurelia
does have that kind of advantage in that
they can also have some really big units
going on because that's their whole
thing is make a couple of units but
don't let them fall. Whereas Fiora is
kind of relying on
>> always having big units and always
taking things down but not letting Fiora
do that kind of buckles their game plan.
>> Yeah, getting over that might threshold
as well. So so important for the Fiora.
did notice no salvage run in the main
there for Van Dorti here on the Fiora
using instead the Axan two of in this
main deck as their equipment hate their
gear hate in this current meta and I
think having something in the main that
does deal with gear so important when
you're looking at guardian angels when
you're looking even at sirens for the
Ireelia it's so important to be able to
have a way to deal with that early doors
we've got the z warren in the monastery
of hirana obviously vendors will be
wanting to go down towards that bottom
battlefield getting themselves as any
card draws as possible, which is
something the Fiora can struggle with a
little bit.
>> Yeah, I think that's the only thing
really, but being able to spend buffs to
do so is perfect cuz you can make those.
You can have that. So, it's a it's a
nice combination of going, okay, well, I
don't have great natural card draw, but
that's okay for the moment.
>> Yes. And we are just having a quick word
on turn one there with the judges, it
seems, to make sure that everything is
correct. We'll work out exactly what
that was, but uh yeah, not really much
gameplay to analyze yet.
were channeled and I don't think there
was an easy two drop in hand. So,
>> no. And I think that's the thing. You
want that easy curve, don't you? You
need that early two drop just to be able
to start getting things on the board,
start making it kind of worthwhile. You
want the uh two drops and into like a
Doran's Blade and then into those four
drops and so on and so forth.
>> Let's see where Vendor goes. It's just
going to be the Fiora to kick us off
getting Worthy out on the battlefield.
worthy great uh when a unit you control
becomes mighty, you can pay a power to
ready that unit. Gives you again pseudo
accelerate is the way that we tend to
talk about this slightly cheaper and
when you play something like the set
brawler, it immediately buffs itself. It
becomes worthy. You get the Fiora
dualist grand duelist trigger off it to
channel extra rune and then you can even
use that extra rune to pay the power
cost for Fiora worthy to then ready the
set. But here's the Ezreal. Uh it's
going to get the discard onto the scrap
heat meaning we are drawing three cards
here. Something the does so well is get
through a bunch of these top cards.
>> And honestly, that's kind of what we
want to be doing at this stage of the
game. We want to be building that hand,
building the board, and just slow
rolling into this battle because there's
going to be a lot of big fights coming
our way on these battlefields. So,
Aurelia kind of wants to go slow in this
moment because trying to go too early
into a Fiora can be really devastating,
especially with the amount that they can
kind of buff those units up or do some
extra damage during combat. It's not
worthwhile right now to kind of push
into anything too too uh too early.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh Viora being out this early as well is
really good. We got the set to
originally like straight away bring the
buff and then of course we can start
readying things
>> right away.
>> We'll get the buff on it. You don't have
to immediately ready here. There is a
kind of a nutritional thing between
these two decks where I think Aelia
slightly favored into Fiora just because
of the ability to pull the Aurelia out
to actually over buffer to get past the
might thresholds of the of the set and
the uh Fiora worthy but because of that
if you're vendor you don't want to push
too many of your resources in early
doors right if you can find a good trade
angle onto an onto a makes sense but
otherwise I expect to see this more
slower attritional game in the early
game while both the players kind of
establish their base.
>> Yeah, which is honestly really
respectable. Again, like I'm not the
patient kind. I would be like, "Yeah,
get me in there."
>> But these guys are the experts on these
decks and very much showing us for why.
Looking like we're eyeing up the Ezreal
again.
>> Yeah, I like that. Honestly, might as
well get more card draw onto the board
right now. We've got a cold shot as well
as a possibility.
>> Yeah, I guess there's the argument to do
the cold shot anyway. the like the
Ezreal reduces the optional cost of the
repeat, but you've already got one
Ezreal, that's reducing that cost. But
if you just want the draw discard uh
from this initial Ezreal, you can go for
that instead. I didn't see a scrap heap
in hand. So, just going to discard.
>> Is it going to be the guardian angel?
Okay, getting rid of one of those
protection tools
>> drawing into a seal
>> against Fiora. Yeah,
>> cuz I feel like that's one of the decks
where you want to keep those protection
tools really under your belt.
>> So, not surprising. We're just passing
over to Vendorsi there. Set readies and
so does Fior. Of course, we got the uh
end of uh we got the extra rune
channeled from Fiora's legend ability
last turn. So, we're doing really well
for rune production here, which is
something that kind of set decks have
set Vora decks have struggled with in
the past.
>> Yeah, if you're LS LSU, just thinking
about that guardian angel uh discard, a
lot of your decks do like to play
salvage in the main and it's a very easy
lowcost killer gear draw card. There's
also the Axan and then you're stealing a
guardian angel which Fiora doesn't
usually have access to not being in calm
domain, right? So, I kind of get the
idea of okay, maybe this guardian angel
isn't as effective for me as it would be
in other matchups. Set's going to go in.
Uh we'll get the conquer and the
monastery of trigger. Going to leave the
buff on there, but what's technically
happened here is a buff has been
sacrificed uh for the monastery of draw
trigger and then a rebuff has come on
from the conquer trigger. Vendor there
stacking them, but it doesn't really
make much sense to take the buff off,
draw the card, then put the buff back
on. Right.
>> Just a bit of a waste there. But it's
understandable that like set is a great
maneuverability card in this instance,
and that's where a lot of your card draw
will come from is just moving that set
in and out so that you can draw cards
effectively and spend those buffs. Uh
but then again, you kind of want to keep
the buffs for attacking turns as well
because it can increase your uh increase
your might there to eight which is
humongous. So it's a nice flexibility
spot you get. You either get power from
it or you get a card draw and both are
powerful in their own right. It's just
nice that you can choose the situation
that fits. Yeah, looks like we might be
having a small discussion about the
timing of a Grand Duelist trigger here
because the set when you get rid of the
buff, it goes below the mighty
threshold. You then draw the card and
then you rebuff, it goes above the
mighty threshold. Grand duelist can then
be exhausted. Yeah. To get yourself a
rune exhausted, but uh it looks like the
vendors is just having a quick check
with the judges to make sure everything
was done appropriately. It may have been
that we uh drew the card a slight bit
too early or maybe we accidentally
revealed from the top of the deck as
there is going to be a quick deck check
happening
>> understandably these interactions
especially where you had to remove the
buff and with mighty being your unit has
to be at five you're right dipping below
and above that threshold
>> can complicate things slightly. It's one
of those things where shortcuts are
great because they do allow you just to
get through those like few triggers a
little bit quicker, but if you are a
little bit more deliberate, it means
that you don't fall into positions like
this. It also looked like maybe Vendor
needed to shuffle the top of his uh
deck, not including the cards recycled
so far. Perhaps two cards came off at
once or something. Judges have organized
it. It's all sorted. Both players happy
as we go into the next portion of this
turn. Victorious coming down. Dorman's
blade there is going to make it mighty
as well, giving it deflect, ganking, and
shield.
>> That's a lot of effects, and they're all
very good in their own right. But we
also get to then continue with all of
that might into the next turn, which is
fantastic. Kind of beefing up this
battlefield, making sure that kind of
Fiora is doing what Fiora does and just
makes it kind of feeling like it's
impenetrable.
>> Yeah, a lot of might on that bottom
battlefield right now. Five from the set
and then seven from the Fiora on attack.
that is or when she is defending she is
seven because of the shield. Currently
she is six because you don't get shield
unless you're on the defense but it
really not very good targeted removal
like it's things like the fight or
flight that are bouncing them back but
you don't have falling stars you don't
have singularities you don't have those
easy like I will just kill your unit
before we have to get into combat. No,
exactly. Aurelia also kind of benefits
from kind of buffing your units, making
things bigger, going on in there and
actually fighting the real fight,
whereas that's not great for Fiora.
Like, we don't want that. We want to be
being the aggressor, not taking the
aggression. Uh, so it does put Aurelia
in the driver's seat a little bit for
those uh for those combats, which isn't
what we want. So, we're going to go in
with, of course, the seal of discord for
a cold shot.
>> Another Ezreal. I think that might be a
few too many. Two Ezreals. Nice. Three
Ezreals. It's a little bit overkill. And
it is going to go to the bottom. We'll
go through the second cold shot trigger
hit. Uh, not so fast. And a Titan. A
Titan obviously really effective later
on to make sure your Aurelia Fervent is
protected well.
>> And that's what we need.
Guardian Angel, like you say, is that
too easy to remove from
play. So, actually a tieer maybe, but
no, we're going to go for the not so
fast just to give a little bit of uh
flexibility. And I I I respect that. You
know, the not so fast is really good
against some of Vendor's
>> largest spells that can help Fiora to
stay in the game. And we're definitely
going to see those big tsles at
Battlefields come really soon. So
probably just preparing for the
inevitability of a lot of kind of
pumping spells.
>> Yeah, it makes sense that you want to be
able to protect that Aurelia later on
with the not so fast. Double rafts are
in hand as well here for LSU, but not
the largest of trashes. I think there's
only four cards in there right now.
Don't really want to be taking big
combats on that Monastery of Herana. Can
go up towards the Zorn Warren with one
of these Ezreals. With double on guard,
you're getting the Ezreal up to for
attacks in alone, you're giving it
plus4. That takes you to seven. That
would be enough to kill off one of these
units. And perhaps sacking an Ezreal is
enough. You also have the Defiant Dance
and the Discipline, which gives you
another effective four and then minus
two.
>> And this is exactly those combats I was
talking about. This is the attritional
war. And it's just kind of building up
your hand until you think you have the
advantage over your opponent. U and then
kind of seeing that they've got not too
many runes ready so that they can't
react in time and it's all about that
back and forth. So going with the
discipline there. So we've got a plus
two and a draw one on the Ezreal. So
Ezreal's a little bigger now at five.
>> Yeah, on this bottom battlefield on
Monastery of Ferrara, we currently have
six from the Fiora and then five I can't
apparently I can't write. Here we go.
And then five from the set. will go up
to seven.
>> So, when you're looking for damage, you
do need to get over the 12 mark, which
is possible with the discipline and with
the uh defiant dance. At the moment,
we're at five. We've got double on
guards, which gives us another plus
four. That will take us up to nine. And
then with the DD, you take yourself to
11 and then your opposition down to
nine. But Ezreal is just going to go up
to Z warren. We go for the discard draw.
>> I think that's really nice here. You're
just kind of again giving yourself every
option humanly possible. You want to
make sure that every ball is in your
court before you make your final
decisions. The extra card could be the
difference between winning or losing
this combat because this combat is where
it's coming down to is this big fight at
the end of this turn.
>> The thing that LSU has to play around as
well as a punch first. We have enough
body runes. We have one energy available
on Vendor's side. So the question is, do
you risk it for you're going to risk it
for the biscuit? Ezreal going in
currently at five. They've got a lot in
their court and we just got the defy off
the card draw there as well. So that
could be what helps us. We go for the on
guard first. So we're up a little bit
more now.
>> My handwriting is so bad. But I hope
that helps that you can see there's 12
might on that side right now. As you
>> go in alone. So the on guard is giving a
plus two.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, I I can I can just do this. There we
go.
>> There you go.
>> 12 on this side. Ong guard gives plus
two. We're now at seven. Another on
guard will get us to nine.
And then we need to defiant dance.
Probably the set to avoid the deflect
that's on the Fiora.
>> Yeah, we don't want to be playing that
paying that deflect cost. Something that
Fiora has done very well into kind of
Kaiser and Aurelia style decks in the
past where they're forcing the opponent
to have to use more resources where they
really don't want to.
>> Is it the defiant dance? Oh
>> first. Okay, so that's a minus two
target set.
That takes us down to 10.
Ezreal gets the plus two. Goes to nine.
>> And then I expect we're going to see
another on guard.
>> Yeah, that makes the most sense. And
this is the line we talked about at the
start of the turn. Blowing out the set
and the Fura would be huge. Ong guard
down for 11.
>> Can they be a response? We have more
response in hand though of our own.
We've got deflects.
>> Punch first doesn't it gets around
deflect which is huge here with the
double power. So
>> it's too it's too big. That punch is
just too big.
>> Okay.
>> Buff splory
to glory. But that does not get round
deflect.
>> It doesn't. So deflect might come out
here. This is that huge tussle. This is
going to be such an invigorating
huge battles whenever it kicks off at a
battlefield. They're just going to go
headto-head, toe to toe, just like this.
And that call to glory can be played for
free if you spend a buff, which is
great. So, it's got a plus three now.
But of course,
>> that it did that it did.
>> Down to 11. There's the punch first
afterwards. The call to glory coming
out. So in total we have minus2 on the
set takes it down to two + 5 puts it up
to seven + 7 is 14 in totality and I
think we are out of gas on the side of
LSU.
>> Completely out of gas. We're out of
runes to play. We haven't got really
anything low cost left in the hand that
can be utilized. So it looks like Ezreal
is taken down and going in aggressive
didn't work out.
>> Yeah, we lose the defiant dance. We lose
two on guards. We lose a discipline.
>> That's so many resources early in the
game. That's really scary. VSU.
Vendority probably feeling pretty good
about managing to come out of that
combat alive with set still there.
Gaining that hold point is going to be
huge as well. Wowzer. That's not what I
was expecting from that combat.
>> Absolutely massive. The good thing for
LSU is now your trash is a lot a lot
larger than it was a few moments ago.
You can see the count with the double
rasa in hand. You can get them out right
now and you did manage to get rid of the
Fiora victorious. However, on the other
side, Vendor is still in a strong spot.
Can make that set mighty with the
Doran's Blade. Can then when it becomes
mighty, ready it. So, take it back to
base. Doran's Blade ready it. Instead,
not going to do that. Just going in with
the Fiora.
>> Going to try and control this Monastery
of Hana.
>> Back with the Fiora, making it mighty.
We're rebuilding the board. We're
saying, "Okay, well, you couldn't deal
with that and you had so much in hand.
So, if I just rebuild that same
structure, yeah,
>> then surely the result must be the
same." So, we're hoping, I think, for
the same result there or maybe bringing
it Oh, we're going to gank across and
take the Ezreal.
>> Gank across,
>> take down the EZ. And we used that Fiora
to put the pressure down onto LSU. And
now LSU sitting at three runes and no
units on the battlefield or in base.
>> That's wild. That's overpowering
ability of Fiora once she is mighty. She
gets so many effects. Deflect, ganking,
and shield. Hello. Do you want more? No.
It's perfect. Set going back to base. I
think that's brilliant. Protect it.
Doesn't have a buff. you don't need to
leave it there and it's just a bit
vulnerable.
>> It also allows you to reconquer next
turn, get a buff and get the mighty
trigger once again.
>> And Vendors in a really good spot right
now, but we still haven't seen LSU bring
out that Aurelia Fervent did expend a
lot of their resources to try and win
out on that previous combat. Does have a
last rights in hand. Has a couple of
rosters as well, a stack deck alongside
it. So has a few ways to regenerate a
hand advantage, but it is going to take
a couple of turns. And by then, Vendor
is going to be at five, maybe six
points,
>> and that's exactly it. Vendor's already
got units in play. They're strong units.
They've got protection. They've got
buffs. And it's going to take us a while
because we can't ready units right away
in a lot of circumstances here. So, it
it could be a little bit of a struggle
to get things kind of moving again. And
I think that's the struggle is we can
get things down. We can rebuild. We can
reestablish our board. We can
reestablish our hand. We're going to
start with a stack deck to begin that
process. But can we then actually makes
it make anything actionable this turn?
>> Stack deck down. We see the guardian
angel, a discipline, and a third card
that is
>> okay. Well, a discipline's very helpful
in this instance. Yeah, Selon Herder
would be great, but there such an easy
way for it to be wiped away from the
board if it is left at one of those
battlefields. Discipline does give us
card draw.
>> Exactly.
>> Guardian Angel, we still have to play
around the possibility of salvage or Aan
coming out
>> of the Fiora.
>> That's a tough decision. I think I would
go for the cheaper card draw here. I go
for the discipline personally.
>> I mean, the the risk with discipline is
you don't really have a unit to to buff
right now. It does work out well later,
but for the moment it
just, oh, I'll just buff a unit and then
it's okay.
>> Okay, we got it. We do have another
stack deck in hand, so we can go for
that. But it looks like we go for the
Raza first.
>> Okay,
>> bringing that into play. And again, that
gets us a unit on board, which is very
much needed at the moment, and it's a
strong one at that. So, we don't have to
pay a couple because thankfully there's
lots of cards in the trash.
>> Okay, I see here's here's the thing.
When I was talking about the discipline,
I was like, oh, you don't really want to
just buff your opponent's units, right?
it it you know you do still get the draw
one but we're kind of doing that on the
Rasa because we can still ready it with
the blade dancer. So Rasa will get that
plus two go to eight might we'll get the
card draw out of discipline and we'll
look to try and take down this Fiora.
Still three runes available for Vendor.
Importantly not two bodies though. So no
possibility of a punch first.
>> And that's the thing like I said at the
start of the turn it's going to be about
finding a way to ready a unit and get it
moving and get things actually
actionable. We now have that pipeline
thanks to that stack deck.
>> We do see where we go from here.
>> Another stack deck. Yep. Just keep
getting things into that hand. Keep the
flourish going. Keep the momentum solid
cuz that's what we need at this point.
And we don't want to be kind of having
these cards like actually the these
draws aren't great. I'm not going to
lie. Like that that discipline was
lovely, but this one bit of a trickier
situation. But we're putting cards that
we don't need right now to the bottom of
the deck. And it's a shame about the
Stellorn Herders because I would really
love to see those in this match, but
they're just too expensive right now for
the power they're dishing out.
>> The Fiora is going to fall,
>> which is kind of big. Fur is a really
important unit in this matchup.
>> It is, I think, for the moment. Uh,
Rendor will still be okay with the
position of the game that that Rasa goes
down to six after this turn anyway. I
will see the discard draw trigger.
Traveling merchant put into the trash
and then a scrap heap picked up which is
not what you want to see because not
only have you drawn the cards that you
wish you had discarded, you've also
discarded the way that you would discard
that card. So a little bit unfortunate
for LS. You can of course uh next turn
bring this Rasa back assuming it
survives and then look to go back to
Zorn Warren either with the Rasa or with
something else to get the next discard
trigger. Or you can just play out the
scrap heap if you so desire.
>> If you need to. Yeah, that would work
out as well. So, already on Ventor's
board now, lots of runes, which is
really nice to see, but I'm not sure
where we go from here. Is it just kind
of continue that onslaught, continue
overwhelming battlefields, continue to
buff up our guys? I'm not sure if we've
got any other equipment right now to be
able to help out. I haven't really seen
much of the hand, so I'm not certain
where we can go. Ideally, we kind of
want to make this Fiora mighty, but we
also want Set. So, it's a tough one. Set
only needs to conquer to become uh
mighty, though, as we do get the buff.
>> We're going big. Is this uh like a
harness dragon?
>> Oh, it is harness dragon. What a call.
Okay, Harish dragon just immediately
removes one of your opponent's units
from play. So, that Raza's gone.
>> Yeah, massive there. Harness dragon just
coming out as that kill spell does give
you a huge amount of might as well, but
doesn't become mighty importantly. isn't
underneath that threshold. Does allow
you to go in with the set though. Get
the contact. Get yourself a buff. Get
that mighty trigger. Yeah. Just wanders
it. He's set. He's He goes where he
someone here, but my dragon dealt with
it earlier.
>> My father said I had a mother said I had
a temper. And then Yep. Buff it up. Set
once again. His favorite thing to be is
buff.
>> Mhm.
>> The favorite thing to be is buff. It's
so true. It's so true. Grew up in the
fighting pits. this Vestion warrior able
to do anything he pleases gets the buff
gets readyed as well can be drawn out of
this battlefield if Vendor desires just
to add that extra degree of protection
and that's exactly what is going to
happen
>> bringing it back again like there's not
a lot in an Aurelia deck that can do
anything about things in the base we're
just kind of chilling there so actually
it's a nice place to be we can get those
buff effects as well next time for the
conquers and so actually bringing the
effect to bring your units back to the
base for Fiora deck is great. We love
that. And there's so much might on the
bench uh on the on the battlefields as a
potential for next turn that you kind of
don't need to worry too much. Aurelia
kind of on the back foot right now,
which is unexpected in this matchup.
Looks like we might have to just go in
to try and draw more cards, but I'm not
sure other than Stellicorns how we're
achieving that.
>> It's a tough one for LSU cuz you
invested a lot into the hopes of killing
a set and a fur with an Ezreal. And I
entirely understand why you would do
that. You set your opponent back so far
in terms of tempo on the play that it
becomes really difficult for them to
regain that advantage. You can then play
your Fiora out, start moving her around.
It becomes so difficult for Vendor, but
when you lose that trade,
>> you are put so far behind. We've seen a
couple of stack decks as you say, the
Stellorn exists as well, but you can't
play a Stellorn out easily into a set
harness dragon for your worthy. It is
just too difficult for you to do. So
instead we will go for the rasa the last
rights. We will activate our blade
dancer
>> to ready this rasa with the equip going
in from the last rights. What are we
putting on the bottom here?
>> Are we going to get bag? Yeah. Diviant
dance just to again just try and give us
that combat advantage that we're going
to need. I think that's the thing. Or
maybe Oh
>> defensive or aggressive plays if you so
desire.
>> So they're going to the bottom. They're
not going to be used again. and then
we'll take something with our last
rights. I'm surprised that they went
back, but I guess yeah,
>> I you don't really have recursion right
in the Aelia deck. So that your
recursion is okay, we'll recycle these
and maybe I'll recycle enough and stack
deck enough to actually get back to
those cards, but it it's very unlikely
that you ever get to that point. Now
with the Rasa going in, you can discard
the scrap heap to the Zorn Warren
trigger. You also have the conquer
trigger from the last rights. What are
we going for LSU?
>> Maybe another Razer again. Yeah, just
going straight back in.
>> It's also cheap.
>> It's cheap. It's cheerful and not that
cheerful. It's cheap. It's not cheerful.
And honestly, it's probably the best
choice here. It's got high might level,
which you need going into this matchup.
And at the moment, it's going to be our
cheapest option to be able to leave some
runes for other other costs this turn or
just to leave standing in case of
combat. At the moment, you're looking at
needing to gain war points. You need the
point advantage here because otherwise
set and Fiora are just going to run away
with it with their new pet dragon. I
think there's also the argument of where
does LSU place this and that's what
they're thinking about right now. You
can put it onto Zorn Warren and then
have an effective 14 might at that top
battlefield. But if you do that and then
get blown out,
>> that's a nightmare.
>> It's so doomed. Like you have nothing to
put your last rights on apart from Aelia
Fervent sitting in your champion unit
zone. So yeah, deciding instead to go to
base will play out the Rasa has three
energy up. Couple of uh points and prods
coming out here from Vendor. So, we'll
see exactly uh what is going on there. A
little bit of a discussion happening,
but I I don't think it's anything too
consequential. Already a thumbs up from
Vendor as well.
>> Looks like we're good to go. It's a
tough situation. You've got to redevelop
the board, but you also need to be
actually scoring points cuz we need
those points to win. And
>> at this point, the last rights feels
dangerous in there alone. It doesn't
feel good to have Fiora set and a
dragon, a harness dragon kind of staring
down at you when you know you need that
last rights for your recursion and
there's no way to get it back into the
base. So, it does just kind of have to
sit there and then you're at the mercy
of all of these mercenaries who can take
you down.
>> Mhm. I was thinking about whether you'd
want to hide a tie turner for LSU here
as well. And you you tie Turner onto
Zarens. You then can use the router to
come in, get yourself up to that 12 14,
no yeah 14 might mark and that beats a
harness dragon and a set. That's only uh
11 even with the Dorman's blade equipped
as well. It would win out on the trade.
>> Looks like that was a spending a buff to
make set a lot bigger. Doubling his
might up to eight now. So, and then we
of course get the Fiora trigger. we get
to
>> uh channel that rune exhausted. So then
that's just increasing our fervance for
next turn, making it even more difficult
for our opponent to make a comeback.
When you look at the rune difference
between these decks right now, you can
see the Vendor is in a really strong
commanding position to make comebacks
and to also have the advantage during
combat.
>> Yeah. So now 14 might on the side of
Vendori at least in I'm only looking at
the harness dragon and the set brawler
cuz you don't really want to send fury
in. Her ability to ready your units when
they come out and become mighty is so
powerful. Um with the Doran's blade
could equip onto that harness dragon to
get it up to eight itself. Instead it's
a we talked about the power of Axan the
power to steal fast.
>> I mean that's what you keep it for.
That's why you pulled it off one of
those stack decks earlier on. stops you
from having that stolen away.
>> Aan was duped by the knock so fast and
that does not take effect and it would
have been quite devastating. Definitely
picking LSU's board apart but again we
had to spend resources and it's we're
down to two runes now. It's pretty it's
pretty devastating. So regardless that
Ashan still had a really big effect even
though it wasn't the initial desired
effect.
>> Yeah. Means now you're looking at like
do you have an on guard for this roster,
right? That's all you can really think
about.
>> And as you can see, there's not one in
hand attaching to set. So this puts you
to 10,
>> which would mean an ong guard still
means that you only trade. Russ is going
to go down.
>> Last right still in play, but now won't
have that hold effect.
>> Set will get the conquer trigger. Gets
himself a buff
>> and then set.
>> Yeah, Zorn Warren's trigger as well. So,
what are we discarding here then? Dorty,
let's have a mossy doesn't have a
massive grip, but has a few cards. An
unsung hero. Yeah,
>> I mean there's spotter at this point.
You don't care about the unsung hero.
>> No, that's an early game card at its
best right now. It's kind of like, oh,
no, that's fine.
>> Not a problem at all. And then it's
whether you kind of What are we on? Five
points. So, we kind of do want to push
for the six here, I'd say. So, you do go
in with the harness dragon.
>> There's six.
>> Yep. No, there's there's no way for that
to be countered in any consequence
spending that buff
to draw a card now that we have the
ability to do so. And it's kind of like
we got to trade a bad card for a good
card hopefully uh with that. So, it's
another really good reason to go for the
monastery at that point is just being
able to spend that buff that we actually
don't need right now. We've got Doran's
Blade with Mighty kind of permanently
for the moment.
>> Dragon buffed. Uh, no, no, the set was
buffed, but you can spend the buff from
wherever.
>> Oh, yeah. Sure. Yeah. Yeah. You're 100%
right. Yeah.
>> Yeah. The the buff was on the set, but
we because we are in control. It's not
spend a buff on the that's here. Yes.
So, you can spend the one that's on the
set or one in base.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Makes a lot of sense. And
LSU going to get up to four runes. Needs
to really gain control of one of these
battlefields. Has a ride the wind in
hand. Arasa with the last rights on it
gets pretty strong. up to eight would
outmatch the harness dragon, but with
three runes up, Vendor has a plethora of
tricks. Still another punch first
possibility.
>> Yeah, you've always got to be concerned
about punches. I don't like being
punched, so I don't think uh Raza would
either.
>> Yeah, nor do I. I mean, Russa, you know,
they kind of they've they've sununded a
few times. I'm sure they've been punched
a few times. Do you think you become
sort of like immune to the punches?
Obviously, they still hurt, but it's
like I'm used to this, you God, not
again.
>> Yeah, that's just another punch for me.
>> Arza once again with the last rights
kind of moving in on that set. Going for
the going for another big showdown
potential.
>> Focus.
>> And here we go.
>> It's a punch first. It's a punch first.
Yeah. What a surprise.
>> What a surprise. Vendor will crack out
the fists.
>> Push the set up to 11. You know when you
see those two runes going down, you're
like, "Oh, I know. It's the punch."
>> Literally going up to 11 here.
>> Spinal tap. You know,
>> that's wild.
>> Rasa is struggling in this position. Two
can ride the wind over to the Highness
Dragon.
>> Yeah, looks like that's the play is try
again, but over there it's like, "Oh,
that didn't quite work out. Poke the
bear. Didn't work. Let's hop on over to
the next battlefield and see if I can
take this dragon by surprise instead.
Well, doesn't have the runes for an
extra punch first here on the harness
dragon, so does become a little bit
harder for him to truly protect. But
>> oh,
>> where are we going?
>> Repost. Repost. Repost. Repost. You are
going to stay here, my friend. I'm going
to buff up my set. One of the best
signature spells in the game. Repost
stopping any chance of Rasa getting out
of the fight. Repulse says, "No, you
stay with me." And unfortunately, that
spells disaster for Raza. Last race once
again bouncing back to the base, not
getting that conquer ability is huge.
Really looks like the writing's on the
wall here. Van Dorsy really taking a
commanding presence, making sure they're
winning those combats.
LSU's last option, blade dance. So, last
rights onto your rasa blade dancer
trigger to ready the rasa. Go into the
harness dragon. There's no runes
available for Vendor, so won't be able
to protect against this. But still,
Vendor has the Aan later on. Like,
that's a massive trash for trash. But
LSU has no runes now.
>> So, we're going to go down to just
having two at the beginning of our turn.
And is that going to be enough to keep
up with Ventors onslaught? We have two
more units in base. And although this
Raza might manage to get a point here, I
don't know if it's going to be enough to
just keep command enough of this
battlefield.
>> And we are floating to two energy. So we
can get back a two cost unit.
>> Traveling merchant going to be the
choice. I mean it's two might more. It's
two might more. Gets us up to 10 on this
monastery of Hana.
>> Do you want to play
>> considering maybe keeping it in base?
>> I think you've got to buff up that
monastery. I think you've got to try and
hold it away from Vendor at this stage.
>> I agree. So, it will go to the
monastery. Gets us up to 12 might down
towards that bottom side. Vendor Vendor.
Let's see if Vendor can clutch together
the win. This could be the turn. if they
can piece it together and take down
LSU's one battlefield
>> with five runes. The set unable to move
unless it is brought back. Made not
mighty then readied somehow.
Uh we'll see where Vendor decides to go.
Does have seven might in base. needs to
add four to that to be able to take over
the monosu forana and go 10 up in this
round 11 performance.
>> Nothing in hand that LSU can do. As you
say, no runes available.
>> And that gives Vendor the the notion
that it's kind of safe to do whatever he
wants to do this turn. There are no
runes in play. You can do nothing. Cool.
I am a free I'm a free agent here to
play another set brawler.
>> And it's just going to get buffed. Go
mighty. Recycle a rune.
>> So we channel one exhausted. Then we
recycle to the Fiora. Ready it up.
>> Spend the buff. Go to go in. Win the
combat. Vendor takes game one.
>> The underdog. Fiora. Not very well
represented in T2, but I've always
believed taking the big win away from
Aurelia, who we thought would have the
advantage. Yeah, I thought I thought it
was favored in the match up. I do think
LSU will be looking back at that four
card investment into the Ezreal to try
and clear out the set and the Fura early
on and be kicking themselves. It did not
go well at all and it cost them so much
in terms of early cards, in terms of
early tempo. In the sideboard for
Vendor, we have a couple of cannon
barges and a couple of unneutened
spirits. Not really going to bring those
in. Maybe you could add in the sabotages
just to try and play a little bit of
hand disruption into this Aurelia, but
so far having an absolute stormer.
>> Yeah, Fiora is a really strong deck and
I think it's been underestimated
throughout this competition. It's
actually one of the decks I was
considering bringing if I was playing
this event and it hasn't had great
conversion uh over to day two, but
that's because it didn't have a great
showing in day one. and those who did
come over to our second day seem to be
doing really well. So, I'm really proud
and really happy to see that they're
still on in it. Now, for LSU, we're
probably looking at some more of these
kind of comeback mechanics that we're
going to need. Maybe the maybe the hard
bargain and another not so fast
>> hard bargain just making uh the Fiora
spend a little bit more of her energy,
make it a little bit harder for her to
actually have as effective turns. It's
when you get into these like attritional
wars on a battlefield, having a hard
bargain at that point just does give you
that little bit of acceleration that you
need overall.
>> Apart from that, I don't see major
changes. I do really think LSU will we
call it the salty runback in league.
Have you heard of a salty runback?
>> So, it's when in in the old days when
you were drafting a a fivegame series,
you could pick the same champions again.
So, a team would lose and then pick the
same draft, the same five champions. We
call it's a salty runback. They think
they just misplayed and they can play it
better. They're salty, so they're going
to run it back. Yeah. And I I wouldn't
be surprised if LSU goes for a
predominantly salty run back here. I
don't think there's major changes to be
made.
>> It very very much could happen. Now, I
think that something that's really
poignant right now is that the
battlefields that are chosen aren't
possibly going to be as advantageous as
last time. We've got Okay. Candle
Sanctum and Sunken Temple.
>> Yeah, Sunken Temple really good for the
Furer when you are getting those mighty
units in. and caramel sanctum obviously
giving you those extra cards as well.
>> Starting off with just a traveling
merchant for LSU. Not a bad start for
Aurelia. We want those lowc cost units
in play as soon as possible. And
Vendor's turn looking quite simple. Just
bringing out the Fiora and moving on
into LSU's second turn where we start to
see a bit more dynamicism from the
Aurelia matchup. We might be able to get
a Stellicorn down now actually which
might help out with that card draw that
we were lacking last game.
>> Yeah, nice lowcost units here for LSU.
Stellicorn still four. It's expensive
enough but the ability to get it out
early when you know it's only a Fiora
worthy on the other side of the
battlefield makes you a lot more
comfortable. This Fiora worthy we saw it
from Vendors against someone like a
Kaiser you wouldn't be doing this. You
don't want to play something in your
base when it can get killed by a falling
star. But here it's like okay I know LSU
is not playing targeted removal. He
doesn't have like co the weaks and such
that he can use against me. Instead, I
can play this out. I can use it for the
rest of the game. Whereas LSU will be
trying to get that stellic corn herder
out as soon as possible. Traveling
merchant not moving around on LSU's
turn. We go back over to Vendor who's
going to put down that set brawler. saw
to great effect last game. Is set gonna
once again just be an overwhelmingly
strong unit and really kind of make
Aurelia sweat to be able to overtake it.
Of course on play and on conquer we get
that buff. So set is of course now even
bigger and a mighty unit which is kind
of what we're aiming towards. It not
only allows us to channel more runes
faster, but also allows us just to be
bigger into these Aurelia decks who do
like to kind of try and like we said
yesterday, protect the princess.
>> Yeah, I think it's uh I mean it's
looking like another Stellorn though
with five tapped.
I wonder is just going to be the Aurelia
Fervent. Only one rune left to help
defend it, but it's not going to go out.
turn past again without the Stellicorn
moving forward. LSU, even with a second
Stellicorn in hand, deciding that he
wants to make sure this is well
protected when it does start advancing
for that extra card draw as the game
goes on.
>> Nice thing about Aurelia here is at
least it does have the deflect cost. So,
if you're not in a pure combat
situation, you do have kind of spells
slinging around, then that does help out
with this matchup. But in this instance,
Endor is probably going to be trying to
go in with as much raw power as
possible. And that's going to be where
the units might is much overwhelmed when
it comes to Aurelia.
>> See, for the moment, I think Van Dorsey
expected to take the first step onto a
battlefield of the two players. Unsung
hero being used here. Good death nail
effect, but you do need to find three
might from somewhere to get it up above
that mighty threshold as it only sits at
two.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean draw to it. You need
to find three M somewhere.
>> There it is. There is the big old sword.
The BF sword. It certainly is big and
it's going to help out perfectly to make
that unit mighty.
>> I like the fact you are practicing the
flavor text these days. I'm doing my
best. Good. Yeah. Going to chuck this
onto the unsung hero most probably. Then
can ready it with the Fiora. Also
channel the rune from your grand dualist
legend. Ready it with the fura. go in
probably towards sunken temple. You have
one rune up. You can pay the cost to get
that card draw. But instead of readying
it, just puts the uh BF sword on and
decides against sending it into battle.
Fior worthy on the other side does put a
little bit of pressure down on you. I
just expected you to want to get the
extra card draws out of the death nail
from Unsung Hero.
>> Yeah, I'm a bit surprised about that.
But then again, we're not the experts.
We're on the desk and
>> I'm certain they've got a game plan in
mind. And sometimes going slow we've
seen it to great effect throughout this
tournament from being able to maybe
allow your opponents to kind of get
smaller units stuck in bases. Maybe
that's what we're going in uh
battlefields. Maybe that's what we're
going for. Knowing that LSU was wanting
the card draw off the Stellorn and
possibly won't be able to bring it back
to base. And then leaving that really
kind of vulnerable unit there means that
you get to take it out with ease and
then you're getting the benefit of
battle as well. Uh, so for anyone who
doesn't know Candle Phantom, you get to
look at the top two cards of your deck.
You can recycle one or both of them and
then put them back down in any order you
desire on the top for the ones that you
remain where remain in your hand. I
guess uh at the moment we have a rebuke
and an ong guard in hand. We've got
double rasa, a defy, a seal. Having a
rebuke would be really nice.
>> It would.
>> And they are going to go down. Rebuke on
top on guard on the bottom is how I
believe that ended up.
>> It also kind of gives you a little bit
of a spy into what units you're going to
have available for the next few turns
because we've got quite expensive units
in hand and no way to cheapen them right
now with nothing in discard pile razer
in hand. Kind of clogging that up a
little bit is not ideal. So looks like
we're trying to be able to draw more
here by going for the sunken temple.
>> There's the rebuke coming off the sunken
temple trigger. Conquering with a
mighty, you get to pay one if you so
want and draw a card. Traveling merchant
going in for the discard draw. Wonder if
we're getting rid of this Stellicorn.
>> Decided that we are far enough in terms
of card advantage ahead. Also allows us
to draw that on guard. So we have a
>> slew of protection for the next turn.
>> Are we going to see one of those big
back and forth battles once again?
>> I feel like we are. Like I saw a defiant
dance and on guard, a rebuke in hand. If
you're LSU, you want to hold that rebuke
for as long as possible. Make Vendor use
as many tools in their tool kit, as many
cards as possible out of their hand
before you just bounce a unit to the
enemies, the opponent's enemies. That's
a League of Legends one there. The
opponent's hand.
>> It's a tough one though. Thought still
has a lot of power on board. We've got
multiple mighty units. We've got ways of
making them bigger.
>> And I It's just I'm not sure it's going
to be enough. LSU does have a lot of
runes standing though. We've got three
spells. Also, we've got the Ong Guard,
which is going to be able to buff, but
that's not super helpful. And not so
fast might be what kind of turns the
tide in this instance if Endori decides
to go particularly aggressive. And I
think you go for the Aurelia, it's just
kind of alone right now and vulnerable
in that sense.
>> I I I understand that. I think Vendors
will have in their mind, this Aurelia is
alone. Why is this Aelia alone?
>> She should not be alone. I will take
that.
>> When you're choosing it as well, it
gives that plus one might. You also have
the on guard. So an ong guard here onto
the Aelia is plus three might
effectively because of the choose. And
then you also have a defiant dance in
hand which is another plus three might
minus two might. So a five might swing
alongside the rebuke as well if you ever
get to a position where you are actually
overpowering the Aurelia. We'll go go in
with the unsung hero and the set a spent
buff set. So it's at eight. Wowzer. So
yeah, we've gone in big on for a 13.
Thank you for that quick match.
going in with a big 13 trying to say
look I think this is going to be too
much even
>> even if you come back at me and that's
what I was talking about with that pure
might total rather than using spells
like punch first which could be uh which
could be kind of sent back your way that
could be
>> counterpelled
>> and for LSU there's a risk of a double
punch first coming out of vendor right
that's an extra 10 might immediately if
they are put on the same target rebuke
then becomes an incredible option for
you. But Vendors is eight and two. I
don't think he's going to double punch
first on the same target. You know,
>> I think it would be a little foolish
overall. Also, Repost a threat. The good
thing for Urelia in this matchup is that
your buff spells tend to not have a huge
energy cost. So, Repost is only giving a
plus one or plus two instead of
something like a a big plus five or six.
That can sometimes happen. LSU thinking
through the sequencing here. Defiant
Dance first.
the most probable option for that plus
three minus two, but even then you are
only getting to seven yourself.
>> So, we're not quite there yet, but we
still have the rebuke. We can still send
something flying back to its owner's
hand.
Defiant dance bringing those totals.
>> So, importantly, the reason you put the
first counter on here is you have chosen
the Aurelia Fervent. Yes. So, that gets
the plus one might from being chosen.
Now we see the next sequence come out.
The Aurelia moves up to seven. We go
down to 11 on the side of Vendor.
>> But I don't think it's going to be
enough now because we now see the Rebuke
come out and probably push the set back.
>> I think you push the unsung hero down
>> cuz the set is down to two.
>> There's the repost.
>> That is a welltimed repost if I've ever
seen one.
>> And we'll see who what the repost is
targeting. It's going to give that plus
two across. He's going to go onto the
unsung hero. So that's an extra two over
there. I've I This is why I need to do
the math the entire time. So we still
got seven here.
>> And then on this side it sets at two + 5
+ 2 is 9 as far as my maths is working.
>> And on guard takes us to Yeah. takes us
to 10.
>> Takes us to 10 8 9 10. Yeah.
>> Just going to trade.
>> Just going to trade. going to keep it
simple. I don't love Aurelia coming out
of play in this stance, but then
removing the set is still a big deal.
>> Yeah. Yes, it is.
>> I wonder if we have I was thinking a
last rights here would be nice, but
it's uh it's not in hand. Double Rasa
Seal on guard deciding against using all
of the resources there. But I I don't
blame LSU for backing out at that point
because you you have to look at how much
energy and how many runes Vendor still
has up. If you then on guard and get
blown out by a punch first, you've
invested so much into this Aurelia and
you you're losing those combat trips.
It's what cost him in game one.
>> The triple Rasa in hand actually hurts
me with so little in discard right now.
We've got three big units that just so
expensive to cost and we don't really
have a way of churning through our deck
right now. So maybe actually we're kind
of thinking about allowing things to be
defeated so that we actually are gaining
more in our trash to allow for
>> the earlier plays of those cards. We
kind of do want to be cycling through
some of our resources in some sense
because it's all we've got going on
right now.
>> On the other side, we have a course to
glory, a hidden blade, a challenge, and
an axan at the back. So want to avoid
putting those gas down if you are LSU.
Looks like is going to be attaching the
Doran's Blade here to Fiora again.
Making her mighty is always a good
shout. She gets lots of fantastic
effects. Doran's Blade of course giving
a plus two power on that one as well.
Definitely worth its weight in gold in
this instance.
>> There it is.
>> And then do you want to do much else
with your turn? We've expended a lot.
And I think it's just
>> Oh, you're going to move it. We're going
to go for it. Knowing that LSU used a
lot of uh resources in that previous
battle, maybe they're assuming that
there is
>> an on guard moment though.
>> You on guard and you trade in
>> on guard. And I think that was the
beautiful thing about keeping that back
is that you made your opponent think you
were out of resources, but that was
false.
>> Really nicely done there by LSU pulling
Dorsy into the battle, but with the call
to glory have the runes available to it.
And now
>> there is a defy. It's going to get
countered. Okay, we're still going and
more and more resources are going to
LSU's uh trash at this point, which is
great for them. They're loving playing
these cards at this point. It's making
things cheaper for them later.
>> Vendors is going to be mad. You lose the
Fiora worthy.
>> Thought it was safe. Could have just
held back, I think. Was trying to get
over that, you know, the two-point
threshold that LSU is already at. So, it
would have been great to be able to wipe
away all the units at the board, but a
little bit overeager there from Vendor.
And it's kind of been the the
catchphrase of this series. A little bit
overeager at times. It's a difficult
battle to play. We've got into day two
already 3 p.m. here. So players have
been around for 5 hours already just
today.
>> But uh
>> and we're struggling at this point for
LSU because we we we really are wanting
to get more units into play. So being
able to take out that big Fiora threat
is huge cuz we're still a little bit
away from our Razers. And I don't think
they were just counting up the the trash
there to see.
>> I think it was nine.
>> Oh, so actually we can afford it now.
>> Yeah, you can play the Rasa. So I think
we're going to float the energy here.
Use the seal to play Arasa.
I mean, we could traveling merchant
first for the discard draw. Discard
Arasa and then play the two others. But
there's also six might that you're
putting into your trash without Atlas
rights to recur it. We'll count again. 1
2 3 4 5 6 Oh.
>> Oh. Was it only seven? I thought it was
more than that
first. So,
>> I mean,
>> maybe move some more into the trash
first or just No, we're going in with
rather just spending the extra cost to
be able to get up there. I still love a
big discount. So, I'm still not mad at
that. It's a cheap% investment, right?
>> Yeah. You'll take 70% off when we can do
it and twice on Fridays.
>> I'll take that. Yes, please.
>> Another couple coming out here. It's a
Titan in base. Can decide to switch with
the Rasa
>> choosing the Rasa readies it which now
allows us to go in with the unsung hero.
So the reason you put Titan in base is
then you can blade dancer
>> the Rasa when the Titer chooses the Rasa
it in the base goes in gets rid of the
unsung hero will be card draw for
Vendor.
>> Brilliant sequencing there to get that
Raza over and then really batten down
the hatches. make Vendor sweat a little
and remove every last unit from their
board. Really showing the strength of
Aurelia and kind of what we were
expecting from game one and then we just
didn't see it come into fruition. This
time Vendor's got a really uphill big
uphill struggle. Now we can ready units.
That's a positive. We love that. But
we're still kind of lacking right now in
having them available to play. So we're
going to need to really look at what we
have available. We had the Axan at the
back of our hand last turn. So that
might come into play, but I don't
remember if there were any other units
of notes.
>> I think it was only the Axan a challenge
and a repos.
>> Speaking of the devil,
>> we steal a gear. Like cool, go ahead.
You're welcome to it. I don't think the
uh the seal is going to do too much for
you. Can only pay those purple uh chaos
power costs. Although, if something has
a pay any power, you can use the seal
for it. So, still denying something from
LSU, denying the ability to uh not have
to recycle those runes. Does work.
Auction now equipped with that Dorman's
blade.
>> Being able to use Fiora to channel
another rune exhausted. So, we're
keeping up the pace even though we're
having to recycle to be able to do these
attaches. Going for another attack. Just
really using our only unit in play to be
as big and beastly as it can be.
>> Yeah, currently sitting at seven. Uh,
sorry. Nine. In fact, that's why I
should do the math first before I say
something. I was trying to do it as I
was talking. It just, you know,
immediately fails. Nine is big.
Challenge the Russa
>> and you win that challenge. Not enough
runes for the not so fast out of LSU.
>> I love a good challenge.
>> You don't have to go into combat. You're
not risking any comebacks. If they can't
counter the challenge straight away, you
know that that's gone and it just limits
the amount LSU gets going into their
next turn as they only get one hold
point putting them on five, which is a
much more awkward position to be in
>> when you're looking at kind of that
straight down to victory.
>> I was trying to just quickly do some uh
maths, some thinking about what where
I'd be going here as LSU cuz you still
have double rasa, right? So, I'm
wondering if you just all in on candle
zap. You're just saying, "Look, I'm at
five. You're at a couple of points. If I
just Rasa Rasa here,
>> it sounds like Oh, he's not even a
couple, just at one point at the
moment." Vendor Dorsy instead, it's
going to put it into base.
>> I think you do have the option of kind
of taking it slow here and you don't
want to give Vendori too much time to
make a comeback.
>> The risk is if you do go double Rasa
into Candle Sanctum, a single punch
first and a call to glory is plus eight,
right? That that puts you in a really
difficult position overall. So, we're
just going to sit with this Rasa back in
base. Hold the second one in our hand.
Look to try and go to six. See if
perhaps endorsey overextends with the
Axan.
>> He's going for an on guard. Okay. Yeah.
Able to ready.
>> Yeah.
>> And then, yeah, move on in and grab
that.
>> Draw a card as well as Zig.
>> It's huge right now. But unfortunately,
the only other card in hand is Raza. So,
we don't have a lot to come back with.
>> Well, you do have the sunken temple
trigger, right? So, yeah, you pay the
one to draw the card hit. It's a cold
shot, which is good, but not really what
you wanted right now.
>> No, but it can help us to flow through
and see more cards.
>> It looks like we're going to bring
traveling merchant back for that discard
draw, and it allows us to see more cards
because of that. So, we're going to
discard, get the Ezreal. Not enough
runes to play it right now. Looks like
we might retreat the Titer 2.
>> Saying that three times fast.
>> No thanks.
>> Titer two.
Oh, I think I think retreating the
Titaner is good here. You know that
Vendor has these really strong units
ready. I think they're just building up
in base and then going in for the win.
Going to the seventh and eighth point on
the same turn. If this Raza that is in
sunken temple gets taken down, you're
kind of okay with it because you're
intending on taking the seventh and
eighth point in the same turn.
>> You're going to have to work your way
through an Archon. Vendor a long way
behind currently. He has the cord to
glory challenge repost hidden blade.
Axan's going to go in
>> kill off will get that draw nice and
early from sunken temple.
>> Go to two.
>> LSU doesn't have a huge amount of might
on board.
>> No, it's an uphill climb for Vendors,
but they can do it.
>> Yeah, pay the energy, draw the card.
I wonder if you challenge the Rasa just
to remove some more of the power that uh
LSU does have.
>> I think if you can, you should. Yeah,
looks like that's what we're going to go
for. Get rid of the rata.
>> Yep. And there's no response. We know
there's no response to that one card in
hand. We know what it is. But I think
that is a tell. That tells Vendor it's
not anything they need to worry about.
>> And now we can start investing a little
bit more on our side of the board. Would
be an epic comeback. One to six. Getting
back into the game. Lucian
>> will come down with the weapon master.
steals away the Dorman's blade, becomes
mighty. Can't ready it. We don't have
the Fiora worthy, but we can channel one
rune exhausted. And now just a traveling
merchant in the titer. There is one free
point for you
>> if you so desire it.
>> We do have the Rasa. Oh no,
>> double double Ezreal on hand. So we have
a bunch of card draw, but is it going to
be enough? Because we also need the
runes to be able to play that. So we get
a little bit more
>> defiant dance and a discipline. I like
the divine dance in this instance.
>> Yeah, so do I.
I think you go in, you get the one from
candle lit and then you just you don't
really look to try and kill the archon
this turn. You're waiting for next turn,
but the problem is then vendors is
getting really strong.
onto the Ezreal to take him to five
ready with blade dancer and then we have
the defiant dance which takes action
down but there's still enough runes on
vendor side for a punch first and they
have a repost in hand so these are the
things you have to play around LSU
wisely I think deciding not to go all in
to try and kill off the game this turn
>> I think honestly it's very wise decision
don't put all your eggs in one basket
note that you are so far ahead that you
do have the option to take your and then
try and deal with Vendor's kind of
oncoming onslaught as you would expect
from a deck like this within time.
You've got a little bit of pace behind
you. You've got a little more card draw
now and hopefully Vendor is running out
of resources of their own. Maybe not
units cuz that's not really how these
decks go, but hopefully things like the
punch first just aren't quite there.
Going into the tide turner with Lucian.
Looks like we're going for the Defiant
Dance here.
>> We'll make it four into three. trying to
see if we can just eek out combats and
just whittle Vendors down.
>> Call to glory. No defy.
>> That means Titan loses
>> that one. So we're going up to the
three. Vendors uphill battle is still
crushing onwards.
>> That is Lucian will be readied after the
conquer and he wins for the first time.
Going to hit the candle lit Sanctum
trigger. You can look at the top two.
Put them back in. All right. put any
amount of them back on the bottom.
Recycle them and then put the ones that
you keep on the top in any order. So,
one on the top, one on the bottom.
>> So, that top card is now something we we
want. We want that.
>> I mean, you would hope so.
>> Yeah.
>> Cuz otherwise, perhaps not the wisest
choice to put it on the top. The amount
of times I've been playing a card game
and I've in other card games called
Scry, right? I scried one, looked at it,
been like, "Yes, I would like to keep
that." And then when it gets round to my
turn again, forgotten what the card was
and been surprised
>> and you're like, "Oh my goodness."
>> I think that speaks to my skill. A
hidden blade hidden here for Vendor, I
believe, on that top battlefield.
Really? Yeah. One of the main hidden uh
cards that you do play in this Fiora
deck. Makes it harder for LSU to try and
gain control of that area. Cold shot to
kick us off. One power recycled. Another
Arshan of course in base as well now
ready to go as well. We don't really get
anything from the effect of that but
just having another really strong unit
on board there
>> reposting the cold shot.
>> I mean I love it. It was one card in
hand for LSU. Why give him two more?
>> And you kind of know that the previous
turn there wasn't a threat in hand. So
you assume that actually this might
still not be a threat. And indeed we see
it as the discipline goes in just to
draw a card I imagine
>> to try and hopefully get out of the
situation. Ooh, not that helpful.
>> Yeah, not helpful whatsoever. However,
traveling merchant can be sacrificed
if you so desire. The seal is going to
come down. Traveling merchant, I mean,
you can you still get the draw even if
you don't discard. So we're going to go
in here with five and two making seven
into the seven of the auxan.
>> The draw is a ride the win from the
traveling merchant move. No conquer
happening.
>> Oh, it feels so bad. LSU is just so far
behind at this point in regards to now
board presence. So close yet so far
because we're so close to the win on
points, but the board is empty. Yeah, I
mean it's incredibly well played by
Vendors to stabilize after LSU was able
to take such a lead early on
>> just picking apart that board.
>> Triple Russer in the graveyard. Like
what are you looking for at this point?
>> What's left? What's left that can handle
>> our last rights?
>> Our last rights. That's kind of it. But
then you need to be able to conquer with
that
>> or to hold a battlefield. And at the
moment, Vendor is probably going to be
looking at putting things into those
battlefields that you can't deal with
with these smaller units that that's all
you've got left, right?
>> So, at this point, Vendor is thinking,
"Okay, well, I probably want to be
getting all of these really strong guys
just sat on these battlefields. It's not
necessarily about the points, although
we do need those, but it's about making
it really hard for LSU to be able to
actually get use last rights.
>> Just control the space." Ashan equipped
with the BF sword gets the mighty
channel rune. And this is another thing
that Fiora has been able to do really
well is just to replenish the runes.
Like you look at the other side. LSU has
>> four
>> three and a that's his Yeah, that's his
hand.
>> Yeah, that's painful. That is painful.
>> That's what I'm saying. It's a It's a
really tough situation to be in. Fior
has done this incredible job this game
of keeping all of their resources really
high strong and making sure that they're
replenishing what they need to to be
able to make these really big plays.
>> I mean also really big for Vendors to
come back like this because they were
only 10 up. This is the second game of
the best of three. If they weren't able
to claim this in time, we'd be looking
at a draw rather going to 821 rather
than the 92 that they are currently
looking at. Defy ride the wind is
nothing for LSU.
>> The uphill struggle is being successful.
We've got both battlefields taken. If
LSU can't dismantle one of these, then
that's game over. And it doesn't look
like we can. We have no units.
>> Nothing we can do. The fist comes up.
Vendor takes it from seven 61 down.
Coming back and being able to claim the
win there on the Fiora. Superb stuff all
around by Van Dorsey. Ventors makes the
climb. That is the biggest climb that I
have seen during this tournament thus
far from going to such low and just
sticking in there, believing in what his
deck can do and taking it back from your
opponent by just whittling them down.
>> Yeah, really impressive stuff from
Vendors. LSU game one a bit of an
overextension with the Ezreal. I think
game two still struggled after losing
their units early on to really get back
into it. Uh, and as soon as Vendori took
control of the game, it really felt
over. It was just great stuff all around
from Vendor as we round out round 11
here of our Cub Bologna.
>> I think it was a really lovely tale as
well to show why you should never give
up.
>> Yeah,
>> we should never ever give up. We've just
got to keep climbing. And speaking of
climbing, it's time for us to climb over
to the interview area to speak to our
>> There's no interview.
>> Oh, no interview. Oh my goodness.
>> We can we can speak to each other though
if you want.
>> Oh, that would be great.
>> How you doing? Are you enjoying Rift
Ranch? having a great time. Honestly,
I'm really pleased to have seen that
matchup. Really happy that we were able
to highlight a deck we haven't seen yet.
>> Yeah, true. It was a lot of fun to watch
the Fura. And we're going to go to a
break, more climb over the desk as
opposed to to do an interview. Goodbye.
We'll be back
then.
Welcome back everybody to day two of the
regional qualifier here in Bolognia,
Italy. James Hillary joined by Leonard
Kunig for all the action. Uh we're
running out of Swiss rounds. Uh there
are not many left to cast here. I think
this is uh our round four of the day
which puts us at round 14. Am I correct
on that? This might No, 14 is totally
wrong.
>> Never do math on stream. Never do math.
It was eight yesterday and five today
means he's around 12.
>> We should Yeah, exactly. We should be
>> see this is why don't trust my math what
we're doing.
>> Trust Leonards.
>> Yes. I think we're doing round 11 now
actually and then there is another swift
one afterwards which is round 12 and
then there's also round 13 if I'm not
completely mistaken.
>> You know what? There's going to be a
graphic at some point that's going to
come up and he's going to tell us. Uh
it's been a long weekend full of magic.
Uh wow. Full of Riftbound action here
today. Exactly. Magical plays coming
through here. Uh we have a big match
this uh this round for you. Two
heavyweights in the scene for Riftbound
as we get ourselves ready to go. Marcus
Bartell, a former European champion in
Yu-Gi-Oh going up against Alan ZQ, a
very very very well-known player for of
course Legends Rune Terror World
Champion and the best of Kaiser from
Husen from the regionals there. Yeah, he
is surely one of a kind and I think at
this point he is just aura farming. He
has announced on X that he is going to
win multiple metal best off cards of
Ezreal the Prodigal Explorer and he's
absolutely crushing it. He's the only
undefeated Riftbounder in this
tournament. You can see a tech on the
bottom right of this deck that is so
absolutely genius. We've seen it before
yesterday from Ludvik who was also
running Ezreal Prodigal Explorer. That
is the Vex, a card that you actually
mentioned in the beginning. I think it
was one of your favorite picks.
>> Yeah, it was crazy.
>> Weirdly, it was one I picked because
it's a card that I like, not a card that
I thought was going to be played so
much. So, I I guess I'll take a win on
on that one. And then we look over on
the opposite side of the table. Um, as I
said, a very formidable player in their
own right playing the Draven. This is
the first time you and I are going to
actually get to cast a Draven game. And
this version is the mid-range Draven.
Wow. Okay. There's a card in this list
that we haven't seen too much um like
we've not seen a whole lot of Darius
recently sometimes throughout this
tournament. You and I haven't been able
to to see it too much. Obviously saw it
a heck of a lot in Origins uh in the
Kaiser decks.
>> Absolutely. It's one of the easiest
units to just play and then push into a
battlefield immediately. Was always used
with the cleave card. So you could imag
immediately for six energy just have a
ready unit that goes up to 10 might
which is absolutely crazy especially if
you're looking at the power level of
origins. However in the Draven deck in
Draven you want to have some tempo. This
card is also incredibly useful paired
with some units that are incredibly
sticky. So you can push a Ferris for you
develop it you already have a great
presence on board and then in the next
turn you're following that up with a
Darius. it's really hard to beat them.
That is also why so far Draven has been
the best deck of the tournament.
>> And Draven on the first turn of the game
is always a good sign if you're a Draven
player. Um, one of the reasons that
Draven is is quite so um so consistent
is it curves out extremely well. Uh, two
might into four might into two power
into four power for instance goes very
well throughout the early game. It's
going to be a very early Ezreal play
from Allan getting that draw
>> immediately developing it. Also, he
forgot to put his headphones on which is
not too bad. But now we know we fixed
that.
>> One thing about that uh we of course do
play with some delay there. So, uh it's
not that uh he will be able to hear us
at any point. Thankfully, they are these
these games have already at least begun
and started taking place. So, we are uh
working with a little bit of a a buffer
there. So, Treasure Hunter goes to the
battlefield over to Reaver's Row, will
get the gold. And that's one of the
things getting these gold tokens early
on just allows you to kind of compensate
for recycling at any point, whether it's
with the Draven ability on the attack or
defender trigger or there are multiple
other cards in the deck that that force
recruitment uh force recycling. Treasure
hunter going to use the Reaver's Road to
back away as Ezreal goes to the base.
>> That is already inherently broken,
right? You have a two drop. Of course,
only one might, but you scored a point.
And then you had the reverse row as well
to just immediately generate another
piece of gold, but the bellows breath is
being used afterwards in base. So, you
can also hit the Draven with it and then
go for a frigid touch immediately.
Making so much use out of this passive
ability of Ezreal. Lens is showing
everyone, hey, here I am and I'm going
to rock you like a hurricane. Yeah, I
I've seen a lot of chatter around this
Ezreal deck being very very strong um
into a lot of the matchups like Draven.
And of course, Ezreal with Raver's Row
for once, you can't actually move it to
a battlefield and say, "Yeah, I'll just
take that defense trigger." However, the
problem with that is you of course uh
essentially losing a combat uh which
Draven is fine with that. It's like,
"Yeah, I I'll get benefit from doing
that."
>> Especially versus a Kaiser, right? So,
that was two draws immediately. is very
good for Marcus. However, Alensz, I
mean, he is playing the Ezreal deck. He
is going to repeat so many card effects.
So, you really want this Ezreal Prodigy
in your base. You want it to be safe and
sound.
But now, how are we going to follow this
up? I think this is a Raven Bloom
Student. That is a two drop that has
been falling out of favor when Spirit
Forge released. Oh, we are going to
actually play the seal. Seal of discord
so important in that deck. Oh, we are
going to go for the combination that
shouldn't be possible. Fizz plus the
arcane shift.
>> Oh, hard bargain in response. So, Arcane
Shift ends up in the bin. Will now of
course try and take Kaiser out from the
battlefield as uh that will come
through. Hard bargain.
>> So we're dealing the damage here.
Fighter flight is not happening. Have we
done any damage to that Kaiser before?
>> Wait. Yeah, that's what I was looking
for. Um,
am I missing something? It's It's
possible I am.
>> I think we might be missing something.
This did
>> because typically Arcane Oh, there's
>> it's three damage.
>> Yeah, Bellow's breath wasn't cast as
well.
>> There might be something on the fizz
that makes your And it's not on the void
gate. Are we assuming that void gate is
the the battlefield? Cuz we're on
Reaver's Row, right? Voidgate is the
other battlefield. Kaiser was set on
Reaver's Row. I mean, maybe I'm missing
something, but I I
>> So, for the moment,
>> I feel like Kai'Sa should have been
alive on one.
>> Does Voate is it asymmetrical? Is it
just units at this point?
>> I think you blinked out I think I have
it. I think you might have blinked out
the Fizz and then replay it and then get
the frigid touch from the discard pile
to lower the Kaiser's might. Then again,
we did not see
>> shortcutting potentially. Okay, sorry.
But uh I'm going to clarify this. I'm
going to try and clarify this with some
of the judges. Of course, this game is
already happened. It it has happened in
the past. We're working with a slight
delay here. So even if we realize
something that would be wrong with the
game, which I honestly when we were
playing with Allen's EQ versus Marcus
Patel,
>> I'm going to assume they know what
they're doing.
>> Absolutely.
>> We couldn't help it. So we're going with
what we got here. Nex is hopeful. Noox
is hopeful.
>> It's going to be played in the base
after a falling star. Vex is now ready.
>> I'm pretty pretty sure you're right. It
was the the Fizz Arcane Shift Fizz
again. Uh and then it it gets the
frrigid touch out of the the the trash.
So, the Reaver's Row is absolutely
pivotal for the Draven strategy. If
you're playing Reaver's Row in game one,
especially because you probably know
what your opponent is on. Maybe you have
a different battlefield you want to play
when you know that you're playing a
Draven matchup or when you don't know
what you're playing. Mariva's Row is
incredibly powerful because every time
you use it, you save a unit. You can
have something like an overzealous fan
that gets you very important points and
then again, if your opponent uses it,
you get a free draw. So now the morbid
return gets you back the Ezreal. This is
also a really nice way to play around
the scenario where you think, hey, maybe
I need to play two Ezreal or three
Ezreal in my deck to constantly have
Ezreals. You can play W return in case
your Ezreal gets removed from the
battlefield. However, you can also use
it on other cards like the Fizz
Trickster.
>> Yeah. And then I I So there's a couple
of really unique interactions here. I
think you saw Allan unte.
There actually was, I believe, a combat
showdown going on with Vex. Even though
the defender trigger comes in and rea
technically Vex is involved in a combat,
so allows you to pay less for uh a spell
that happens during a combat. Vex is
involved with just uh catching up on the
current state of the game from this. I
will say Allan being 11 and0 with a deck
that constantly recurs things from the
the graveyard and is
>> relatively complex to play is impressive
at this point to be to be very clean on
exactly what's happening. Clearly I've
lost what I'm
saying it's scary to go up against as
well because this is also a deck that
really needs some time. you have grinded
out games deciding Oh, I love this
reverse ro. I'm going to go into that
later on. But this is a deck that really
takes quite some time.
>> Yeah.
>> And I'm very impressed that he actually
managed to not draw a single time or
lose to timeout, but just went 11 and 0.
That is absolutely massive.
>> Yeah. Huge. I mean, you expect that from
a player that, you know, was
>> getting the best of Kaiser in a meta
that Kaiser was uh very very prevalent
of back in Houston. Now I really enjoy
what Alz is doing with the reavers row
here. You have this vex five might and
he just shies away from an overzealous
fan which is only at two might knowing
hey I do not have any combat tricks and
I don't want my opponent to commit
heavily into this play so that they can
get the actual kill on my Vex.
>> And I find it interesting we were
talking about this a little bit uh
knowing that that we were going to kind
of be looking at this matchup for a few
minutes before we started. Um, we were
talking about the the prevalence of Vex
in this list maybe not hitting Draven as
much as it hits other matchups because
for instance like uh like in Aurelia Vex
will shut down pretty hard but Draven
has uh spinning axes which I'm pretty
sure Vex doesn't actually affect. I'm
pretty sure it's spells uh during the
turn and of course gear
>> do not get affected by that.
>> Exactly. Especially not if it's quick
draw.
>> I mean it doesn't change anything.
>> No, but quick draw makes it nice and
difficult to play around. That's that's
the one you can use in combat on the Q
carefully sequencing out his turn in his
mind. All right, we are going to maybe
do something with a Raven Bloom student.
Of course, you have just drawn into
Singularity a card that is really well
used by Ezreal. However, Ezreal,
especially in this version, if you do
not have gold tokens from, for example,
a card shop,
>> you will not be able to use your seal of
discord to reduce the power cost you
have to pay for Singularity. I wonder
though singularity here is there a
danger that you it whiffs because yeah
>> that you we know there's multiple
spinning axes in hand. So do you just
like with the targets when they get
selected you go spinning axe spinning
axe I'm up and above because you you
imagine Darius is the one that's you're
going to try singularity and I would
assume Nox is hopeful potentially on top
of that but spinning ax will put both of
those. Uh although voidgate would
prevent the Noxus hopeful. So you might
have to put both or at least cast two
spells just to to untap Darius to keep
it safe on on that seven.
>> Yeah. I mean if your opponent uses a
singularity just to get rid of your
noxis hopeful I think you just take it,
right? You don't need to necessarily
preserve it and put two spinning axes on
it.
>> I guess my point is more that Allan has
to think about through all of these
lines. It's like which two which two
cards or or you know uh what two
abilities are going to be able to
nullify a singularity. So, it's one of
many, many, many options at this point.
And this is why I'm I'm impressed at the
clean gameplay that you is required from
an Ezreal list like this.
>> Now, Marcus even said, I don't even need
to play a combat with this. Is not going
to use the spinning axes on the Vex
fight with his Nox is hopeful. Now, a
seal of discord is now going to be
tapped so that the Vex comes in for
free. Vex cheerless. Those stack, right?
So, if you're attacking with two vex,
your opponent has to pay so much for
each of those spells. Yeah, that's the
really important thing to be to be aware
of. It does have to be a combat that
involves Vex. So, yeah, if you're
attacking or defending with both of
them, you'll get both triggers, but
other than that, they uh
>> do not both apply in that regard.
>> That sounds like it's made for the
Urelia matchup, which is otherwise a
really tough matchup for the Ezreal
deck. But if you're playing versus
Urelia, they just have one big unit and
you tell them all of a sudden your
discipline is costing four energy and
two power.
>> Oh, that's painful.
I think one thing that that uh
>> we're going to see the the spinning X
potentially here. I was going to say one
thing that that might be pretty
influential in this match up, the Brin
here that we just saw in in hand may
very well
>> uh come to importance later.
>> Thundersong is also a card you need to
learn how to play around it. Yeah,
>> because there's many different things
force you.
So, if you play it and you have 10 runes
open, you kind of need to throw all of
your cards in hand into it or just
accept that the Brin here is going to be
a massive turn for your opponent. So,
what you want to do is keep some runes
open, but try to play as efficient as
possible on your turn still so that you
don't give them a great Brin here turn,
but also don't force them to not play it
because you're tapped out because then
you're always tapped out and that
doesn't help you,
>> right? I was going to say uh Allan
looked like he was going for arcane
shift a cost reduction but that is going
to be a double hard bargain that is paid
five for for the repeat that which is uh
a significant investment but it will
cause Darius to ready and get that
additional might.
>> Marcus is driving a hard bargain here.
Rebuke is going to be played for one
>> wow
>> and then there yeah that is that is
painful
>> after that hard bargain. You have to
assume there's probably not another one
coming.
>> And then that forces something else. If
the Darius is going to get removed here,
that forces the following thing, the
spinning ax. Do you have to equip it
then so that you don't lose it on the
next turn?
>> You kind of have to put it either you
play another Darius or you have to put
it on the overzealous fan. There's
already one trigger on the Raven Bloom
student. So this one is at three now
because you know the other one got
negated.
>> Yeah. And you can't afford the Darius
either.
>> Yeah. So
>> it has to go on the fan
>> that I mean you keep the spinning ax
around but your opponent just steals one
more power from you which is really
really strong and in those grindy games
just I mean sometimes it doesn't sound
that bad that you have to pay one extra
power cost right but if you're looking
over the next future turns right if
you're looking at the next four turns
that is in total four energy that you
are missing just because you had to pay
one more cost if you're trying to be
very efficient. Okay, here's the second
spinning axe.
>> Again, not affected by Vex. So, this
time Vex will uh head to the trash.
>> But then again, this is a unit that
definitely can be gotten rid of. I don't
know if that's even a sentence,
actually. Sorry.
>> Makes sense.
>> But I'll take that.
>> I mean, if if if you now get rid of the
overzealous fan, which you really can't
necessarily do by combat. Ah, no, wait.
Actually, it's not the revers effect.
It's it's
>> sacrifice this card and then push one
from your opponent back. But if you just
singularity it, which in the void gate
still works,
>> you're going to get rid of the double
>> damage.
>> Yeah. Now, now that becomes a question
of like what's what's the importance of
that? Does Allan also have any
additional uh ways to do it? Are there
any like mainboard rebukes? Um I wish
I'd have paid more attention to the deck
list. We've seen one already. Yeah.
Okay. So, how many are there going to
be? I guess then is is the answer to
that? Like are there any left
>> in the deck?
>> You have Fizz Trickster. So
>> yeah, you can bring it back. That's
another very very solid point. This is
again what I mean about this deck is
like there's so much to follow in in the
sense of like your trash is not out of
the game. Like the only thing so far
that's banished is the Arcane Shift. Um
and I believe
>> the second one was hard bargain, right?
So that's also a target for Fizz.
>> Yeah, definitely
>> in future.
>> Oh, it's really really strong what LZQ
can do with those fizzes here. The only
thing that is not as efficient about
Fizz than with just hard playing the
card is if you're pushing Vex into the
battlefield and you have an action spell
that is going to save you from the
overzealous fan with two spinning axes
or get rid of it rather, then it's it's
going to be much cheaper than when
you're just playing a Fizz, right?
>> Very true. Very true. But uh you know
that would be that would be broken if if
Fizz could be used at any speed other
than uh the the regular speed.
Pretty sure we just got a uh quote
unquote free called shot with the uh the
first seal. There is a fizz in hand.
There is a mind spplitter. So uh
sometimes the best option is just find
out what you're playing against and get
rid of something.
>> Oh, we're going to use a spinning X
again. This is the biggest overzealous
fan I've seen in quite a long time. But
this looks like an absolute destruction.
Alan ZQ is going through this match up
like nothing else. Now gets complete
information. There's Darius. There's
Darius. There's a Ferris 4Runner.
>> These are huge units. Huge, huge units
that if they stick on the battlefield.
Here comes the Fizz. Is this Do we go
for the rebuke and then get
>> free rebuke from the Fizz effect? And
Alen just gives up and says, "Yep,
that's that's going to do it." Wow,
Ellen ZQ, that looked like child's play
for him. Honestly, he just went through
this matchup.
>> That is very clean.
Very, very, very clean. Uh, impressive
at at that point. And I mean, I think
most people would be quite panicked with
uh uh seeing three spinning axes come
out. And
>> yeah,
>> very impressed by Allen's first game in
this series.
>> Look at him rolling up his sleeves here
going into game two soon. There you can
see the deckless. Look at it. Remember
it. Write some notes down because this
is what it's all about. We have 1,000
tailed Watch here, one mind spplitter.
Those are cards that you are seeing
quite frequently with triple cold shot
and of course also stack deck. So you
have quite the draw power in this deck,
especially when you're considering that
most of your cards just alone trigger
the Prodigal Explorer ability. So you
can draw cards and then you can combine
those with more Arcane Shifts.
>> And there are some interesting ones like
one copy of Smokecreen, uh, one copy of
Morbid Return, some some very like
finely tuned details to this deck, which
I I I like. It's impressive. But, you
know, when you're net decking and you're
taking someone's deck, not having the
rationale for why specific cards are
one-offs in there, like you might think
you know, but actually until you've
played out the amount of reps that a
deck deserves can be very difficult to
play it out. Now, we see Marcus is
sideboard.
>> That's that's true. So, sometimes if you
just net a deck, you don't know what
it's all about. But for random one-offs,
there's always one reasoning that that
is always going to be true. It's going
to make the game for your opponent much
harder. First of all, if they don't play
around it because they think you might
not play it.
>> Mhm.
>> And second of all, if they play around
it constantly because they have seen it
in either on your table in the previous
round or in game one and they play
around a smoke screen and you never had
a smoke screen, but it's in their head.
So, you're going to make you might might
not even draw it, but it's still going
to affect the game.
>> I think that might have potentially an
impact in this matchup as well. uh if it
if it comes to it. One copy of Edge of
Knight in Marcus' deck and at least one
copy of Switcheroo that we saw coming
from this. So uh very interesting
matchup. I I would say of all the
matchups we've had so far, this I would
say is like our heavyweight contest of
names in in car games playing now on day
two looking for a spot
>> in the top eight. 11 and0 against 10 and
one. You know, Marcus Patel.
>> Yeah,
>> I've I've seen him play other games so
far already. I know how great of a TCG
player he is. He's super experienced. He
has the titles to his name as well.
We're immediately going down in power
again. Starting off with the Azri. We
want to find our seals. We want to find
our cards. But also, I talked to him
before the round. I was like, "Did you
play versus Allen already?" And he said,
>> "No, dude. Thankfully not, because if I
see Allan, if I play versus Allen, I'm
just going to scoop, man."
>> Well, that at the end of the game
happened for Marcus uh in game one
knowing when he was done and saying,
"Okay, let's get into the next game."
Interestingly, Targon's Peak, a
battlefield we haven't seen so much in
Spirit Forge. Um Marcus is saying,
"Yeah, I kind of doesn't want to play
Annie." Uh
>> exactly. Let me let me play Annie. Uh
>> t There are people who play Annie over
Draven because it's so strong to get
your two runes back at the end of the
turn. Targon's Peak makes your deck just
Annie on default plus the Draven
ability. It is phenomenal. You can just
play out in most of these turns,
especially when decks do not want you to
get those combats and they shy away from
combat. They give you a few free points
maybe with something like the pit rookie
combination with Kull.
>> Yeah,
>> you know, they are giving you some
points, they take those points back. But
if you can be more energy efficient, you
can play a Ferris 4runner on six runes
and then ready two runes. There is so
much Draven can do with two energy open.
Yeah, and we we've we've just seen some
of it in hand with a Ferris 4Runner as
well, but it's actually going to be
Marcus Singh go with a Ferris 4Runner.
Didn't want to commit into it. Um, of
course, this turn wouldn't have been
able to untap cuz you're not conquering
Tarun's Peak, so wouldn't have access to
that. It would have to be on a
subsequent turn, but there are multiple
spinning axes and here is potentially
the way already flipping one one rune.
It is Allen's priority first though in
the uh the showdown. Uh, this is one of
the ways where you can kind of play
around this. Vex, spinning X, again, we
mentioned it in game one, does not get
affected by Vex's uh, asymmetrical
ability. For those of you that are not
familiar with Vex, it will make your
opponent's spells during combat with Vex
cost more. It's one and a recycle. And
your spells will cost one and one
recycle less during combat that Vex is
involved with.
>> And it's so funny because you can just,
you know, you don't have a seal yet. You
think, hey, cold shot might be
expensive.
>> Free cold shot.
>> Exactly. together with your Azil.
>> Ezreal. Cool. I'll look at four cards
and take two of them.
>> It's so good. You basically essentially
play six heals now.
>> Oh, and then an an arcane shift is
another great choice. That looks like a
retreat.
>> We are getting just through so many
cards already in this turn. You just
need to make sure that you can save the
Vex if your opponent has enough combat
tricks because when you're playing
versus Draven and they leave open six
runes, there's going to be something
coming your way. And now you you
basically are just uh looking
looking at like all these cards that are
low cost. It is to a minimum of one. So
super fight does not become free. Um but
you're looking at all of these cards.
You're like, well that cost one, that
cost one, that cost one. Like everything
is so cheap. This is half a binder in
Alenq's hand. Can also go for the
projectile explorer gets more cards. We
want more cards. We want more cards.
Double stupify equals triple draw. Now,
the first response for Marcos. He's
like, "Hey, can I play some cards?"
>> I I would like to play a card in this
showdown, please.
>> Now, that is
very interesting. Puts up the Draven to
a total of nine might minus two. So,
it's seven again. We're going to resolve
the stupify as this was a reaction
response onto the stupify. And now Lens
Q has the priority again and is going to
just use Rebuke for one power cost and
one energy cost. Vex all of a sudden
disgusting.
>> It was so overlooked but it feels like
it's the obvious choice for every deck.
No.
>> And Allen. Okay. Hard bargain important
spending a lot. That's a six cost
repeated hard bargain.
>> But Alan ZQ drives a hard bargain too.
It's got a hard bargain. The hard
bargain. you can get your Draven back
and the spinning X preemptively put to
the trash. This card is not going
anywhere. It's another game where Lensq
is dominating
>> and Marcus took an entire turn off
calculating like, okay, I'm going to
need the spinning axe. I'm going to need
the repeated hard bargain in order to
win through this. And Allan says, "No,
I've seen half of my deck. I have the
cost reduction in play and I'm just
going to have every single answer that I
need in this situation." Dude, you were
on to something with your Vex
prediction. This card is absolutely
phenomenal. It's so strong.
>> I am that annoying hand destruction like
tax you kind of player uh when I play
card games. So, I'm so sorry to anybody
that ever has to play against Vex
against this. But Allan is making it
look incredibly strong. It's it's so
crazy. And honestly, this obelisk of
power is not going to be attacked next
turn because let's be honest, we have
now conquered the Targon's Peak.
That is going to give us two runes at
the end of the turn. It's going to
refresh them. We're going to put them
active again. Now, double seals. Triple
seals. We're never going to pay any
power cost again.
>> And when your spells are getting reduced
in cost anyway, and you're like, okay,
well, I just need to skirt around the
whole I need to recycle thing part of
things. And that's
>> I'm assuming that is yeah for one
probably for the number of cards Allens
is counting proving it that it is at
least low cost. Who who even needs to
pay for spells and units anymore in
Riftbound.
>> Exactly. Not not if you're Alan EQ. This
looks this is just an utter destruction.
Goes in with the spinning ax onto that
vex. We are now at even might. Does LZQ
even want to respond this? Is it
possible? Hey,
>> I think he actually forgot the target
speed trigger.
>> I think you might be right because there
was a conquer through, right? That that
did happen. Um, as mentioned, we are um
these games were played out a little bit
in the past. So, nothing we can say or
do at this point in time
>> would affect the state of play. I think
you may very well be correct on that,
which is uh costly
at that point. Now we
>> if it indeed is the correct
>> got rid of that Vex somehow Targon's
Peak is going to be held and now the
situation is it even changing so much.
You only have six runes for this turn.
So you only have six energy. I mean
power cost is not something you're going
to be very likely to pay with your three
seals of discord.
>> Mhm.
>> But there's only so much energy you can
pay.
>> Yes. Uh Alan does also have another Vex
in hand. Of course, again, it's quite a
costly unit to actually get out onto the
battlefield to uh to get it into base
and then it obviously takes another turn
from there.
>> He's giving him a run for his money
though. I feel like those two runes
could have really done a lot there,
especially since there is cards like
Wages of Pain and Head or the Arcane
Shift. Those could have been used on the
attack onto the Vex. Now, we're going to
develop a Vex. We're going to hide the
wages of pain into the Targon's Peak. Of
course, just paying with the seal of
discord again. We're never going to pay
power cost ever again in this game
unless it has to be mined.
>> Yeah, that's uh
if you're Ezreal and you have three
seals out, something has gone well in
the game so far. However, it's a very
strong like a like scary hand on the
side of Marcus having big units, having
uh you know the Ferris 4Runner there.
This is setting up to be next turn
contesting battlefields trying to go
over the top trying to establish
presence and say, "Okay,
>> it doesn't matter if I have to pay a lot
for spells if I'm just stronger than you
in the moment and and so strong that you
cannot get past me."
>> I can see that now. All of a sudden,
Marcus Patel is in a really advantageous
position, has bigger units on board, and
I think it always felt like to me that
Alan's EQ was really far ahead in both
of these games. But I think that's just
his aura at this point.
>> But look at the spells that are in hand.
There's arcane shift. There's um you
know, if you hold a battlefield, you can
arcane shift and as long as you control
it. Sorry, when I say hold, I mean if
you're controlling a battlefield, you're
able to play the unit back to it. So,
it's something you deal
from the other if the Vex is there so
that you immediately bring more power
over you've got the hidden card as well.
There's like a lot of tricky options
that Allan has. I think from Marcus'
side that is like, okay, what crazy line
is Allen going to do if I try and go
into a showdown?
>> I mean, if you're playing versus Ezreal
that is controlling two battlefields
currently, that's scary. it becomes just
so much scarier with the archangel.
You're absolutely right about that on
the spot. So, Anzu, he hasn't targeted
cards in a long time here. Also, we
cannot forget about the wages of pain
that is being hidden right now. I think
about four to five cards in hand. We're
still going to consider what we're
taking back for the Mob return. It is
another Vex. So, not only for the Aelia
matchup, this card is being highly
valued by Ellen ZQ. Of course, Seal of
Discord is going to be exhausted to pay
the power cost.
>> Like crazy in a good way is what I mean.
I'm not saying crazy bad decision. I'm
saying crazy that like Vex is a card
that was not on people's radar coming
into this and we're seeing it have such
a high prevalence in a game where
somebody is 11 and0. Allan is 11 and0
undefeated with this and we're seeing it
come back with a morbid return. Again,
another card that is on nobody's radar
for being in the meta right now. We've
all talked about and heard about Draven,
Draven, Draven, Draven all the time. The
League of Draven is what we were
expecting this weekend. And it's not
over for Marcus yet. Still has the point
lead. Still is developing a board. But I
am in awe of just how this matchup is
playing out 100%. It's it's really
really interesting. Now I'm quite
curious. Oh, against the odds putting
two extra might on this Ferris 4Runner.
And Alen ZQ is just answering with a
wages of pain. There could have been
some potential play with the arcane
shift as well to deal six damage to the
ferris forrunner. But now that it's
boosted anyways, I feel like you just
you just take the even trade. And I'm
saying even in in quotation marks
because there is still going to be six
might in the base of Marcus. Patel can
now conquer the tagon. Peak is going to
ready two runes at the end of the turn.
Place another Draven and the overzealous
fan.
>> It is a big battlefield. I think there's
a Kaiser in hand as well. We're looking
accelerated units at the end of the
turn. Marcus will get the untap
raise two runes because of the conquer
on target speak. Now Alan, this is where
this is where the million lines in front
of you make this very tricky. Marcus has
a very clear strategy. The board has
been established. Now, how do you just
conquer both on the next turn in order
to take this to a game three?
>> And I mean, this is what Draven does
best, right? People have been talking
about how incredibly strong Draven is in
these scenarios.
>> Double Vex
>> if you're at point.
>> Spells are going to become basically
free at this point.
>> The good thing is you I think you know
at LZQ side that there can't be spinning
access anymore.
>> Okay. Allan does take a step back from
that showdown starting. Moves Ezreal to
the obelisk of power first. now moves
Vex in to begin the showdown on targets.
>> Oh, is he?
>> And then you're going to blink the
Ezreal back. Yeah, because of course it
it then of course is going to go back to
safety.
>> Ezreal taking this and is of course
going to be able to draw more cards. We
have another body. We don't want
>> Don't need a third Vex. Get get out of
here.
>> Oh my goodness. Instead of drawing into
useful combat tricks, you found two
Raven Blues.
>> Two students.
>> That is rough.
>> But you do have Bellow's breath and
smoke screen. So those cards can help
you. There's also frigid touch. So if
you are the thing is he put two vex into
one battlefield.
>> So
>> I mean that that makes smokec screen and
bellow's breath and and frizz touch very
very much cheaper on a on a following
turn. But that is true but only if the
combat is happening with the Vexus. If
you spread out the Vexes evenly, you
don't really get the the full discount
of two energy that you're paying less. I
think I like it. You can give your
opponent one obelisk of power conquer
>> and then you're holding with double vex.
That is a pretty decent line. Battle's
breath is just going to be used now
>> on the
>> on three units in the base.
>> Are we just
>> We're still in the in the combat.
>> Yeah. So the the reduction cost is still
going. Again, even though we're not
dealing with anything within the
battlefield that Vex is at, there is
still a combat showdown going on.
>> So you can't play these cards for free
with Wex, right?
>> No, no, it's to a minimum of one. I'm
pretty sure
>> one energy, right? So
>> yes, I'm going to double check that. I'm
pretty sure it is.
>> Pay the power cost, of course. Ezreal is
going to trigger as the legend ability.
So that's another way of finding cards
to draw. I think you only need to pay
one energy in total for the double
bellows breath because you have Ezreal
Prodigy in your base as well. So you use
that one to not pay the extra energy and
the Vexus take away
>> the power cost of the Bellow's breath.
>> You are correct. It is to a minimum of
one energy specifically. Um it important
to be very clear on that especially at
this point when you're fighting for top
eight potentially. I mean, you have to
believe Allan ZQ being in an 110
position. You're thinking about, okay,
>> you never want to say you're guaranteed
until mathematically it's done. But
Bella's breath is going to come out, put
damage
>> on the back line. Now, does that mean
while we stay in the combat here, we see
smoke screen, smoke screen, frigid touch
>> on the backline units.
>> Frigid touch looks good here for two
different units. Yeah, there we go.
>> The Draven gets killed immediately. And
with the overzealous fan,
>> yeah, smoke screen goes on it as well.
Is that enough? It is. It will eat
through the overzealous fan. So,
>> just utilizing combat phases to deal
with totally different parts of the game
is the level of like indepth that Allan
is going to in this match up.
>> I am in awe about this. This is so
fantastic
is doing here. And Marcus Patel, he is
one of the best TCG players in the
world. But
>> I mean, there are more options. Is it
Bellow's breath again or Okay, cold
shot. Okay, we're we're not going for
more kills. We're going for I need to
refill my hand again. C free shots. Um
just by tapping that seal.
>> Yep. And remember, you still have to
play the power cost. You're you're
ignoring the energy cost. So culture is
not the most efficient card you would
want to use with a fizz, but I mean at
this point discord if it's a seal of
discord. Yeah,
>> you have 20 seals basically at this
point.
>> I feel like we've had more arcane shifts
in this one round than I've seen
anybody. Yeah, I was going to say
anybody play.
>> Also very interesting to note there is
going to be another Ton's Peak trigger
because we have just conquered this
battlefield. So actually also making
good use of that if he remembers this
time. I can see players forgetting
battlefield triggers way more often when
it's actually about battlefields of the
other player.
>> Yeah, there is the untap. This time Alan
ZQ will ready the uh the two runes at
the end. And also never to underestimate
regardless of the fact that both of
these are extremely experienced players
playing in a feature match in a high
pressure match is always going to be the
time where you know it you have to focus
on so much. I can always understand
something at the end of a turn just
sneaking by and I I knew I forgot to do
that. That type of thing
>> can never underestimate. It's easy to
watch a game and and say ah I still
forgot this bit
>> and we even missed stuff. And we are
watching the game. We see both players.
>> Tell me about it.
>> But there's also, of course, this is
such a nice dynamic game, Riftbound.
That is you are having so many different
interactions. There's so many things get
that can happen to you. Kaiser is going
to try and take the oblisk of power.
Wants to get another wants to get
another door.
>> Is this the same thing you do it on? Are
we doing it on the Fizz in order to get
that spell cast? We are.
>> Are you rebuking?
Are you rebuking the Kaiser
>> or it's just to deal like get a minus?
Is it stupify? You find a supery, get
the minus one, get a card draw, get
>> and deal free damage
>> cuz you, you know, looking at it, okay,
could be frigid touch or whatever, but
no, go for the super, get the card draw,
refill
>> the amount of cleanliness. I mean,
that's the way I'm going to keep saying
it. Allan is playing very cleanly and
Marcus is putting up such a fight, such
a good fight. Now, we'll go up to seven
>> with the conquer.
>> Going up to seven is not really going to
help him. He's trying to hold that
battlefield with everything he got. This
is hiding another card. This is another
game shot
>> and hiding all the units at the
battlefield.
>> I was like, we need to be able to
calculate the map. So, it's two mechs
plus a Noxus hopeful plus a fight or
flight. And now Allan is going to ready
at this point. It's just to go to 12
and0. If Allan can go and hold this
first battlefield and then conquer the
second, it's a watcher
draws into Thousand Tailed Watcher.
Surely that is going to be enough with
the Raven Bloom, with the Ezreal, with
the Watcher,
>> that can still be fight or flight. So
when you play Watcher, most of the time
you don't have enough runes to do
anything else. Held on to seven, by the
way, of course on the Targon's Peak. So
now if you are going for that watcher,
you have four runes left to do some
shenanigans with. Max is not going to
help you. Now we're going to do
something really smart and we start
poking. We start going for some combat
out. Surely that means it's then, right?
What else is in hand? That is the
handshake. And Allen's EQ will take the
game 2 and zero. 12 and0 undefeated here
in Bologonia. That is incredible.
>> Look at that smirk on his face. Look at
that smile. Alan's EQ is absolutely aura
farming to the max. He's dominating the
rift bouncing. He has announced that he
wants to go for multiple Ezreal Prodigal
Explorer best off cards.
>> And surely in with a shot. surely surely
in a great position for that.
>> I think if he is playing the deck at
every tournament, I think that is going
to mean that the numbers for Ezreal
players at these tournaments trying to
go for the best of cards, they are going
down surely because this is a player,
this is the player you will have to
compete with if you want to go for the
best of Ezreal.
>> That is a scary deck to play against
because so there are so many lines you
you literally cannot account for
everything in that situation. The the
mid combat, okay, I'll target Fizz. I'll
grab something from my trash. I'll play
it. There are so many options. Even if
you're just grabbing Cold Shot, looking
for other things. Um and and bringing
the VEX tech in for those showdowns
where you're going to focus on other
parts of the game, uh I think is is
genius. It's it's so good. So, credit to
Alan and I know Allan has testing
partners that they're always talking
about. So, the team that have kind of
workshopped on that, I would love to
hear more about that as we see Allan go
through the rest of the tournament. 12
and0 is in such such a wonderful
position for Allan. And I mean Marcus is
a player we're expecting still to be
competing. We're still looking at will
they be able to make top eight, but that
is a big name to take down on your way
to an undefeated run so far for Alen EQ.
>> Yeah, that should mean actually that we
have Alan ZQ guaranteed in the top cut.
Of course, I I don't trust completely
here, but I think that should be just
just one more round of Swiss. We were
going to confirm that later on, of
course, but
>> we're not done. Let's go for another
game. Let's get another one from this
round. Let's jump into our second
feature match as we head in ever closer
to a top eight. And uh I think I knew
what this was before we sat down, but
I'm so excited. I'm pretty sure it is a
Kaiser
and a Rex. I will we'll have that
confirmed. I'm seeing red and and
yellow.
I I'm going to need to take the next
couple of minutes just to ramp down for
a little moment as I am excited to see
Rexi, but that was such a cool first
feature match. Rex eye we haven't seen
no
>> for our games so far. Uh so this is the
version, you know, with void rash under
Titan trying to get cheaper units with a
bit of a finish on that under Titan.
>> Rexai Breacher is a gorgeous card.
>> It is. I love it. But these decks in the
beginning they were very unit heavy, but
now people have started to play a lot of
removal. You're going to get free cards
from the top of your deck most of the
time and therefore you are you're
finding so many cards that you play
cheaper.
>> And there's another asymmetrical
interaction with this where when you
call a weak immortal Phoenix, it will
see itself die uh to the spell and come
back. Uh, so if you have the accelerate
like sundisk that we've seen being
played, it will be able to come in,
accelerate with the assault, kind of get
onto battlefields very, very quickly. So
I think that's a bit of tech that throws
people uh when you see it for the first
time. Whereas Kaiser, this feels like
I'm looking at an origins list other
than progress day if I'm being honest.
And I don't say that in any bad way. You
and I talked about this off camera a lot
coming into this. Now up to three copies
of Time Warp uh in Kaiser. A lot of
Kaisers in Origins were running a lot
less. There's a few extra cards here
with the get excited allows you to
discard time warp. You've been a big fan
of that combination to deal with big
units on the battlefield.
>> I do like it more if you play more
progress days. I will be very clear on
that. That is my personal opinion on
that matter because get excited is a
card that loses a value. Of course, most
of the time there's not always going to
be the scenario where you discard time
war for Get Excited and you get rid of
an exactly 10 might unit. So to use the
tempo that you're gaining with get
excited by removing big units, you will
have to have the value of resolving
progress day so that you do not fall
behind on card advantage, which is why I
prefer more progress day, more time
warp, and then get excited.
>> And as we head into this, an eight and
three for both players, Bullet and the
Duffin,
>> that is three different runes
immediately. And something in me screams
that this is wrong. Well, you know,
sometimes sometimes you just like a
little bit of variance. Um 8 and three.
This is a very important very important
round for both these players. You would
have to imagine uh a win here keeps you
alive. A loss pretty much removes you
from contention. Again, we'll have to
run the math exactly, but knowing an XM4
is not necessarily going to be able to
hold on. So, cheap early game units for
Rexside dropping the poro and also
Noxus. Hopeful. I think already X2 is
going to be really tough to get into the
top eight. So top eight from over
a,500,800
people,
>> but that's where we're looking at best
of cards cuz we're looking at Rexite
content. Who is in contention for that?
So yeah, very very very true. As we head
through our final set of Swiss rounds,
>> can I just say I love Daring Porro?
>> Yeah, you can. He's so daring. Very
daring. There's uh there is a void rush
in hand. Um, Rexi,
not as I said, this is the first time
we're casting it. Rexi, of course, when
you conquer, you'll be able to uh re um
is it look or reveal on Rexi legend
ability? The uh
>> you are revealing.
>> I thought so. Yeah, this is where is
reveal is uh you're revealing from the
top of the deck and you can play one of
the cards.
>> Yeah,
>> here comes And now you're going to use
that seal of rage that you just played
for nothing so far. So, I think we're
just generating some fury power to see
what is going to happen from the top of
our deck. I was uh already seeing some
immortal Phoenixes being played there. I
was looking forward for that because I
can imagine that this is a card that is
tough for Kai'Sa to handle with the
recurring
>> because it keeps coming back every time
you use a kill spell on it. It's going
to just recur come back from the trash
and uh kind of sit there and always when
you have that call the weak interaction
that's always nice. Uh, hidden blade,
piercing light.
>> Well, those are not necessarily the
cards that you wanted to hit,
>> but we're going to see how we continue.
Piercing Light. Hidden Blade is a
relatively important card here because
this deck can struggle with card draw a
little bit, the Rex eye side. You you
it's very rune intensive is one of the
ways I would put it. Ooh, piercing light
to just deal with the Kaiser. Just say,
"Okay, yeah, I'm going to repeat it. I'm
fine. Leaving my power job is done." and
end up taking out the base copy of
Kai'Sa.
>> Honestly, heavy investment on the turn.
Think you're losing a little bit of
tempo, but you're also taking away some
of your opponents, of course. And you
deny card draw, which is always
important, especially versus Kaiser,
especially when there's only one
progress day in the deck. If they do not
find it, the deck can struggle from time
to time. You have the lecturing yaw, but
I don't cons I mean, that's a very
stupid statement that I'm going to make.
I'm already sorry for that.
>> It's okay. You're welcome. I'm ready. I
don't necessarily I don't necessarily
consider this card card draw because it
just replaces itself, right? It's a it's
a small body that helps you find other
cards faster. So, you're basically
playing less cards in your deck.
>> Oh, there is progress,
>> but it's not going to give you the card
advantage.
>> All right, never mind.
>> Yeah, I know. I was going to say we we
we can just circumvent that issue by
having the card. Sometimes, you know,
the best thing to do is just have the
answer.
>> Exactly. Just draw.
>> Just draw the card you need.
>> If if you have it, you have it, right?
>> Yeah. So that's
>> look how many cards you got on hand.
Card draw not a problem.
>> And now you're never going to top deck
into another progress day which you
don't have the time to play. So great.
Going to go into the Veiled Temple.
Veiled Temple. Also another interesting
battlefield when you conquer. I believe
you get to either unequip an equipment
or you get to ready a gear. So this also
helps Rexite with being so power hungry
as the community calls it because you
can seal of rage then go into the Veil
Temple and then seal of rage again.
>> I think that's also what we did earlier
by the way. That's why we went. Oh,
>> that's what I was going to say. That's
that's one of the reasons why I I love
when we see players of this caliber uh
at an event like this because
>> every time we think we have a good read
on a deck of like okay Rexite's kind of
hungry for recycling. Somebody's like,
"Yeah, but why why haven't you tested
this?" And I'm like, "Well, let me tell
you, there's not enough time in the day,
but if you've tested it and you want to
bring it to an event and you do really
well with it, I will be happy to steal
that tech and uh and and bring it in."
So, always love seeing new things or at
least, you know, things that people
perhaps haven't originally thought of uh
with the deck. And honestly, I'm a I'm a
big fan of all of the seals basically at
this point. I think every single seal is
going to find a way to become meta
relevant. Cards are so good. And you can
already see that the players are really
valuing either gold tokens or seals in
most of their decks because they say,
"Hey, you know, the cards that cost
power,
>> they are usually a little bit stronger."
>> Yes. So, not having to do that, not
having to pay for them. Rexite breacher
is going to come in. Ooh, quick hex
tech.
>> That should take care of it rather
quickly. Yep.
>> And this is one of the other areas where
this deck can slow down on the side of
Rex size. So, you got a couple of
mechanisms. I was going to say the
lecturing yle dies too because it has
assault plus one so it was already
declared as an attacker so it goes up to
four might
>> correct yes so yeah that that the way it
will play it uh what was I was going to
say the the accelerate that Rexai
breacher gives to other units can be
quite influential as you start getting
phoenixes to come back from the trash is
the other way of doing that I do find in
the games I've seen from Rexi and the
players I've spoken to I I did um an
interview actually with Alexander the
from Challenger TCG talking about like
how important is accelerating. It does
slow the game down a little bit if you
aren't able to get out through the mid
game and into the late game cuz look at
how low economy now we're going in this
match up. Watcher into removal with the
Bellow's breath is
>> not backbreaking but it it is difficult
for for Rexite to now reestablish a
board.
>> You know, I was just going to say to you
that for now you're losing the ability
to accelerate all of those cards, but
you are you have a developed field. You
have a developed board. You have so many
units. Boom gone.
>> Yeah, boom gone. And uh you have to get
the phoenixes out in order to get rid of
the phoenixes. I believe there was a Is
there a color week in hand? I I think I
know we know there's a saw a hidden
blade earlier. So if there is a call the
week, you're totally fine taking the
trade on the Phoenix.
>> That does not look like it
watcher, you do it.
>> I know. That's what I mean. It's like
that's a great trade. If you are happy
to take that, you take out a watcher
with it. But uh
>> no, not indeed. There is a brin here and
a piercing light. I do appreciate it
when the players put their hand
far enough on screen that that we we get
to see it. There we go. Both of them.
There was a lot of cards in the Duffin's
hand and a lot of them with damage
spells. I saw a singularity. They uh
>> I think I saw a piercing light as well
with all of the runes in the world that
uh the Duffin needs. Only looks like
three left in the rune deck.
>> The situation looks rather good for the
Duffin. I want to say you have so many
more cards in your hand. You just need
to The thing is Rexai can play without
many cards in hand, right? Because you
can look at the top cards of your deck.
>> You got to stop them from conquering the
open battlefield. And Kai'Sa is not
necessarily the greatest at that if
there is a developed board. It's tough
to stop your opponent from conquering if
they do not die to something like an X
ray.
>> I was going to say I think I saw a
falling star in hand for the Duffin. Oh,
it's a piercing light this time. Uh, I
was going to say that I there's a lot of
options now to clear the back line.
>> Oh, that screams singularity to me.
Something here screams singularity after
the piercing light cuz you you hit your
own watcher. You clear off the broker
>> and you're not particularly worried
about the watcher taking damage at this
point. There's not really anything, at
least from from my perspective, that
that can happen. We know it's a Brin
here in hand.
>> Exactly. So I think what you want to do
is you want to stop them from conquering
by just never letting them go there. Oh,
actually there is not enough runes after
paying this for a singularity.
>> So quite curious.
>> So that was with a repeat now.
So double double and the Nox hopefully
is going to take two. Is it then Falling
Star will be the finish on top? Yep,
there we go.
>> Just do the math. Make sure everything
is less than three and you'll be more
than okay with that trade.
>> Again, just keeping Rexside down. If you
can't conquer, you don't get the ability
to uh utilize the Rexai legend.
>> And that is also massive just like
having such a power turn clearing the
entire bot and then following up
>> the turn after you get the call the
week. It's always how it happens.
>> Yeah, this this is one of those cards
that is incredibly situational. But you
had a situation where it's immortal
Phoenix and just a watcher on the other
side of the battlefield and you're like
if I just had a call the week you you
get your whole board gets cleared and
the next card off the top is call the
week.
>> Yeah, it is really sad especially that
the lecturing yord was found as well
that almost found its way into the runes
because otherwise I think it would have
been worth to just call the week your
Brin here and the
>> trade.
Exactly. I think that would have
actually been the play even though it
does not sound like the best one. But
since the lecturing yodle is there, that
means that cull the week is borderline
useless and your opponent is going to
get more points. Falling star is going
to take care of your next unit. Rexi is
being completely starved out.
>> Yeah, that is uh a very painful
situation. That lecturing yodle is
really frustrating if you're bullet in
this game. Who is by the way leading the
series one and zero. I think it's
something we hadn't really touched on at
this point. The Rex side did take game
one.
>> So, this is post sideboard
>> as we can kind of lay the playing field
a little bit more for this match. Eight
and three likely playing for best
starts. Just playing the the small units
at this point. Watchful sentry, watchful
sentry.
>> A lot of people have gone away from
playing them uh just because the Draven
match up kind of is miserable. It's
interesting that we put one watchful
sentry into the veil temple and the
other one stays in base because I was
thinking about units that you could
accelerate and I'm immediately thinking
of Kai'Sa now. Kai'Sa would just get a
very positive trade against that unless
you have a stupifier of course. Now
piercing light onto the lecturing yord
and the watchful sentry. So we are
denying the hold. I think we at first
pointed at the good old thousand tailed
watch twice. Yeah, it was repeated. So,
fourth four to the watcher. So, that
tells you something else is coming.
>> Yeah, that is going to be first of all
your mortal phoenix that is coming back
and now call the weak also still not
great but
>> the falling star will
yeah okay there was a double tap on the
sentry there. I was like I don't think
that's what's happening. Uh but yeah,
the the three points will finish off the
watcher. So, the Phoenix is here now.
Watch has been dealt with. Is that a
Kaiser mirror? I bet everyone is just
removing units all the time.
Hey, turns out Falling Stars still
pretty good. Spirit Forge didn't change
that much in uh the spells available.
I'm hearing a lot of commotion from the
the player area. So, somebody is clearly
happy as we are heading towards our top
eight. Um this is really the the the
right down to it moments that we're
seeing
is where basically just one more round
to go after this.
>> Just clearing the units back with a
singularity. All of those two drops.
This is what the I want to say modern
build of Kai'Sa is all about. You clear
and then you play a little bit like
Victor actually. You have those one
drops. Those two drops that you're okay
barely any one drops but you have your
two drops and you're lecturing yawles.
Those cards that replace themselves that
give you a little bit of value but they
can also score some points because I
mean you need to win the game at some
point. You can't only clear stuff.
>> Yeah, clearing units doesn't win you the
game unfortunately. There has to be
followup. So you're trading away your
points with your opponent and then in
the end you're trying to win the game
most of the time with time warps or with
your thousand tailed watches. And I mean
just being able to use a singularity
clear your entire opponent's board and
then setting up a watchful sentry is so
valuable because you know if my opponent
removes that watchful sentry great I get
to draw a card. If they don't I I might
even be able to hold with this.
>> So where does Bulac go
from here?
>> We know he has a call of weak in hand.
We don't know how are we going to see a
call the week. Oh my goodness. Call the
week on watchful sentry. I cannot
believe what my eyes are seeing. It
seems to be the right play. But how is
this back?
>> How is K the week on a watchful sentry
the best play that you can make? That is
a desperate scenario for Bullet.
>> Yeah, definitely the uh desperation
coming through in that situation.
Sometimes it's like I I have to work
with the tools that I've got at this
point. My opponent has half their deck
in their hand.
I'll just give him another card. Hey,
when you got 10, what's 11?
>> I know the card is called Immortal
Phoenix, but you know it's going to die.
Singularity again taking off that card.
Rexai basically has infinite value in
its ability of the legend because every
time you conquer, you can look at two
cards, you can play with those. But if
you can't conquer, but is this a meat
grinder? Is this like I'll just burn
through every single unit Kai'Sa has?
Although I will say yeah. Okay. No,
there there is a scoop. I was going to
say we would be in here for the long
haul if we weren't going to game three.
So this matchup as you said potentially
really important for the best of Rex
site uh determining factors and of
course best of Kaiser
>> uh likely I I would imagine from the
number of Kaisers we had coming in today
too likely we're going to see it in top
eight but it is possible
>> that uh the Duffin is playing for that.
We've seen earlier there is more
progress days cited. I can I I dig that
kind of depending on the matchup you
want more value for some you want more
tempo also of course thermmo bean is a
card that can be used. What I liked to
see in some of the mind decks is
pickpocket in the side just because
against specific decks like those
miracle versions or like something like
Rexite that is really relying on the
seals of rage or okay I'll give it to
medic on
>> Yeah. Yeah. You can just get rid of
seals and that is so huge. I mean you
have seen how many power costs the Rex
has played in the last game.
>> Yeah. Significant significant number. um
sideboard for Bullet. Mostly, you know,
there was a couple units in there, an
Imperial decree as well, some salvages.
The scout is soaring,
flying. There's of course also the
Underten. That is a card that I have
liked in Victor so far. If you're
playing Victor Leader, the orderheavy
deck
>> under Titan really helps your unit based
strategies to go crazy. And if you
reveal it, you actually get two energy
for completely free
>> which is very helpful in uh in that
situation. Also that nice big, as you
said, the finish that we've seen in
Victor getting the extra. Um, I wonder
where. So, we only saw game two. So, I
know Bullet's
battlefields include Arena's greatest
>> and that is where we're going, which ga
arena's greatest is not always the
optimal situation cuz of course Kaiser
can just conquer very quickly
>> and get up to
>> eight. um Reaver's Row
both kind of like unit heavyish decks in
that regard. This version of Kaiser is
playing a lot of low cost and that's a
no two drop turn from Bulat.
>> It's actually interesting to see a
Kaiser player on Rever row. I didn't
really pay attention to that when we saw
the entire deck list because Rever's row
it has been seeing a lot of play in
Origins of course. However,
as Draven is such a pivotal part of the
meta, just giving so many Dravens their
best
>> That's true.
>> Battlefield possible is it's brave.
>> That is brave. That is uh a really good
consideration around Battlefield choice
with deck building. Falling Star comes
through, takes out both units. And this
is where Kaiser plus Arena's greatest.
You're like, "Okay, I'm going to take
that. I'm going to keep this tempo up. I
will go up to two. I'll play another
unit. I'm going to imagine on the back
end
>> cuz then you're going to go into four on
your next turn if Bulak can't remove the
sentry. No, we'll say go. Okay.
>> I like how the Duffin has a very clear
game plan here. He is just getting rid
of those units. The void burrow ability
from the legend Rexai. It cannot do
anything if you can't conquer. So, if
you don't have any units, you will also
not be able to conquer. However, Rexai
breacher can be accelerated. So if you
have four energy to spare and one power,
then you can just bring that in and
start to conquer. However, then you have
very little energy left over.
>> Okay, there's a sundisk. So we'll allow
the accelerated phoenixes when they come
in. And I think that's what we're about
potentially to see.
>> That definitely got to help.
>> Yeah, Phoenix does have assault. So it's
going to get get stronger when it is
attacking. So goes towards Reaver's Row.
Of course, we'll have the option for the
defender trigger here for the watchful
sentry.
>> I mean, this is usually a unit you would
easily get rid of with the hex tech ray.
I believe that is something that the
Duffin can do on his next turn if he
wants to.
>> It looks like he has two. So, he's
contemplating whether he wants to use
two. But actually, there's only one fury
room, so you cannot use both of those.
And I think it's a little bit more card
efficient if you just wait for your
turn, take the assault boost from the
immortal Phoenix, and then just boom,
take one away.
>> Yeah. Yeah, that is very fair. Of
course, that assault only
>> really only active when the Phoenix is
an attacker in a showdown, like a combat
showdown. So, yeah, there you go. I'll
just do it on my turn. It's fine.
>> Kaiser, daughter of void, is such a
powerful legend. It's incredible. you
keep ramping with your good card.
>> It's so ingrained that after playing
Kaiser for a while, I forgot I needed to
recycle runes when I was playing other
decks. I was like, "What do you mean
these spells aren't free?
>> What do you mean this stops me from
winning the game?"
>> Yeah. So, could could very well have
played both, but I think that the
decision there not to damp. Um, and to
just say, "Yeah, okay. I'll I'll I'll
I'll just deal with it. You take the
point, have your one activation if you
want it to. Uh, I'll I'll end up getting
things back." Question is, are we going
to play Kai'Sa now from our champion
zone accelerated into
>> four? Yeah. Yeah. Tidy for the Duffin.
And this is the pace of Kaiser and and
Arena's greatest does give kind of like
that little hop ahead
>> for Kaiser.
>> There is a world especially with the
immortal Phoenix and the trash that we
see a huge Rexai turn. If you can get a
unit readied on to the board in hand as
well,
>> you you have the sundisk, then you clear
off the watchful sentry and then you
call the weak, then you get back your
immortal Phoenix. The question is, do we
have enough runes for that?
>> Yeah, we'll have to have to count it.
There's also uh falling star as an
option if you want it. There's a void
rush if you're having a dig.
>> Yeah, I think I think void rush is a
nice choice. So every card you could
play from this costs too less and I
think the broker is a really really
Wait, you would have had to exhaust the
Sundisk before, right?
>> Yeah, if you want to play it
accelerated.
>> Oh, can you can you
>> which is going to be the next unit I
suppose will will come in accelerated.
>> Okay. Oh, we're falling starring. Okay,
so that line that uh I put myself there
uh did not work out, but of course that
is again because these players are
sitting there.
>> Okay, so the Phoenix comes in
accelerated from the sundisk. That is
where that was going.
>> That still absolutely works. But you're
double DM. Look at this. There's only
two auto runes.
>> And this is the situation that we were
saying, the high cost, but then when you
have the accelerated phoenix is the high
payoff in okay, I can actually contest
battlefields. I can make sure that I
have presence and and what looked like a
very strong position for the Duffin. Now
there's a rebuilding moment where you're
without units, you don't have your
chosen champion, and suddenly you're
like, "Okay, I have a lot of damage
spells, but I've got to stop my opponent
from climbing up and up and up in the
points.
>> You know what? I think the position is
actually still really good for the Duff.
There's so much removal in that. Oh no,
is that going to be a piercing light?"
That is so nasty with the stuper fight
taking out two units with the one
piercing light. The only unit has
>> there's a yortle to reestablish some
presence on the board. So it's uh we'll
have to see what comes off the top for
the Duffin off that draw plus the next
turn. If there's an accelerate unit or
at least a unit that can be present on
the battlefield, we can still keep the
pace going up to six on the next turn.
That's a uh slow Phoenix or at least non
accelerated Phoenix coming on. That's
two cola weeks in hand as well. So
setting up potentially for the return of
the Phoenix next turn.
>> Uh plus the accelerate the big turn that
the Rexai player had completely
recycling almost all of these runes
really hurt the tempo of the deck and
the recursion as well because now you
cannot go for a cult weak play and get
back your immortal Phoenix. You will
have to just stabilize your first
immortal Phoenix and then use that card
with the call the weak then you will get
a huge one off. If you call the weak
next turn with your immortal Phoenix,
you get both Phoenix back, right?
>> I think progress day in hand. Oh no,
maybe not. This looks uh
>> if the Duffin is a Ferris runner. Yeah.
Develops. If the Duffin was to just
remove the immortal Phoenix, that would
have been really really huge there. Not
being able to drop the cult of weak
anymore. Another plundering poro in
base. So this time around we are not
going for any kind of spell shenanigans.
We're like hey I have a huge chunky
unit. Just try to beat that. Fisa is
truly a rogue deck slayer
cuz even if you
at this point call the week's not
getting many good targets.
>> No.
>> This sounds really weird but even Ferris
4runner is going to leave behind two
three might mess. So
>> the efficiency of the the trade makes it
really tough. feel like, well, yeah, I
get rid of one unit, but now I'm left
with two that I got to deal with.
>> I think Oh, we're going into the big
battlefield. And I think that trade is
just going to be taken. It's nine. If
you can somehow
manipulate the might of your opponent or
yours, the Ferris Forerunner actually
might stick onto that battlefield
because the Electric Yodel has the tank
ability. So, nine damage so far coming
through onto this battlefield. There is
Electric Yod. There is far forward now.
Do you have anything to stop some
damage? You're only on one rune left.
That could only be a super fight, which
would mean an absolute quadrakill.
>> Yeah, looks like the players are just
determining where we're at. Of course,
it's going to be attacker triggers go on
the stack, defender triggers go on the
stack, and we're going to see where
Duffin reacts to because there is a
Reaver's Row trigger, I believe, before
the Phoenix does get the assault from
attacker triggers. That was what they
were clarifying. Okay, we're just going
to trade. Okay, that's that's where
we're at.
>> It's a quadra and I think that is still
fine for the duff. But if that was I
don't even think
>> minded fury has anything for that
situation on one room. But if it was an
on guard, actually on guard only gives
plus one when you're not alone.
>> If you could manipulate the tank ability
from the lecturing yodel would have been
pivotal. But I think if your opponent
pushes all of their units into one
battlefield and you get to get an even
trade with two mech tokens out, you can
double conquer in the next turn plus a
plundering toro gold token. You're
golden.
>> Yeah, you you are at that point. I may
actually have been wrong about that
assault. I'm That's chat. I'm going to
look it up after this. Okay, I will
educate myself just to make sure I have
that that sequencing correct, but cuz
we're going to focus on this round.
Focus in on this game as the Duffin goes
up to seven points. And we know what a
Kaiser can do from this moment where
you're looking to win. It's a piercing
light keeps the battlefield trimmed.
>> You just play around Kig and the
immortal Phoenix as you know. unit after
unit after unit.
>> It's just also mainly about removing all
of those units. Look at those plundering
porros. They are not going to probably
conquer anything next turn unless there
are some accelerated units that trade
away the plundering porro from the
revers. Can you imagine a triple conquer
with plundering porros?
>> I don't know what you can do. It's going
to have to be up to the top of the deck
with void gate for bullet. Reveals the
parro reveals the hidden blade. Looks at
the hand. What are you going to do with
just merely a single porro? You have the
hidden blade, but what's it going to do?
You're not going to want to use the
hidden blade on your opponent's units,
and you don't have any units on your own
side. So, that is super tough. The
Duffin will take the win and advance
>> to 9 and three in the second day of
Swiss. Very tense.
>> Great performance. a crushed cup there.
We love to see it. It's been cooking
some tea with Kaised.
>> Yeah, just piping hot with all that
removal in that matchup. And uh we are
getting really close to the end of the
Swiss rounds today. Nearly at that point
where we're looking at top eight in the
bracket. I cannot wait to see exactly
who is coming out of our final round. Uh
maybe undefeated in the case of Allen.
believe he's the only undefeated player
as of the the the finish of this round,
but a lot of other players still in
contention for that top eight, still in
contention for best of cards. And we'll
keep you up to date with exactly where
everybody is as we go through the day.
So, some some fun stuff. Uh but after
two series like that, I need a couple of
minutes and I'm sure you do, too. So,
stick with us. We'll be back with the
last round of Swiss in just a few
minutes.
Heat. Heat.
Welcome back to regional qualifier here
in Bologna. A very fast car to swap. I
think we're going to challenge Ferrari
for their pit stop speed at the moment.
Unfortunately, we do not have dynamic
aerodynamics, so we aren't able to, you
know, flip over our aerodynamics. I
can't remember what the name of the
thing, but spoilers, that's the one.
Have you seen the new Have you seen the
new uh Formula 1 regulations? Do you
care about Formula 1?
>> I haven't seen the new regulations.
>> Ferrari have done this really cool thing
where the back of the car, they can 180°
the top spoiler. I can't remember what
it's called. Sounds really good.
>> And it gives them a bunch of extra
speed. Anyway,
>> I was thinking more of a pit rookie
myself, but
>> yes. Yes, that Oh, this is why you're
here for the relations. We're going to
guess some flavor text before we get on
into the final round of Swiss. So, let's
have a look. Oh, yeah. You've been
reading them out, so I am ready for you.
They call it the noshion. Hello.
>> Oh, they call it the noshion. Hello.
>> See, I think Cleave.
I think Cleave
because Noxious, Draven, Darius, it
could be spinning axes, but I feel like
Cleave.
>> I feel like Cleave is more generic, so I
feel like that is
>> Yeah, I feel like that's that's more
telling. I feel like I feel like we just
go with I think we're happy.
>> Lock it in. Cleave.
>> Battering round. Similar idea.
>> Similar idea.
>> We were in the right ballpark
>> that we were.
>> Just not on the money
>> that we were. Okay. Next up. Next up.
Here we go. Here we go. Here we go.
>> See if you guys at home could get it
quicker than us.
>> I mean, they can cuz we didn't get it.
So, even if they took Millennium, they
would have managed to get it quicker
than us.
>> What are we going for the next? It's a
hidden one. Um,
>> oh, a hidden card, right? Okay. Uh, we
switcheroo. Uh, no. Uh, I like to think
of her as a pre-boarding party.
>> H. Okay. So, it could be in reference to
Misfortune's weapons or a unit.
Misfortune has. So, like I'm thinking
bullet time.
>> I was thinking weapons.
>> Yeah, because it's like, "Oh, here's my
pre-boarding part time." Bullet time.
>> Um, but maybe we're getting distracted
by the misfortune. Maybe there's
something else that goes in before
pre-boarding. What do you need to do?
Well, women and children go on first and
then after that, people in business
class, first class always get to go on
whenever they want. Um, check your seat
number. I I I'm a bullet time Andy. I
think I think I think it's got to be
I've got to say I'm not well versed in
the misfortune kind of deck
>> core. Yeah.
>> So I think bullet time is the most I
know from that other than the core units
themselves and she's not going to say
that about herself is
>> exactly right. I mean it could be
Misfortune talking about Misfortune in
the third person.
>> No. That's her jam. I'm going to be
real.
>> Okay. Well, we'll go flavor text for
>> bullet time.
>> Bullet time.
>> Sneaky deck. No, you're
>> How did we not get it?
>> It's She's a deck hand and she's sneaky.
She sneaks on boarding.
>> Pre-boarding. Sneaky.
>> It was the misfortune. It did. It threw
us off. Threw us off. We thought it was
a misfortune card. We were wrong.
>> I will say
I didn't study any of the flavor text
getting ready to cast this. So, I I feel
I feel foolish cuz I should have done
it. These are the important segments,
you know.
>> Are they?
>> Yes.
>> So, we should have been studying the
flavor text instead, not our matchups at
all.
>> 100%. Nothing's free. All I ask for is
your loyalty.
>> I have a big vibe on this one.
>> A big vibe.
>> Do you?
>> But I would like you to go first cuz I
feel like I've gone first time so far.
>> I don't know why I feel like this is
sort of maybe a hard bargain angle or
something like that.
>> I get hard bargain. I think this is a
chem baroness. I think this is a Renata
card. Hostile takeover because nothing
is free. I have taken you over and you
take the loyalty. I like that. That is
where I'm going with the Yeah, that's
where I'm feeling this one.
>> Yeah, I feel like maybe maybe you've got
that on the money there.
>> Okay, here we go. Hostile take over. Our
final answer.
>> Have we watched Arcane?
>> Oh, it's just Ronald Glass.
>> It's just then, you know, then I feel
good. You know, it could be hostile
takeover. It could have been glass.
>> You know,
>> yeah. Oh, there's a fourth.
>> Oh,
>> there's a fourth. We're going for one
last one before we get into the final
round of this. What are we getting? What
are we getting? Come on.
>> I'm faster than I look. Older two, if
you can believe it.
Wized Elder.
>> It's an Origins card, I believe.
>> Uh, I mean, that's just because it has
old in the name. Faster than I look
older, too, if you can believe it. Who
else looks old? Himerdinger looks very
old.
>> I don't I feel like people look old.
That's the thing. They are old, but they
don't look it is the implication, right?
>> Wait, wait, wait. It's older than I
look. If you can believe it, which kind
of implies you
>> faster than I look or if you believe it.
>> So, they're saying like
>> older than I look. So, it's faster than
I look. I'm also older than I look if
you can't believe it.
>> Yeah. So, like a case of like I don't
look old.
>> Okay. I I would read it the other way.
But so far, I've got all of them wrong.
>> So, do you want to play the guess here
for the casters?
>> No, cuz I have no idea what this could
be. I'm just trying to think of like a
character that maybe could be
misconstrued because of their age or
status.
>> Ah, I mean, Himedinger does like to talk
about how old he is, but I don't get the
fast. He's definitely not fast. He's not
fast at all.
>> Come on.
>> Yeah. Wizendelda is just an old card. I
feel like this is like we're looking at
a blue, a purple, you know, we're going
into those sorts of, you know, that sort
of space.
>> Maybe Victor or something like that.
>> Yeah, Victor's quite young though. I
mean, that does vibe with your thing.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. I don't know.
>> Okay.
Take something out of the hat. Grab it
out there. Pull it out. See what you
think.
>> I genuinely don't know. I think I give
up on this one.
>> I'll go Himer just to just to have a
have a guess for us here at the desk.
>> Bite myself. Simeon ancestor. Okay, so
it older than I look. Yeah. Okay. Simeon
ancestor. I guess the buff ready makes
sense as well for the I'm faster than I
look cuz you get, you know, buffed and
then ready and then straight in. That
makes sense.
>> That makes a lot of sense.
>> I feel like we were dealt hard hands
there.
>> I was definitely flumxed by pretty much
all of those. Actually, I did a much
better job yesterday.
>> Did we?
>> Yeah, I feel like we did.
>> Did we get one right last time?
>> Yeah, we got Lux.
>> Oh, we got trusty Ramound, didn't we?
>> Ramound. Yeah, we got Lux and Ramound.
Yes, yes, yes.
>> So, yeah, we did quite well yesterday,
actually. So, um, but speaking of things
that hopefully we'll get right this
time, our game is ready to go. We are
going to jump back into the action for
our final Swiss round.
>> Here we go. We'll have a look at what we
have for the final rounds of Swiss.
These players playing on the cusp of
making it into our top 64 and top eight
contention, I believe, on our feature
stage. We're going to start off with
Novagis who is playing Civ Battle
Mistress. One of my favorites to win the
whole thing. Nothing too out of the
ordinary here. Three Noctturns in the
main alongside the edges of Knight. One
one Edge of Knight, one Switcheroo.
>> I must correct myself. I thought it was
the other match that we were showing.
These are this is a top 64 contention
match
>> indeed. And this is one of the uh one of
the top civers of the day right now.
kind of on par with another. So, we've
got two CV still in contention for that
best of as well, but top 64 is still
incredibly desirable at this stage,
getting you that invitational to the
regionals.
>> Yes. Uh Koopa Kulp is playing for that
top 64. Um can't get best of because
Allan ZQ is playing Ezreal and has gone
I think 11 and0 maybe 12. well playing
around right now to look for that 12
and0 uh in the main here for our Ezreal.
Only two arcane shifts. We do often see
one being left behind. It's the pack of
wonders treasure trove mindsplitter
combination though that we did see at
runes and rift and they're invitational.
So I really like this combo. You can
bounce the mind spplitter back with the
pack of wonders then play it again.
Chowo chow to your hand I believe is
what they say in Italy when the mind
spplitter comes down. No, no maart to
align with it, but it really does give
you a lot of control as the game goes
on. Kind of this uh this base lock setup
that you can have. Takes you a while to
get there though, so you want to be able
to control the early board. Plan a
couple of moves ahead, plan a couple of
turns ahead at least to make sure that
the civ doesn't overwhelm, which it
doesn't tend to do anyway.
>> Okay, here we go. Starting off the turn.
Novag is going first with Civer. Let's
see if they can play any units nice and
early. Looks like we're going in strong
with that. A nice two drop or maybe just
a seal. No. Yeah, we do have the
traveling merchant. Always a fortuitous
start.
>> Yeah, always nice to be able to get that
discard draw early on. You've also got
the zone wars to help with that pack of
wonders going to come down from Kuba
Culp. If you don't know what this does,
you can tap it to bounce a gear or a
unit back to your or a hidden card,
sorry, to your owner's hand. Often we
see it in combination with the treasure
trove, which works really well because
you're getting those extra card draws.
Can also be used to bounce the mind
spplitter, then replay the mind
spplitter to remove plenty of cards from
your opponent's hands.
>> Oo, okie dokie. Looks like we're going
for the warren kind of avoiding sigil of
the storm at the moment as it can be
disadvantageous. One of those
battlefields I was talking about earlier
where it might not affect you as much as
your opponent and so it's kind of nice
to put that threat on the board. Is this
not a very nice place to go? Yeah, not
at all. You don't really want to be in
there recycling your runes. Gust back to
get the traveling merchant out of the
board. Pack of uh sorry, not pack of
wonder discord going to come down. The
civ there able to generate a gold when
we do recycle that rune and those gold
so valuable to Civiver later on in the
game. Especially Civ Mercenary where if
you are spending that two power, you get
a bunch of bonuses out of her.
>> Absolutely. And that's the nice thing
about it. At least we're gaining
something for having to recycle runes,
which is great. And again, fortuitous
for yourself, but not for your opponent.
So, a very nice start there,
>> but not a lot going on in this hand
right now. We can stack deck and
hopefully that will provide more options
for for Kip here, but
>> rebuke. Okay,
>> another thousand tail watcher and I was
it superfy as the final card? I think
so, but I can't. But yeah, I it's it
wasn't
>> it was it was super at the back of the
hand there.
The thing is here, you do always always
have the Ezreal to play. Put the seal
down. You can play the Ezreal for that
discard and then get that next couple of
draws. You have the pack of wonders as
well to bounce the Ezreal if you so
desire. Will of course cost you the
power coming back down, but getting
those extra couple of draws is really
powerful here. Looks like we're going to
discard the mind splitter. See, we have
more in the deck to go and search for.
>> Nothing at the moment. Just taking it
slow. Ezreal's at least in base. So,
we've got a little bit of kind of a
starting
starting go there. Just managing to get
off and just kick things off really, but
both going quite slow for where their
decks kind of usually sit in these first
two turns.
>> Both these decks can play from a a
relatively slow position if they want.
They they kind of want to control the
board in the early game if they can and
then look to create these sort of
unassalable board states later on. With
the civer mercenary out, we are going to
see uh no veggies, which I I think I
called novag geese first time and now I
realize it's just no veggies, which is I
think a mantra that a lot of us have
when we come to events like this. I've
been eating predominantly arenchino.
>> Yeah.
>> Or arenchini, I guess, because I've
eaten more than one of them across the
course of the event. Ezreal down for no
veggies, who is now going to use that
gold,
>> get the discard and the draw out of
this. It's looking like it might be I
was wondering if it be the Ezreal going
out of the hand, but instead going to be
that fight orflight discarded to draw.
Uh I think that's it. Challenge.
>> Both decks really want to control their
opponent's hands to a degree as well.
You can see the sabotage sitting there
for no veggies. Challenge discarded.
>> Recycle and
Okay. Yep. Yep.
>> You have the uh the Zorn Warren trigger
from the Conquer as well, right? So,
>> and that deals with the Ezreal nicely.
So, again, you're kind of just putting
Kuba Club.
>> Oh, the challenge wasn't Sky, it was
played. Just went straight into the
trash. Yeah, sorry. I'm totally I I lost
my track train of thought there.
>> It's been played. And of course that
takes out the Ezreal and then that
threat is kind of off the board and Kuba
Club can now kind of
>> really
not many units going on in hand. It's
kind of why we had to go for the Ezreal
earlier. So really we're going to be
looking at just trying to draw some
cards. So we're going for the stupify on
the civer just to draw a card and hope
that we can get some momentum going.
>> Yeah, this is now you're going to be
looking at the treasure trove into
bounce wages of pain after the stupify
to kill off the civer. Then you can play
the treasure trove. Get that card draw.
Use the Ezreal for another card draw cuz
you target it and you've chosen two
units with spells.
>> Seal makes it free.
>> Sealing to seal makes it free. Treasure
trove down. Pack of wonders bounces the
treasure trove back.
>> My goodness.
>> Get the rune. Get the card draw and then
go to Nove's turn. Only has that Ezreal
up as you can see. Relatively slow in
terms of point scoring early game for
both of these decks. But unfortunately
with no units left, Koover Club is going
to have to really ramp things up late
game to be able to bring anything to the
table cuz Nove,
grab those points and just really push
forward. We're going with the sabotage.
Noticing that Koopa Club is really
struggling to kind of get into this game
at all. using the sabotage at that point
to say, "Right, okay, it's clear that
you're really struggling for units, so I
know that I'm going to be able to take
something. Pop it at the bottom of your
deck here, and I don't want you to have
>> Yeah, get rid of the cord shot. Take
your time, write down all of the cards,
make sure you know exactly what's there.
I think between the cord shot and the
treasure trove, those were your two
options. Cold shot a little bit cheaper,
of course. And having the double seal
means you can pay for both the repeat
costs without actually having to recycle
any of your power. So, you get rid of
that treasure trove likely to come back
on the next turn for Kuba Culp as you're
going in to Zorn Warren. I'll have the
discard draw trigger alongside the
point. It's a cold shot drawn seal for
that. And this is four cards that we're
going to be looking at. Two a time and
drawing one of these. Cold shot into
hand.
>> Love a cold shot into a cold shot.
>> More card draw. Yes, please.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. Oh, no turn.
>> When we see the knock turn, we can play
it just for spending one instead when we
see it from an effect that isn't just it
being in your hand. So, this was a
perfect noturn play.
>> Yeah. But when you're looking at the top
cards of your deck, if you do see it,
you can play it for that power,
>> which is exactly what happens. Knockdown
comes out. Isn't going to bolster up the
defenses with that Ezreal of the
battlefield. That one is just going to
sit there by itself. You want to get
that extra power for later on. Another
Ezreal coming down into the discard
draw. It's a challenge being discarded.
Double draw. But look at how big the
hand for Nove is now.
>> Last rights, we've got a punch. We've
got a lot of combat tricks going on now.
So, not only does Kuba need to really
get some units on the board, but they're
also going to struggle potentially into
actually then taking over these
battlefields and strongholding them,
which is what Ezreal likes to do is kind
of make that like board lock position.
Oh my gosh, we've got more.
Triple seal, but the wax out and like
one of those signets, the ring to really
stamp it down. Pack of wonders,
>> treasure trove.
>> Uh, yeah, it's going to bounce that
treasure trove back. We want to draw the
card
>> and channel that rune.
>> Hopefully, we've got something off of
that, but it doesn't.
>> I think it's a Bellow's breath and a
Well, the treasure trove is already in
hand. Yeah,
>> we've got the Gust. Acceptable losses as
well. Not really going to do too much
for us in this game state.
>> Again, we're just struggling for a unit.
We need guys on the board. We need to be
able to score points. We can't score
points without units.
>> Treasure trove back down. We have two
for another pack that can immediately
bounce our treasure trove back up. There
we are. Another draw. another channel
with the draw card. It's got to be Oh,
>> watch. Okay, so the good thing for
Kubakul on the right side of the screen
here is they're not too far behind in
terms of Nove is a two, right? In terms
of board state, obviously double Ezreal
Noctturn really strong position for Nove
continue to scale up through the game
and Exact losses coming out.
>> It's going to kill off the gold a piece.
Uh, Koop actually trying to deny as many
mind runes as possible from Novely
sitting on none. Likely going to channel
one. I can't remember the exact rune
split. I'll be honest. If it's six and
six, the the high likelihood is that uh
sorry, not mind runes. Uh the Yeah,
chaos runes. Oh, no, no, they have the
chaos runes. It's the body runes I was
talking about. So, yeah, I was Yeah. Uh
yeah, with the gold would have had two
here. Still only has one, which means
punch first actually not an option right
now. But do we need it? Right now, we're
in a really solid position. So, I think
at the moment, you kind of don't mind
not having the access to the punch
first. We'll go for another seal of
discord there just to keep everything in
check. Make sure that we have enough for
the late game as well. Going for a cold
shot. I think that's again really
advantageous at this point. We've got
that happened a minute ago. Is this a
repeat? That was like the same cold shot
from
>> earlier. This is the repeat actually as
we see the Rasa in the stack deck on the
top. Rasa going to the bottom there.
Something you really want to do when
you're playing these civer decks is have
a either a very good memory or enough
intuition to remember what you put at
the bottom of your deck. Some people
ride it out. You can do an unttimed.
Obviously, when you're not untimed
becomes a lot harder to do so going into
the sigil of the storm, we will see the
recycle coming out. C will generate us a
gold off that recycled rune and another
point for no veggies. Halfway to that
eight point mark.
>> Rocketing into a very commanding
position. Another stack deck. just not
letting not letting up. You know, you
got to keep the heat on. I like the
switcheroo at this point. Being able to
even implement that now as a hidden card
would be great. So, honestly, we're in a
really strong position here.
>> Kuba Club does have a lot of runes on
board, which would be fantastic, but I
don't know if it's going to be too
little too late. We're going for the
last rights again. A really great
recursion card for us as well as giving
some might to our units. We absolutely
love it. No need to equip it yet though.
>> That can come in time. holding two up
for the uh fight or flight if you want
to use it in this sort of position can
also look towards that switcheroo and
switcheroo great into things like
thousand tail watcher it gives you so
much power in terms of well so much
might in terms of switching it around
with the thousand tail watcher coming in
>> but here we go we're probably going to
see that thousand tail watcher
>> kick off aiming for both those oh no
turn now they have to be at the same
repeated.
>> So repeated I guess one damage to each
and then thousand tail watcher to reduce
all of those down below the threshold.
>> See if we can do a bit of a a board wipe
really see if that's going to go down.
If we can get the thousand tail watcher
to just then take those Ezreal out of
the base and the noturn from the
battlefield.
Cooper,
just one thousand tail watcher might not
be enough.
>> Yeah, two treasure troves in hand though
does mean they have quite a lot of draw
fresh. They're going to go with the
stack deck first.
>> Have a look at the top double fizz.
Yeah, well the cord shot is what we are
going to choose for now. Those fizzes
will go down towards the bottom. cuz
>> I wouldn't mind a fizz. I would not mind
the f Oh,
>> what are we doing? What are we doing?
>> He's keeping on us on our toes.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I think Kuba Corp there when you are
deciding on the card you want to take,
it is better to lay it to the side of
your hand just to make sure it's very
obviously separate. No veggies was like,
"Hey, is that okay?" It's like, "Yes, we
know it was the one that he put on the
top." So, just for uh ease of uh your
opponent's knowledge sake, just put it
to the side. Make sure you know exactly
where it is. Uh Tre Trove is going to
come out. I believe there's a second
pack of wonders that has not been used
to activate it. But, uh doesn't really
matter for the moment because you are
going to channel two runes anyway on the
next turn. So, having an extra rune
channeled here would actually mean that
you are wasting one of those channels at
the start of your next turn.
>> Ever so true. Noturn was the draw.
Confront is going to allow us to have
our units enter ready and give us that
draw for no veggies. Picks up a stack
deck. Currently pretty low on those
units. Need something to equip the last
rights onto.
>> Oh, speaking of units, that's two. And
we did see the Nox. We can play that
just for one cost instead, which is very
lovely. So that has definitely helped us
out a little bit in replenishing the
board after Koopa Club managed to
absolutely tremendously use that
thousand tail watcher with Bellow's
breath combination. So this time we're
going to be able to get those units back
on the board a little bit faster
hopefully going for the second called
shot I believe there before we do any
other actions.
>> Yeah, using the repeat. We're going to
put sabotage into hand. I think there
was a small question about uh
technically the the card drawn from the
first part of the cord shot was put into
hand before the noctturn was revealed
and you you should reveal it before you
draw but the judge they're like it's
okay we know exactly what was going on
it is fine overall sabotage going to
come out second one of the game here
>> gust singularity treasure trove and a
fizz can't hit the fizz will take the
singularity no surprises at all puts it
onto the bottom of the deck with that
recycle it's a difference between minds
spplitter and uh uh sabotage firstly
sabotage can't hit a non uh can only hit
non-units and then also sabotage
recycles rather than discarding the
card.
>> And again, just gaining that hand
knowledge, right? Knowing what can come
your way allows you to more effectively
choose which resources you're going to
expel and when. and knowing that kind of
we do have another unit now, which is
why we kind of went for that Fizz
because it was really getting really
tricky to keep a board state alive here
cuz Noveis was really doing quite well
at managing their own uh units in the
beginning. Of course, we're going for
the attach there of the last rights. And
now just having a look at what's going
to go back to the bottom of the deck.
>> Putting the noturn and the stack deck
back on the bottom. expect this when it
conquers to get an Ezreal back for us. I
don't think I saw a Rasa in the
graveyard, although in the in the trash.
There's definitely one in hand.
>> Have the discard draw from the Zorn
Warren. Now, we'll have a look.
>> Uh, Traveling Merchant.
>> Lovely. Okay, so just opting for more
card draw, more movement.
>> It's interesting to me because like
traveling merchant obviously does give
you that card draw movement and I guess
you want to keep the two up for the
switcheroo or the fight or flight. So,
Ezreal would have pushed you over that
boundary to only having one rune
available on your opponent's turn. And
uh
>> but I guess we kind of like the discard
draw as well because it gets us closer
to the Raza.
>> That's true. That's true. We're going to
discard that switcheroo. So, we really
are playing around the fight or flight
spending the power. And uh now we will
move on to Kuba Kulp's turn. Still only
the thousand tail watcher available to
them. We've got a fizz in hand as we saw
taken earlier and that will allow us to
sign of kind of recycle a spell as well.
>> We got a gust, a fizz, a bellow's
breath, and a
uh a treasure trove.
>> Treasure trove. So, we do have a bit of
card draw as well.
>> Yeah, the thing with the treasure trove
is we don't really want to bounce it
without being able to channel that room.
We are just doing this for the card draw
to make sure we have as much information
as possible at the start of the turn.
Can move into the traveling merchant,
but we're going to get Fa back. We know
that.
can expect that. Let's be honest
>> with the discard of a switcheroo only a
one of in Nove's main. So
>> Nove has used a lot of cards that show
him cards. So he's been able to use a
lot that actually allows him to
cherrypick exactly what he wants off the
top of the deck. Keep that in hand for
later. And I think you know that's
what's going to be seen here. Obviously
giving them a count as well so they know
how fearful they need to be of a Raza.
>> Yeah, also do have to be fearful of a
punch first. The fist bump comes out.
Kuba Corp realizing I cannot stop the
advance from six to eight and because of
that we will see Nove taking game one of
this round.
>> Nove just keeping that board state
seamless and coming back from every push
back and then a little bit of hand
control on top of that. The threat of
the Raza was just too much and knowing
that it's probably unlikely to come back
from that. It's sideboarding time into
the second game. Yeah, I don't think
there's a huge I mean maybe there's a
couple of changes you want to make.
Don't think cannon barrage does too
much. Hard bargain I could see you
wanting to bring in when you're playing
around on these uh the counter wars.
Invert time lines kind of gives your
opponent as much benefit as it gives
you. But if your opponent has carefully
crafted their hand, then there is the
argument. It's like, okay, I know my
hand is bad and I kind of know your hand
is likely good at this position to chuck
in and invert timelines there. But no,
Veggie's deck. It did what it expects to
do. Gets those knocks out. Didn't even
need to use the Rasers. No,
>> was able to uh put themselves in a
really good position there in game one.
>> Yeah, they kept it all really sleek. I
mean, hitting those knocks was
absolutely beautiful. That's what we
want to see. We want to see them off the
top of the deck when you're using a card
effect rather than drawing them so that
you can play them really cheap. Okay,
we've got some interesting decisions
here to make. I like the Dr. Mundo. We
haven't seen one of those all day. Um,
uh, you know, a big chunky unit can be
helpful when you're struggling. I think
that was our biggest problem. It was
just not having enough units. We had
spells galore. We were doing well for
kind of just keeping our opponent's
board state under control for a while,
but then we just weren't able to create
that lock that Ezreal really loves to do
where you kind of just push your
opponent out from being able to do much.
And unfortunately with the lack of
singularity, because of the um sabotage,
we just weren't able to keep that push
back going.
>> Yeah, I wouldn't mind seeing uh perhaps
the uh not the pickpocket. Yeah, no, the
pickpocket out in in this Ezreal lineup.
It getting rid of the gold for Nove
helps slow them down quite a lot. They
do generate it quite a bit, but the
ability to remove a an effective power
from the civer and get yourself an
effective power with that pick pocket
can be pretty strong. We'll see if Kuba
Culp decides to go down that route for
the moment. We will get into game two.
Huge game for both these players both.
>> Okay, we've got Obelisk of Power and
Valor's lair this time.
>> And is Koopa Pool go first. So, three
runes for them. Can just play the Ezreal
out if they so desire. Has a I want to
say a wage is a pain in hand is there as
well, but it does look like it is just
going to be Ezreal. Play with the known
information. Put out the one you have.
Discard the wages of pain, draw two, and
then pass over to Noveis
power. Okay, I will take my extra rune
as well.
>> I will have that please. That'll be
quite lovely at the start of the game.
And they've got a lot of cards that, you
know, will be able to be employed with
this. That's a really big advantage for
Nove. We're getting the seal down, which
is great. We get to create a gold token
early. We get Yep. again going with the
known information on the board by just
playing that civer out. really similar
turns, but actually, you know, veggies
has a lot more resources going on now
than before. And that's just a really
nice kick off the mark for them to try
and overwhelm the board state like they
did last game.
>> Also, four might into three is always a
nice number to look at as the Civiver
into the Ezreal. There is a stupify in
hand. Singularity off the top not going
to be drawn. instead the seal trying to
make sure that they have good rune
economy through this early game for Kuba
Corp does mean there's a singularity all
the way at that bottom of the main
>> thing that made me sad a little bit
because it would have been useful last
game but I suppose knowing that sabotage
can happen as well going for the seal
and just making sure that you're
creating consistency for yourself is
also important
>> yeah cot out have another look at the
top two pretty snap keep there for Kuba
Corp on the first set
>> it must have been a good
>> I think this might be a treasure trove
of going to hand. Okay, we put them to
the side, have a look through our hands,
see exactly what we do have at the
moment,
>> and make that decision. And it's a
tricky one by the looks of it. It's an
important decision to make. We need we
need a lot of things going on. We don't
want to repeat the last game. We're
going for the treasure trove. We love
that. Get that card draw on board.
>> Acceptable losses
>> and we're going to see that game goes
with it. And then also the treasure
trove does the same. There's the channel
and the draw and Kak then will pass the
turn back over to No Veggies.
>> I love that little combination. It's
such a little sly one. You're like, "Oh,
actually I get rid of your gold, which
is really great cuz you need that." And
actually then I get a card draw and
channel. This is lovely. I think it's
one of those people will often I mean
with with treasure trove obviously it's
relatively obvious that you do want it
to die but people will often overlook
how important rune economy is. Oh yeah
>> and especially in a game like Riftband
where you're not you can't play multiple
runes on a you don't have abilities to
put extra stuff on that easily. Right.
You usually channel exhausted. Making
sure that you have the right runes on
the right turn is so important and
trying to keep your opponents off the
right runes at the right times is great
as well. Challenge coming out here is
going to kill off the Ezreal with the
civer and Kubak did have a super fine
hand but no runes to be able to play it
>> and that's all we were talking about
just then rune economy as well and just
having some standing no veggies knew
that there was no threat. They were
like, "Well, this is safe. I can safely
play this and it not be contested, and
now I can start to rebuild that hand
again and once again cherry pick exactly
what I want."
>> We talked about the invert timelines.
Like often you see you don't really want
to get rid of your hand cuz you've kind
of curated your hand a little bit, but
when you're in a sticky situation or if
you haven't got the draw that you were
looking for, making sure your opponent
doesn't get to keep the hand that they
have so carefully cultivated can do a
world of good. Civ going to be hit.
going to get another gold token for no
veggies. We'll have a look at the top
two with this cold shot.
>> The Ezreal is tempting.
>> I think the Ezreal is the play
>> better than the Confront overall
instead. Confront for the card draw on
the hunt and Noctturn will need to be
revealed.
>> Can we afford it? We could. Yeah, we've
got more runes. Yes. Okay.
>> I mean, we are down to only two and two
gold on next turn alongside that seal
for a power cost. The gold does help out
a lot, but we still need the runes to do
the initial cast. Sabotage time. Knowing
that we're low ourselves, try and
restrict our opponent and also kind of
grasp what they've got going on.
>> I'm Oh, what do you take here?
>> There's two super a treasure trove, a
bellow's breath of fears, and one
mystery card.
>> And that's the one that was picked.
>> And it gets recycled. So, we don't know
what it was. If you guys had a chance
and know what it was, pop it in chat and
make us feel foolish.
>> I mean, it's happened many times this
weekend that I felt foolish. Amy, it's
not a one-off.
>> Oh, don't you worry. Same here. The
players are just setting up that next
little turn going on in again. Fresh
with this board now ready to stupify to
draw. We've got to try and rebuild this
board once again. Duprify draw one again
for the Ezreal trigger perhaps.
>> Yeah, should be. I would have thought
>> we did draw an arcane shift. We have the
Fizz as well. Put it put it down this
turn. Shift next. Three damage with the
stupify would be enough to kill off that
civ. There's also a knock turn that we
need to be wary of. So it looks like it
is going to be Fizz will bring back the
wages of pain that we discarded to the
Ezreal on the first turn of the game.
That kills civ gets us a gold
>> and that mitigates the fact like the
idea of shifting the air shifting the
fizz to get that damage.
>> Yeah, and we get a gold token as well
which is really advantageous for next
turn. Just keeping that going, keeping
that economy on board. Get the card draw
from the Ezreal.
>> And we get Yeah, as you say the Ezreal
legend ability treasure trove back down.
Can't remember. There wasn't a pack of
wonders in hand, was there?
>> I don't think so. No, not that I saw
anyway, but I very well could be wrong.
And we're on to Nove's turn in a really
good position now for Koopa Club with a
really strong board state. Lots of runes
and a great hand going on. And Nove kind
of knows at least some of that
information from having spied their
hand.
>> It's another Noctturn coming off the
cool shot. First stage of the
>> knock. I never see them when I do this.
>> Yeah. But also, you know, Nove has
looked about 15 cards deep into their
main deck so far. And we can keep going.
There's still stack decks there. But
we're just going to go in with this
noturn. Take a point there
>> into the B moors. I think like you now
have good threat for Kobaka to kill off
that Noctturn. Anyway, uh you've got
Bellow's breath. You have the stupify.
You have the ability just to uh take
enough damage onto that Noctturn. Ezreal
and last Ezreal. I think last right
>> the unyielding spirit is going to go
into hand to try and deal with
singularity.
>> Makes sense.
>> It also works obviously in on things
like wages of pain. But
>> it just really it hurts when all three
cards are excellent and you're like a I
really would like all of these, but I've
got to pick one. And you've got to you
got to think about what your opponent
can do, what the biggest threat to you
is. And if it's going to be Singularity,
then that kind of makes a lot of sense,
especially with the amount of runes
right now that we have in play on the
other side of the board. You do have to
think that that threat is there. Moving
on with Fizz into Obelisk of Power to go
ahead and grab that first point there.
And we're finally on the board.
>> Yeah, Arcane Shift targeting the
Noctturn. We have the Stupify to back it
up.
But it looks like Nove is just going to
deny the ability damage.
>> Yep. Using by spending the extra using
some gold.
>> Yeah. and saying, "No, actually, please
don't."
>> We'll we'll still get the Fizz trigger
even though you don't get the three
damage to the knockdown at the
battlefield. Fizz can allow us to play
that spell for free. What are we looking
for? Koopa Culp.
>> Maybe it's
>> Is it a cold shot or a stack deck? I
think are the options.
>> Maybe a stack deck would be
>> that makes sense to me too.
>> Just to again see more cards we need to
keep filtering through. It's what
Ezreal's good at.
>> Instead,
kick us off. recycles the superfire as
well. We have another in hand. There's
the card draw. Ezreal for the choose.
Okay, that makes sense if you want more
draw out of the sequence.
>> Okay, we got thousand tail watcher. We
don't have enough runes to play it yet,
but that is good for the future.
>> Repeat
Bellow's Beth isn't enough. Instead,
>> we talked about the pig pocket takes out
the seal. A nice addition from the board
>> for Kubakulp. Gets you a gold token.
Yeah. Yeah, I
>> I mean I really like it into these gold
generating decks because you can kill
off the seals. Sure. And if it's just a
seal deck, then you're okay. But also if
they you're just getting rid of some of
those golds again, you see no body runes
on the side of no veggies. Pack of
wonders down
>> bounces
the uh treasure trove gives us a rune,
more card draw.
>> Ka here investing more in allowing the
noctturns to survive to a degree just to
get as many cards into hand as possible.
The problem is they do not know that no
veggies has an infer inver infert.
That's my it's my German coming out
there.
>> Invert invert timelines
>> in hand and we didn't see it game one.
So we don't know that necessarily the
threat exists. We ganked over to take
over another battlefield there with our
noturn producing another gold token up
to four points. So Veggies is kind of
starting to make that very apparent that
they're now going down that pipeline to
the win. Here comes the invert times
timelines.
>> Timelines have been inverted. Kubakob
just spent a long time building up this
hand and it is all for N. The pack of
wonders gone. Uh, sorry, the treasure
trove gone as well. We're going to draw
four and we will see where we are. A
seal, a challenge, a cold shot on the
side of Nove.
What you got?
>> Let's have a look cuz we're passing over
to his turn now. We have a lot of runes.
We have gold. We have a seal. So
depending on what came about in that
hand, we might have something absolutely
off the chain or it could all be falling
apart.
>> Well, a pack of wonders off the top.
>> Okay, we got stack
>> another pick pocket. Another Fizz as
well, which is nice in this sort of
situation.
>> A seal for a seal. Very commonly seen
play.
>> Now we'll go and look at the top three.
>> Again, we need as much information as we
can before we commit too many runes to
anything. Yeah, this is kind of the
point for Kobac where he really needs to
get in control of the game. Singularity
>> and double wages of pain. They'll go to
the bottom. Singularity will be able to
deal with both of these knockowns. We
have the runes for it as well.
No real response for no veggies to that.
>> Looks like it's just going to be the
singularity coming through. Yep, that's
a a hard cost to pay. So there goes the
two knockturns and that hidden card has
to go as well. So the fight or flight
goes away. Very unhelpful in this
situation sadly, but understandable why
it was played. And then Fisk could just
head on in there again. Just walts into
a battlefield into Valor's lair because
there's no threat coming back
immediately.
>> Yeah, we start to march up the board up
to three here for Koba with the pick
pocket and the fierce going in. Vmor's
lair obviously a little bit difficult to
play around, but when you have a pack of
wonders, it becomes a lot easier. bounce
the fizz to hand, replay the Fizz, and
use I instead just play the pack of
wonders. I did think perhaps we would
see the Fizz being played, but I guess
you want to be able to utilize your
trash effectively. We're going to bounce
the pick pocket, too.
>> Often, I mean, this this kind of
>> Oh, what we going to call it? It's a
bounce deck, I guess. Boomerang deck.
Yeah. I mean, Boomerang is much more in
keeping for
>> Civot. Yeah, that's the thing.
But that's what
I have now.
But I appreciate that. Similarly, no
veggies hasn't got anything going on
either at the moment, but can
potentially bring some scary units into
play like the Noctturn of the top deck
again.
>> Those Noctturns have done so much work
for Nove. It is his third coming out.
looking at a fizz and a sabotage and
it's just going to take the fizz from
that second part of the cold shot.
>> Those called shots have been calling the
shots all day. They've been absolutely
bringing the fire when it comes to these
top decks. Those knocks
>> might as well just be on the top each
time. I swear.
>> It's very true. It's very true. The
problem for Nove is double wages of pain
is enough to kill off a noturn.
>> So true. It doesn't have deflect and
Kubak is in a riches a riches of energy
right now. Basically got all of his
runes out on that battlefield. In fact
does have all 12
>> six cards in hand. You seen they do have
those double wages.
Also the uh mind spplitter double
fierce. Oh, they put the wages on the
bottom, didn't they? Did they? Yeah,
they don't have those double wages. They
have the mind. like the mind splitter in
this.
>> Yeah, I like the mind splitter. Sorry.
And that is where we're going to go.
Splits the mind of no veggies.
>> We have a look
challenge. Hard bargain and a fizz.
>> Get to remove anything from that hand.
>> Yeah, it's just what do we want to take?
>> I
>> get rid of the hard bargain for the
counter war.
>> Yep. I think that's wise. You know, the
challenge isn't doing loads because your
units aren't big enough to challenge the
mind spplitter itself. And then the Fizz
are quite little. They can get spells
back, but
>> can't get a hard bargain, Matt. Well,
you can, but it doesn't do anything.
>> No, exactly. So, I think that's I think
that was the wisest choice.
>> Pick pocket going to kill off that seal
of discord. Make a gold for Koopa. Still
the noturn and the traveling merchant
available for Nove.
>> This turn would be a great turn to do
so. And looks like I mean they're
uncontested on Battlefield. So they
could. It's then just about having the
backup for next turn to be able to
continue because you need to you're
getting onto that six is all well and
good, but we need the eight to win. So
we need then the backup. We are going up
to the six and now it's going to be
about whether he's able to hold on to
those or whether they're going to be
able to put enough into the base now to
have an appropriate response next turn.
>> It's how you deal with the mind
spplitter really, isn't it? Seven might
on it.
>> Rasa. Rasa. Rasa. Okay, I think we'll
take Arasa, please.
>> Do you reckon?
>> Yeah, I think it might be the best
choice. We're going to sunder some
people.
>> Put it into hand. Unfortunately, the
other two Ras on the bottom here unable
to be discarded or brought back with the
last rights.
>> Yeah, that is a bit of a shame, I
suppose, like because they are the
cheaper, larger units you've got and
they're the kind of appropriate backup
you want at this point. It is a shame
they're on the bottom of the deck, but
equally at least we have one and it's
going to be cheap as chips at the
moment.
Fizz using the gold going to play out.
What are we are we looking at an invert
timeline? I was thinking about stack
deck maybe just because we need to draw
more cards at this point like we're
limited and getting a bit low on
resources and I think that realistically
we need to do something to start
replenishing the hand and okay we've got
>> unyielding spirit a fight or flight
>> and an Ezreal
>> looks like Ezreal is going to be the
play can't play it this turn though
>> no I think that was the fight or flight
>> was that the fight or flight
I Oh, he's keeping us in suspense.
>> Not hiding a card implies not the fight
or flight for now at least. But uh
>> I think it was the sabotage then.
>> It was unyielding spirit, wasn't it?
Sabotage.
>> Totally.
>> That's okay. Like we we've been doing
this for as long as the players have
been doing this. So also a a complicated
board state to work your way through.
Koba Corp fighting back. Well, though
>> got so many resources on board. I think
that's the thing at the moment. We are
absolutely lushified
>> with resources and now it's just about
getting the cards in hand to be able to
make the plays to bring it back. We're
on three points to six, but that's not
that far behind in the in the grand
scheme of things when you think about
how many resources are just clearly on
the board. And the mine spplitter really
Novex doesn't have a way of dealing with
that. It's just so big going in with
seven might to four.
>> So we got an acceptable losses in hand.
Doesn't really do too much for us now as
Koopa.
The mind splitter going in alongside the
pick pocket.
>> Noveturn
will die. Point for Kak
traded. Yeah,
>> I mean that's why you want to uh chuck
in the the pig pocket there as well to
make sure that you are over that punch
first threshold.
>> Going to banish the mind spplitter
targeting the traveling merchant.
>> Unyielding spirit means the damage won't
go through but the mind spplitter will
come back. Can we have another look at
Noveggy's hand?
>> Getting that effect of being able to
bring it back and reactivate that effect
on a mindspplitter is overwhelmingly
powerful. Being able to take a card from
your opponent's hand and then know what
threats are available is just one of the
most powerful effects in this game.
Hands down.
>> Yeah, smart from Koopa Corpus. Play
around the punch first cuz it was in
hand alongside a Russa and a Fizz. It
must have been the unyielding spirit
that they drew off the uh off the stack
deck.
>> So, where are we going? Ka, let's have a
think. If it were me, I'd be scouring
that trash right now. Be like, "Okay, no
veggies. What can you get back with this
Fizz?" If I put the punch first in
there, you can then play it back out. If
I put the Rasa in there, it's there's a
risk of you drawing a last rights,
conquering a battlefield, and then
cracking out the Rasa as well. I think
the Fizz is the scarier point here.
Surprisingly, Fizz is the scarier one
than Raza. And the Raza you can play
around, right? You've got you've got
ways to play around that. You've got big
units. You've got your mind splitter
down, but the Fizz just being able to
bounce spells back is just too
troublesome.
>> Yeah, here comes the Fizz for Koba. Both
the Arcane Shifts have been used for
Kuba. Bellow's breath will be the
target. Paying to repeat it.
>> Repeat that. So that we've got some
extra damage going on. Going for the
Fizz. So that's got two damage on it
now. One remaining to
>> have an effect to remove it from the
board.
>> Yeah. And the traveling merchants also
being superfied. So that's sitting at it
was super at the start of the turn. So
that's sitting at one as well.
>> We have four runes left up.
>> And we're having a quick look through
our trash.
as
>> see what's available, what's been used.
>> It's acceptable losses. Fizz and one
other card that I can't quite remember
right now. The Fizz could try and get
back.
You could you could get back like a
stack deck or something if you're still
looking, but Fizz is going to use so
many of our runes. I think that's the
issue at this point is like we've got
the roots, we've got resources on the
board,
>> but we've had to do so much to climb
back up this ladder at this point that
actually I'm not sure that we've got
enough momentum now to just keep going.
And that's been kind of the story of
this back and forth is that each player
has been quite successfully managing to
do what they can to manage each other's
board and hands.
>> But it's getting to the point where just
can't see the line out of the sand. And
we go into a straight victory for Nove.
>> Big from Nove. I I was trying to work
out. There was another Bellow's breath
in the in the trash. The fizz into
Bellow's breath I think would have
killed off both the units on the
battlefield. So
>> obviously
>> there was a continuation
>> after that point does make sense. It's
very difficult after that point. So
obviously congratulations to November
taking the victory on the civ one of the
final two civ remaining in the
tournament. So still playing for that
best of for Kuba Corp. Little bit
disappointing that they weren't able to
close it out with Ezreal, but after so
long over two days of play, no real
surprises that endurance does come into
these things.
>> Absolutely. And we have a lot to hear,
I'm sure, from our winner of that
feature match. So, we'll see you in a
second.
>> Welcome, Rift Bounders. I am joined by
the winner of the last round of Swiss
here in Bologna, No Veggies. How are you
feeling, man?
>> I'm feeling great. Glad I got that out
of the way, finally.
I mean, you were already top eight in
Houston with the Annie deck. What made
you change decks?
>> Um, so I felt like Annie got a little
bit too slow compared to the other
decks, weirdly enough, cuz he was super
fast in set one. But the other decks
were just doing more unfair things in my
opinion. Like
serving a gold is really impactful and
like the orange cards like just
sabotaging your opponent to death is
pretty good. Um, yeah. Yeah, and I felt
like there was no reason to play Annie
over Draven. And I didn't really want to
play Draven as well. So, I kind of went
for the option C technically, but I like
Civer. I like more.
>> I mean, when you don't want to play
Draven, I mean, when you're playing
Draven, you have a little chance of
getting that metal card. I want to say
with Civer, that's a lot better. There's
only one other player who can threaten a
tiebreak for you. How are you feeling?
What would that mean for you to finally
win a best off?
>> It'd be pretty cool. I'm kind of sad
it's Civer cuz I don't I don't I've
never played Civer in the game. I think
she's I think she's extremely boring,
but she's cool here.
>> Well, I mean, you can have a spell
shield. You can run fast.
>> Yeah,
>> I guess.
>> I mean, you play a pretty you play a
pretty interesting uh civer deck.
Actually, you're playing a miracle
version. We have seen plenty of Aurora
recently. Why have you decided to not
play Aurora Civer?
>> I So, the reason I didn't play Aurora is
because I felt like first of all, it's
not my play style. I don't really like
slow control decks. I tested it and I
hated. You don't really depend on the
Aurora, but like sometimes you kind of
depend on the Aurora and I didn't really
like that. I like I'm a combo player at
the end of the day. So, the miracle
package just like was fit me perfect.
Like it's it's flexible. I can be an
aggro deck when I can be an aggro deck
and I can like be a slow control deck
that just wears your hand down and until
I know I have a lock on the game, I can
play accordingly. You know, the
sabotage, again, not to rave on
sabotage, but the fact that in this game
at least, the hand rip is cool, but the
hand information is even better.
>> Yeah,
>> it's very important.
>> There's so many crazy combat tricks. If
you know what's coming, it's uh
absolutely massive. But also, you know,
most miracle decks, they are either mind
or they are fury plus chaos. So, you're
running orange, you're running body.
Why? What what are you playing to
compensate for not being mind?
>> Obviously, the unfair cards, cha uh
sabotage, of course. Uh punch first is a
big one. Um and uh the MVP in my opinion
is uh
challenge.
>> Okay,
>> challenge has been a card that a lot of
people have forgotten about this
weekend. They play out their Draven,
they don't hold for an axe, and you
challenge our draven, and they're like,
"Okay, four to four." No, it's six.
Like, uhoh.
How many times did you catch people off
guard with a challenge?
>> A lot of A lot of times. A lot of time.
I caught I caught more people off guard
by the fact that Civer suddenly was a
six.
>> Oh, okay. All right.
>> Because she gains the buff in the in the
in the middle of the chain.
>> All right.
>> So, a lot of people don't account for
that.
>> Well, very strong. So, that's that's
reason for success. People at home, play
around challenge.
>> Challenge. I can't play this deck
anymore.
>> As I said earlier, there's only one more
player that can also go to an extra
record. still maybe in contention for
the top cut if you have a good
tiebreaker.
>> Is there anything else you would like to
say to the other civ players still in
contention for the best off?
>> Um
I hope you don't draw Aurora.
>> All right, maybe the luck is with them.
Maybe it is not with the miracle
version. You're very much less relying
on drawing your good cards because
you're going to see half your deck
anyways. No veggies, thank you so much
for taking the time out of your day for
this interview and we're going live back
to the coverage. Welcome back to
regional qualifier here in Bologna as we
are getting ready for the second feature
match of our final round of Swiss. I
think no veggies for someone that has
played that deck for so long over the
last two days. Incredibly coherent. If I
played that for a single round, I think
I would be gobbled at this.
>> I think my brain would just leak out of
my just mush. Just mush.
>> Yeah, but the power of sabotage and hand
knowledge clearly something very
important to know. veggies among other
players. We've seen it used to such
great effect and that that match more
than any had it from both sides. We
really got to see how that knowledge and
that clarity guides the players.
>> Should we move into more refound action?
>> I feel like we must. Do you know? I
think we might as well. Let's get into
our next feature match as we see a
Draven taking on a victor.
>> Looking for a victor, my friend. Will
they be the victor is the question.
looking for those top eight spots.
>> Absolutely. I haven't seen a Victor yet,
but I love the gameplay of this deck. It
hasn't had a huge shift from set one to
two in regards to mechanics, but let's
take a look at the Draven list first.
>> Yeah, looking like the sort of
conventional miracle Draven. A few
knocks in there as well alongside the
Bushwack for a later game. Closing out
of the matchups. Couple of spinning
axes, the last rights. Nothing too
surprising overall here. only the single
switcheroo which we are seeing a few
times in these decks as well.
>> Absolutely. And of course moving on to
talk about our Victor deck. So really
from set one to set two there are a lot
more removal cards available and that's
where it's really starting to shine. And
we have the Zensha as well in here which
is really helping the deck to kind of
find its place in this meta. And I like
the Riptide Rex edition as well. Yeah,
the ability to do a bunch of damage to a
unit at a battlefield does a huge amount
of work in here. Also, the glass
mixologist and the Shinshow. A little
bit of recursion coming out from glass
mologist,
that's the one does help you out quite a
bit in these fights. A lot of removal as
you say, a little bit of gear removal as
well with the salvages. We'll be getting
on into the action. The fist bump
between the two players goes to Driver
piloting the Victor and Daisil. I think
Dael
>> Dyel 97 here piloting the Draven.
>> Draven has been one of the big baddies
of the event, showing that it's
uncontested might, strength, and
perseverance can push through
practically anything. But can it push
through all of Victor's tricks and units
and recruits? And Zwan's on the top,
treasure horde on the bottom here. In
terms of battlefields, it is a Victor to
go first. Ghost of Driver is going to
kick us off and we'll see what we decide
to do for our turn one play. Looks like
it's just going to be the honest broker
death nail effect on that. Really nice.
And you can use it well with the uh the
cold the meek effects as well. Allowing
cold the weak colon
Q effects allowing us to kill it off.
Get the death nail and then make your
enemy sacrifice a unit as well.
Excellent traveling merchant play. Nice
and easy. So, we're able to just start
to get that draw on the board, which we
love to see early on. Back over to
Ghost's turn, I think, after this. I
don't think there's much more we can
play. Nope. So, we're back on over and
looking at already moving a unit forward
just to really start the pace of the
game and set the scale.
>> Yeah, deciding to go for the discard
draw. Wants a little bit more of hand
manipulation early on here. could go
towards the uh treasure horde instead.
Get that gold token for paying one, but
decides that instead of that, we want to
make sure we are getting through our
cards properly. Uses the Victor's
ability to make a recruit, discards the
salvage. Factory manufacturer is going
to make another recruit there in the
base. And uh factory manufacturer,
something you don't see really outside
of Victor decks at all. So, don't really
blame Dassel. D, how do we say we're
going to say his name?
>> D. Dil.
>> Well, it's an A now instead of an I,
which I think it was earlier, unless we
just both misread it. Dackle, dackle,
>> dackle, dackle. Let's go for it.
>> Yeah, he's
>> moving the traveling merchant. Let's do
it. Discard and draw. Want to start
cycling through and cherry picking those
>> cards that we desperately need to just
get off the mark. We've got the scrap
scrap. Drew a nocturn for turn as well,
which is not really what you want to
happen. Is going to pay the one on the
treasure hordes to make that gold token.
then bring out Vanquisher Draven for the
four and request there from Ghost to
Driver. Can you just use your gold not
next to your runes? I think that's a
valid request overall.
>> Just to make it super clear of what is
available to Dackle at this point and
then Ghost Driver able to start their
turn with a flurry of units, which is
exactly what Victor likes to do is
overwhelm the opponent, make more units
than they can handle. The recruits, yes,
they have low might, but they are mighty
in friendship
>> that they are. I think if you're DLE,
you're a little worried about something
like a blood money into cold the weak
here. It would wipe away your board. Co
the week weak by itself obviously not
too effective with how with Dal having
two units on the board, but if you are
able to get a couple out, it could work.
You can also move in with the factory
manufacturer and the recruit to make
sure the traveling merchandise then go
for the curl. The weak factory
manufacturer is going to trade in there.
will get the point for ghost driver
moves up to three
>> and we paying the one. We are paying the
one.
>> Yeah,
>> get that gold token.
>> it's important is it's a important
resource in this matchup especially
because Ghost Driver needs to make sure
that all of their resources are still
ready to use because they want to be
able to keep making those recruit tokens
again and again and again and just keep
up and keep having as many units as they
can. The pick pocket is back on the
board as well. Another gold token joins
us. And now we're going to be able to
just keep up this pressure, bringing
things back, keeping things safe. And
honestly, this is a great base and it's
full of guys. That's exactly what we
want to see.
>> And we were talking to uh some of the
production staff here and they were
saying, "Yeah, maybe sometimes when we
have a Victor deck, we need a slightly
bigger area in the base because already
units are getting stacked on top of each
other. It's like Hoth here. Just
everyone in a very small combined space.
We're going to get knocked back here by
the Draven Vanquisher. We will get the
combat trigger from Glorious Executioner
for the draw.
>> That's the only thing I don't love about
Victor into Draven is that Draven loves
to win a fight and it's really easy
against those recruit tokens. So almost
leaving them at a base isn't great. You
kind of want to remove them with some of
your own removal effects. Take the gold
tokens and such from those and then
don't allow them to draw a card by
having to by by getting to conquer
easily.
>> Yeah. Now D moving into that. Hey, I've
drew one of the cards of my let me look
at all of my cards combo. It's drawn me
another one of my cards of my let me
draw all my cards combo. The Ezreal
comes down and there's the cold shot
>> still going
>> with the scrap heap getting discarded.
Drawing three of that Ezreal instead. We
now have the cold shot in hand. Instead,
we'll go for the seal first and can then
use that for the cord shot. And look at
the top four.
>> Yeah, we're we're doing it twice. It's
so nice. We're doing it twice.
>> Hard bargain and a nocturn. Oh, that is
that is perfect gracious. What is it
with these knock turns today? They are
absolutely coming out on these stack
decks every cold shots every time. I'm
so impressed.
>> Piercing light to hand works really well
into these low might units like the
recruits can kill them off pretty
effectively.
>> Oh, it's looking a bit scary if he ghost
driver at this point. Those card draws
were incredible. Just I think having a
little word about the effect there.
Yeah, it's got ganking. I think we were
just checking what that effect was uh on
the knock turn there. Another traveling
merchant. It's Wow, this is really
stacking up to be quite the battle with
two armies on both sides of the
battlefields ready to close in on one
another.
>> Yeah, Ghost Driver will be needing to
work towards a glorious evolution if he
is going to be able to take down Dal's
board. We have the readying of these
runes coming out. We'll move into
channel and then we'll see what the draw
is. haven't really had a a a very fine
look at Ghost of Driver's hand. I think
it was a Bellow's breath that they were
able to pull out here, but it's becoming
harder and harder to find that spot
removal.
>> Yeah, we kind of need something like
some cold week here to kind of force Dal
into a position where they have to get
rid of some bigger units and you're just
going to say, "Well, I'll let a recruit
go."
>> I mean, you have options like Imperial
Decree into Bellow's Breath, which would
do a lot of work as well.
>> That's true.
>> Uh recruit going in here. Discard draw.
There's the point for ghost to drive
halfway to the finishing line in this
first game of the uh this featured
match. Shiao seems like is going to go
to the trash
and it will do have some ways to recur
that. It's like a spectral matron I
believe can bring.
>> Okay, the bellow's breath that was a
good call.
>> I mean but without the Imperial decree
it's not as powerful. No.
>> Bellow's breath. Are we repeating it?
>> I think that's a yes
>> based on the cost that was paid.
>> Hitting the units in the base. A second
Bellow's breath here as well would make
sense, but a thousand tail watcher works
really well with it.
>> Going to kill off all of the units in
base for Dal.
>> And
I did Did we repeat it and hit the uh
the Draven or did we just
>> I don't think so. I think it was
everything in base. I think they left
the Draven. I think it's just everything
in base. I believe it was those three.
>> Okay, looks like they are going to die
off. You could spinning axe out here to
save one of them. The question is, is it
worth it? The answer is yes for DLE.
>> Puts the spinx ax down. Where are we
putting it? Noturn or Ezreal?
>> I like the I like the Ezreal. I think
the Nocturn like we can we can bring
that back a little bit easier later. And
Nocturn's an easy play if you find
another one. Keeping an Ezreal around
for its secondary effect is more is kind
of a bit more advantageous at this
stage. I think saving Ezreal with that
spinning axe is just enough to give Dal
the advantage into a combat later on.
>> Yeah, I agree with that. Having the
repeat for the cord shots as well is
really nice overall. Ghost to Driver and
we're going in. Looks like it. No real
runes available for DLE. No fake runes
available for them either.
>> No, nothing at all. So Ghost Driver does
kind of have the advantage though of
just being able to go in a bit
uncontested. You can just go in. You
don't even need to take over. You just
want to stop the whole point. So you
just you can just go in and stop.
>> I guess you could trade into that which
>> the problem is Draven has fury runes
available. So they can recycle if
decides they could go down to one rune
here
>> and give the plus four. Just going to go
for the plus two up to six knowing that
ghost driver doesn't have the energy
left and it's the trade.
>> Yeah, just going for the trade again.
Just trying to get rid and mitigate the
hold point there. Not really needing to
get one themselves for the conquer
because they can just now put this pick
pocket in which was already ready in
base. So regardless was really nice for
Ghost Driver cuz they had that backup.
>> They did. And now Ghost of Driver goes
up to five. Might be worth making
another recruit here.
>> I They're tapped out, I believe.
>> Going to recycle for a hidden card.
>> Yeah, I didn't know. I didn't just
didn't notice they were tapped out, but
yeah, recycling one to hide. And that's
all you can do. It's such a shame cuz it
does kind of slow the assault. We still
have the thousand tail watcher and a
gold token, but you know, Draven could
really come back at you if you leave
them alone too long.
>> Yeah. Uh we'll see if uh Dal is able to
get a bit of semblance of control on the
board cuz you do need to take at least
one of these battlefields here. Ghost to
Driver would be going up to seven.
Doesn't need another round before they
can win. But
>> okay,
>> still in a good spot.
>> Stack deck or a fight off light.
>> Ah deck, I think. Yeah, just keep
pushing forward. We need to try and find
a way to take these battlefields. One is
easy. That's the thing. Yeah,
>> difficult to defeat
the one with a hidden card
and blade the Ezreal, assuming it's a
hidden blade,
>> or do you hidden blade the pickpocket to
get it's a wages of pain instead. Three
damage marked on that Ezreal will trade
in. Now we see the hard bargain for the
wages. No ability to pay it. So that
will get put into the trash. Ezreal
winning the combat. Does get a card draw
for DLE.
Only two runes available on this turn
though, Amy.
>> It's It's not enough really. It's It's
just not enough. It's They're going to
struggle to come back from this. It's
>> just not giving. And we don't have
enough in the discard pile yet for the
Raza.
>> So, I think this is where we kind of
have to slow our ropes a bit.
>> Yeah, I agree with you. I think you uh
really need to get some of that rune
economy back. stack
making sure that your hand has what it
wants in it just to
>> give you
flexibility for the future.
>> You have a you have a gold as well. You
uh you could play the cold shot with the
Ezreal's optional ability, not using
your runes. Oh, you have the seal as
well. Don't even
>> pass. We're just going to pass it over.
Keep our runes ready. Kind of leave a
threat on the board, right, to your
opponent. You're saying, "Okay, well,
>> anything you can do, I might have
something better. I might have a
reaction to that. So leaving that just
as a tell to your opponent that you have
something that can go down during their
turn is an important structural element
of this game.
>> Yeah, another hit and blade drawn to
hand as well for ghost driver goes to
six. Has that thousand tail watcher that
will beat out the Ezreal in pure combat
right now. But as you can see there's a
rebuke in the hand of Dal Riptide Rex
targeting Ezreal play to a battlefield.
having to read that line is an unusual
inclusion, but I love it. You just get
to deal that pure six damage
>> as you're dead.
>> Oh, the uh the spinning axe
>> would be given temporary, so putting it
in the trash right now doesn't matter
too much, but technically should still
be on the battlefield. Rebuke comes out
onto the thousand tail watcher. The
knock back to hand.
>> Goes to driver still in a really strong
spot here. Seven might on that Zorn
Warren on the top side. It's going to
make another recruit. I like
>> disposable infantry here.
>> Still going to leave a couple of runes
up and just kind of pass into Dal's
turn. Quite a strong position here. Dal
now doesn't have anything on board
currently. Going to bring that recruit
token back just to have bodies and leave
Riptide Rex.
>> I think closer to hand.
>> Okay.
>> Do we have like a bushwack to ready it
to to get out onto
>> I think we do have a bushwack.
>> I don't know if it's in hand. I guess
>> I think it is.
>> Is it? I'm pretty sure.
>> Okay,
>> I'm certain I saw a bushwack.
>> I believe you.
>> I think it's there.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah, I could see it. I could
see it.
>> So, I think we can get a ready unit into
play.
>> It's just whether we're spreading
ourselves too thin.
>> Yeah,
the other option is try and wipe away
the board a little bit. Yes, you're 100%
right. Second card back there. Good spot
on that, Amy.
As also, if we're going to play
something like a stack deck, you want to
play it early. So, we're going to stack
deck. See a cord shot on Ezreal and a
switcheroo.
>> Oo, I I do like the switcher.
>> Switcheroo. Yeah, especially when you're
dealing into something like a thousand
tail watcher.
>> Yeah, you know what's coming. You just
put it back in their hand.
>> Mhm.
>> Where are we going to try and make our
stand here?
>> It's a troublesome call because you've
got limited resources. We need to try
and recreate that board state. You need
to
>> put your stance back on this game. But
you know what's coming. You know the
thousand tail watch is right there in
the hand. You know that can just jump
back out at you. So it's a troublesome
situation to be in where you kind of
know what is on the horizon but don't
have the methods in hand right now to
combat it.
>> There's the bushwack that we talked
about. Units enter ready this turn. You
have the card draw. Oh sorry. Gold gear
made from that exhaust. It doesn't
really apply too much. Doesn't really do
anything for us right now. Mr. Driver
sitting pretty at six. The Raza goes
into the treasure horde.
>> Just going to score a point. Nice and
easy. Go up to four. Ghost drivers six,
which is a really scary number to be on
because if they're able to then kind of
dip in and out. If this Rex tide is left
alone, then we're able to just take the
eighth point.
>> We know there's a hidden blade in hand
for Ghost of Driver.
>> Exactly.
>> Right. So, you need a hard bargain or
some way to stop the advance, but Ghost
of Driver has enough tools right now.
Ezreal in ready. Discard draw two. No
runes up for Dark. Really hanging his
hopes on this uh defense from Rasa.
>> Kind of hanging on by a thread here. I
think it's important to put the
switcheroo in place.
>> Finds a card. Switcheroo goes in. Hidden
blade is going to cost Darkle this game.
No real way for you to react to it.
>> No. Ghost driver goes up to seven now.
All they need to do is conquer the
treasure horde. That is it. And they
have two recruits to do the game.
>> What are they playing around with? The
hidden card could be something like a
fight or flight, but even that doesn't
really do anything with hidden blade.
>> But we don't currently have enough power
to do so. We've only got two recruit
tokens. So, we're going to need some
jiggory pokery and some shenanigans to
make it happen.
>> Yep. Thousand tailed Watcher will be the
play.
>> We knew it was coming. We knew it was
there. And certainly going to be a very
helpful hand.
>> Thousand tail watcher going to reduce
>> the knock turns
>> might by three.
>> Yeah, take it down to one
>> and then do we just like poke with a
recruit token? Do we put both in?
>> I think going at one at a time does make
sense. Accelerated thousand tail.
They're all going to go in together.
>> Going. We're all in this together.
reveal the switcheroo.
>> We'll put the thousand tail watcher down
to one. So, three into seven now.
>> So, that's no good. Switcheroo
definitely putting a lot of work.
>> And there's the hidden blade.
>> There it is.
>> And down goes Rasa.
>> Don't blame Ghost of Driver for taking
the time to make sure because you don't
know what the hidden card is. Make sure
it is what you think it is and then play
the hidden blade when it is required.
>> Yep. I like that. It was a very clever
play. just kind of poking the bear and
going, "Okay, I know that I know the
threat now and I still have the means to
take this win." Ghost Driver in the
driving seat for the majority of that
game, taking Victor to a 1 victory
against Draven.
>> A 10 victory.
>> Very good. We're just having a little
look at the side deck there. I don't
know if Ghost Driver is going to be
wanting to do much different. That all
seemed to go quite well. Yeah, it really
did have uh the salvage in for something
like the spinning ax if so required. Did
a good job with the
uh early recruits trying to deal with
the board well as well from the side of
DL. I wonder if D's going to change
things up at all going into game two.
>> I'm not sure what would be particularly
helpful. I don't think Victor is what
you're expecting to come up against.
>> Against the odds. against the odds I
think is particularly helpful. The
ability to really buff up a single unit
depending on the amount of enemies
there. Vinhit thundersong as well to try
and stop some of those sneaky hidden
blades and such could do a little bit of
work. But I do like against the odds
>> maybe even a ferris just to kind of
>> start to match how many units your
opponent has on board. You want
something almost smaller than you're
used to. Uh, you know, Draven, Draven's
used to having some big old units on the
board, right? But actually, when you've
got things like call the week, you kind
of want some mech tokens, right? You
want some stuff you can sack.
>> You might want to be like, actually,
yeah, that's fine. Don't worry about it.
>> Mhm. Or things with death now. Even if
you have to sack the first four runners,
as you say, you're still getting six
might back for it. We will move to game
two of this final round of Swiss here in
Bologna and we'll see if Ghost of Driver
can take it home with a 20 and go to 11
and one.
>> What will the battlefield choices here
be?
>> That's a good question. It's a good
question.
>> Candleit Sanctum and Voidgate.
>> Okay, Voidgate coming out of our Victor
player. A little bit of extra damage on
things like wages of pain on the
singularity on the bellow's breath can
do work.
Yeah, I'm surprised at Vidogate, but
honestly
>> kind of impressed.
>> Yeah, I mean, especially if you're
trying to just like ping off, you know,
these Ezreals, these Fizzes, even a
Draven Vanquisher. Having the extra
damage for Wages of Pain, putting it up
to four is huge. Recruit is the turn one
play for Ghost Driver. Dor didn't put
anything out for their own turn one.
Now, it's going to be Draven Vanquisher.
>> Nice easy ready. Very typical of the
previous turn. I think just asking uh
which one that is.
>> Right. Just clarifying there's no point
not doing it right.
>> Yep. Exactly. But it is candleit
sanctum. So we've seen that on today
already.
>> Look at the top two. You can decide to
recycle one or two of them and then put
the ones that you haven't recycled back
on the top of your main deck in any
order on the conquer. Here's the
recruit. Ghostster driver will
thankfully immediately show us what we
were just talking about.
>> Oh yes. And I like this. So, you know,
it's an easy Victor kind of turn one
typical play of recruit in, recruit out,
and absolutely shake it all about and
grab those top two cards to have a
little cheeky peek. And I think that's
important. You're wanting to
>> kind of distill your deck of the things
that you don't need right now.
>> Yeah. Thin it out, find the things you
want, put the rest on the bottom.
Currently sitting with a thousand tail
watch, an Imperial decree, and a
bellow's breath in hand. A huge combo
there.
>> Also a cull and a singularity. I believe
the choice between hidden blade and
>> uh I didn't see I think it was
pickpocket on the top.
>> Maybe not going to exactly what Victor
kind of gained from set two was actually
all of this removal became not only
great for other decks in dealing with
Victor, but actually helps Victor itself
to kind of help these recruit tokens.
Speaking of, here is our first call of
the week. Forcing Draven Vanquisher to
the trash this early and only for a
recruit token.
>> Yeah, it's such a nice trade for Ghost
Driver. Only has to kill off one of his
recruits. Decides it is the one in base
rather than the one sitting on Candle.
Sanctum wants the whole point from
there. I see the draw coming out with
the channel as well. Slightly missed
sequence there from Dal, but it's fine
in the end. Did all of the things that
you're meant to do in your ABC DS. Seal
into seal into Ezreal into discard.
Scrap peeping to draw three cards. Cold
shot, a Fizz,
>> and a hard bargain all go to hand.
>> Looks like it might be time for another
cold shot. Might be trying to dig for a
knockturn just to try and get a body on
the board at this point.
>> I mean, I really think getting through
the cold shot here makes sense. You've
got double fizz and a spinning axe as
well for forces later on. Seal and last
rights.
>> We've got a couple of seals already. So
yeah, I like the last rights here
instead.
>> Double Ezreal. I think I know what I'm
taking.
>> I think we'll take an Ezreal, which I
mean it's a great choice anyway. We can
continue to again cherrypick what we
need. Just make sure that we're
developing the board. We get units and
card draw from Ezreal as well as a
passive effect. Brilliant card and we've
seen it to great success today in many
decks. the Ezreal as well. You can use
it to get your Draven back out of the
trash if you so desire with that last
rights. Does win out on the combats, but
goes to Driver already at two points.
Can kind of play this one a little bit
more slow roll. Doesn't have to try and
dominate the board. Can just use the
recruits for the holds, allow DL to
conquer himself, and then in return
start looking at some of those kill
spells, looking at the wages of pain at
the bellow's breath Imperial decree
combination that we already see in hand.
Here we go. Pigpocket down first.
>> Take a seal.
>> We love that. Get a gold. Pigpocket
doing its thing.
>> Then we're going to bring that recruit
token back.
>> Yeah. Don't want to give free combats to
the Draven.
>> We We didn't We didn't like that last
time. We're not going to like it now,
but we're going to need some more
recruits cuz that's what Victor loves to
do.
>> Just a couple of them stacked up on each
other there. Not the easiest for Ghost
of Driver to maintain a very easily
visualized board state, but is doing the
best job that they can.
>> And we move on to Dackle's turn. Now
we've got over Battlefields. We've got
an Ezreal ready to go. So we do have
some point scoring potential here, but
it's all about then keeping that pace up
now. Maybe Oh, I was thinking about
maybe using a last rights first to get
the conqueror effect, but just going
straight in with the Ezreal for the
point first and then looks like we'll go
from there. Yeah, I think the risk is if
you do last right in that cost three,
you then have three runes left. So, you
can't recur the Draven because you don't
have enough runes on this turn.
>> Alongside that, if the Ezreal then dies,
you've paid three, you've paid a power,
you've recycled two from your trash, and
you don't even get the effect, right?
So,
>> that's so true.
>> With two up on the side of Ghostbuster,
I think it makes sense to play a little
bit more cautiously. uh for this Draven.
Traveling Merchant seems to be the next
option that is going to come down on the
board. Take a second to think about it.
And there it goes.
>> Going for it. Going for the seals. So
now looking at hiding a card.
>> Yeah, we know that's a fight or flight
as you say,
>> but Coaster Driver does not. Could be
something like a tide turner if uh Dal
decides that he wants to switch around
the traveling merchant and and the tide
turner to get the extra discard draw.
Double Imperial decree is a little bit
pricey for my blood, but still with the
Bella's birth, it does do a lot of work
and you've got the wages of pain as well
for later on just to at least kill off
one enemy unit. But really, Imperial
decree works most effectively when you
have either a slew of recruits that you
can constantly throw in. Oh, okay. We've
got a reactionary spinning axe coming
after a pick pocket heading on into
Ezreal. So now that's going to be
attached instead. With the quick draw,
we can just equip that straight away.
Now Ghostaster Driver with the focus.
We know there's a fuff there.
Is Ghostaster driver play effectively
around it? Do you want to invest much
more into this? Because DL plays the
spinning ax. You might be thinking,
well, wouldn't he just have fight or
flighted my unit back? Why is he
investing more in this?
>> Why is there more going on than meets
the eye?
>> Yeah. And can be for future turns,
right? You can play the spinning axe now
to keep the fight or flight around to
deal with bigger threats. Pickpocket
just allowed to die.
Combat one for Dal means that he draws a
card. Now goes to driver is going to go
singularity. That's probably why we
didn't want to invest too much into that
because actually just using the
singularity now takes out the spinning
ax as well out of play which is a huge
advantage.
>> Perfect runes available as well. There's
a hard bargain in hand for DLE but
there's two runes up for ghost to driver
so he's played around the fact that this
hard bargain can come out.
DL might just use it to make the runes
be paid.
>> Maybe just to kind of force your
opponent to use resources.
>> Yeah.
>> And then you kind of know that that's
the end of their turn, right?
>> Exactly.
>> They can move some recruits, but that's
about it.
>> Instead, they all go to the trash.
>> Just decided, okay, nope, you absolutely
take that.
>> Everything goes to the trash. D once
again with a limited board state. Ghost
Driver just moving recruits around to
gain those early points. And now Dal is
once again having to fight their way
through their deck to be able to get
units and get them on the board. And I
think we didn't hit anything more than
some more kind of card draw. We do get
to see more, which is great. We're
cycling through the deck as quickly as
we can, but it's not looking great.
We're running out of resource. running
out of time and we're really just not
able to get much going to tackle Ghost
Driver's onslaught of recruit tokens.
>> Just recruit after recruit. Victor
leading that glorious evolution.
Ghost of Driver having a think here as
we prepare to
end their turn. Does have two runes
still available.
>> Still can do something. It's whether
it's worthwhile. It's the candle sanctum
trigger, right? So, from the recruit
coming in, having a think about what
they want to put on the top on the
bottom. Second recruit goes into the
void gate, gets us up to four.
>> Taking those easy points.
>> The only bad thing here is you're giving
Dal some card draw potential.
>> Yes, but also Dal needs to accelerate
something out for that to be effective,
right? So,
>> oh,
I think that
>> it's a knock turn.
>> It was a knock off the top deck, which
is not what we want. We want to be
seeing that with the effect of a card.
So that was a shame. So we're just going
to discard that
>> hard bargain and a bushwack going to
hand. You can see
>> bushwack at least will help to
potentially get something accelerated
later into play or pseudo accelerated
but right now really unhelpful.
>> Yeah, we'll go for the cord shot.
Battering ram and stack deck off the
top. Battering ram is the one that goes
into hand. Then something that was
snuck. A very nice jacket being worn
here. Unfortunately covering up slightly
the cards that did go in. I think it was
a stack deck perhaps. Bushwack down. Now
>> this means that you can you draw and
then you can get the battering ram in,
win a combat, get another draw.
>> H sorry gold gear from the bushwack.
Then you can get the battering ram down.
Then you can get a draw from winning the
combat.
>> So at least then we do finally see
something coming kind of pseudo
accelerating.
first
>> Ferris battering ram and a cold shot.
>> Wouldn't be surprised if it's a second
ram here.
>> I think it would be
>> could also go for the cord shot just for
more card draw.
>> Cycling through the deck once again. I
think it's Yeah,
>> deciding to hold on to that second
battering ram in the main deck.
And here we go. Battering ram down. uh
played to base and then ready and
immediately gone into the candle
sanctum. We'll have the trigger from the
combat glorious execution of drawing us
a card.
>> Then we'll look at the top two.
>> Could have stacked those differently if
they had wanted.
>> Spinning axe and battering ram going for
the battering ram on the top. Putting
the spinning axe to the bottom. So we
don't have that option. Yeah, I think
that's one of those moments where you
you tell the players are a little bit
tired because to me optimally look at
the top two, organize how you want them,
then draw a card. But maybe
>> I mean, maybe drawing first and then
setting up a subsequent draw is slightly
better. I'm not sure on the statistics.
I'll trust Dal. They're 10 and two and I
am 02 cuz I wasn't dropped from the
tournament fast enough.
>> I heard a rumor that they paired us
round one.
>> Oh, really?
>> Yeah. But then so someone beat me round
one.
>> Someone two owed me round one because I
I wasn't there.
>> Yeah, but I wasn't there either.
>> Well, I I I I I've been shown medic 02.
>> So yeah.
>> Oh, there we go then. But here we go.
Moving on to Ghost Driver's turn.
>> Can they start to bring it back now that
Dal has a little bit of momentum?
>> It's still only a couple of points away
for Ghost Driver, right? sitting at five
right now
>> and they got a lot of removal in their
deck and they got a lot of runes ready
to go.
>> We have Bellow's Breath Imperial decree
>> in hand.
>> Exactly.
>> That's an easy wipe of Dal's side of the
board.
>> Hard bargain energy not available for
Dal right now.
>> No, Dal doesn't have any standing runes
either. So, we don't have any energy
left to be able to spend. Going over
with a thousand tail. Watcher
accelerated.
>> Yep. Straight into that battlefield.
I'm going to cycle the runes. The
battering ram loses out. Watcher candle
let sanctum trigger now go to six for
ghost to driver.
>> Ooh, this is such a scary position to be
in if you're dack
>> stupify and cull the weak the two off
the top in hand. Still two of those
decrees of bellow's breath and something
else.
>> Well, reckon we're going to be able to
take out that Ezreal with ease as well
this turn. Now
>> it's also do we really need to put them
both on the bottom?
Have one left, one rune left. It's a
wages a pain at the back. Could hide
that
>> if we wanted. Could also just make a
recruit and play for next turn.
>> So close to go to driver. Yeah, bring
the recruit back.
>> Play another one.
>> Leave the thousand tail watcher out.
>> Play a threat. Yeah,
>> pass it along. We're we're two points
away from the win.
>> You've got to expect they're going to
want to take both battlefields next
turn. kind of probably expecting the
thousand tail watcher to fall.
>> Mhm.
So,
Ezreal is there. We need to get through
the thousand tail watcher. We don't have
that bushwack, but we have a fizz that
can replay it. Cold shot first using the
seal.
>> Noturn.
>> Noturn revealed from the cord shot. Gold
used to play it.
>> Was that another one? Another one.
>> Two knockturns. But unfortunately
because we didn't fizz before this and
pull back the bushwack, they don't enter
ready.
>> No. So
>> obviously hard to think about that
sequence because you also want to look
at more cards before you make decisions
for your turn.
>> Exactly. And that's the really difficult
part about sequencing in Riftbound is
that the obvious, which is normally
always look at more cards, may not be
quite as advantageous. We still have a
few more tricks up our sleeve.
We have the last considered pushes
Ezreal to five
>> does mean we'll be able to
>> get a conquer
>> get a conquer up to three but is still
lagging very seriously behind Ghost
Driver.
>> I mean I think the the attempt now is to
try and make Voyate big enough in terms
of might of your units that Ghost Driver
can't take it back away from you. But
we're going to need to be able to put
some units in there. And right now, we
don't have any way of getting
anything else ready to go.
>> Well, we can uh we can play straight to
the battlefield, right? Cuz we control
it currently. So, a ferris 4runner could
go in there perhaps.
>> That would be a nice one.
>> Yeah.
>> What are we going to do, Dal?
>> Traveling merchant to base.
>> Okay.
no longer have the
energy for the first one. A battering
ram to base as well.
>> Okay.
>> No, no. Changing the mind.
>> Acceptable.
>> We changed the mind there on where we
go. Just making sure we played the five
cards for the turn to let that bannering
ram get out. So now Ghostaster driver
needs to get through two. Do they have
the runes for Imperial Decree and
Bellow's Breath? You need six energy and
two order and a mind.
>> We have it.
>> Hold to seven. We do have it. The
problem is do we have it with a hard
bargain repeated which is available?
>> That's the problem.
And we've left runes available.
So both players are very in the know
that that is a possibility. They haven't
seen the hands so they don't know it's
there for sure. But the threat is there.
And that's what it's about. There we are
>> debating what could happen.
>> Imperial decree.
>> When any unit takes damage this turn,
kill it
>> with a word. I end you.
>> The other problem is here. You can move
two recruits in, do damage to the ram,
do damage to the edge, and the third
recruit comes in as well. So ghost
driver just looking for this. Dal
thinking about that hard bargain. You
have to feel.
But even if you hard bargain repeated at
this point, you only have one energy
left to do anything else on this turn.
Imperial decree will leave the chain and
will have been played.
>> Ghost to driver. Do you just go in with
two to kick us off or do you try to
bellow's breath first? That's the debate
>> you have to feel.
>> I think you go in with the recruits I
think at this point. But
>> but Bellow's breath is the play.
>> Yep. I will target the Ram and the
Ezreal. Not repeated. There's the
bargain.
>> So that didn't quite work.
>> Was repeated. Ghost of Driver can't pay
four.
>> So Bellow's breath breath will not be
played,
but now you've got one rune up. Dackle,
what can you do with a single rune? A
wages a pain to try and take out one.
The handshake goes to driver
>> taking the 2 and 0
>> with Victor of all decks. We weren't
expecting that, but boy am I glad to see
Victor being victorious in our last
round of Swiss today.
>> Huge performance all around by Ghost
Driver. Really well done. Such patience
as well. I get the line using the
bellow's breath and the wages of pain
first because if you go in with the
units and they're bounced and they're
not ready then you have to wait another
turn. Really nice stuff all around from
Ghost of Driver. A bit unfortunate for
Dal I think at times just wasn't able to
keep up with the amount of kill the
amount of spells that Ghost of Driver
was able to bring out. They were just
absolutely on it with making sure that
those units and recruits were just
seamlessly dancing around the board and
just overwhelming Dal's defenses. But
let's talk more about all of their units
with the man themselves.
>> Hey, James here with Matias in between
rounds before we get to the top eight.
And I have to say congratulations. Not
only have you made top eight, you are
the best of Victor here in Bolognia. How
does that feel?
>> It feels amazing. It's unbelievable. I
went today stood up. I couldn't sleep
much at night. But I was like, I'm going
to lose to something. I'm going to face
the Dravens today and I'm going to lose
it. Um, so last match, Miracle Draven
was fine, but mid-range is likes the
worst. But I only got one and somehow
won two times with top decks. So, you
played Miracle Draven recently. Uh, what
else have you faced on your road to the
top eight? What's been tough for you so
far?
>> So, the awesome thing is I nearly faced
everything. I've faced three Dravens,
two of them mid-range, and I faced other
than that totally different legends. I
faced Owen, Ari, Aurelia,
um,
>> plenty, lots of different lots of
different legends.
>> Everyone played something else and it
was awesome. Maybe due to me tying the
first game, I got into the kind of off
bracket of Swiss wise and faced all
those matches and yeah, it's been a
blast.
>> Well, congratulations so far on your
performance. I wanted to ask a little of
your Victor. Uh, which version of the
deck are you playing?
>> So maybe you know the Houston list, but
got pretty far. So I think Grip Tide Rex
is a good card still and Kenso made the
deck better. since I was like the card
that makes me want to play Victor still.
And there are some improvements with
ages of pain. So it's kind of similar to
the Houston list if you know it. So it's
like 20 units, 20 spells. I'm playing
Raven Bloom and sometimes spraying. I'm
not playing the best deck, so I have to
hope sometimes. And it's working quite
well. You made top eight and that is the
important thing so far. So I'm going to
let you get ready for top eight. Uh
we'll leave it there and good luck in
your next round. Hopefully we'll see
hear more from you later today.
>> Thank you very much.
>> I feel
love
in your eyes shining through me like the
way so that we can see.
Feel the warmth of my love
shine.
Feel the light.
Welcome everyone to the top eight stage
of the regional qualifier here in
Bolognia for Riftbound. James Ori joined
by Leonard Kunig to take you to top
eight action. That feels so good to say.
For the first time here in Europe, we
have eight players determined as the
best of the weekend.
>> Yep. Four different legends in fact. So
quite the variety. Of course, the most
represented one is Raven, is it?
>> I would assume so. I think that is a
very good guess. We will take a look at
the bracket in just a couple of seconds
time. Uh as you said, a bunch of
different champions represented legends
here. Uh Draven, I believe we got a
misfortune in there. We got some Ezreals
in the mix. Of course, as we have seen
in the last feature match, there is also
the Victor Leader is chosen champion
unit for Herald of the Arcane Victor.
So, that deck is also very very
interesting. It hasn't had a lot of meta
share in the last few tournaments over
in China and also an online grassroots
tournaments. The deck was not
represented that well and that's a
breakthrough performance also for the
best off of course and that means we've
said goodbye to quite a few legends.
We've said goodbye to the likes of the
Aurelia and the Kaiser and the Ahri and
the Jinx and Annie. Those were a little
bit of a pick.
>> One Urelia. I was giving you wrong
information earlier.
>> Okay.
>> Sorry. I think there's one Aelia that is
still in the tournament,
>> but yeah, there's so many legends that
didn't make it top eight. I mean,
there's way more than eight, so that has
to be the case.
>> Yeah. Yeah. We'll uh we'll take a look
at the bracket as we get through. Not a
surprise to see Draven being quite so
popular. I think it does feel though
like the Ezreal that we saw from Allan
has really really put a cat amongst the
pigeons proverbally with a very
different play style of games. I mean it
is the card that you predicted to be so
good in this meta. Nobody found a way to
utilize it before but now we are seeing
the Vex Ezreal build that was so strong.
We've seen a matchup of Alenzq versus
Marcus Patel. You imagine that might as
well still happen in this tournament
because both of those rift pounders made
it to top eight of the regional
qualifier and that was a stomp. Let's
take a look at the bracket. Let us get a
real clear picture on where we are in
the tournament. So it is Ezreal,
Misfortune, Draven, Aurelia, Draven,
Victor, Draven and Ezreal. So uh
>> five different legends.
>> Yeah, quite a lot of uh of spread here.
So, no mirror matchups by the looks of
things to begin our top eight. Uh, some
very familiar names here. Of course,
Alan ZQ, uh, one of the the players
we've been watching throughout the the
day. We've obviously got Prismaticism,
who people are very familiar with from
Riftbound in the past. Sebie and Crows
have both played on stream over the last
couple of days for the top half of the
bracket. So, we know everybody up there.
And Randy, very familiar people on
stream. I'm pretty sure we saw Ghost
Driver as well. Marcus.
>> Yeah. Wow. We've we've basically seen
everything. But I am sure that this is I
think just the standing after top eight.
So these are the top eight. But this
should not be the bracket if I'm
completely mistake. If I'm not
completely mistaken.
>> Oh, cuz it's one versus eight. Uh so
yeah. Okay. We we may very well have a
slight update to that uh in our
matchups. I I believe you are correct.
We'll get clarification on that because
uh it's important with seeding going
into a bracket stage. Of course, the
higher you are, the better your seating.
Uh and a very important clarification
happened uh with the competitive rule
set just to make sure that everyone is
on uh the the page coming into this
event. If you have a higher seed, you
get selection in game one of whether you
play first or second. So no more dice
rolls, no nothing like that. It's like
higher seed gets to pick in that match.
>> And I'm very curious to see what's it
going to be on the side of Alan ZQ, for
example, because the Ezreal deck doesn't
play too many two drops, right? You
don't really need it. We've seen
Ezreal's pass all weekend long.
>> Are you saying if you're going second,
you go second?
>> But then you could also on your second
turn play a Vex.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm a I'm a going second
hater. Just I it it betrays everything
in my being to go second as uh you know
from from games I've played in the past
that that is typically not the the
favorite thing. I understand there are
there are situations where people feel
like it is it is fair. Um we will indeed
take a look at that as we get closer. We
will be keeping an eye as on as much of
the top eight as we can and um there has
been a lot this weekend of interesting
stuff. We of course that means are still
determining a bunch of the best of cards
but a lot of them have been given away
on the uh the champions we were talking
about have not made it to the top eight.
So congratulations to any best of
winners from the event. We know that
there's a best of Victor still in the
top eight. Uh two players fighting for
the Ezreal best of as well.
>> Definitely. And some players like Crowns
who was playing Urelia earlier on the
stream versus Specimen. He got of course
the best of Urelia. Funnily enough,
Specimen got the best of Teemo. So that
was a match, we didn't know it back
then, of two best offers.
>> Yeah, sometimes you just don't know the
significance until until it's happened,
but that is indeed the case. Um, it's
been such an interesting weekend so far.
But we do have just a couple of moments
as the players are getting ready uh
ready for everything to do with the top
eight. Um such an interesting weekend in
the sense of I feel like we've seen a
lot of matchups in the higher tables
with legends. We weren't expecting like
our Rumble game that we saw yesterday. I
was not expecting Rumble to really
swiftly enter day two with a really good
set of results. Yeah, the deck looked
like a enhanced version of the mid-range
Kaiser we have seen so much of in
Origins. You had these big tempo plays
with the Darius, but you also had this
nice mech engine and this passive legend
ability of Rumble that all of your mechs
have defender and that goes so well
together with the Ferris 4runner because
if that one dies as a defender with
seven, if that one dies, you get two
mechs. Those are four defenders. So, you
get even more value out of that card.
That makes Ferris 4Runner, which is
already a basically 12 might card, a 15
might card. And that really helps with
your tempo and developing your board
state.
>> So it it as always is a good indicator
that, you know, if you want to be like a
local hero, run your favorite deck and
just grind it until you've got all of
the matchups down in your head.
>> You can go from Nexus Knights into your
summoner skirmish, maybe get that buy at
a at a regional qualifier and and maybe
put up some results yourself. We've seen
a lot of fun stuff. saw some Ranata
Glask yesterday as well, which I I I got
to admit I wasn't necessarily expecting
the top tables either, but we've seen
some interesting round uh no like rounds
play out with the Ronald Glass scoring
mechanisms. You know, I I wasn't the
biggest fan of the deck before that, but
now I'm really intrigued to give it a
shot just because you can generate so
much gold and then cheese out some nice
time warp turns there. There are turns
in which you if your opponent leaves up
open some battlefields, you can just
jump from from three to eight in one
turn and that is just absolutely
fabulous.
>> And then accounting for like time war.
We saw the echo uh attempt at a play. So
So really interesting deck construction
on that one. I'm trying to think of um
you know I I do feel a little
vindicated.
>> I didn't say Vex was going to be played
in this tournament, but it just is my
play style. So I coming into Spirit
Forge was like this card I I love it but
nobody seems to rate it yet and I will
just jam it in decks. So seeing Allan
play like multiple copies
>> is is music to my ears. I think the
success of Vex is based on multiple
factors. First of all best off cards.
There is not everyone on Draven because
Draven as we have seen earlier can
really struggle with Vex but has some
tools. Some people play the long sword
which is not affected by Vex, but you
also have these spinning axes, you know,
and they are not affected by Vex. In all
other matchups, there are so many combat
tricks that are being used that are
spells that you don't want to use them
versus Vex, but also against the Draven,
this deck, this card is really good
because you're just making your own
spells cheaper. Your rebuke all of a
sudden is not as painful anymore. And I
think there's there's just multiple
factors. Some matchups I think that
Ezreal otherwise struggles with. You are
destroying with Vex. Urelia has one
unit.
>> You You push it, you have your five,
six.
>> You try and play a bunch of spells. You
can't. You haven't got you haven't got
the the runes available for it. Vex is a
card that you really need to know the
exact text on the entirety of the card.
And there is a lot on it.
>> And now I know they're going to test us
with how well do we read the cards. Uh
as as we still prepare for top eight, we
got a moment where they're going to ask
us to guess the flavor text. We all have
a place among the divine. We have only
to accept it. Um,
okay. I will say I normally do stop
reading cards after the rules text. So,
I think I'm going to be particularly bad
at this one if it's not a champion quot.
>> You know, I would say same, but most of
the time in my career as a trading card
game player, I've realized that I most
of the time stop halfway through the
card and then
>> you don't even finish the rules text.
>> Yeah, I reading weirdly. So obviously
divine is like a key word. It's pushing
me in the way of like
>> something to do with divine judgment,
but probably not on that card.
>> Yeah, there is a card that is an
absolute removal, right?
>> I think it is mind.
>> Okay.
>> Seven energy.
>> Just kill everything.
>> Okay. Which one is that though?
>> It doesn't see a lot of play. That's
what I'll tell you.
>> Yeah, I don't even know the name.
Actually, it's it find it found it way
to some sideexc, but I'm just really
blanking on the name. So, it's it's the
this it's a full art card that is very
yellow.
>> Okay. Are we going to see a full art
card that is very yellow? I'm just going
to leave it at that because I have no no
real guess for this. Oh, it was Carus.
Okay. Okay. So, this isn't about the
flavor text. I I understand now the the
flavor of this text. Um Carus, I think,
is a card that is like one or two
mechanics in like a new set away from
being absolutely broken. Like once we
see a card that has like a death nail
effect that is like unbelievably
exploitable, Carus is going to like
skyrocket. We've seen it pretty much
anytime you do a duplicate effect uh
with mechanics like it feels pretty
good.
>> It it can be really strong. Actually
immediately going into the next one.
>> They called my crew scurvy dogs and I
took that personally.
>> Is that something fortune buccaneer or
something like that where it's something
build water? I'm like, it's something a
captain.
Yeah, I'm like, it's not gangplank cuz
that's not in the game yet. For League
of Legends players, you'll know what
we're doing. Um, yeah, it's a buildwater
card. Um, it won't be Riptide Rex
because I feel like Riptide Rex is not
too chatty. You know, this is a
>> You haven't had a conversation with him?
>> Yeah, I tried. It didn't go really well,
but
>> he just hit you really hard is what
happened. He showed up.
>> I just got shot with the cannon barges,
but I think uh I think you're on to
something with the misfortune bucket.
Want to lock that in? Uh, I'll lock it
in, but I think it's a bad guess. Chat
probably have it already.
>> What are we gonna see?
>> I'm quite curious.
>> Oh, brazen Buccaneer. I got the
buccaneer bit. I got I'll take that. You
know, close enough. Um,
>> okay. Makes sense. Again, not another
card that we see too too much. But you
can of course like that discard a card.
Yeah.
>> Even then, I'm like four four five is
it's not bad, but as a vanilla card,
>> that is true. But I mean in something
like uh decks that want to be mighty
like for example Volibear this can be
quite good poisonous but I didn't know
that at the time you see.
>> Okay okay okay okay
>> okay.
>> My first thought was Teemo but it's not.
I'm guessing that's more like a singed
type of line something chemac.
>> Mhm. So I do not know enough about the
lore of Renata Glusk.
>> Oh. Oh yeah. Me too. I'm sorry to say
League of Legends players Renata is like
a blind spot for me. She seems
>> could be
>> no judgment like the type of person to
accidentally poison someone.
>> Uh sweeping statements.
>> So I am going to go with Renata glass.
>> And that is the genius one.
>> Ooh. Okay.
>> Or
>> are you going to get it? If you get
this, you get the Renata Glass.
>> Is that a genius or a synonym?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> No, no, you don't. I don't have that
power. I do not have that power to to
give. What do we got?
>> Give me Ratata Glask. Come on, please.
something.
>> Oh, give me huh?
>> Oh, lecturing your That is a card I've
seen so much. I've literally never read
I stop at draw a card and I'm good. I
forget this card has tank so many times.
I have never read it like to the bottom.
>> Okay, you know what? I I want
vindication. I want one more. Can we get
Can we get one more?
>> I've been Okay. I I was about to say
I've been told we can't, but we can get
one more. Uh you you want to prove
yourself by getting at least one more? I
mean, we have nothing to lose. can go 03
and then give up a good we can also go
04 with a small 2% chance of going 1
three.
>> We're in the losers bracket at this
point.
>> Absolutely. Just a reminder, we are we
are getting things ready for the top
eight on stage. So it we're not doing
this out of choice. I promise you we're
not uh keeping you here.
>> Okay.
>> Is it a master y card? You think
>> is this a bait?
>> A true master is an eternal student.
Master Y is the Is the word student the
key here?
>> Production. Are you messing with us?
>> Is this They're saying it's correct.
They're saying it's correct. So clearly
this is on the card.
>> But I mean I I don't think it would say
Master Yi.
>> It may.
>> If it was on Master Yi. So maybe on
Highlander.
>> M. Maybe. Uh I I'm I'm stuck on is
student still a key? I'm not cheating
and bringing up chat. Otherwise, I I I'm
really tempted because I know chat, I
know you know. I know you know it. The
collective knowledge in chat is always
omnipotent. Um I'm terrible at this, so
I'm I'm sorry.
>> I'm saying it is the master Yi signature
spell and you're going to see it in
three, two, maybe a little bit more. I'm
putting a lot of pressure on production
right now. Four, three, two, one.
>> No sage.
>> It's a bird.
>> Yeah. Okay. Well,
checks out. Checks out.
>> I I figured I mean that would have been
I second guessed the Zephr Sage.
>> The the ever present in the meta Zepha
Sage.
>> Of course. Yeah. And I mean this I am
going to I have learned my lesson guys.
I will read all of the flavor text on
the cards and I will memorize it
>> for next like future events. You're
going to be like I I know only the
flavor text. I haven't studied the meta.
I don't know the cards but the flavor
text nailed it. If I am ever going to be
invited back to those events, I will
only read flavor text before that. But
of course, we're we're some meta heads,
right? We do like our riftbound
strategies and we have some favorite
cards that we have been looking forward
to seeing before this tournament. And
there it is, your Vex.
>> You know what? I'm I'm going to take the
win on this one. I'm going to take the
win. Vex and Fizz being present in at
least the undefeated Swiss deck. I will
uh appreciate that that apparently other
people appreciate my my style of playing
too. I will say I would not have been
able to pilot it to the level that Alan
has. I think I'd cast like one spell and
be done and be like well that's my
benefit that's that. But me on the other
hand I went for a more old school also
Ezreal approach pit crew and cull and
that has been a combination in the best
of Teemo.
>> Yes. So, I'm taking
those Ezreal decks, this combo.
And I think that also has something to
do with the good old dropping of Draven
because of the best of chase on Amy's
side.
>> It's Jay,
but I want it to work.
>> I talked to our best of Victor.
>> I asked him why he went for the zoo
version, quote unquote, of Victor, and
he said, "I'm not a believer of Jayce
and Vanguard Armory."
>> I am. Uh, anytime you can uh cheat out
uh a big part of a mid game or end game,
I I think it's very effective.
Somebody's going to make Jace work. I
know a couple of decks are are trying to
trying to jam it. We'll see if that
comes to fruition in future events. And
then um I know that medic revealed to
the world was uh fortunate to be able to
do that. So going on brand, uh I am a
little bit surprised we didn't see more
or with the with the spell up. I I do
think there's something there, but I
think it's one of those ones where we've
seen a lot of like either single target
removal like rebuke, that type of thing
where you can just play through the
deflect and it doesn't really matter
like when you have Rex size that are
running like cold a weak uh and a bunch
of decks that are running cold a week,
victors, runa glass, that type of thing.
I mean there's a lot of ways to deal
with it. You're playing calm runes so
there is some counter spells that you
can have to protect your on but we have
seen on multiple times on stream
utilized in other strategies. So we have
seen a very cool team that had a black
market broker almost infinite combo.
Well also takes infinite turns right to
make your own better with infinite gold
tokens. Now as to some meta card
predictions as well.
>> I've had the feeling that Ezreal Prodigy
was going to be good.
>> Oh yeah, absolutely.
What gave it away? The fact that
everybody was like I putting Ezreal in
my deck.
>> Definitely. Guardian Angel. Of course, I
think the sole reason why Aurelia is so
high up in the meta is Guardian Angel.
Without this card, the deck would not
exist like it does right now.
>> Yeah. And you see Aelia there as one of
Amy's picks alongside Draven. I mean,
these two have been uh rampant all in
the like the player area. The tables
were full of Dravens and Aurelia all
weekend. So, the fact that Aurelia only
has one deck represented in the the the
top cut going to top eight, I think is
um you know, not quite what I expected.
I would have thought maybe two or three,
but still uh having some presence,
>> it feels surprising, but then again, if
you consider how little people eight out
of 1,800 are approximately, then
considering how big of a share three
decks from eight would be when Draven
>> really is the most dominant deck and
Urelia was I think the third most played
deck only. I think it was still Kai'Sa
ahead of it.
>> Then uh some cards we did see a lot so
far this weekend. Ferris 4runner. I
think we talked about Ferris 4runner
pretty much to death. So then it's going
to spawn two mechs uh once we're done
talking about it and treasure hunter.
One that kind of sneaks through the
early game. We don't talk about it all
that much because it's like hey well
I'll just play a treasure hunter and
I'll move and I'll do things. But that
passive like I just get more economy the
for the early turns really allows you to
stay in the game uh with your runes
intact as you go for forward especially
in these these mid-range Draven decks we
have seen that in the match up of Alan
ZQ versus Marcus Patel Marcus Patel in
the matchup with Rever's row started
with a treasure hunter pushed it in
there gold token reaver's row push it
back gold token push it into the other
battlefield triple gold token was not
enough to beat this incredibly well
build deck by Alan ZQ, but it still put
up a lot of pressure and resources.
>> That was a previous match for Alan ZQ.
Let's take a look at Alen ZQ's uh
bracket to well, I say Alan ZQ's
bracket, that's actually not the case.
It's a top eight bracket. And I was
going to say who Alan ZQ will be facing
in the bracket as we do have an updated
version of that for you to look at our
matchups. I believe this should now
show. Yes, Alan ZQ facing up against
another Ezreal in the Manaland.
We have very rarely seen mirror matches
this weekend. Of course, I mean on the
tables there were plenty of Draven
mirror matches, plenty of every mirror
match, but it's going to be quite
exciting to see this perhaps on stream.
Then we of course have crows on the
Aurelia Blade Dancer versus Randy. This
is also such a stacked match already.
It's three Dravens still competing for
that best off cut. Well, Misfortune from
Zeic
>> Mhm.
>> has already gotten it. And then of
course also the Victor.
>> Yeah. here going up against Marcus is
Sebby and then prismaticism going up
against Ghost Driver Draven versus
Victor. So we heard from Ghost Driver
earlier uh just you know he's kind of
faced everything
in yesterday and today just I've faced a
whole load of different legends and I I
I kind of felt confident into most of
them. So I I'm excited to see that match
up potentially how that turns out
between Prismaticism and Ghost Driver
later. I believe we may be focusing in
on Sebie and Marcus as our first feature
matchup. Um, and if that is the case, I
think Misfortune is one that people I I
think it's fair to say were not
expecting to see at this point in the
tournament. I think if there was going
to be uh a calm and body, sorry, chaos
and body uh uh champion, it would be
civet instead of the misfortune like
that. the the new fresh take on Aurora
where you get, you know, access to the
same good cards but potentially a better
uh champion from the chosen champion
zone.
>> Yeah. And I mean you get more access to
gold easily.
>> Yeah. The legend ability is a big
difference.
>> Yeah. You have a little bit of better
rune management. However, you can argue
that when you are playing a Aurora deck,
>> your rune management is not that
important after you played Aurora.
>> You just count to nine and then you're
like good.
>> Yeah. Take my hands off the wheel. We're
good. Exactly. If your opponent does not
have the hard answer to the Aurora
immediately and you need to get back to
the next one, I mean, you're going to be
able to play it back to back anyways if
you have multiple, but I think you're
just chilling from that point on.
>> Yeah, I think that's fair. I am nowhere
near the same level that these players
are playing. I played a couple games of
Aurora over the weekend while we've been
here in Bolognia. Uh, it definitely
feels like you're kind of on a knife's
edge right up until that point where you
hit an Aurora and now you just cross
your fingers, hope there's no gear
removal on the other side of the
opponent's turn. And if you get more
than one turn, you're like, "Cool,
nailed it. Got it."
>> That is a lot of tempo. You're getting
basically cheating out two units. And
the cool thing is that your opponent
kind of has to either have multiple
copies of gear removal or has to top
deck into it, right? Because most of the
time these Aurora decks, they're playing
triple copies of mind spplitter while
also having
>> some other units but very little. So
it's either extremely rewarding like a
dead blur and predator and you can
immediately go into a combat with a
deflect unit in the at the end of your
turn or you get this huge volar furious
that can draw you a bunch of cards or
you find your mind spplitter to make
sure that your dazzling aurora is going
to find another card and live another
day.
>> Yeah. And and I I feel like coming into
Spirit Forge, people looked at the
Aurora deck and said, "Well, they don't
really get too many tools, like too many
additional things." It was like Kaisen
and Aurora, maybe there's not that much
in Spirit Forge for them, so maybe it'll
fall off and there's more gear removal
and but I think it's kind of stabilized
at the point where you can kind of
>> depending on which list you're playing.
Some people have been playing things
like last rights to be able to bring
back units once they're gone, which
means you can actually trim the number
of units you play in your deck cuz
Aurora is just to get the first few out.
Uh and then you can just play around it.
Um, it is still obviously dependent on
what is what is left in the deck and
what is left in the in the uh in in the
trash, but it has been interesting to
see how the tools have adapted going
into a second set of cards.
>> Exactly. Even if your opponent removes
your cards, you have the last rights to
get those cards back, especially also
when you're holding and conquering. So,
there's there's so many options to get
your mind splitter back. However, the
argument again that there is a lot of
gear removal right now does not really
work out too well because you have to
side a lot of gear removal into the
Aurora deck because again mine spplitter
is going to snipe it from hand. So
either you have to or you're top decking
into it otherwise you're probably not
going to get rid of the dazzling Aurora
>> and sabotage as well is there just in a
lot of main boards as well. Some people
play a sideboard, some people play a
main board. Oh, we'll we will dive into
the intricacies of Aurora and how that
plays out when we get into our feature
match, which is very very very very
close. I do promise it is on the way.
But while we've got a moment left, if
you have any thoughts to share about
your experience, if you were here at the
venue in Bolognia or if you've been
watching the stream, hello. Thank you
very much for joining us all weekend.
You can get involved on social media.
use the hashtag RQ Bolognia, which uh if
you spell it the way I pronounce it is,
you're probably going to get it wrong,
but uh
>> no, I think you you'll be able to find
it there on social media. It'll all be
good as we are getting very close. So
close, in fact, I can tell you we can
start the top eight here for Riftbound
regional qualifier in Bolognia. We're
going into game one of this best of
three. A reminder, these are now untimed
rounds. So, we're here until we have a
winner
>> indeed. And it is going in. We're going
to choose our battlefields
have revealed the legends already. Not
that they were questioning who they were
playing against, what they were playing
against. At this point of the day,
everyone knows what everyone else is
playing. And you can see this hard ram
triple mobilized, triple catalyst of AON
to just turbo out this dazzling Aurora.
You have the sabotage, not three, you
have challenge, which also of course
helps you and invert timelines.
>> Yeah, I like an invert timelines. Uh I
will say as well, two copies of
Volibear, uh which is I've seen a lot of
lists running one uh Volibear imposing
uh great if it comes out from Aurora
feels bad if you have it in hand at any
point. like the the couple games I
played sometimes it would be like okay I
check my mulligan hand I send two to the
bottom off the top comes a volar and I'm
like well that's not getting played ever
because of the damp after dazzling
aurora yeah exactly imagine two whereas
on the other side we have Marcus we did
see this list earlier today where we
have that good mix of Draven that we've
come to expect the various forrunners
spinning axes you got the edge of knight
in there and now just look at all of
those different combat tricks all of
those cards you have to play around
versus Draven when two runes are up.
Tight turner, hard bargain, edge of
knight, hidden, switcheroo, and rebuke
and fight or flight. All of those cards
are interactions. Don't forget the
spinning ax, the probably best card for
Draven. All of those cards have to be
taken into account by your opponent when
you have just two runes up, which is why
Targon's Peak is probably in the deck of
Marus Patel. I don't know that this is
100% the case, but Sebie, I would say
game one is probably the going to be
that easiest moment. And that this is
something I am sure on. Game one will be
the easiest one for dodging hand attack
because there's only one mind spplitter
in Marcus' list. So that means Aurora
basically unless Marcus, you know, gets
to a point where there's no Aurora
online, and this is where choosing to
play first or second is going to be a
big factor, Sebie should be able to get
the Aurora down with a very short window
on uh what Marcus has availability for
that mine spplitter. So we're off to the
races. Going to start things off with
some draw. Catalyst is what you want to
see, but also I think there was an
Aurora in that three cards, which would
tell me that Sebie probably has one in
hand. Uh, want to ramp up into it, but
putting one to the bottom means you're
not going to see it. Yeah. Okay, there
is one in there. Good. That is uh
I'm glad to see that from my from Sebie
because otherwise I'm like, you you need
that. You don't put this on the bottom
of the deck. What are you doing? No, we
are set up also with the catalyst of
Aon. So, that's a pretty good start. Of
course, in an ideal world, you will also
find the mobilize before you stack deck.
>> So, there's also a little bit of passive
pressure on the board here as well. I
know we touched on battlefields a little
coming into this. Sigil of the storm
does slow down your opponent. Double
catalyst is nice to see if you're the
Aurora player. That is Draven probably
not going to be so happy to to see that,
but Sigil of the Storm stops people from
kind of scoring both battlefields very
frequently. So it it passively stops the
attack that Draven wants to do early.
>> Goes into the reverse row with the
overzealous f just for some easy points.
I think the the good thing about sigil
of the storm is usually in a back and
forth game for example with an Ezreal.
Sometimes Ezreals play at the sigil of
the storm.
>> They remove your units when you conquer
the sigil of the storm. So you're locked
in on one battlefield for almost the
entirety of the game. You can't afford
to conquer it. But versus the Aurora
deck, you can just place a unit in there
and then chill.
>> Now, with perfect information, we know
there's no mind spplitter for Marcus.
Obviously, Sebie does not know that at
this point. So, it means that as long as
the top card of Marcus' deck is not a
mind spplitter, the first Aurora will
resolve. But Marcus, if a mind spplitter
comes off the top, this is going to be a
pivotal moment early on in our top
eight.
First third turn Aurora or fourth turn
Aurora rather.
>> Marcus is now going up to seven. Is he
going to find a mind splitter? Is only
playing one. That kind of looked like
one.
>> It did look like one.
>> We are so close to the Aurora turn.
Draven is going to the sigil of the
storm. You have to float one of your
runes before and then you can put it
back onto
>> I am I'm waiting with baited breath.
I keep getting tiny flicks through the
hand
>> that I mean if your opponent is at this
much Oh no, we're going to play a Darius
here. So we're preparing for a big push
as well. The thing is if your opponent
only plays
>> a dazzling Aurora doesn't find a bad
dead bloom predator, which I'm not
really even sure we saw in that deck
list.
>> Uh no, I didn't see any in the list. It
was mine spplitters and the volars were
the primary. I will say keep in mind
just resolving a dazzling Aurora getting
it onto the battlefield does not win you
the game immediately. There's a bunch of
points on the site of Marcus good
potential to hold next turn and go up to
five. There's no aspirin climb in the
game. So you are almost there then.
>> Yeah, I think that's fair. has been so
so focused on like this first Aurora
which does take a few turns off in the
early game and then and then it just
allows Draven to do the Draven thing of
like cool I'll play efficient units on
curve and I'll I'll basically just
conquer battlefields and I'm okay
recycling a little bit.
>> Now we're going to see some big
information here. Sabotage Catalyst of
Aons last rides fight of flight. And I
think this is already the point where
you start taking some notes. See so many
cards until the first unit is revealed.
Of course, when you're looking closely
at your opponent's deck, you know which
cards they can or cannot have in hand.
That's something to really keep in mind
sometimes. Now, of course, other
information is going to be exchanged. Q
is going to see this hand that Marcus
Patel offers him here over zealous fan a
treasure hunter a spinning ax and I
think it is a hard bargain
so that is actually not the strongest
hand when you're thinking about going
into a heavy mid game here but
this turn also did not get a lot of
tempo going for him right because he
played he played nine energy to power
cost just to play a mind spplitter
basically I mean the mind splitter was
for three and it's going to accelerate
theoretically, not the keyword
accelerate, but it's going to accelerate
in the means of next turns there's going
to be many more big guys coming along.
>> That's one way of dealing with a
spinning ax is taking it out of hand
with the mine spplitter. And you know,
you you're so right about now the the
turn that Draven is going to be able to
have does put pressure on it. It now
looks to what can Sebby do in response.
That is a big card in this matchup. Uh,
switcheroo off the top from Marcus.
Again, the the thing about playing big
units is if uh we just say, "Yeah, I'll
take your might. I'll I'll take that.
That that sounds great." Uh, ooh, an
overzealous fan. I'll trade that. I was
going to trade it anyway. I mean,
overzealous fan is actually also still
really strong in that match up because
it just pushes your opponent's unit back
and you don't have that many.
>> Yeah, exactly. You're just like, "Okay,
I'll just keep my timer ticking."
>> Yeah.
Also, there is still the Darius in the
back. I think you keep those you take
those easy points when you can.
>> I think is this the moment where you
immediately push in the overzealous fan?
No, what you can do is also push in the
Darius, then play two cards, ready it
again, and then push it back to base
just so you can secure your units.
>> Also on Reavers, so we'll have that
defender trigger if uh if needed on a
further one. And he this is the combo
when it comes to two cards from the set
that I think is synonymous. And now
we've moved it away. It's still fine
with Nois Hope. I was going to say
overzealous fan on a battlefield with a
unit. Normally Draven means you just get
so much value of just, yeah, I'll push
you back from combat. Oh, I want a
combat. I'll I'll draw a card. I'll
create a gold. So good.
>> Sounds good.
>> Now we're also hiding another card. That
could be the possible switcheroo. So
Marcus is already at five points. Of
course, now it is going to be the tough
play. Oh, picking up a Volibear. That is
not what you want to see as your top
deck. I think SeekQu is missing some
cards like challenge that are going to
really push you forward, help you push
through those BS, especially with this
Darius goes for a cold shot here. Now
that you have already used the dazzling
Aurora, you have it in play. It's not
going anywhere. I think you can just
freely ramp away all of your runes. You
do not even care. Keep in mind when your
runes are gone, they are kind of really
gone because you're not playing Civer.
You're playing Misfortune.
>> You're not getting them in exchange. So,
uh, I do have a follow-up that there are
no dead bloom predators. I had that
confirmed, uh, in the lineup. Oh, and
there's a Volibear in hand. We talked
about how awkward that can be
>> as we go potentially
potentially towards a Aurora. And
there's a card that I saw in the list.
The bullet time has been taken. That is
one way of of kind of cutting in front
of things
>> like whether it's an overzealous fan
take it out potentially. Um
>> although it is action speed so it's not
reaction so you uh wouldn't be able to
do that before the trigger. It is more
just to clear out a battlefield.
>> Thing is bullet time it's a I want to
say last resort card.
>> Sure cuz you're you're going to spend so
much to do it. I mean, there's some
situation when you're playing versus
something like Victor and there's 10
recruit tokens. You're absolutely fine
just recycling one rune.
>> Challenge.
>> We're going to go for a challenge here
>> on the Darius as well. So, there will
just end up
>> I mean, you know, most of the cards in
hand of Marcus Patel.
>> That wasn't too much.
>> Yeah, just a visual thing here. The
spinning ax is also in the trash. So, we
currently have two trash piles with a
Darius at the top and a spinning X at
the bottom. Um
>> hopefully we can
>> I mean this this time around it's fine
but basically life.
>> Yeah, exactly. I was going to say it is
fine but uh from from a visual point it
is a little different. So there is the
bullet time to to damp
>> for kill the overzealous fan. I'm there
was where the tap was going. Of course
it will do it to all enemy units at a
battlefield.
>> But I think Oh, are we going all
>> going to be enough? Yeah. Four. So this
is the I'm going all in moment.
>> Yeah, you I mean your opponent is at
five already. Switcheroo is also getting
killed. We take three and if we want to
take the sigil of the storm battlefield,
then we would ramp Drap another one,
recycle another rune, but I cannot
imagine that is going to be the case as
Reaver's row is open.
>> Yeah, an important note on Switcheroo uh
for people that perhaps haven't played
around a lot, it does have to be at the
same location. Um so could not have
sorry same battlefield specifically.
>> Oh I am quite curious if something
>> was a little bit of a misplay here from
SEQ because he can't play the mind
splitter currently as there was not
enough chaos runes. Now he can again if
he wants to develop that mind spplitter
>> put away too many chaos runes
>> and now found another one again. There
is now exactly seven energy open. So you
could develop another mind splitter, but
that would leave you with absolutely
nothing except for the dazzling Aurora
and perhaps a Volibar furious that you
might pick up in the end there into
the reverse row.
>> So end of turn we have to do Oh well as
why pay for it when you can get it for
free.
>> Yeah, that's absolutely great. You see
hard bargain and the treasure hunter. I
mean, it's now immediately after this
dazzling Aurora got played. It was rapid
so fast that Marcus Pel just got starved
out of resources. Only has a two drop in
hand. Really needs to find more cards.
The upside of these Aurora decks is
there is not a lot of combating against
the Draven deck. The Draven deck is
completely starved out.
>> Picks up another card. Now thinks what
can you do with this? You can go into
the sigil of the storm. You will have to
forfeit one of your runes. You have to
recycle it. But uh I mean at this point
you have one card in hand, two cards in
hand, treasure hunter, the other card is
still not revealed. What is it going to
be?
>> That's a drop.
>> Knox is hopeful. One thing I think that
that we've talked a little bit about
Civer and Misfortune and the
differences. One thing that will be a
benefit at some point in this game for
Sebie is the legend ability for
Misfortune. The ability to exhaust in
order to give a unit ganking. uh
suddenly turns this from two minds
spplitters that have to take two turns
to get around the battlefields to just
okay well one of them can go over there
that's fine of course you have to play
around things like overzealous fan fight
orfly rebukes
>> gust is going to come through on the fan
is this the moment where we go ganking
>> this might be the moment where you see a
handshake soon but of course this is
untimed
>> from from six points to two is has have
we turned that corner already is that is
that the case
>> I I could see I can see it too, but
we're in top eight, right? So, do you
play to your outs?
>> Exactly. It
>> It makes really no sense to just forfeit
that game. Quite curious if Seic has
picked up all of the units in his deck
in his hand already. That kind of looks
like
>> Well, there's another Volibear. I think
there's one in hand, right?
>> There's two Volibear and one minds. So,
I think we're going through the entire
deck.
>> Oh, wow. That is unfortunate draws and
that could turn the game around actually
>> to be pedantic
because you're not shuffling. We are
seeing the exact order of cards
>> left in Sebie. Yeah, okay. You were
correct. And now Marcus gets Oh,
>> that does that happen actually when you
play Dazzling Aurora?
>> Maybe there's a ruling for that. I have
never seen a player shuffle in
Riftbound. That is that is completely
new to me except for of course the first
turn.
Maybe there is a ruling for that. We're
got to see if this was correct or not.
We're going to
>> Yeah, I I'm just going to continue on.
We do have the the players on the
spotters. I'm going to assume I'm going
to give them benefit of that at that
point. It's not something I've run into
myself specifically,
>> but as fan gets played.
>> Oh, I I really like what Marcus is doing
now. There's also a complete change of
posture because he realized, okay, my
opponent, I know exactly what cards
there are on hand. There has to be at
least one volibear if you do not know
the exact deckless and there has to be a
mind splitter.
>> Oh yeah, of course. When cuz you're
recycling things,
the the shuffle comes through. So now we
have to just wait till uh you can play
the volley bar out.
So
>> I mean playing the volley out that's
going to take a few turns because we
have bullet timed before.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You dramped yourself.
>> Yeah.
And now Sevie Q is quite curious. Very
unlucky on the draws there. This is
really not what you want to have from
your dazzling Aurora just to hit two
units and then be gone.
>> I guess that is also part of it, right,
of of why you're playing uh the last
rights is because there's a part of the
equip cost. You can recycle back into
the deck the units that are in the trash
already.
>> That is true. But there's nothing in the
trash.
>> Oh yeah, they're in the hand. They're on
the battlefield and and and yeah, you
are so right. This is such an awkward
spot to be in. Um,
>> pass only playing on two minds splitters
here. You do not have there's no cards
in hand for Marcus. So, it doesn't even
feel good to play a mind splitter from
hand because it actually recycles two
runes just to be a vanilla. It's going
to take at least 20 turns.
>> So, we're not even looking through the
deck at this point. Uh oh. No, we're
going to reveal it.
>> All right. So, the cards are going to be
shown again. That looks just to make
sure. So, I guess it if you're paying
attention,
>> if you know the top deck, every single
turn,
>> you know every single turn what your
opponent has been drawing. If you have
the time to look through this and
understand,
>> we could be here a while.
>> I think Marcus is now just checking the
deck.
>> Yeah,
>> of course, this is information that
you're legally allowed to have.
>> Yeah, every card has been revealed. And
then, of course, because there's a
recycle mechanism, it will uh result in
it being randomized. As you said, it is
it is diff it's very weird to see the
shuffle happening.
>> I'm so not used to it.
>> It's crazy. This is absolutely crazy.
And I think this is exactly what Marcus
is saying right now, too. This is uh
something that I've experienced a lot
before. But now, all of those runes are
still open. Holding two for now is at
five. So theoretically, Marcus could
have another turn of chill in a little
bit, but I don't think that you want to
necessarily let it get there. Do it. It
really comes down to the cards that
you're drawing here.
>> Yeah. I I I feel like I jinx Sebie by
being like, you know what's bad when
you're playing Aurora? Drawing your
Volibear. And you were like, drawing
both is really bad. Uh and unfortunately
>> dead bloom predator instead of the
second polyar that unit would be
absolutely uh
>> there's other things as as we're
actually getting into some action on the
game as overzealous fan Kaiser and Nox
is hopeful and a Draven are all going in
on that one mind spplitter.
>> Okay,
>> damping.
Oh, there's the scoop. Just going to
look to clean up everything and does
manage to take the game as Sebie in the
first game of top eight. So, one and
zero at this point in uh a fun game, but
I I think you know, one that you really
have to to contrast with so much of the
other Riftbound that we've seen here
this weekend is a very unique game here
on stream.
>> I did not realize how strong bullet time
really is again in this meta because
you're able to ramp up so fast. I mean,
we've seen ramping us down catalyst of
back up again. Then, Dazzling Aurora did
all the work for Misfortune there. It it
just got you some units and that was all
that was necessary. You ripped some
cards from hand and then you basically
did not play a single card on your turn
>> until until you just bullet timed again.
It was really really interesting. But
also this shows how quote unquote weak
Draven can be if you starve it out of
draws.
>> That's the headline quote right there.
This shows how weak Dven can be. No, if
you do not get into combat, your
opponent doesn't offer you anything. You
score some points, of course. You Marcus
was rapidly going through the points.
>> Yes. Um I do want to come back to this
for sure. Let's take a look at
sideboards as well. We have them on on
screen. Uh this is the sideboard for
Misfortune. So, uh Unyielding Spirit,
not so much for this matchup. That's a
lot of like Kaisers. Uh invert timelines
don't know so much. So, where where
would you think we're going with this?
>> Is it another Gust? Gus did have some
effectiveness in that game. Gust is, I
think, a very important tool against the
Draven match up for specifically this
deck because overzealous fan is a really
strong mechanic against decks that only
put big boys onto the board, right?
Those big heavy might units, they just
get stopped by a two drop and that is
really annoying. But with a gust,
>> you could just on reaction speed take
this ability away from your opponent. I
mean, you would rather do it proactively
because otherwise on defending they just
use it.
>> And do we care about fading memories? Is
that like do you fading memories a
Draven and and let it go and maybe you
know cuz if it dies and then can you can
you get rid of you know subsequent units
from that. So we'll see we'll see what
Sebie actually sideboards in. This was
the game one list of course as our
players are pretty much playing as we're
bringing you the action. Bullet time
doing a lot of work there. Um I feel
like if you're Sevy you're like okay
that was a weird game but I'm one up.
I've just got to like make sure I get to
Aurora. make sure I can can contend
through this next game and two my way
into the semi-finals.
>> Yeah, I'm just I'm just brainstorming
here how good Sigil of the Storm really
is in Aurora decks
>> because I I understand that you're
dramping your opponent for one.
>> Actually, that's fine. You don't want to
give your opponent a Battlefield one
that they can play with and you get
>> one power away from your opponent.
That's I think it's fine, but it doesn't
do that much because you don't combat
all the time. Meanwhile, no gear
destruction. Oh,
>> in the sideboard of Marcus. Now, of
course, when you're playing a spinning
axe heavy
>> uh Draven, uh thermo beam
>> is not asymmetrical. It hits everything.
So, you don't want to get rid of them.
But it is surprising to see literally
none because it it does mean that uh you
know, you going up against Aurora, you
don't have too many options to get rid
of it outside of the mind spplitter. So
surely they have to both come in at this
point. Surely you you have to maximize
your chances of having a mind spplitter
on your turn where you get above that
threshold of seven runes to play it.
>> Yeah, I think that is the game plan here
because also I mean if you're what can
you realistically play, right? You can
play angled shot which works only on
equipments.
>> It's a good card but as you said exactly
not in this scenario.
>> The other one would be factory recall
right and that card just bounces a gear
to hand on action speed. That means if
your opponent plays the dazzling Aurora
and then doesn't go into combat, they're
still going to get at least one probably
Mindsplitter or Volibar Furious out of
the deck. So I think that card is also
not really helping with this. So triple
mind spplitter after siding.
>> Valid strategy. I like it.
>> Fair. Fair. As we uh we're talking about
Draven a little bit in between games. I
think that has been one thing that
players have started to pick up on a
little bit more of like how to play
around Draven's effectiveness in combat
and winning combats and avoiding bad
combats. I think that is where so much
of the deck was strong right at the
beginning of Spirit Forge where we were
seeing people practice doing uh you know
summoner skirmish local events and some
of the online events as well. I think
we've had this curve where that side of
why Draven is is good has somewhat been
figured out to a little bit. But the one
thing that I think is really important
and a lot of people won't understand
this until you play a weekendl long
event. Consistency can be key of like
can I just draw cards that curve out and
let me just play good efficient units
and spells to be able to consistently
make my deck work. Yeah. And I I feel
like this was the most unlucky Seabek
could have gotten in that game, right?
>> It felt like it.
>> So, Dazzling Aurora only hit two units
and he drew into double Volibear. That's
a 12 energy double power cost card.
>> I feel like if you are winning a matchup
versus the I want to say best deck in
the format apparently.
>> So unlucky. I think you shouldn't win.
>> Yeah, it's hard to say. I think
consistency like most consistent tech
for sure in like especially in a in a
grueling Swiss like 13 rounds. I'm like
yeah you just want that consistency to
be able to
>> you know round after round make sure you
nail it as we are in top eight so these
players are obviously going to have the
time they need in order to sideboard
make some decisions and and get ready
for the next game. We are untimed on the
rounds that is a very important
distinction between our Swiss rounds and
our top eight. I
very happy to be watching this match up
in a top eight
>> two players that we've been following
all weekend.
>> Also, we do have a other matchup that we
are having on camera. So, if this one
ends rather quickly, we can also watch
the other game. I don't know whether
we're going to watch it live or whether
we're going to watch the full record of
some of the games there, but we have the
match up prepared for you guys.
>> Depends on how long Allen's games go
with that the Ezreal. Um,
>> as mirror match
>> mirror match could take a while, could
indeed take some time as we head to a
second game between Marcus and Sebby.
>> Now Marcus has the option to go first. I
think this is a very important thing
that you want to have versus the Aurora.
You play a bunch of two drops. Can't
miss it. Really, you can't miss that one
because that's two points you're missing
in the long run. You will have to have
the first conquer and then of course a
hold again when your opponent is trying
to ramp you up. So really cannot miss
that one. So playing in Targon's Peak
and at the obelisk of power. So you can
also hit a three drop. Does Draven even
play those?
>> So there there's a few different things
that happen with Obelisk here, right? Is
you Yes, if you're the the Aurora
player, you're like, "Cool, I get to
Aurora closer." Draven gets to play
Draven like
>> I I guess it's when you're on uh when
you're going second, you get to play it
pretty much right away, but you get to
play Draven plus have some additional um
you know, utility on that turn with an
extra
>> an extra rune available. But that's
going to be a quick Nox is hopeful gets
the Legion cost reduction thanks to the
stacked deck.
>> You know what? This is a incredibly
powerful first turn usually against most
decks. But Rift Bond is unique in the
way that all of your units, doesn't
matter how mighty they are, they can
only score one point.
>> And and this pressure on the board
really does not do a lot for Marcus. So
there was no catalyst from Sebby on the
opening turn, but it was immobilize to
just get one rune.
>> Yeah.
>> Still decent.
>> Yep. Yeah. Still helps you get to the
Aurora. So I think Marcus probably is
breathing a little bit of a sigh of
relief that it wasn't Catalyst
immediately and then you're really
ramping heavily. Stack deck again.
>> This time will reveal him immediately.
The might go. No surprises on that
either. So takes the targon. Peak
decides to go into this early. Find that
very interesting. I think that in the
next turn there is a decent chance there
could be something that is dropped and
you want to prolong the Ton's peak
trigger if you know what I mean. Right.
So that you do not take it now because
in the next turn kind of unlikely that
something's going to happen. You would
rather want to take it in the next one.
So you mind splitter and then have two
runes open.
>> There's one Aurora in hand. Now, if
Sebie has the luck to draw a second,
two mind splitters and cold shot.
>> Oh, you want those to go under the deck.
>> Yeah, you obviously need the cold shot.
The cold shot is what I'm ooing about
because it's going to be able to at
least give you the option to dig for
some more. You'll dramp to do it, but
we've already seen that Sebie is no uh
has no worries about damping when
necessary
>> after Aurora has been played because if
you do that before, you're going to take
away your pivotal Aurora.
>> That is very true. That is very true.
But I I yeah, you are totally right. You
can't you can't D ramp too early on. So
it will still be a problem if this
Aurora gets mine spplitted out of hand,
which surely it will. I
>> I think the coolest thing you can have
in this deck Oh, actually brings in the
Misfortune Captain. I think the the
coolest thing you can do in this in this
deck is stack deck, reveal two units,
and put them on the bottom of the deck
so you can make sure that you're not
drawing them and you have enough aurora
cards. Now, is this misfortune
potentially knowing that Mindsplitter is
coming? It's like I have to have a
backup plan because you're going to tap
your Aurora immediately here. There's
like almost
>> I I would be engeding.
>> Doesn't even doesn't even wait for his
opponent. He's like, "You want this?
Yeah, you want this."
>> Yeah, we want this. You'll get it. Next
turn. There could be a potential super
risky turn. Actually, no. We have with
the Misfortune Captain, we've dragged
ourselves in a way that we hit eight
runes next turn. So that is not even
going to be the Aurora turn already
predicting that there might be a mind
splitter going first.
>> And that's what I mean. It's like if you
have now a challenge in hand, you're
like, okay, it's going to push me back
in order to Aurora. So do I have to
fight for the for for essentially
developing a board or developing a
strategy based on what is still here?
Mindsplitter is a bit problematic, I
will be honest, just as a unit on its
own. Like you don't you can't really
challenge your way past it too well.
Draven is something you you kind of want
to take out, but again, you're not
dealing with the biggest threat.
>> Oh, Draven doesn't even take the
conqueror on the obelisk of power,
realizing that this misfortune captain
might as well be able to really
challenge him now that he's completely
tapped out. Can't get the targon's peak
trigger. This turn of course was only
holding it. And now we're going to
called Shot. N figured that maybe if you
play cold shot, you want to wait until
you have enough runes to play your
dazzling Aurora on that turn. So you can
float the runes and then Aurora on the
same turn.
>> Volley bag goes to the bottom. It was a
bullet time that went to hand. There's
two catalyst. So no no surprises going
there. Problem is there's no Aurora in
hand, right? So you can be waiting
forever if you never draw into it.
Doesn't matter if you've got the runes
up or not.
>> Yeah, you can be sat there with nine
runes up and be like cool, my Aurora
will get cast anytime. Yeah, damping
heavily into this. going to D ramp all
the way down again. It's August and I
didn't see the second card is a hard
bargain.
>> Feels like this this game SEQ is playing
a completely different deck.
>> Yeah, I mean this is this is the
downside, right, of of Aurora when it
gets taken out of hand early.
>> Punch first will help you get past the
mind spplitter
>> is going to be the priority which but
>> punch first is a heavy dramping spell.
You have to take away two orange runes
to do it.
>> If you punch first, you're never
auroring, especially after you went down
to four. Now you are at four runes. Of
course, you're still floating and you
can play a catalyst of eons here.
>> Yeah. So, we'll get two more. So, you'll
be able to to at least stabilize.
So next turn again if we do not play
something like immobilize next turn
there is again no chance to play a good
old dazzling Aurora because you are
right now at six would go up to eight.
Now we're going to play a challenge. So
we're going to take another rune cycle
that Draven is being taken out and
Marcus Patel looks like he's fine with
it.
>> But so much of what Sebi is playing for
is just slowing you down just a little
bit. just like take away one unit, be
able to play around it. Okay, maybe
that's enough. And and just say, okay,
harder for you to take multiple points.
Uh target peak is going to allow the the
uh readying of runes at the end. There's
a gust in hand.
>> That's cool. At this point, Sebi is just
playing Misfortune. It's just an actual
Misfortune deck
>> readying everything. Oh,
>> big big card here with the Misfortune
moving to the battlefield. We're in here
getting play to the battlefield and and
sorry to the base and at this point
there are no real options for Sebi to
play out at reaction speed to that. So
the mind spplitter goes in takes out the
misfortune. That was the backup plan for
Sebie after damping was can I contest
these battlefields and we've already
seen another mind spplitter drawn for
Marcus for any potential Aurora that
cannot be played before that mine
spplitter resolves. He keeps the
pressure up so much that his opponent
has to constantly damp himself. Catalyst
of Aons is now considered and that is
again a huge turn where you do not get
any tempo. You do not get anything done.
Yes, next turn is a possible Aurora
turn, but you're for sure going to be
met with another mind spplitter. And by
the way, you don't even have one.
>> Well, is this where Marcus goes with the
mind spplitter? Is is this it where
you're like, well, he's either got it or
I take it now. You're at six. There is
no unit. I think if you mind splitter
and there was an Aurora, I don't even
think you would take it at this point.
>> It's a mine spplitter.
>> Is this the bullet time that you take
and and just say I'm going to stop you
from clearing out the whole battlefield?
You do DM to do it, but
>> I think it should be the bullet time.
It's the only card that can really stop
you. If there is a dazzling Aurora top
deck, it's doing nothing because you're
on game point and you're at six.
>> You get the information. Punch first. No
unit gust. No target, no Aurora means
likely in game two, Marcus knows there
shouldn't be a hope for Sebie to turn it
around. If it's an Aurora off the top, I
don't even know whether it turns it
around cuz that is a stacked
battlefield. Uh, sorry, base for Marcus.
And I think
>> checking
>> Yeah, we're going to say checking the
trash for no real reason at this point.
We're going to a game three between
Sebie and Marcus. Very, very strong.
Also, Marcus playing around a possible
bullet time top deck. I know that bullet
time wouldn't have saved Sevi because if
you take out a mind spplitter, you're
basically taking away all of your runes
and then you still again can't play the
game anymore while your opponent is
loaded in base with units. So, we have
seen a first game where Sebie was really
unlucky but still won with the double
mind spplitter. And now Marcus
sideboarding pattern against this deck
with no gear removal but hand removal
has worked out quite well. Well, I can
imagine that when you're on the play, I
think this time around he's going to
have to use oblisk of power, right? So,
when you are going second, that could be
a first turn Draven. Really cool. But I
think you can hit your opponent very
hard on a hard bargain.
>> Yeah, it really depends
when you kind of go you go through the
steps. It really now depends on like the
the catalysts like the number of
catalysts that come out, the number of
ramp spells that come out in those first
few turns. uh for Sebie whether that
whether you can beat the mind spplitter
turn because you have to feel like
Marcus is going to mulligan aggressively
for it uh and draw aggressively for it.
I mean, you also still need a two drop,
but I mean, if you're mulliganing
aggressively, you you either keep it in
hand or you're mulliganing for both,
right? You keep a mind spread in hand if
you draw one, but you're still going to
try hard to get a two drop. Actually,
>> I don't think you do.
>> It's obelisk of power. You're going
second.
>> You can go Draven.
>> Draven. Exactly. Yeah, that. So you um
yeah, you can just aggressively mulligan
for for your your answer to the Aurora,
which again, no gear removal, but hasn't
seemed to be a problem in at least the
second game.
Sideboard once again from Sebie. I guess
a option that you would have is if you
are mulliganing for a two drop, you drop
it and you keep two runes open for a
possible hard bargain. Because if Sebie
Q starts, he starts at three with the
obelisk of power and then goes to five.
So immediately on the second turn, I
mean that would work at two.
>> If there's a catalyst, yeah, you can
maybe
>> you can bargain it.
>> Hard bargain it. Yeah, there's there's
options there certainly. And this is the
thing is like there are so many lines
that you have to be thinking of as a
player in this situation. Top eight. Um
never underestimate first of all the
power of the scouts code and secondly
never underestimate how complex the game
at this level can be. We've seen our
players having to make incredibly
precise
plays. I'm I'm letting the crowd I hope
you can hear that through the
microphones as Sebie has a lot of
players in support watching
>> this match up. Shout out to the crowd
here at uh Bolognia here in Bolognia.
They've been very very
>> like, you know, enthusiastic. I was
going to say rowdy, but I I I actually
don't think it's rowdy. They just been
very enthusiastic.
>> The Polish community has brought so many
talented players to this tournament. I
mean, we are seeing multiple in the top
eight and it is just a blast to to watch
them play. We've had so many on the
featured matches and they are just
cheering for Sebi. They want him to win.
But also, Marcus is a household name in
TCG. He has his fans and he has his
friends who also want to support him.
And that's one of the coolest things I
think about Riftbound is the convergence
of players from so many different games
uh so many different communities and
then we even have players who are making
a name for themselves for the first time
in any game in Riftbound as well. So it
is uh really heartening to see just how
much enthusiasm there has been here all
weekend long. So thank you everybody in
attendance. Thank you everybody at home
that has been watching. We've got a lot
more Rift Bands still to play. We're
getting ready for our last game of this
best of three and that animation means
we are pretty much ready to go. Players
are deciding their mulligans for a
knockout stage at this point. Sebi and
Marcus this game advances one of them to
the semifinals.
>> Now I want to know what Marcus hasn't
had because that is like a mulligan for
one.
>> So three cards are pretty good. Yeah, we
have discussed so many different
mulliganing strategies and they all
include combinations of like three
different cards. So I would say it's
very unlikely that you actually get
them. But if you have three cards in
hand that you want to keep, that is
going to be really cool.
>> Oh, two from Sebie and one of them off
the top is a catalyst.
We are aspirants climbing
an obelisk of powering.
This is the absolute late game
battlefield scenario, right? Obiskov
power that gets you there faster for the
dazzling aurora and the aspirants climb
prolonging the game. Now stack de is
going to be used. Are we profiting
immediately off of the obelisk of power?
Seek is probably trying to find
immobilize to ramp up even faster. Now
do not be alarmed. We are going to nine.
>> We will go to nine.
Actually, if you find immobilize here,
you are going to go up to six next turn.
And then if you catalyst of aons, you
can't be hard bargained for without the
repeat cost. Ooh, there is immobilize.
As you said, that's four. So, it gives
you the non repeat.
>> Well, the crowd is going ballistic.
Everyone in there is absolutely wilding
Draven.
>> There's Draven. That's the uh the the
benefit of getting getting obelisk of
power which means it tells you there the
shields are down for this catalyst which
is going to accelerate the game. Uh it
was there is an Aurora in hand.
>> Wow. And there is a
>> catalyst is going to be played. So one
mind spplitter in hand means that's not
going to be able to come from the top of
the deck. Gets to the point
>> where we're at dazzling Aurora next
turn.
>> And this can't be a mindspplitter turn.
This is going to be an uphill climb for
Marcus.
>> And we know there is no gear
uh no gear destruction in the sideboard
of Marcus' deck. So, it was all about
getting a mind spplitter out
>> and it hasn't happened at this point.
It's going to be readying for Sebie into
Dazzling Aurora and what is the card
that we will see because Marcus has
taken control of both battlefields which
means Marcus will go to four. This is
for Marcus now a really really tough
match because he is controlling both
battlefields. You're right about that.
But the on curve dazzling Aurora is
looking to close it out rather sooner
than later which is already a tough ask
from this deck. Now you also have one
rune left remaining. We're going
>> to We know it's not a dead bloom. We
know it's not going Oh bear off the top
is a huge card. And now it's down to
what can Marcus have in hand in order to
uh play through a volley volley bear
imposing. That is a 12 energy cost 10
might unit shield plus three tank and
when your opponent tries to move into
the battlefield that is not his. You
draw a card. So Volibear imposing is
imposing a real threat for
>> mind spplitter just one turn too late
after the ramp. Oh wow, it was second
Aurora which with this list there's not
too many units in play anyway. Two gusts
and a mind spplitter. So
>> I'm calling you. Do you take the mind
spplitter?
>> Well, if you take the mind spplitter and
last rights comes out then you give a
target back to Aurora.
>> Yeah.
>> So there are not many targets. I mean
Gust is doing nothing. Do you take the
Aurora and just Well, you This is such a
weird situation. It's It's a time where
Mind Splitter has revealed an Aurora and
you have to second guess cuz it wasn't
coming down immediately. But it is going
to be the Aurora. I don't want to have
to face too quick of an onslaught.
Marcus is thinking, can I just play
through this? I'm going to lose one
battlefield
and then we'll see how I can recover.
Oh, Marcus now deciding he has seen the
full head. He has full information
hiding two cards. There is only two
gusts and a mind spplitter in hand for
Seabq. So those cards there, they are
not pushing the mission for Seabq. If
those are both fight or flights or if
there's a switch route, there's very
little that SEQ can actually do against
this, but picks up this massive spell
from the top that looks like a challenge
that he is just absolutely ripping here.
>> And if there's something you don't want
to challenge, it is a Volibear if you
are on Marcus' side. So Volibear will be
able to put out a bunch of damage onto
the Kaiser. That puts a fighter flight
away as well. That was not huge. Able to
be used. Volibear goes to Aspirin's
climb and takes control. And we've still
got an Aurora to resolve at the end of
this turn.
>> Yep, the Aurora is going to Oh my
goodness.
>> Just a flat mindspplitter from hand.
takes away another option overzealous
fan is not going to do much the other
units as well. You at this point need
crazy amounts of removal spells, but do
you even have those? Of course, Draven
does not really play hard removal in the
deck just because of the reason that you
want to go into those combats. You want
to push your own units to maximum amount
of might that you can reach. But that is
going to never be enough honestly if
you're facing Volibear imposing.
So players are just talking through with
our our table spotter the exact
situation that we're in. Of course, we
want to make sure everything
is correct at this point in the top
eight. So we will uh bring things down
for a moment as they are
clearly counting things through.
>> So they
>> we do not have the player audio just for
uh clarification. So we're not sure of
exactly the point that they're making.
We were very excited about the Aurora.
So I have not been counting runes. the
Aurora was definitely correct.
>> That that is typically not something
that I'm able to juggle in my head while
getting uh you know excited about a
game.
>> Well, you are an Aurora player, mate.
>> H I don't need to count that when
somebody else is playing it. I only need
to count it when I'm playing it.
>> It's a that's a very good point. Darius
getting taken out because Darius
actually is posing a threat for the
Volibear together with the mind
spplitter. But then again, keep in mind
this was a hardplayed
unit. There is going to be dazzling
Aurora in the end. We know there is two
more mind splitters on the bottom of the
deck of seabq. So probably going to find
another volar before
>> rolling the dice again. What comes off
the top? We know it's a big unit.
>> It's Volar. No, it has to be unless it
was sighted out.
>> Okay, so it should be another copy of
Volibear imposing then.
>> Oh, have we sided on the crowd? They
want to see what card is.
>> They want to see what the card is. We
want to see it, too.
>> Oh my goodness. Bullet time.
>> Oh my goodness. Double volley bear
>> on to Aspirin's climb.
>> And now Marcus realized that this is a
tough game in top eight of the regional
qualifier here in Bologna. The first
major event in Europe. We have had so
many great games and now we're looking
forward to closing this one out because
that is a huge aspirants climb for
Marcus. So, we're very excited about
this and I am excited too. Is there a
chance that you rip rebukes off the top
and really mess up the plan of Sebie? Is
is that within the realm of possibility?
>> I think you need multiple rebukes.
>> It's stranger things have happened. That
is indeed true. But
>> I I just always like looking at the outs
here for for the player that we we we
perhaps think has started in some ways
to to to lose control of the game cuz
the Marcus has had full control up until
this point. We are going to Aspirin's
climb. We're going to nine points. So
the game is not over. We're on a hold.
So it's going to take Sebie quite a few
turns to get to nine holding just one
battlefield. And we know there are no
more units there. So it's on drawing
last rights.
>> Yeah, I mean this is two extra draws.
Marcus deciding to push the mind
spplitter into this obelisk of power,
his own battlefield that he wants to
stack good defenses in. But Volyar
imposing when a unit moves to a
battlefield that is not his. You get a
draw. So that was a very very expensive
move there. And keep in mind this is not
a civer deck. Woolly Baron posing is
such a huge unit. And Misfortune just
gives ganking. And there's one more
unit. Ooh, sabotage comes out. So,
that'll be able to uh yeah, eat a
spinning axe. Another significant card
removed as Marcus will tidy up the
bottom of the deck. There is also the
misfortune from the chosen champion zone
as well, just as another unit to play.
We've got Last Rights potentially
accessible from the graveyard. So,
Marcus is really banking on these top
decks to pay off. Either something to
draw into more options
>> or like just a rebuke off the top would
would help. But is it enough? That is
going to be a gust to take back the
overzealous fan.
>> That is the problem with Draven. If your
opponent can guarantee that you get no
draws in a bad situation, very rarely
top decks can help you out. You need a
lot of pressure with the deck. There is
going to be for every overzealous fan
that is going to be played, a gust will
find its way. We know that SEQ has
another one of those. Double volley bear
imposing right now. If you give it
ganking, could actually be a little
tough for you.
Yeah, cuz you still do have to take the
mine spplitter and the Draven off this
battlefield. You You still do have to
stop Marcus from going, you know, hold
hold. Okay, great. I I'm there. You have
to build back into the game. I mean,
there's also a world
>> where I believe there's another bullet
time left for Sebie where Sebie just
grabs every single rune that is
necessary and says, "I'm going through
the battlefield and just bullet times
everything away."
>> And then at that point, Volbear moves
across and really the screws turn
>> really starts to hold both battlefields
there. I don't think it will happen this
turn just because we have seen the gust
already and I feel like the overzealous
fan is the card that you would have
really not targeted with a gust if you
were going to deal spread damage anyways
>> but there is a finish there is the point
there is that you know non-combat
version of clearing out a battlefield
and Sebi has not been you know afraid to
say I'm dramping
>> we're going to see a new organization of
our runes
>> it's going be misfortune from
>> the captain
>> champion zone and that does now give a
good amount of strength
>> in base for sebi
>> it's accelerated as well you can really
something that's exhausted so you can
give
ganking if you move the misfortune
>> is it multiple units moving okay it's
going to be volar goes back misfortune
goes to the battlefield
>> vol goes Insane.
>> Oh, and both Volibear are going.
>> Math is for defenders.
>> Math is for defenders. That's scary
math. That is 27 might all of a sudden
while the aspirin climb is just being
held by the misfortune clarifying
something with the judges. And that is
going to be a win for Seabq.
>> Seabq gets the reveal from Marcus and
Seabq will advance to the semifinals.
Phenomenal. The curve, the divine curve,
the almost the aspir into the absolute
victory there. There was going to be so
many so many runes. He had the catalyst
of aons. He had them mobilized before
and then he just hit immediately. The
dazzling aurora also had a sabotage to
make sure everything is going as
planned. And of course immediately at
the beginning the STE deck putting two
minds spplitters under the deck. So
guaranteeing that with the minds
splitter in hand you're going to hit
Volibear after volar. What a sequence.
What a a best of three. Uh everybody get
ready to make sweeping statements about
Draven. Uh I mean it no um no
discounting Marcus' performance. Top
eight performance. Uh two and like one
and two in the round of eight. Um really
had a good showing across the weekend.
So, excited to see what Marcus has in
future events that we undoubtedly will
see. But this moment is Sebis going into
the semifinal rounds piloting a deck
that everyone thought was dead.
>> Everyone thought was gone. No one was
going to play Misfortune Aurora. It was
either Civer Aurora or nothing. But
nevertheless, Civer uh Misfortune, see,
even I'm doing it. misfortune. Aurora
comes out, brings two copies of Volibear
imposing
>> to the to attack, like not even just
defending with it. He's able to clear
out the battlefield and say, "Okay, the
game is mine."
>> Yeah. And Marcus, of course, he could
have dragged this game out for a little
bit longer, but he said,
>> "Hey, dude, you're in absolute control
of this. I'm never ever going to take
back any of those battlefields."
Realistically, there's there is a chance
that you can get the misfortune captain,
but then again, he was only at five
points and we were in an aspir game that
goes to nine. So, even if you get it
there, have another Volibear is just
going to get ganking and it's it's
really going to gank your Volibear ganks
hit hard if they work.
>> They do. And you know what else hits
hard? Top eight of Riftbound. We've got
more for you. Let's go right into game
two of our second feature match. Uh, if
your brain has any power left, get ready
to lose it because we have got an Ezreal
mirror match. And it is Allen ZQ we saw
piloting this deck to be undefeated in
the rounds we saw from Swiss
and we'll see how clean and how composed
the play is now in in the top eight
situation with these two. This was
Allen's deck earlier. Uh, the Vex being
an inclusion that I think not many
people saw coming. I was speaking to
Kasanova who um, you know, Riftbound
fans will recognize from a lot of
co-streams and also the regional
qualifiers from North America. Uh, Cass
was saying about how they've been
training against this, how difficult it
was to beat uh, convincing Allen to play
Vex in the deck as a part of that team.
So, uh, it it really has been a surprise
to most people.
>> Yeah, that is true. Now, Alanzi Q is a
little bit with his back against the
wall because he's 10 down so far.
Interesting. We're going to see that
quite soon as I have just heard. And
there is triple pickpocket in the
psychic I think for both players
actually because this card is going to
get rid of your opponent's seals. So,
this is a slightly different version of
Ezreal. There is no Vex. Um,
>> triple Arcane Shift. There's a down well
in the main as he said. Triple Arcane
Shift here. We've seen how well that
combos with Fizz.
>> Yeah. And only with Fizz because there
is no mind spplitter and no thousand
tila watcher in this deck list.
>> Very very true. So this is where legends
can kind of play out in very different
ways. Even though many of the cards are
the same. Yeah.
>> Even though it is very very similar.
>> Allen's EQ and the Manland will
be taking it to game two. Valen can can
bounce back in this one. He will of
course then take it to a tied series.
But Manland is looking to close this
out. Looking to go two and zero over the
Swiss leader which was is one heck of a
feather in the cap on your way
potentially to a semi-final round. I
mean every TCG player knows the curse,
right? If you're undefeated first after
Swiss, you have been chilling for
multiple rounds already where you have
been like I can basically intentional
draw or chill. But if you lose the first
game of the top cut.
>> Yeah.
Um, and one thing I'm pretty sure we
only have the two Ezreal players, right?
So, this is a best of Ezreal eliminator.
>> Oh my goodness. As well,
>> this is huge actually. So, we have not
only the top eight match with the first
After Swiss versus the player who got in
as eighth, a player with an X2 record
actually after Swiss. got in on tie
break and both of them they have they
are telling us hey this is how you play
play Asreal. You just you just throw it
out in the first turn.
So Arcane Shift to the bin. We know that
it won't stay there for very long.
Eventually the Fizz is going to come
back. Arcane Shift will target the Fizz.
Fizz will get the supervi. Everything
goes through. Uh now this is a weird one
for a mirror matchup where Arcane Shift
is actually pretty good against Ezreal.
you can pop the opponent's Ezreal with
an Arcane Shift pretty handily.
>> That is true.
>> There's that three damage break point is
uh something that I was a little bit
worried at with regards to Ezreals
because there's a lot of spells that
will deal three damage in in the current
meta. A few less now than when we saw
the presence of Kaiser in in Origins,
but they do still exist. Three is not an
insurmountable amount of of damage to
get to.
>> That is true. If you keep your Ezreal in
your unit in your base,
>> yeah,
>> there is a good chance that it will
survive for the moment because Arcane
Shift and I think Wages of Pain 2, they
only hit units at Battlefield.
>> Ah, thank you. That is a very good
clarification um to know. However,
something that will be able to hit the
backline is Level's Breath.
>> Yep, that's
>> and Stupify will deal with the Azreal.
>> Yep. And since you have your own Ezreal,
that is also going to be much cheaper. I
was going to say the seal doesn't really
help you too much if Bellow's breath is
going to cost you two mind runes, but of
course Ezreal is going to make the
optional cost a lot cheaper.
How I was about to say, how important is
a seal? Cuz at one point Allan EQ had a
seal and Manland didn't, but the seal's
there. Ezreal's there. See one, see
another at this point as Ezreal will
find his way into the base of Manland.
>> Which artwork do you prefer from the
seals?
>> Ooh,
I got to say the spirit forge one is
very pretty.
>> I you know what I I have I think two
copies of the the the regular seal. I'm
not unhappy to have that is the way that
I will phrase it. But the the tasty
spirit forge ones are
>> it's looking fantastic. Not easy pass.
We have just played another Ezreal on
the side of the Madland. So, we are
seeing multiple different versions of
how you can play the deck. Double Ezreal
on the side of the Madland. We know that
there are more ways to get your own
Ezreal back on the side of Alz. I don't
think he plays more than one Ezreal, but
he is definitely playing Morbbit Return,
a card that if your Ezreal gets removed,
you can just get it back from your
discard, from your trash.
Now, since we have two Polish players in
the feature matches, the crowd is going
ballistic here in Bologna. So many of
these Riftbounders have traveled to
support their friends. And
>> I feel like I saw a tweet that there was
like a hundred
>> Polish players traveling like it was a a
giant number of of the players here. A
big picture of them all outside the
venue. So, thank you for the travel uh
to the event.
>> Gets the pig pocket out. immediately
gets rid of the seal before there can be
a lot of value generated from the man
land.
So now we're going to go for another
stack deck completely exhausted. And
this is very interesting because you
know this matchup has been going on for
a few turns already. We have recycled so
many runes. There hasn't been a single
point that has been scored so far.
>> Control matchups. It's perhaps one of
the maybe not the first time we've seen
it in Riftbound, but uh
>> definitely the Ezreal Ezreal uh mirror
is something that on our broadcast we
haven't seen this weekend. So get ready.
These are unttime drowns.
>> Y
>> everyone at home, make a cup of tea or
beverage of choice to uh to to weather
the storm through this.
>> I mean the first game took 40 minutes
already.
>> I know. I know that. So we we are here
for a treat.
>> Cold shot I think. Found a hard bargain.
We I know that we have added a seal of
discord.
>> Could be. Is there a good way for you to
just loop the pickpocket then? If the
seal of discord is being played, is it
worth it to try and loop the pickpocket?
That's also so good. Immediately seal of
discord and then call shot with the
Ezreal in your base. You're just going
to draw two cards for free. But it's not
only drawing, it's just choosing.
>> Oh, what's better than uh getting one
card, getting two cards, and then from
that getting away to get another card.
>> Yeah, you're not even spending any kind
of energy for it.
>> I I I genuinely feel like if there was a
way to track how many times we've cycled
through the deck, we're we're going to
need to to to find that for this game
because we are going to see multiple
versions through of every every deck. By
the way, uh drawing cards is a great
mechanic. It's a very strong thing to do
in Riftbound and when you can do it
consistently like this. Um,
>> wow. The man is really going through it
right now.
>> You really wish you had a battering ram
at this point.
>> Yeah, I think I mean he he picked up a
Rasa. I don't know if we're at 10 cards
in the trash yet, but there's a pig
pocket being played on his side, too.
Gets rid of the seals and then gets a
gold token for it in exchange, which
just makes it so much better as well.
So, I guess that really is going to
start to add up, right? The the pick
pocket plays as you were were talking
about. It really hurts the economy. You
can see even the uh the rocket barrage
has come in. Is this going to be a
situation where you do take out the the
seals on the opponent's side?
>> I think there might be a better way of
doing it. You retreat after you push
into the dreaming tree. So, you get a
point, you get a draw, you get a rune
exhausted, you play that pick again, you
get gold, and you get rid of the second
seal. And I don't think there's a lot of
recursion for those seals.
>> Uh I'm trying to think and I I it's not
coming to mind. That is a good line. And
again,
>> I do want to commend first of all both
players, but the two games we've seen
from Allen um on stream today
have been very impressive for the
cleanliness of like lines knowing what's
coming next, what what your accurate way
of playing is. Clearly, Manland has has
>> been, you know, exceptional to get the
game one. We unfortunately did not see
it on the broadcast as we were watching
our first featured matchup of this
round. Well, when you get rid of your
opponent's seal, uh I guess it's pretty
good to get one of your own.
>> Yeah, especially when you pick up two
with a culture.
>> You do have to say goodbye to the other
one for like three turns worth of
drawing. Like we'll see it again pretty
soon.
>> You're going to cycle through it in in
no time.
>> That's how we'll know.
>> Keep that in mind when we see that seal
of discord again. We've gone through the
entire deck.
>> All right. Okay. Okay. That's That's
good. That's good to note. This is This
is the time stamp.
>> Yeah, exactly. Time stamp.
>> Hey, now a turn pass after finally
excitingly a point was taken by Alan's
EQ. And after considering that you took
like five turns to get a point, this is
a crazy lead. Now,
>> uh this is the only Ezreal mirror we're
going to have in our top eight. So, just
to put it out there, this is this is a
once in a lifetime, a repeat retreat.
>> Are we just going to mirror our
opponent, but LZQ has of course not
played out the seal, knowing
>> doesn't have to use it on that one.
Wages of pain is being used so rather
aggressively.
>> Trying to say no repeat for you, but
August because it does fulfill the uh
under three might.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh part of that. So, we'll return to
hand. It's it's repeat retreat at home.
>> Yes, that that's true. I mean,
>> basically does the same thing in in this
matchup.
>> You just don't channel a rune exhausted,
but you do get the draw. I don't know if
we've taken the draw from the dreaming
tree, but you get one.
>> That's really interesting. In this
matchup, you probably never want to gust
your opponent's stuff at all. So, it
really is just another copy of retreat.
>> This is this is something that you
haven't really seen in Origins, right?
Control matchups that just play so
heavily for value that you're really not
taking points. We're taking away gold
tokens. I think that Alz might be
incredibly happy to see this.
>> Trade the gold for the gold.
>> Yeah, he just added a seal of discord to
his hand. And you would rather have a
seal of discord than a gold token.
>> But then how many repeats are we going
to have? Uh how many ways of uh of
bouncing that pickpocket are going to
come through? This is quite literally
death by a thousand cuts for both player
of like how how do you just eat through
the economy one single interaction at a
time?
>> I think the great thing about riftbond
in this regard is also that you don't
have to necessarily eat through your
opponent's economy.
>> Okay.
>> You just need to score a few points
sometimes.
>> Sure.
>> Right. You're
>> Yeah. Yeah. You are going to like at
some point you're forcing out resources
from your opponent when you try to take
too many points with your pickpocket.
For example, if you throw that
pickpocket in, oh, there is a Dr. Mundo
in hand.
>> Push, push, push to the wind. Maybe
>> that is one way of dealing with a lot of
these small might units and small
uh like might caring spells like gust.
Obviously
not
going to get through. There is a
bellow's breath and with the fizz we're
going to get that combination that we
saw a little bit earlier of like you you
get the bellow's breath. Fizz will end
up potentially recurring things and you
know dealing damage through to the base.
We'll see exactly where that comes
through from Allen. We haven't seen the
damage applied yet. We have just seen a
draw from Ezreal Prodigal Explorer, the
legend ability. So that both players are
approximately at 20 cards in hand.
Another Fizz.
Fizz of course is going to recycle the
play the spells. So I don't think you
can ever run out of cards in this deck.
It's going to be the Frigid Touch. We
did see this combination earlier.
>> So Bella's breath damage was still
applied and the Frigid Touch going to
get repeated. will take out both units
from the base.
>> I mean, the board state is massively in
Alen's Q's favor.
>> Massively. And now is the point where
it's like, as you said, you do still
have to score points. You still can't
make uh play for either of the
battlefields. And I would say that's
probably one area that Allen ZQ's
>> um deck list having Vex, I wonder
whether they're still in for this match
up, but more units
will kind of stick around. And the more
you can play, the more you can kind of
punish Manland. And here you go. Ezreal
moves to a battlefield. It's rare. We
talked about Arcane Shift only targeting
in a battlefield. Wages a pain as well.
Alan Q is really putting up a lot of
pressure now. 3 to 0 in points. Saying I
have so many cards in my hand. I don't
even really care if you take care of the
Ezreal, if you get rid of it. If you
have to use your turn now, play
something like a wages of pain. You have
nothing that makes it cheaper right now.
I don't even think there is anything
that makes it cheaper. By the way,
>> that's fine for him. You're not
developing a board. I maybe get to hold
in the dreaming tree with the pick
pocket. You're very unlikely to target
that pickpocket with anything because I
might just gust it back to my hand, get
a draw. I might just retreat it again,
get a draw.
>> I do like the pressure that is now
currently all of a sudden applied
towards the manland.
>> Both of these players deep in the tank
of where to go next. And this is round
one of the top eight here at the
regional qualifiers in Bolognia.
If either of these players wants to
become the champion here in Bolognia,
it's going to be another two rounds
after this of uh mindbending plays from
the Ezreal. So Pucker comes back in.
There goes the seal.
>> That is not a lot of value you get out
of those seals. Ppucker is such a strong
card.
>> This game has been seal. I kill your
seal. I blame my seal. Here comes the
seal.
Here comes a Fizz. A lot of a lot of
recurrence in this game.
>> So, we'll see what the target is for
this. There are two Fizz in the
backline. So, will it be something like
Abella's breath? I think that was an
arcane shift. So, we're going to
shortcut, I think, to kill one of the
Fizz.
Allan's going to take a look through the
uh the trash here of Manland. And if it
was an Arcane Shift again, yeah, the
players are shortcutting will be able to
take out a unit, recur a spell. You get
the fizz again. It gets another spell.
>> Oh, we took the stupify. So perhaps a
frigid touch also in play there before.
So you can reduce the might by one. Oh,
no, not a fridge touch, but something
that deals two damage
or a bellow's breath. I will say
if anybody is completely following all
of the lines, maybe you should get a
ticket to Leil and uh look at playing
Ezreal yourself because it is an
incredibly complex deck and it is credit
to both of these players
>> for being in the top eight with it,
getting through a field of Draven and
and Kaiser and Aurelia and lots of like
combat heavy like really punishing decks
if you don't establish a lead early on.
But I mean, look at the advantage that
ZQ has. I think you think because I mean
you can just play another pickpocket,
get rid of the gear. I think that is the
third gear you just got rid of. You have
the double fizz in base. You can go for
another conquer. Go up to 52. That is
first of all something your opponent
will have to get through first.
Just like pickpocketing. I feel like
this sequence has been illegal of just
like kill a seal, get a seal, kill a
seal. as a singularity,
which has not been something we've
really seen from Allen all day in the
games that we have seen.
>> Yeah. I think he just wants to
aggro this.
>> Sure. Yeah. Yeah. Just keep the keep the
board low and and say, "Okay, I know you
have all your answers, but I need to
burn them out of your hands so that I
can keep control."
>> But is he singularity, though? It seems
like there's only two units on the
opposing side of the field.
I think he has taken it back. You know
the the ruling is that if you have
played a card and there was no new
information gained, you can still rewind
that last action that you did.
>> Okay, I will just leave it up to Alan
and Manland to resolve things in the
way. Here comes Vex. So, it is still in
the in the deck from the main board.
>> I think you're really profiting from a
few units in your decks. Pigpockets both
in base. Fizz is now currently in the
obelisk of power. And I really like that
Alz he just almost on the side scored a
few points and now you know the manland
he has to actually play to really
remove desperately those units from the
battlefields. You need to first of all
catch up and second of all you need to
make sure that Allen is not holding that
he's not getting any points back because
you are so far behind.
less value, right?
Alen in the hopes of not
going to lead for another bigger card
advantage for LZQ in the process.
>> Well, Man has enough cards to start
playing them. I'm pretty sure he's at
the point with having enough cards in
hand, probably comparable to the number
of cards remaining in the deck. And the
trash, I think, is actually a bigger
pile than cards remaining in the in the
deck. So, we're at that stage where uh
you know, Man should have options.
There's pretty much everything you can
imagine. There's Ezreal, Last Rights. I
think it's another Last Rights in hand.
Uh
Rocket Barrage, fighter flight. I think
that's two hard bargains. So, not too
many options. You know, I say that find
the options, but there actually aren't
too many for this situation
>> in order to slow Allen down. That's
actually quite surprising. We've we
focused so much on the economy of like
attacking the seals that Allen has uh
kind of quietly got to this point and
that's going to be the game. You know,
there is something to be said for
understanding when you can't turn the
aggression back and Allen will even the
series up one a piece. That's the other
half of this uh situation is knowing,
yeah, I'm I'm I'm toast in this game.
Let's go game three. I don't want to
spend brain power on this.
>> Yeah. And Allan just takes this game
swimmingly with the Fizz Trickster that
is accompanied by Ezreal. Now you get to
actually
>> see the side deck again. Dr. Mundo was
cited in his opponent has not seen the
>> didn't see it. Yeah, we did not. Well,
we saw it. Opponent did not see it. So,
uh we'll see whether it has presence in
the final game between these two. Uh
this is the main boards once again.
How's EQ?
>> That is one retreat.
Feels like there were more. I think on
the side of the mainland there were
more.
>> Yeah, they were definitely on on the
side of manland and we had gusts that
were working as retreats.
>> So the decks they do look kind of
similar if you're just looking at them,
but actually there is quite a few
differences of course where there is the
Vex which is a unit that is pressuring
your opponent in combats quite heavily.
There's so many difference like value
cards like Gust. Gust help you in some
matchups. It stops your opponent from
taking early easy points. Takes away a
lot of the tempo sometimes in the early
turns, but also it gives you a lot of
value in those matchups when you're
bouncing your own pick pockets.
>> Yeah, so we know the pick pockets were
sideboarded in for manland
and uh with a list like this, it is
quite tricky to see exactly what has
come out for it.
Trying to remember what we saw. We The
problem is with this deck,
>> you see so many cards recurred from the
graveyard.
>> Yeah.
>> That it's like I don't know whether it
was one copy of that spell, three copies
of that spell, Fizz played four. Like
how does that come about? Cuz you ar
That's the other thing. Fizz gets arcane
shifted and you get multiple Fizz
resolutions and then you have the
potential for last rights to bring it
back. There's a lot of ways to play
cards for like six times.
>> Yeah. So basically every card you have
in your deck you can use multiple times
and it's on you as the player to decide
which card has the highest values in
those matchups. The only card that I'm
pretty sure we're going to see
>> use this is I think pickpocket is going
to play a pivotal role again and I think
players are heavily mulliganing for it.
>> Void gate
>> mirror in Ezreal mirror that is going to
be really tough to score points. This is
going to be the uh hardest an Arcane
Shift has hit because no matter which
battlefield you're at, it's going to
although again in this match up most of
the units are three anyway, so it
doesn't truly matter.
>> But Bellow's breath tr Oh, that's
actually a significant change for for
that. Bellow's breath now has the
ability to take out units on on
battlefields in this matchup
>> more so than before.
>> Alen's EQ actually finding the seals
immediately plays it out. So the Ezreal
actually discards a morbid return, which
is I think a card that I would have
thought had a lot of value in the match
up, but we're going to see actually
hasn't seen too many cards removed. Adds
a pick pocket while two arcane shifts
get
>> two arcane shifts to the bottom. So we
now know there's less potency from that
in this matchup. And that's what I was
going to say is like with the Fizz, we
probably will see a morbid return at
some point. Like potentially it's there
at least to uh be able to come back.
>> I think we need to get to the bottom of
this. Well, we never saw the seal of
discord again, so we didn't we didn't
get to the bottom of the deck last game,
and I I don't know that we will this
game. Arcane Shift was one of the
choices there with the stupify is uh
yeah, that's I think that was the card
that we were digging heavily for
accepting that you are dramping
yourself, recycling one rune, paying one
power for that cold shot to just find
this pig pocket, get rid of the seal of
discord, getting one gold token, and
this is a huge momentum swing again. And
Alenszq of course getting the value of
the first seal. Not too much value
actually. It was just trading one for
one with the pick pocket. But the thing
is if Alz had a pick pocket here to
answer that there is no seal of discord
being played. Is there a world in which
you're just holding the seals?
>> And we just know that
remind me if this was this game or the
last. I know it just happened but did we
put seals to the No, it was Arcane
Shifts went to the bottom this game. It
was the previous game that a seal went
to the bottom. Um forgive me there's a
lot of things getting recycled in in the
bottom. I was going to hypothesize
whether Allan was going to be a long
time without seals, but no, there is
still the possibility to draw into them.
>> James,
>> yes, Leo,
>> am I crazy?
>> Well, do you want me to answer that
question without the rest of
>> No, no, no. Let me give the give some
context for my defense.
>> All right, let's go with that.
>> Or is there a world in which you do not
play your seals of discord
>> in the mirror match when you know that
there are pickpockets in that game?
>> This is crazy. until pick pockets are
being played because on the side of the
manland if he has seals of discord now
one pickpocket has been played pop the
gold token and then next turn you have a
rather protected seals if you want to
have it
>> somebody is going to delve into that
somebody will figure that out I don't
think I'm the right person to answer
that question specifically uh maybe
we'll ask Allan or Manland whoever wins
this match maybe we'll we'll get that
question posed to them for now all I'm
thinking is about you got to got to pick
a pocket or two from uh from Oliver, but
uh that is not relevant to this game at
all as uh this is a top eight match
between Manland and Allen's EQ. Of
course, big names on the Riftband scene
here in Europe and on the world stage,
of course. I mean, if you're not playing
your seals of discord, I mean, we
haven't found any even if even though we
dug for it, right, with the cold shot,
you are on three runes while Alan ZQ
went second is on five. So, you
effectively lost one. We start with a
stupify on the Azreel, which is also
most of this. This can signalize
a bellow's breath.
This can symbolism of many things. Oh,
that was actually the end of the turn
for Ellen ZQ. So, now we're even losing
track of which turn it is.
>> Yeah, it was must have been on the chain
before the turn passed. So, uh getting
that card drop.
>> So, I I think that the manland is in a
very good position. I mean, what I mean
with very good is it is slightly
advantageous
of play.
>> This absolutely is a game of inches. So
it's like is it enough of a lead to take
some sort of control from here?
>> There's another thing we haven't really
seen. Ras so far the man land is going
to be able to take the first point.
Retreats the pig pocket. So he knows
that he can just keep the pocket on the
line
>> and the the players of course
shortcutting a little bit here just to
uh you know Allen's saying yeah sure
you're going to play it again. That's
fine. I'll take my gold. You take your
gold. take the point.
>> I think it's looking really decent
because you have your own pick pocket
that would maybe try to get another
point there. Maybe it's coming back to
bite Alan ZQ in these match ups that he
is not running multiple copies of
Retreat or Gus. And we're going to see
the first seal of discord now played by
the man land. He can now go for a cold
shot with the Edriel in the base.
I was going to say shuffling and then
putting to hand is uh
>> dangerous.
>> Yeah, dangerous is either Ezreal combo
>> or a signature spell. I was like if I
did that I would absolutely put the
wrong card in my hand that I that I was
was looking for.
>> Um so now how does Allan kind of
tip the scale back if there's a
possibility? I mean surely there's a
possibility to do it for either player
in this incremental change. Many we uh
we do feel like has somewhat of a little
advantage for now. It's going to be a
cold shot.
>> Honestly, we are in the mid game and you
are paying for your cold shot in Ezreal.
>> Yeah, that is
>> that is not a good sign.
>> That is unusual
>> is one way to put it. Um that certainly
is not something we've come to expect
across the weekend.
I mean, the manlet has been getting a
little bit more aggressive with the
retreat on the pickpocket. Immediately
replaying it, even though there was no
seals of discord that the the first
pickpocket play took out the seals of
discord. Great. Love it. Great to see
it. But now since he doesn't have one of
his,
>> he used it to just get a gold token,
which is I I wouldn't call it greedy,
but it was a rather aggressive choice.
Now, if there is going to be a play of
another seal of discord from Alanzik,
and he actually gets to keep it around
for a little bit, that could be
incremental to outgrind his opponent.
Now goes into the void gate with the pig
pocket. Are we going to see a retreat
here? Reaction speed gets the pig
pockets back. Plays it. The seal of
discord
>> gets gets the valuable trade now. So,
man playing that seal of discord out
will just say, well, I guess that's
fair. Turn about fair play from that
moment.
>> But that was the one retreat Alan ZQ
had, right? We know that if you still
have your gusts in your deck, you have
multiple retreats,
>> but actually
>> the one but you got Fizz.
>> That is a very good point.
>> You got Fizz. So it's one of six
basically cuz three Fizzes, Last Rights,
Morbid Return, Arcane Shift is actually
like one of nine.
>> Gotcha. That
>> genuinely is like with you one copy of
this card if you see it once you'll be
able to just play it nine times.
>> Yep. That That is that is so many
iterations of the different cards. It's
1-1 currently. If you're just tuning in,
it is the top eight of the first
European regional qualifier for
Riftbound in Bologna. And we have the
first after Swiss Alan EQ versus the
eighth after Swiss in top eight, the
Madland. One question that I always get
at Nexus Knights by players are not
familiar, is there a maximum hand size?
No, there is not. which is very
important for this matchup.
>> This is half a binder.
>> Yeah, this is most of your deck by the
end of this matchup. Uh if it's not in
the trash, it's in your hand. And if
neither of those things is true, you've
probably lost the game. That is
completely correct. There is going to be
a seal of discard. We're going in with
another Ezreal. Is this gluttony or is
this the correct play? We're having
double Ezreal on the board. Seals of
Discord is now being tapped as well. So
we do have
>> two seals in play. One is in the trash,
one is
>> exhausted
>> and Mland may may end up playing towards
the Rasa. Um again have not seen a lot
of this matchup. So the knowledge of
when you're dropping Rasa um is
something that I'm I'm looking to learn
from this game rather than uh look at
predicting. But of course, the the trash
is not full enough yet for Manland to to
drop that basically for full value where
you get the cost all the way down and
can basically play it free.
So, it's Alan Ziku's turn now again.
Four runes open for the manland.
Those can be used for plenty of things.
We can see hard bargains in the hand.
Has already shuffled up the hard
bargains to the top of his hand to
possibly repeat that card. You you get
the value from the sealer discord by
using it once. It's now a gold token.
>> Yeah, that is that is true. But you at
least you got it once. I mean, you also
had to pay power cost to play it. So, I
mean, it's just it's like gold token.
>> Did you say bad? Is that it?
>> No. If it gets popped, it's just
nothing. It has done nothing. It was a
blank card if it gets popped
immediately.
>> I am desperate to have the sweeping
statements coming from this event to be
like Draven is bad now. Seals are bad
now. I said this is where Draven can be
bad in a situation where you never get
draws. Okay. Okay. I don't want all the
Draven fans to rage on me. But oh, we're
going in with double seals of discord
and that would mean that our opponent
needs multiple pickpockets to just get
rid of them. If that is going to be the
case, you're all out of seals.
>> Yeah, exactly. And uh Mindsplitter goes
to hand. Draven does have a lot of fans
and they're overzealous typically as uh
mind spplitter followed up by is a
rocket barrage and a singularity. Rocket
barrage goes to hand war gear
destruction.
>> Uh rocket barrage
>> also has damage on it. It's a utility
spell. Has two options.
>> Takes out two seals if you want.
>> Ooh, gives you that's expensive, but you
know what? It could be worth it.
>> Yeah. If you're playing this with Vex,
then you might not pay too much to use
it.
Is it an action?
>> I believe so.
>> Yes. No, no, it's not. No, it's it's
it's always the repeat line on that.
>> I got to admit, the repeat line I always
read is action. It's like the um
>> it's like us doing the flavor text
earlier, but with rules text.
>> Oh, another pickpocket followed up by
Alan's EQ. You don't need to bounce it
if you have it in the right moment. Next
seal of discord is gone for the man
land. Currently has none on the field.
And if that stays that way, you're going
to lose the grind game. However, there
is a hesitation on one of the runes that
he has does have a retreat and had has
st deck in hand while the pick pocket
thinking about it is already sitting in
the void gate. Retreat came to the front
of the hand.
This is it's such a weird control
matchup in the sense of it's not control
in the countering spells archetype of
control. It's it's controlling economy.
It's grinding your opponent down and
down and down to get very small
advantages. Um, and it's impressive that
both of these players have managed to
pilot this deck to avoid like a draw
bracket in Swiss and get through in the
time required.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. I'm glad you agree
>> cuz that genuinely is something you have
to consider, right? Is you have to be
able to close out games without drawing
too much.
>> We're in 77 minutes, right? So,
>> well, we're untimed now. So, I'm sure if
either of these players hit an Ezreal
mirror in the rest of it, you probably
were like, "Well, I guess we're drawing.
Let's just go take a break."
>> Good point. But right now, you know,
there is the pig pocket that is being
targeted by the Arcane Shift played by
the Fizz. It's really cool to see that
you can discard Arcane Shift if you play
multiple copies of it. Pigpocket is now
being replayed. Of course, takes care of
the seals of discord. There is still one
left on the field. Allen ZQ only has
this one seal left and there was a
retreat as well. So PP pocket would be
able to deal with that um if you were to
retreat it play it again. Now I do
wonder
is that enough to like close the game or
is there a point at which this is quite
a stacked base where Allen goes okay
this is the moment with Bellow's breath
on like coming back to Allen's turn. Is
it too much to play into the base? I I
have no answer for this specifically. Um
it it is just looking at like what are
the options of playing in a different
play style. Where is it that it goes
from hurting the economy to removing
units to be able to conquer
Battlefields?
>> Yeah, that's a very very good question
in this
>> I know incredibly mindboggling.
>> We're going to find out.
>> Definitely. I think I'm I'm quite
excited for the Raza to come down at
some point. While Alan Zakue already has
a pretty threatening unit, which is a
two drop, but in this matchup quite
threatening in one of the void gates,
and that is the Raven Bloom student. I
think that this card actually is super
hard to deal with in the mirror match
because, you know, Draven Bloom's Raven
Bloom, not D, Draven Bloom,
>> that's a very different card,
>> of course, gets one extra might this
turn if you play a spell card.
So,
>> so what we're saying is
>> use so much on this deck.
>> The Raven Bloom student could be bigger
than Rasa quite easily.
>> Yeah.
>> And then could be like the biggest unit,
the biggest brain.
>> They've learned a lot from all the the
spells being played.
>> The thing is we have seen those players
go through stack decks and called shots
as soon as they have them. Of course,
also to re make some use out of their
seal of
>> discord. A lot of the canrips have gone
is is one way of of putting it. So that
that is a very true point in that uh you
have to have the gas left in the tank in
order to do that. Yeah. But I mean
question is when are we going to see the
Raza? The manland has quite the big B
presence already. Of course Alan ZQ has
a lot of cards in hand but I think that
we are slowly but surely getting nearer
and nearer to the point where the
players are starting to play actually
for the battlefields for those points.
Are we going to see a hold of Raven
Bloop Student here or are we just
discussing how many cards we have left
in the deck?
>> It looks like Allan is counting cards in
the deck. I I don't know whether we're
going to get there cuz it didn't happen
in in game two, but just as a reminder
as we uh stack deck, big cheer for stack
deck. Um
>> if you get through your deck
>> Yeah.
>> Uh and you have to recycle your trash.
Your opponent does get a point. One
point is extremely valuable in this
match up. Let me tell you,
>> if we do that like five more what? Seven
more times.
>> You think we're gonna we're gonna win by
just going through our decks?
>> We could be here. We could burn out.
Burn out followed by burnout followed by
burnout.
>> Oh, that is fantastic.
It's going to take a few more minutes
though.
>> It's a wincon. It's a wincon. Oh, there
is the third seal of discord ever
is expanded and now I think the manland
is actually going in heavy here with so
many units. Let's say threatening board
stage. However, Raven Doom student gets
to hold one more point. So, Manland
saying do or die. I'm going to force you
to deal with my units otherwise I'm
going aggressive.
Also, I think we can see the trash of
Alan ZQ, which is only six cards. So,
his Razes actually, they are still quite
expensive.
>> And I'm looking at what options. So,
there's I I can see a stupify. Um
>> there's a morbid return. I think a stack
deck.
>> We are floating to runes for a bellow.
>> This might be potentially a huge push
bellow. Is this Can you Is there enough
there to repeat Bellows enough times
with Fizzes
in order to like take out most of every
Oh, it's Bellow's Watcher. We've seen
this tech elsewhere. Is there enough of
a followup following this? It's Bellow's
breath. Plus, you get the minus three on
the back end. So, it will deal massive
damage to Manland's backline.
>> That is everything except for the Rasa.
if you have not targeted the Raza, if
you're repeating. But now, of course,
the man has is completely
exhausted on runes. So, no hard bargain.
Is there anything Oh, wow. is using the
retreat. Completely exhausted.
>> Target. What's the target? So, um I got
excited about things and didn't see
which units Allan tapped. Did you Did
you cap happen to catch the exact
targets? It must have been that Ezreal.
I think they talked about it but they
have never shown that. Just gets out
everything. Frigid touch as well. This
is a complete board wipe from LZQ out of
nowhere gets another point of course
with the repeat on Bellow's breath. Then
plus the watcher effect on top. It just
needed a one tick of damage on
everything to wipe. And we said Manland
put everything into the base in order to
turn the game around. And Allan says no,
I already have the answer in my hand.
the trap snapped and that is the
advantage of playing thousand tailed
watcher. We've seen the deck list. The
man is not running that cut. Possibly
has not played around it too much. Has
not expected it. He is proficient in the
Ezreal deck mirror match, but that was
something he didn't see coming. The
entire base was ripped apart by thousand
tailed Watcher, Frigid Touch, and
Bellow's breath. And there's another
gear to that play which we haven't seen
is if you can arcane shift the thousand
tailed Watcher on top of it, you can
basically clear everything. But it
wasn't necessary in this situation. I
know Allan didn't have the the the runes
available for it, but it doesn't matter.
It was good enough in that situation to
clear everything, including the retreat.
And now Manland is in a world of
trouble. Behind on points, behind on
units, and potentially out of the top
eight as Allen is looking to focus in.
This is how happy the crowd are on uh
the complete destruction of the
backline. We have the time to go and
look at the the crowd for now in this
mirror matchup.
>> I'm just going to let you en enjoy this
for a second.
>> Fantastic. We could have had this audio
a little bit more, right?
>> We have to at least see what happens in
the rest of the game cuz Manland is
really struggling. We saw in the last
game recognizing that the game was done
and conceding, but now it's top eight.
Your life in the tournament is on the
line. So, you want to play to your outs.
It's understandable to want to try and
get there, but there will be a point
potentially where Manland says there's
not enough left in my deck. What is left
in the deck to turn this around? There's
a lot of count like small spells that
are situational. There's a downwell
there. That's not what you're looking
for. There's a rasa in hand. Maybe that
helps you get out. Double Estreal this
turn discarded a last rights and also a
hard bargain. So those are kind of high
value cards. Plays a Raza and passes.
goes to six, readies,
>> readies the runes. Now Allen's in a
situation where it's a double conquer to
be able to take this game and you know
that Manland now has the Rasa has two
Ezreals. Things have to be put in very
precarious positions. That's seven runes
being tapped. It's a mindslitter. You
get all the knowledge. You get
everything that you want to see.
>> Those are these huge drops.
>> Wow. Okay, that was just clarifying
which card it actually was instead of
just instantly going.
>> I thought it was the instant grab on
Danwell. So,
>> you don't care about pickpocket anymore.
>> Allan's going to take a moment and
Manland is obviously going to think
about how this affects things. Alan,
even though it feels like this is the
last potential set of turns of the game,
Allan is still going to write the cards
down because
>> in the event that things don't go the
way the line that Allan picks, you want
to be clear on what the potential next
steps in this match are because top
eight is on the line.
>> Okay, let's now go one by one through
the cards that you're seeing there on
the side of Alen ZQ. Rocket Barrage
deals some damage, can be repeated, is
there to remove gear. You are not
playing any gear anytime soon except for
gold tokens. If your opponent pops a
gold token with rocket barrage, be my
guest. Pocket does the same. Gust is
there to bounce the pig pockets to
remove gear. So, three cards doing that.
They're not helping anything. And then
there is last rights, of course, but you
take out the downwell. is possibly the
only card that can threaten a big
momentum
>> and that would have been like to slow
Allen but you know downwell doesn't do
enough to fully turn the game you know
all we're doing is saying okay let's
let's take a beat at this point a double
conquer from Allen on the next turn wins
the game you know Malan can maybe delay
for a couple of turns but to establish a
board behind that there's a rasa as well
it does feel like if we had like a
momentum counter it would be heavily in
Allen in ZQ's favor as Manland is going
to awaken.
>> He just passes. We go through eight beat
C
>> channel draw from the top.
>> Is it a good enough answer? It's a fizz,
so you can look for another answer, but
are any of the answers good enough? You
do not have these great pushes with
Thousand Tailed Watcher as you're not
even playing it. Fizz, of course, gives
you so many more options. That is a card
that can turn games around. But then
again, also keep in mind there's only
one point on the side of the man land
>> and and you have to you have to contest
the battlefields otherwise Allen's EQ
just goes to both. You don't have enough
real spells to be able to stop Allen's
EQ going one at a time to open
battlefields to win the game. So
something has to be present. You know,
Allen's EQ has options. Is this the
first time we might actually see things
like gusts being used on Ezreals if the
opponent's Ezreal? is then it becomes
removal. Then it's enough to just get
over the last mark to get to eight
points. I mean, do you at this point
just proactively bounce the Raven Bloom
student just so that you can avoid it
getting big on the next round because
you're really easy to take every last
straw. No,
>> when there's a rasa, a watcher, a mind
spplitter, there is a rain move soon.
You're right. It could get bigger, but
the the might on board is already in my
opinion like strong enough to get
through this. Won't argue with that. No,
it's at this point Manland is going to
look. There's the hand extended. Manland
will concede. Allan ZQ will advance to
the top four here in Bolognia. The
Azreal mastermind. The crowd is going
wild for weeks. Everyone has said that
Allen's EQ is going to be an absolute
monster, a force to be reckoned with
here in Bologna and he has shown why.
Undefeated in Swiss and then played for
the best of card in top eight in the
Ezreal mirror match against so many
pickpockets against all odds. Crushed
it. Best of Kaiser in Houston. Best of
Ezreal in Bolognia. What a resume line
to add for Alan ZQ. Believe it or not,
that was just the top eight. We've got
more Riftbound with the top four coming
up in a few minutes time.
Welcome back to the regional qualifier
here in Bologna as we are getting into
our final four. The top eight has been
culled. Four players are leaving. And
now we get into the semifinals before we
round it out with the grand finals just
a few moments away. The action is
already underway. We already have our se
first semi-final being played. So, let's
get into it as quickly as we can. And a
surprise to be sure as we have Allen.
Well, not really a surprise for Allen
going through on the Ezreal, but Zeic on
the Misfortune is going to be matched by
Ghost Driver on the Victor, the Herald
of the Arcane taking down Prismaticism
to make it through to our semi-finals.
Bracket not quite updated for us yet. As
you can tell, things are going rapidly
now.
>> Things are heating up and Draven can't
handle the heat apparently because
they're dropping out of our top eight as
we continue through as others prove that
they can triumph beyond that.
>> Let's get on into the action. See the
crowd favorite alongside Allen's EQ
taking on Ghost Driver, who we saw have
a superb performance to lock their spot
in the top eight. Honor Victor into the
Draven matchup has now won a couple of
them in a row. We'll have a look at
Sebick's list. It is Aurora MF. No real
surprises in this list overall.
>> No, not at all. And honestly, I'm not
mad about it. Misfortune's got a very
simple game plan, but kind of execute
that to perfection and you can overcome
most things. You want to get that
dazzling Aurora out. You need to ramp up
early with those runes. Bullet time to
deal with any threats on the board and
then just push forward for points. It's
simple yet effective. Low on units,
heavy on damage.
>> It really is. Ghost Driver on the other
side relatively low on units as well.
Using those recruits predominantly has
cool combos at the end like the Imperial
Decree to manage to get the damage down
with the Bella's Broth. You can see how
many spells in this deck are targeted at
taking out a unit, killing a unit,
sacrificing one of your own units to
kill another unit, the hidden blade, the
cold, the weak. It is all about control
of the board.
>> Sorry, was there something about killing
units in there? Apparently, you want to
kill some units, you know, and you get
all of the best of that from order
alongside the blue, the mind runes,
giving you things like singularity, the
stupify, the bellow's breath, just to
really top up your control. Both the
players have been here for a long time
today. But fighting for that first uh
first place in the finals, fighting for
that match as we get into semi-finals.
Once again, rounds in semi-finals are
untimed. The players obviously if they
are playing incredibly slowly will be
asked to play at an appropriate pace but
the expectation is that these players
will be taking just that little bit more
time to really ponder their decisions
and as they should. This is a really big
deal. We're here in the top four of the
regional qualifier Bolognia the first
European qualifier ever. And here we go
in with Misfortune's
brightest moment. Loving going first as
always what you want with Misfortune.
You need that early ramp. You need it
now. We're going to mobilize first to
even push that a little bit further and
get three runes out on our first turn.
>> Yeah, getting up towards that dazzling
Aurora is the most important thing you
can do for Ghost Driver. We see the
Shinshow, Vengeance, Hidden Blade, a
Stupify, and a Cole the weekend. Just
going to be a recruit to kick us off.
The stupify coming down onto it for the
card draw. Can't reduce it below one
anyway. It's already the weakest it can
be. So, just get that extra card draw
out. And okay, on to seq now. Of course,
we just need to ramp as many runes as we
can get towards Oh, the dusting aurora
is already in hand.
>> That it is going to go for the stack
deck. Looking for a catalyst here if we
can find it. Top three, no catalyst. A
fight or flight
>> and I didn't see what was going into
>> again. Just getting that stack deck,
digging further into the deck, looking
for those catalysts, looking for those
mobilize. Anything to help us get those
runes in fast and furious so that we can
get the Dazzling Aurora down so that we
can start seeing our units. What we
don't want to see is our units in our
hand. We want to be getting those out of
the deck with Dazzling Aurora.
>> SEQ did do a good job about playing
around that in the top eight, though.
Had a couple of mind splitters in hand
for a long time, was still able to
manage to navigate the game. Ghost
Driver going up to five uh six five
runes in fact here. Again, not a huge
amount that they can do. Just want to go
into the treasure horde, use an energy
to make a gold out of this. Make sure
you get all of the power that you can
onto the board and then we will see
another recruit coming out to base. This
is kind of how Ghost Driver has played
before. It's relatively slow. You are
looking for these points that you can
get from things like the plundering
power and the recruits, but really
you're waiting to see what threats
develop and then trying to deal with
them. The good thing for Ghost Driver is
you do have that singular main deck
salvage. So, if you can get to that, you
have a bit of gear removal.
>> Yeah. However, safety and numbers
doesn't work against Misfortune. That
bullet time is going to shower down on
every unit that Ghost Driver tries to
populate the board with once it comes
into play. So it might be a bit of a
tricky situation. Generally speaking,
Ghost Driver we've seen has been
populating the board and then flurrying
those units out when appropriate, but
they might not get the space to do so.
>> The good thing for Ghost Driver is they
do tend to like this patience game. Like
keep units in base, have one recruit on
either battlefield. Bullet time does
need to target a battlefield to do that
damage. So if we see an extension of
multiple recruits into one of the
battlefields, then perhaps that bullet
time will have a great effect.
Plundering Po is going to be the play as
Ghost Driver just looking to get up to
that threepoint mark. See still waiting
to get towards the dazzling Aurora is
going to take a little bit of time for
this going though with Misfortune is
that you don't score the points early.
You're late game scoring your points and
kind of pushing yourself up there where
your opponent can't kind of fight back
at you and you use control mechanics to
be able to stop them from rebuilding a
board. Mhm. We'll see if Savic who can
get back to that sort of position.
Currently have the last right out. Is
really nice for recursion of some of
those larger units and when you have so
many kill spells, it is nice for Ghost
of Driver to be in that position
for the moment. Just taking their time.
>> Understandably so. The stakes are so
high at this point.
>> A lot is riding on every move. the
victor. We are I didn't see this in
their quarterfinal match or in their
sorry their last round of Swiss. And
whenever another non-recruit token dies
you make another recruit. So it's kind
of this recursion technique or at least
reanimation technique I guess for your
units allowing you to get a little bit
more uh might into your base.
>> Yeah, just pushing that forward kind of
like a
like you say a reanimation of those
units. As long as it's not a recruit
itself, then you're kind of golden.
Unfortunately, a lot of our units right
now are recruits, but I still like the
Victor for the extra push himself. Four
might isn't that shabby, especially when
there's nothing else facing you on the
other side of the board. At this point,
Ghost Driver probably just wanting to
furiously gain as many points as they
can before SebieQ does go for this
dazzling Aurora,
>> which is possibly being considered now.
>> See what the top deck was. We got
another stack deck. We do have Aurora in
hand. There it goes down immediately.
>> Don't actually think we have too many
units in hand. This is really nice for
See can get towards some of those
stronger units. Looking towards things
like the mind spplitter. Obviously the
volley bear.
>> Here we go with our first Oh, it was the
top deck. The mind spplitter comes down.
>> The top ghost driver is going to have to
reveal here. Bellow zinc out a
vengeance, a wages, a hidden blade in
the cold of the week. So lots of removal
tools. The wage is not as powerful
against these Aurora decks.
>> All the weeks got to go.
>> Agreed.
>> That's too scary. There's a lot of good
cards in that hand, but I think yeah, a
great great choice of jotting it all
down and making sure you know what's
coming, but then I think the call of the
week's got to go. That is the most scary
card here. Each player kills one of
their units. Of course, Ghost Driver is
just going to take out a recruit, but
then Sebecue's only got big units.
That's the whole point of his deck. He's
only got big guys, and they come out
slowly. We can recur them with last
rights, but right now that's going to be
a struggle. So, as we're looking at the
board right now, a really bit of great
early hand control from Aurora, from the
uh not Aurora, Misfortune, Aurora build,
uh
>> from the Aurora play there. But yeah,
Mind Splitter is a fantastic card of
this deck. Just being able to look at
your opponent's hand, know exactly
what's coming for the next few turns,
know what threats are on board and what
is coming your way. that you can
appropriately spend your runes in the
next few turns.
>> Ghostaster driver there. It says they
went to six. I thought it was five, but
I may have miscounted in terms of
points. We'll see if that is exactly
correct cuz I thought we were at three
at the end of last turn with the recruit
at the start and then recruit hold into
the plundering power recruit on that top
battlefield. Uh for the moment just
really thinking about how they want to
try and deal with this Aurora in base.
doesn't have salvage in hand. Has to
really wonder exactly how you want to
play it cuz you also don't really want
to give up too much control of these
battlefields. Factory manufacturer will
get you another recruit since will be
able to enter ready because you already
have two units in your base.
>> And with the tank, I it's it's four
damage mitigated with a plundering power
and a recruit. But there's still seven
just from the mind spplitter without
even having that last rights equipped
onto it. No, we can expect an effective
nine from the mind spplitter. So, either
you need to bulk something out that's
going to be better than a nine in a
battlefield. Otherwise, everything's
just feeling a little bit lackluster.
>> Not quite putting in the work we need to
put it in. So, what have we got there so
far? 3 4 5 6 7. Not quite there to be
able to take a mine spplitter with the
last rights.
>> Yeah. I wonder if you're thinking about
just culling the weak here, killing off
one of your recruits, getting rid of the
mine spplitter anyway.
>> Y
>> investing that resource. Now you do
still need to worry about the dazzling
at the end of Seeq's turn, but for the
moment you aren't under too much threat
on that next turn at least.
>> No, it's nice here because Seeq will be
hardressed to kind of use the last
rights to take a conquer this turn now
and bring back that mine spplitter. So
at least we're slowing things down a
little bit as far as SEQ is concerned.
and Ghost Drivers doing a really good
job of managing their resources,
bringing some of the units back to base
just to keep them ready for next turn
for some maneuverability.
>> Yeah, the risk of course is Misfortune
Captain can come in accelerated. You
equip the last rights and then you go in
for that conquer. So, not wanting to
lose too much to that threat. Still
keeping up two as well for the hidden
blade which can be used when the
misfortune comes in. goes to driver
trying to play around the fact that on
board SebieQ does have a way to
accelerate into that battlefield and
start to challenge.
>> Yeah, that on board knowledge is so
crucial in this moment, especially when
SebieQ knows what's in Ghost Driver's
hand and not the other way around. Okay,
looking at some more cards. We love a
bit of that. Let's see what stack deck's
going to give us now. Looking like a
bullet time and a couple of others, but
I didn't see what the other cards were.
>> Definitely a bullet time. I think it was
the one at the top. So that seems to
have gone back onto the bottom of the
deck. What would Sebeek be looking for
in this sort of position? There's a
bunch of options. I know they do run the
gusts. They could be looking just to
bounce back the manufacturer or a
recruit, which disappears of course when
it is bounced back to the hand cuz it is
a token.
>> Yes, maybe sort of a fight or flight
challenge kind of angle. Gus, kind of
anything to push
>> the last few units back. So maybe an
accelerate can come in and take a point,
but
>> because at this point we that's what we
need to start looking at, right? Ghost
drivers in a great position and SEQ now
needs to start to put the pressure on in
regards to actually going towards
winning the game. We've done a great job
of board presence. We've done a great
job of controlling what's in the hand,
which sabotage is going to help even
more so with kind of eyeing up that
Bellow's breath there.
>> And that's what this is all about for
SEQ is kind of this control angle. You
might think, okay, Misfortune looks like
it's a really seriously kind of aggro
deck. And actually, it's kind of the
opposite. It's this control variant.
It's all about what's going on in your
opponent's hand and when you need to
time things effectively.
>> And now using the sabotage to get rid of
the hidden blade, the wages of pain
can't kill off the MF in and of itself.
So, we accelerate the misfortune out.
Can look to try and conquer this top
battlefield if we so desire. Could also
just go down to the treasure horde. And
it's only a one might recruit down
there. The risk was something like a
hidden blade when you move in.
>> Not going to equip those last rights.
Don't need the extra might for now.
>> Ready's a rune from the first time I
move trigger on misfortune captain.
>> Yeah, looks like we're just going on in
there. Ghost drivers deciding whether to
respond
>> to this misfortune.
>> It's the wages of pain right now, right?
or even going for the bellow's breath to
bring it down. Repeat it takes it down
by two wages of pain does give you a
little bit more damage. So deciding the
bellow's breath was the better option.
Hard bargaining out of it though
that those two units will get taken out.
Another recruit is maid from the victor
which is why that one stayed on the
battlefield. It wasn't just
shortcutting.
>> No, no, not at all. But we are going to
hide a card there with Misfortune to
give her a little bit of backup and
again just make her a little less
squishy to Ghost Driver's kind of pummel
of attacks right now.
>> Dazzling Aurora, the first card revealed
from the Dazzling Aurora. Not really
what you want. They're going to go
through and find our first unit on this
end of turn trigger. It is Volibear
imposing a massive unit. 10 might shield
three tank. And when an opponent moves
to a battlefield other than mine, draw a
card.
>> Unit is certainly the word I would use
to describe Volibear in this instance.
My word, what a colossal titan to be
going up against. When you're looking at
a deck like Ghost Drivers where you've
got lots of little units, you do get a
bit afraid when you're staring down at
10 might.
>> It's so difficult for you. You are
looking for those just instant kills.
Got to
>> unconditional kills is what you need.
The hidden blades,
>> the colder weaks,
>> the tricks.
>> Yeah, ghost driver. They're actually
taking notes on what's going on to the
bottom of the main deck here. Smart, you
have the time. You might as well
>> know that another Dazzling is down
there.
>> Ghost of Driver only needing those next
two points to really tip the scales in
their favor. Take down the first game of
this best of three in the semifinals.
>> But the issue will get the hold. SEQ
really does have a hold on them at this
point. They've done their best to
control what's in Ghost Driver's hand.
They've only allowed smaller units to
survive on the stage. So now Ghost
Driver's got this really difficult
notion of trying to bring it back and
deal with some of these larger units.
And all they've got to do so is well
spells. They can't really dish out
enough active might damage to win
combats against these Titans. Yeah, it's
going to be really difficult for ghost
to driver in this situation. Drew the
pickpocket which doesn't do much into
the dazzling aurora deck. Great for
removing things like seals, but we don't
see any seals on the battlefield. This
isn't sea life sea world places where
you might see seals. The sea, I guess,
is also one of those.
>> And apparently a riftbound stage. Uh but
not in this instance cuz uh we haven't
got any out yet. and doesn't really look
like we can do a whole lot.
>> So, with Ghostaster Driver there
holding, I do think that previously when
we've moved up to six points, it was
actually at five cuz now it is still s
sitting at six.
>> So, that was a miscount from three to
six the turn before pickpocket comes
down.
Could kill off a gold if there was a
gold around, but there's no gold to be
killed.
>> There's no loot.
>> Yeah, recruit pulled back. Yeah, you
when you play the pickpocket, you can
kill a gear with energy cost no more
than one. If you do, you make a gold.
So, I mean, you could kill your own gold
to make a gold, but there's no gold to
be killed. Since will come in ready, go
to driver setting up for a future turn
with something like an Imperial decree
to send in a few recruits, get the
damage down, keeping them back to avoid
the bullet time that Seeq could play
out.
>> And that's the risk. You've got you've
got to build up in base with that risk
of the bullet time. So, you've got to
build up in base and then go in when
you're ready. But that just allows SEQ
to start gaining points. Finally, hold
points are going to be where Seviq just
ramps up. Now that 1 to six gap looks
big, but it isn't when you consider the
context.
>> It really is not. It's one of those
where as you were talking about like SEQ
you you build and you build and build
until you have the dazzling until you
start getting these massive units out
and then it becomes really tricky for
your opponents to take control of the
board state unless you are you know
packaged into that that purple miracle
you know things like the fight or flight
the rebuke that allows you to bounce
some of these units but for ghost driver
you're not getting huge amount of draw.
>> Nope.
>> You don't really want to be using hidden
blades on your own units for the extra
draw cuz you kind of want to kill the
Volibear and the MF.
>> You really do. So whenever you get those
resources, they are being invested into
trying to mitigate some of the power
that Sebq has developed.
>> A little bit of a discussion about a
rune being around. Yes.
>> So it just looks like we're ironing that
out for a moment and then we're readying
for the turn. Here we go. back over to
SebieQ as we go ahead and jump straight
back in to this heavy control moment
that Misfortune is presenting. And we've
still got card draw in hand. We've still
we've got units in hand, I believe, as
well now. So, among the depths of the
Dazzling Aurora, there might still be a
couple in deck, but this is a very low
unit deck in general. you're generally
wanting them played off the dazzling
Aurora and then you're kind of using
your tips and tricks in hand to kind of
dig through uh just like challenge.
Okay, going to take out one of the
bigger units taking down that Victor so
that recruit tokens can't keep spawning
in.
>> Yeah, killing out anything that can give
more units over to Ghostaster
MF Bounty Hunter being tapped to give
the Volibear ganking. Making sure that
we have the runes appropriately paid for
that challenge does mean now Sebq
doesn't have the runes for punch first,
but punch first doesn't really matter
too much here.
>> See is going to go over to the treasure
hord get their third point of the game.
>> Dancing right up there to three points
to six. But as we've assessed, Ghost
Driver is kind of stuck in the mud on
that six and Sebie Q's now coming up
behind. It's not about who gets up to
that six first, it's who gets to eight.
We are just coming on from behind and
the you know the early bird didn't quite
get the worm in this instance.
>> It's one of those now where you're
looking for what your outs are as ghost
driver and I think thing like the most
obvious one is Imperial decree right the
the ability to play Imperial decree go
in with some of these recruits avoid any
bounces from Sebecq would make a lot of
sense. The last rights is going to get
equipped to misfortune here with the
sabotage and can't see quite what was
under it. Back onto the bottom of the
main deck. It's mine. Oh, sabotage is
going to stay. Mine spplitter is going
to go to the bottom. Coaster drivers.
Yeah, you you shuffled them a few times.
That's okay. No need for any more
shuffling of that. And now I think Seeq
probably just going to move towards the
Aurora step. There we go. Gust off the
top. Final flight mobilize. Where are we
going creature-wise?
>> I don't know what we have left, but
another mind spplitter will do quite
nicely. Yeah, there wasn't one in hand,
so that suits. And again, continues to
chip chip away at Ghost Driver's hand.
We once again get to have a little peek
in there and take something away. And
that's just that's damning at this
point. It's really difficult cuz Ghost
Driver just can't seem to keep anything
in their hand. It's gone.
>> Yeah, wages of pain. I think the only
non unit that was in there
>> seemed to get uh put away pretty
sharpish.
>> Seems
>> I think you've got to target the spells,
haven't you? The units aren't a problem.
You're used to that. That's your whole
jam is getting these units overpowered
and overwhelmed.
>> Invert timelines, a volley bear imposing
and a cold shot in hand.
In invert timelines, you don't really
want to play at this point. No point
giving better cards or different cards
over to Ghost of Driver. You know, they
are struggling a little bit at the
moment. I have the rest of those
recycling recycled to the bottom of
SeekQu's hand uh deck as we move into
what is a pivotal draw for Ghost Driver
here. Amy,
>> Ghostaster really needs to pick up the
pace, but I don't know if they're going
to be able to. Both battlefields have
such colossally huge units.
>> That is not what you want.
>> Oh, that is not what we needed. Another
small unit just not going to help us out
that much. We needed something to bring
us back into this game and that top deck
wasn't it. We can make another recruit
token, but it's looking like we've run
out of steam. If you're Ghostaster
Driver at this point, you're just going
to have to keep building that base as we
assessed. You don't want SebieQ to take
any more from your hand. You can't leave
anything kind of remaining. You've just
got to play out as much as you can. And
back onto SebieQ's turn, who's taking an
absolute storm ride up to eight points
at this point.
>> Ghost driver has two more draws. Two
more draws to try and find a way out of
this situation. See is going to continue
to try and deny him. Cold shot most
likely to kick us off here just to have
a look at a few more cards. You have the
gold as well. You can use one of your
chaos runes to pay the power. So we can
repeat that. Cord shot. Look at the top
two twice. Draw one, recycle one both
times.
>> Another cord shot and an aurora. Don't
need the aurora. That can go to the
bottom. We already have one. And we're
in a commanding board state. Next up, a
challenge and a punch first.
>> I like the challenge here.
>> I agree. I think punch first doesn't
give you too much. You're already
outing. Get rid of this Shincha on the
board where you can. And those are the
two cards that have gone into hand.
Yeah, the challenge
>> again. Chip away at the larger units.
Shinjia feels like the perfect target
there.
>> There we go. See just doing everything
they can to make ghosta driver's board
as small as possible. Give them as few
outs as possible. And there's not a huge
amount you can do. You don't have
something like a bellow's breath that
can just wipe away six of these recruits
in one fell swoop. Instead, you just got
to pick and you got to poke and you got
to prod and you got to slowly wh your
way to victory. dazzling aurora trigger.
We know one of the volley bears is in
hand, one out on the board. And there's
the splitter.
>> And that's why ghost to driver couldn't
risk keeping any cards in their hand.
They had to play out because otherwise
mind splitter was just going to take it
away. So if it was advantageous at all
to play it and in this case putting a
unit down isn't exactly a bad thing. Uh
then it was worthwhile. So SeekQu
doesn't get anything any hand knowledge
because there's no hand knowledge to be
had. means SECQ only has one creature
left in their deck. It is a mindslitter
>> with both the volley bears
>> already in play in so to speak. One in
hand, one on the field and two mind
spplitters out. Now goes to driver. You
are looking for an Imperial decree.
>> We need it. I think it's the only thing
that gets us out of this situation
>> and you need to be able to play it
through a hard bargain. Repeat it cuz
See has the runes to do so. Thousand
tail watcher.
>> Does that change the maths?
>> It might well do. We at least will be
reducing everything by three and then
you can kind of swarm in on a
battlefield. But I don't we definitely
can't do two battlefields. And I think
that's the shame of the situation. But
we're still going to have to play this.
Like we can't not otherwise it surely
just gets taken away again by a mine
spplitter. So I think we don't have a
choice but to play the Thousand Tail
Watcher. the the choice is how are we
going to go about it?
>> Well, let's do some maths here if we
can. With the last rights on the MF,
that's seven plus seven on that top
battlefield. 14 in total. On the bottom,
you have the Volibear imposing who does
have shield. I believe shield three if I
remember correctly
>> with the mind splitter as well. So, that
will be 20.
>> An effective 20 on defending. which is
what's going to happen here.
Otherwise, it is shield freezer
takes off the top. That's eight might
remaining for See on the bottom. You
have six off it as well. That's 14
>> in hand. We have a hard bargain, a cold
shot, an invert timelines, and a volar.
Nothing to do about this thousand tail
watcher. You do just have to accept the
minuses on that one for this turn.
>> Ghoster Driver does not attack. Passes
the turn. I believe we see the holds
come out for Sebecue. Ghoster Driver, no
cards in hand. A bullet time.
>> Ghost driver has to take both
battlefields. I think that's the thing.
So, what they're trying to do is build
up that base, go and take both
battlefields. That's the game. That's
the win. That's how close they are to
winning is they need to take both of
them on the same turn. So, they're
building up to that moment. You have to
remember as well we have perfect
information. Ghost of Driver doesn't
know if there's two punch firsts in
hand. Doesn't know a fight or flight in
hand as well. So it has to play around
every possible out. We'll skip to
basically the end of the turn. See I
think just realizing
>> well
>> I can just go for the dazzling.
>> Ghostaster driver truly looking I
believe for an Imperial decree. It will
be a mindspplitter off. How deep is it
near the bottom? It seems
>> there's the mind splitter. Nothing in
hand. Where is this going
>> on the bottom out of it? I feel like you
you only need to hold the one right now.
>> But splitting up your units forces goes
to Driver to potentially do the same.
>> Yeah, 14 on that bottom battlefield. The
Volibear was ganked across with the
bounty hunter misfortune's ability. So
you can see SEQ investing more on the
top side thinking they need a little bit
more defense there. What is off the top
for Ghost Driver for game one of this
best of three in the semifinals of the
regional qualifier here in Bologna? Can
the Herald of the Arcane get some Hex
Tech magic from the top?
>> It is a time warp. You buy a turn. Is
that enough?
>> It might be. Time warp does allow you to
take another turn. You could play it
just to draw another card.
>> I think you Not impossible.
>> If you time warp,
you lose a few of your runes.
Currently sitting at 11 on the field, I
think, which means you wouldn't be able
to pay for a hard bargain.
Ghostster driver does not know that, but
you caught one card in hand
>> and your opponent has all of their runes
standing.
>> So, it looks terrifying to try and take
over any sort of battlefield.
>> But that's going to have to happen at
some point.
>> I The question is as well is if you are
going to time warp, do you want to go
in, kill a few things, then time warp to
try and be in a more advantageous spot
on the next turn? I think that's what
goes to driver is currently thinking
about how much can I take off one of
these battlefields. The volley bear
imposing with shield three and tank is
13 might you need to get through.
>> Is it a possibility to attempt to take
one battlefield and then hold?
>> Yeah, it's it's very possible but you've
got to play around double punch first.
The mind spplitter battlefield is where
we are going. Thousand tail watcher in
with
an additional
46 might uh seven might in fact 14 v14.
Is there a response from Sebie Q? I
don't know if they've got anything in
hand that can come back at this, but
apparently maybe shot.
>> We're going to go searching. We're going
to go searching. Repeated cool shot.
Fight or flight catalyst. Fight or
flight immediately.
>> Yeah, straight away. We don't need
catalyst right now. That was for early
game and we didn't get it and we don't
want it now.
>> Catalyst. Not great. Neither does much
for us. I think we took the mobilize in
the end. The cheaper of the two.
>> Oh yeah, that makes sense.
>> We have a stack deck in hand as well and
a bullet time. Have a lot of tools.
to try and deal with this.
>> We have to go on the push back. We have
to try and just stabilize and keep this
battlefield under control for Sebie Q
here.
>> Use the two fight or flight targeting
watcher.
>> Makes sense.
>> It gets bounced back. We'll trade a mine
spplitter for the remaining three.
>> Okay, we've got a lot of recruit guys.
How many recruit? 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 eight
recruit tokens is enough. You could
flurry them all in there, but you leave
yourself so volatile because then you've
got nothing left other than the thousand
tail watcher in base.
>> I mean, I think the logic is at this
point if you are looking for the hold,
you send in seven time. Here we go.
>> Time warp out by Ghostaster Driver. A
hard bargain is met and the time will
stop for Ghostaster.
No extra turn for you, says Sebieq.
>> And Ghost driver with a nod to the head
extends the fists. Game one to Sebeq.
>> It's time to set sail with SebieQ as we
come into our first win of our
semifinals.
Let's see what game two has in store.
Whether Ghostaster Rider can pull the
ship back in their direction.
>> It was so close as well. If you get an
Imperial decree a little bit earlier
would have done a lot of work in the
cyborg.
Maybe a Gust could come in here for
Sebecue. The unyielding spirit doesn't
do a huge amount cuz most of the kills
are kills rather than damage deals. It
does work around a singularity. Invert
timelines as well not the best when
you're looking to remove so many cards
and you don't want to give the cards
back to your opposition.
But what a play from the Aurora. uh
widely regarded as one of the decks that
was playing for best offs.
>> Absolutely. But now we're here in the
semifinals of Bologna Riftbound regional
qualifier with a Misfortune and Victor
Deck. And if you'd have asked me
yesterday if I could have predicted
that, I would have told you there's no
shot. And I'm so glad to be wrong.
>> So am I. So am I. I think the two
salvages very likely to come in here for
Ghost of Driver trying to slow down that
Aurora plan. Alongside that, you could
look for another Imperial Decree just
make it a bit easier for you to find
that out because you are running two in
the main though and it is a bit of a
brick if you draw it too early.
>> I do think adding the two salvages makes
a lot of sense. Probably take out the
pick pockets. They're not giving you a
huge amount. Not too much gold being
generated by the dazzling Aurora player
>> and the three might it doesn't really
give you a lot overall.
>> No, it they're not helping that much.
That's the thing. We saw it really not
come into play that much and even when
they did come into play it was kind of
like oh yeah well there there it is. Uh
it's not doing much but there it is. So
I think yeah when you when you're you
know killing a gear and drawing one
instead salvage is feeling a lot better
there. And then of course you've got
that extra last rights removal. So maybe
you'll slow SebieQ down. Kind of play
them at their own game. Be like, "Oh,
you're taking things away from me. I'm
going to take things away from you.
Let's see what the second battlefields
are and whether they're going to turn
the tide of this game."
>> It's always possible.
>> It's always an interesting pick. I'm
really bad at picking battlefields
myself. I'm genuinely awful at it. And I
think it's such a it can be such an
important mechanic of this game.
>> It really can. It's uh Obelisk of Power
and the Raven Bloom Conservatory
on the bottom side.
We will see uh how effective this Raven
Bloom is and you are managed to defend
there and it's defend not hold
importantly. You are revealing the top
card of your deck. If it's a spell, you
are putting it into your hand. An honest
broker recruit as a turn one for Ghost
Driver with that extra rune out of the
obelisk of power. Zeb very happy to be
at four even though they are the second
player to take their turn one in the
game on turn two I guess but it's kind
of second turn one into a catalyst
>> catalyst immediate ramp perfection
exactly what we want so many runes at
the start of the game you don't care
about units at this point that is not
the point of what Misfortune's going for
runes and runes we're getting a plenty
>> it means on turn three we will have
enough runes for that dazzling aurora
goes to driver taking their time. Expect
this to be I mean you can see it's like
do I do I go storms? Raven Blue
Conservatory does give me the defend
trigger, but I'm not really going to
defend for a while. Might as well be
there. Get the first point and the
second point with the Honest Broker
going in.
>> Trying to go heavy on those early
points. I think it's completely fair
considering what happened last game. You
just want to get there quickly.
>> Yeah, because in late game you are
likely to get one turn, one chance to
really turn it around. You saw if an
Imperial decree had come out, you just
needed that one or those two points to
really manage to close out the game. So,
you got to swarm. You got to be out
there fast. You got to be getting these
early points because you know there is
an inevitability out of SeekQu. The
dazzling will be played if you have a
salvage. Yes, you can answer it to a
degree, but then another and another and
if not those, then the creatures on top
of them for SeekQu. It is the oncoming
storm of this misfortune. Ooh, this is a
bit of a not great hand to be honest.
We've got some really interesting late
and mid game cards, but really at the
moment we're wanting to dig more. We got
a cold shot there, so thank goodness we
managed to stack deck into cool shot.
And that's kind of what you're wanting
to do at this stage of the game as
Misfortune is shred through the deck
towards the Dazzling Aurora. Now, you've
got the advantage with those runes.
You're going to be able to keep the pace
there. But now we're wanting to shred
quickly through the deck to get to our
Aurora so we can play it as soon as
possible.
>> And we will bring out the MF early. No
need to accelerate. Don't want to pay
that extra cost for now. In hand, a cord
shot, a challenge, a hard bargain, and a
fight or flight. Two more points over to
Ghost to Driver. Halfway towards
equalizing this series. We'll go up to
seven runes in total. getting towards
that point where things like the
Imperial decree do start to come online,
but you you only have an MF on the other
side. No need to play those big kills.
Another Honest Broker in hand.
>> Ghost to Driver got the two hole.
>> There's a salvage sitting there.
>> The first card in the hand I believe is
a salvage here for Ghost of Driver. Two
Honest Brokers, a salvage, a hidden
blade, and one other card that I can't
quite identify from this angle, but
Ghost of Driver is holding on. And
obviously no dazzling Aurora in Sebcq's
hand as of now.
>> Wages of pain.
>> It would make sense. It would make
sense.
>> Regardless, looking quite hot here in
regards to what we kind of need to push
forward and just keep these keep these
hold points running for a little while.
We need them to run a little bit hotter.
>> We do for the moment. Ghost driver
holding back in base. Going to make a
recruit to kick things off. Making sure
the mats works. This energy is one that
can be spent right now and it can have
another recruit to add to the evolving
army.
>> I don't know what the play here is. I
don't know what Riptide was rip tide.
That's actually a really interesting
inclusion in this deck, which I haven't
seen much before, but I like it in this
build that we've seen from Ghost Driver
already today because it does give a bit
more aggression and we could use a unit
like that to take down this misfortune.
It's not something that you typically
see.
>> Yeah,
>> it gets you that six damage. does quite
a lot of work in matchups like when
you're playing towards things like the
Draven when you want that just little
bit of extra damage into those uh units
that can really outmatch your recruits
early on. Pass of the turn.
>> We're in a war range but haven't got one
in hand yet.
>> Holding holding up salvage energy on the
other side.
>> Still have that cold shot. can still
look to draw more cards.
>> Angle here little fly on the wall.
>> I do find it funny that See like always
draws upside down from his deck and then
when when he has to put like the cord
shot cards in or the stack deck cards
in, he then switches it all around
afterwards as well.
>> To have the sabotage as well in hand. It
would be great to use that to get rid of
>> the salvage that is sitting in. Another
cold shot. Punch first and another
called shot.
>> We do need the gold shots.
Unfortunately, we're still digging for
that dazzling Aurora. We've got to keep
siphoning through this deck. We got a
Gust
>> there. That's not helpful. And a
catalyst of AON.
>> Yeah, Gust definitely more than the
catalyst right now.
>> We need to keep pushing things back.
>> Catalyst does give you the card draw.
>> That's true. when you are all stacked up
on those runes.
>> But I think at the moment we're still
looking at just pushing things back and
cycling through the deck. And we do have
another cold shot. So we can keep going
with that card draw. And at least the
gust does give us give us a bit of
maneuverability to push our opponent's
units back. But we're just going to go
in with the misfortune. Just going to go
with a simple aggressive move and say,
"Look, I I want to I want to take my
first point." Okay,
>> defend trigger. The plundering power
goes to the bottom. Going to get a death
nail here from the honest broker as
ghost driver will make themselves a gold
because the victor's out. You also make
a recruit.
>> So you kind of get a bit of a refund as
well on that um death trigger.
>> Misfortune taking a a conquer point
there
>> which we didn't see early game last
game. I like that this is being played
so differently. It's nice to see the
deck has flexibility as well. both are
being played very differently so far.
Just the cards have come out in very
different order and that could really
turn the tides.
>> And because of that, Sebu has actually
had to use a lot of their power now
using that mobilize to try and get some
of these runes back. You can see those
those three upturned runes with the uh
Sisphen Voltob that's sitting at the
bottom. Those are going to have to be
recycled at the end of the turn, but
they're flipped up to show that there is
still energy remaining. Challenge like
this go MF to Victor here to stop that
recruit engine from continuing.
Yeah, the challenge to just keep
whittling away
at just considering which one we were
going to recycle that uh to just keep
whittling away at ghost uh ghosts
units once again really
>> double fight or flight Augusta hard
bargain in hand still with that sabotage
as well that See is holding on to for
now hidden fight or flight towards the
bottom battlefield adds a little bit of
protection to the misfortune turn is
passed. See a long way away from a
dazzling Aurora playing very much like
they don't have one makes it pretty
obvious but having to do so because
otherwise you are just going to fall
behind in points too rapidly
>> to Ghostaster Driver here on the Victor
>> and that's the thing you've got to just
keep up because otherwise go to driver
is just going to keep pushing those
cheap units taking those whole points
keeping on to those conquers so there
had to be some sort of advance here. Soq
had to respond by putting the misfortune
into a battlefield just to slow things
down a little bit.
>> And now a bellow's breath drawn for
ghost driver. We'll look for the first
conquer here on the obelisk of power.
>> Just sending one recruit in like a
little a little spy. He's having a
little scout. See if anyone's there.
Nope. Cool. I'll have a point. Thank you
very much. Up to five there for
Ghostaster Driver.
>> I mean it's really big for Ghost Driver
if they can find a way to try and get
through this misfortune. And Riptide Rex
is exactly that. The fight or flight
will need to be activated for Seecute to
bring that MF back to base. Will keep
her safe.
>> You see the two recycles coming out
there. Power cost on the Riptide Rex.
Not too commonly seen, but we talked
about it as a possibility here. Getting
rid of that fight off flight. Another
conquer gets ghost to drive it to six
and they are just one good turn away
from equalizing this semifinal.
I heard myself over the PA there for a
second.
>> It's giving the players a moment to to
think about it. Honest broker down
instead of
>> is a great addition this deck. I really
enjoy the fact that you've gone for that
slightly more aggressive unit. Really
being able to fight your way in there
and normally that's not something we
know Victor decks for. We know them for
these overwhelming smaller units. But
actually being able to put a Riptide Rex
in just to deal some extra damage, but
also then keep a larger unit swimming
around for a little bit as well is
really advantageous. At this point, I
think you're just looking to keep with
this exact pacing holding and chipping
away because Sebie Q's just on this back
foot of not having the dazzling Aurora
yet. We haven't found it. It's just
nowhere to be seen.
>> Pass the turn. We're not going to see it
yet either. Child comes out. Punch
first. Gust sabotage.
>> Feels like it's a cold shot or maybe a
sabotage first.
>> You could go for it. There's a hidden
blade, I believe, still sitting in the
hand. There's a hard bargain in there as
well that does deal with the hidden
blade because there's only two runes up
for Ghostster Driver right now.
>> Mhm.
>> I think seeing more runes always makes
sense. We'll have the MF go in. The
reveal on defend wages a pain to hand
now.
Misfortune looking like they are
>> in a fortunate position to win this but
we're coming through with the hidden
blade and of course we have the hard
bargain to counter back at that
>> and that means that you don't get the
hold
doesn't really have those accelerate
units to get out here as well so really
needed to take that battlefield well
played around it does it early
pays for the hard bargain
manages managing to take that
conservatory back
is big.
>> Mhm.
>> Ghost driver is now going to have to
work a little harder to get this
misfortune kind of out of the way with
Riptide Rex there. It's a little easier,
but SebieQ has a lot of runes still
standing, so you can expect some
punching action, etc.
>> Yeah, nothing hidden at the battlefield.
See, I think does still have a fight or
flight in hand if I remember correctly.
So we'll be able to mount something. I
think probably not hiding it to not give
too much information over to Ghostaster
Driver. I don't want them knowing.
You've holding on to the punch first as
well. So you can sequence as you like.
Wages of pain aimed at misfortune.
>> Sabotage punch first. Fight or flight. A
gust.
>> We'll get a gold here for ghost driver
holds to seven. Remember on that top
battlefield. Bellow's breath for two
more repeated.
>> Okay. Using the gold and that mind rune
looking for the two damage. See, that MF
is dead. And now the recruits can make
their march towards the second
battlefield.
And look for that eight. He gets it. The
concession comes in. We're going to game
three as Sebecue falls to Ghosted
Drivers swarm of recruits.
>> Victor just taking the lead there. Not
any breath to be given to Misfortune.
They absolutely took the battlefields by
storm. Just didn't give any wiggle room.
And that's exactly what we need to do.
We need to go in fresh and fast. And
that is what this is this matchup is all
about. Can Misfortune get to that
Dazzling Aurora in this game two? The
answer was no. Are we going to see a
repeat of that in game three or will
Misfortune just overwhelm Victor's
resources as we saw in game one?
>> And you you see some of the
inconsistencies of misfortune of Aurora
generally as a play style here is when
you don't get the Aurora both you need
to play incredibly well but also your
opponent needs to not get their game
plan online as quickly as happened here
for Ghost of Drivers. So for Sebq a
little bit of a struggle. There was
always that salvage in hand as remember
as well for ghost of driver. So did have
ways to deal with an Aurora if it came
down. Sideboards I don't expect too much
to change from game two
>> as really for Sebeek just didn't quite
get online. We'll move into game three
in a second as we look again at the
main. There's nothing really here that
you you're thinking I have to take this
out. the invert timelines I guess as an
option if you are using those mind
splitters effectively but that's also
reliant on you getting to the dazzling
aurora and invert timelines can often
help you do that
>> exactly so honestly I'm not sure many
changes would need to be made I think it
was just unlucky that we didn't see the
dazzling aurora so the game plan wasn't
able to kind of push its way forward and
that's the risk you take when you play a
deck like either of these both have a
very clear game plan more so with
Misfortune and if you just don't get
there then you kind of run out of steam.
You just can't go any further with it.
So, it can be a bit troublesome.
>> And we will be going to Aspirin's climb
for Seabek. Takes us to nine, which
obviously is great for him. Delays the
game just that little bit. And it's a
void gate for ghost to driver for those
little bits of extra damage. The
bellow's breath ticking up to four. The
wages of pain going there as well.
And let's see. See on the plate will
mobilize
>> to start us off. Get that extra rune
out. Three for ghost to driver draws I
believe a plundering porro
>> useful at the beginning of the game.
Cheap to play. We make one. Yep. One
recruit and then maybe play the porro
>> or just pass. Oh,
>> maybe it wasn't a plundering. Maybe it
was the superify. Go for the draw here
>> and then passes the turn. Yeah, I think
if it was a porro it would have come
down. So I maybe just misread the card
art there. Five now four seq building up
towards that nine mark which is the
vital mark for Aurora decks. A stack
deck to look at the top three puts one
immediately into hand. Wonder if that
was a catalyst.
>> Got to expect that it was certainly
something worthwhile if it goes to hand
that quickly. SEQ's been playing this
deck for many hours at this point. So I
think I did see a catalyst.
>> Makes sense. Yeah. Plays it out.
Channels two more.
>> Perfect.
We are at seven. Next turn there is an
Aurora possibility. Ghost driver has to
play around it. We see Imperial decree
in hand. A vengeance. I do not see the
salvage. It could be waiting there. A
recruit played out alongside it. It's
Shin Sha.
>> Shinsha coming in ready because there's
two recruits in base. So that's handy.
We can push forward. Try and get those
early points again. This time we could
move a recruit and Shinjia into a base
each and then that kind of goes along
with the game plan that happened last uh
last game which worked out really well
for ghost to driver. So maybe that's the
way we go forward with this now and try
and kind of hope the dazzling aurora
doesn't manifest next turn.
>> I mean it's kind of a hope and dream but
the way SeekQu's played is I have an
Aurora. I am getting to this Aurora as
quickly as possible. not even stopping
to play out the MF. Can't quite see the
whole hand for Seb, but even if you
don't have the Aurora in hand, just
ramping towards it.
>> I would I I I very much
>> follow along with your presuppositions
about this position. Mind spplitter
drawn. Aurora down.
>> There it is.
>> Aurora is down. Now, that will use all
of our runes for the turn. We will have
to use it as our final action. So at the
end of the turn, we reveal from the top
of the deck until we hit a creature.
>> We have two volleys and a mind spplitter
as units to hit.
>> The mind spplitter, which is a great
unit in this instance, getting the
knowledge of ghost driver's hand, but
also being able to remove a card.
>> I wish that hand was in the middle of
the battlefield instead of off towards
the side.
Elation and devastation on the faces of
the crowd
as we see
SBQ taking their time writing down the
cards that are in hand
and then can decide to get rid of any of
them. There was a salvage and not the
runes to play it
>> with only one left up. The salvage taken
out.
No killing that dazzling Aurora off
quite yet.
>> Still likely two more in the deck. No
reason not to have side decked in all of
them. A Vengeance and Imperial decree is
what I see down towards the bottom. We
knew about those. The salvage picked as
the one to be discarded. Got to go.
>> Yeah, no real surprises there at all.
>> Not at all. Ghost driver is going to get
two hold points though. We did manage to
hang on to those uh those battlefields
since the only thing SEQ could do of
course was use the first instance of
dazzling Aurora. So we do rocket up to
uh four points here and that's kind of
what we want that trajectory to look
like and to continue as. But now we've
got the really horrible uphill struggle.
Sevie Q's engine is online and if game
one was anything to go by that's a scary
time for ghost driver.
>> It really is. have a Shinsha, a Riptide
Rex, and an Honest Broker alongside the
Vengeance and the Imperial Decree.
Haven't really established a board state
for Imperial Decree to be as effective
as we'd like it to be. Mostly used in
combination with the Bellow's Breath. We
see Ghost of Driver taking their time
thinking about exactly how they want to
play this. I don't blame them in the
finals on the line on this game. We are
playing to 9, climbing up alongside the
other aspirants as all our players here
aspire to be the champion of the
regional qualifier in Bologna and Sebie
Cube in prime position to take one step
further up that staircase.
>> Let's see what the plays are going to
look like. We're just going to get some
more units on the board. We got to keep
building that base. We know how it it's
all about that base.
>> It's all about that base. No treble.
>> No trouble. In fact, for Zeb with the
dazzling aurora out Shinsaw, there a
pair of them.
>> What is this? Game five blind pick in
OGN.
>> We've just got a very niche reference
right there.
>> Very niche, my guy. Come on. I'm a TCG.
>> What is this two sh
is passed as you say. Build up the base.
Try and find your way out of this
because there are there are outs.
>> You've got kill spells are plenty.
You've got more salvages in your deck.
You've got Imperial Decree Bellow's
Breath. You have Imperial Decree six
units in base to go in and trade.
>> It's far from over. See still has a long
way to go to kind of get Ghost to Driver
in that lock that we had them in from
last game. There's a long way to go.
With two open battlefields, only one
unit currently in base for SebieQ
themselves. So, it could only actually
take one point this turn unless they're
able to accelerate something in. And the
chances
to none. It's only the MF, right? That's
the only thing you could bring in.
There's no real port real reason to
expend that resource right now. You can
just play on your opponent's turn as
much as possible. Stack your deck. Look
for every tool in your toolkit to deal
with what will be an attack eventually
from Ghost of Driver. Less than halfway
towards his goal of that nine points
though. See just taking their time. Has
two well has one more mind splitter in
the deck and two vols cuz there's one in
hand. and now gets that mind spplitter
out.
>> We have a look at what Ghost of Driver
has drawn since the last turn.
>> Honestly, a great time to play a
mindspplitter raw from hand as well
being able to take a look at this hand
once more. And there's some delectable
treats in there to choose from.
>> I think it's assault.
>> I think it's the decree. Sorry.
>> That's the only card there that can kill
multiple units. Vengeance is going to
kill one, but you have a last rights to
recur that if that happens. Riptide
rescuers as well going for
>> a change of mind. No, perhaps just
wanted to make sure they knew that that
was the Imperial decree. So, it is
vengeance in the trash for ghost driver.
It makes sense. It directly kills a
unit. I understand it. But Imperial
decree does do a lot of work. However,
you have to attack into it or have a
Bella's breath or a singularity
followup. True.
>> So, I do get the intention from See,
>> very understandable.
>> Going to hide what we expect to be a
fight or flight up towards that top
battlefield.
>> In with mind splitter. And here we go in
with the dazzling Aurora.
>> And there's another mind splitter. Which
>> Oh, we get another card.
>> Yeah. Which one do you want to take?
>> Yippee.
>> Decree or riptide? Yippee
>> decree. I think probably
>> yippi decree.
The crowd decrees.
>> Fantastic.
>> Oh, the support from the community is
absolutely exhilarating.
>> Yeah, it has been incredible across the
course of the weekend. And now as we get
into the later portions of the
tournament and the later portions of the
night as well. It's 900 p.m. as uh we
watch Sabiku alongside all of you at
home and the fans still here in the
venue with us. Mind splitter went to
that top battlefield. You want to avoid
something like a Riptide Rex doing the
extra damage at the void gate. We know
that's the only card left in hand.
>> And it's not that scary.
>> Yeah.
>> Seven to six and then a bit of six
damage kind of when it's played. That's
fine.
>> Mhm.
>> That's fine. The mind splitters are they
tower above that six at seven dam seven
might. So actually they're kind of okay
with it. They're not really the target
of those Riptide Rex. We're looking at
the misfortune for that. So actually in
a really sticky situation here where
finally Sebq seems to have that lock on
Ghost Driver's uh whole game plan
>> has assembled the pieces and Ghost to
Driver doesn't have a spanner to undo
the spanner that's been thrown into
their works for this game. Didn't quite
see what the card draw was for this turn
and can't see it from that angle either.
Thank you Production for trying though.
I appreciate it.
It is the Riptide Rex. Target the
Mindsplitter. You can chuck in a recruit
to do the damage here to kill off one of
these. We talked about already the
recursion with the last rights recycle
coming out. Those two mine runes needing
needing to go back and it's going to be
two recruits in because of that hidden
expected fight or flight. And there we
go. Two of them in. Just want to kill
off one of these mine splitters if we
can. Fight or flight. We'll target our
own mind spplitter and the two recruits
will die off.
>> One mind spplitter back, but it's only
got one health left, but that
regenerates at the end of the turn. He's
okay. He's going to put a plaster on and
get on with his day. But two go ahead
and take out the other mines spplitter
just doing whatever he can. The ghost
driver needs to start g regaining points
and getting back into the game.
>> Trying to get up towards that six mark
as well with the aspirin climb though.
Usually you look at increments of two,
the even numbers. Here we're a little
bit odd. We're looking for seven if you
can. Honest broker goes in to that void
gate. And now Seeq, no mind spplitters
left in the deck, which means only one
thing. There's a big bad bear on its way
at the end of this turn. Volibear in
imposing is going to get cracked out
from the dazzling Aurora sitting with
the last rights and imposing in hand as
well. So only one unit left in the deck.
here for Sebie Q.
>> We can get that out quite easily. We can
use the dazzling Aurora to
>> to employ that. But
>> we also thankfully have the last rights
in hand. And so we can use that for the
recursion on the mind spplitter that is
currently sitting in our trash.
>> The one thing I love about mindsplitter
is just being able to use that onplay
ability every single time. And a deck
like this employs it so perfectly.
It does such a good job. Goes to driver
though sitting without a hand. The
sunshaw will die to the mind spplitter.
See will go up to two. Second mines
spplitter is going to trade in with this
honest broker. Will have a gold gear
come in as the honest broker leaves
behind a little present for ghost
driver.
>> I think ghost driver will take all the
presents they can get in this scenario.
It is a tense top four game here between
these two decks. to unexpected rivals.
>> It really is. Seeu as well. I was going
to say holding on to this misfortune
might just be playing it out. There's
the risk with something like an Imperial
decree or even a cold the week or a
hidden blade that you do run out of
units. And even if you have a last
rights, if you don't have a unit to
equip that last rights onto, you're not
in a good spot cuz you can't procur
anything cuz you don't have a unit to go
and hold and conquer with. The last
rights will come down.
going to be equipped to the mind
spplitter.
>> Trying for the hold, I imagine, on that
one.
>> Put the mind spplitter back in the deck
to make it so that you don't need to
recur it later. That's the other option.
>> Dazzling Aurora to use it and get that
into play that way as well, which is
great.
>> We will hit the Volibear this turn
though cuz the mind spplitter
>> is at the bottom.
>> Yeah,
>> we know that
>> it must be beneath it. So, dazzling a
trigger. Volibear imposing is going to
come out. We'll see where it goes.
goes to driver knows there's only one
unit left. Well, doesn't know there's
only one unit left. Could think there's
two. There's the volley bear imposing.
What a surprise. It goes down to the
void gate on defense. 13 naturally 10.
The shield three obviously buffing it up
when you do have an attacking unit into
it.
>> An effective 13 against lots of recruit
tokens and a riptide rex is not a good
feeling. And I think that's why this
misfortune came down at that point as we
saw the Riptide Rex activation and then
you're not as fearful of it. You're
like, "Oh, okay. Well, I only saw one
last game. What are the chances of you
getting around to another one somehow if
there is one?
>> This is fine."
>> Yeah. Ghost driver taking their time to
make sure they properly note down the
cards that are going to the bottom.
We'll do a quick shuffle and I think
a relatively quick series this one so
far. 60 minutes for us to be nearing the
end of the third game. It feels both
these decks kind of have a very specific
game plan, not just cycling through like
a, you know, Miracle Draven, Miracle
Ezreal, those who have specific game
plans as well, but it tends to be a lot
more about looking at the top of your
deck.
>> These guys kind of have their engines
going,
>> but Sebu's engine is currently much more
fearsome.
>> One of them has a 1000 horsepower and
one of them has a few recruits power.
>> Yeah. And unfortunately, SebieQ is very
much on the way to the top of that
climb. Ghost to Driver technically ahead
in points, but on board state alone
really struggling. And another rift
bricks does come down. Takes damage
there on the mind.
>> Seven because of the void gate
>> because it does the extra damage with
the abilities
>> about the battlefield and that will kill
off the mind. I mean, it happens. You
saw See did the same overight put six on
it and then realize, oh, there's a void
gate here. You're absolutely right.
>> I do end up dying. See will get those
two whole points. There's no cards left
or no units left in Sebeekq's deck. The
Dazzling Aurora will trigger. Ghost
driver will be allowed to look through
every card in that library when it does.
Another Dazzling here. Immobilizer
catalyst and that Volibear imposing.
Doesn't really need to use any of them.
Can just use the catalyst for that
little bit of extra ramp. We just want
that little bit of extra oomph so that
we can kind of play things naturally. We
can hard cast them as some might say.
>> So we start off with the catalyst.
Channel 2 can play the mobilize off the
back of it, but also want to kind of
represent that we have something. We
want to have a hard bargain, a punch
first, something to make it a little bit
harder for ghost to driver. So we keep
the rest up. We'll be looking through
here. And if my maths is correct, and it
it's often not,
>> there shouldn't be a unit left for us to
find.
>> We've got
>> Oh, mind splitter. Oh, cuz of the
recycle of the last rights. Yeah, there
we are. It was on the bottom all along.
I told you it's often not.
>> But I forgot about the last rights
recycle. I thought it was uh still in
the trash, but there we are. That's the
last unit. Definitely. Possibly. Maybe.
>> No, that is definitely this time, but
yes. Uh the other mind spplitter went
back to the bottom because of the last
rights. And that was a great way of
using last rights to kind of cycle cards
that you want back into the deck, which
isn't often a thing. Often if it goes to
the bottom, it is stuck there forever.
Not in this instance. Dazzling decks do
have a great recursion instance in its
own right there.
>> Ghoster Driver can actually work out
that SEQ has a Volibear in hand. That's
true
>> because we recycled the mind splitter
and hit it before hitting another volat.
>> Whether that is something that affects
how Ghost of Driver plays the next turns
is something that only they know. They
have much more experience with how they
want to play the Victor deck than we
have on the desk here.
>> I don't think that it would give away a
lot. Volat doesn't have I mean like it's
got power. It's got more strength, but
it doesn't have any abilities that would
otherwise kind of affect Ghostaster
Driver's main game plan in any
considerable way than is already being
achieved.
>> We'll see what we get off the top here
for Ghost to Driver. It is top deck
central. Population one and a few
recruits and a couple of sharks. Another
recruit being formed.
>> We're sitting at
>> seven, I believe, available. Honest
broker coming down. Not really what you
want to see. Feels like we're in that
same position
>> that we have been in before where the
struggle becomes that SevieQ is now
gaining on us in points and we just
don't have the power to fight back.
>> Also having that mindset to get rid of
the thousand tail watcher that ghost
ghostaster driver was sitting on is
huge.
>> Makes it so much harder for the victor
to come back. We're looking at something
again like an Imperial decree. The hold
trigger comes out for Sebq can bring
back the mind spplitter would have to
pay for it. Importantly, last rights
doesn't just give you it for free.
>> No, you got to pay for it. But we do
have the money. Well,
>> energy.
>> Yeah, we do. Yeah, we do.
>> So, we could well do that. It can come
back.
>> I have been informed the other match has
concluded. Allen going through 2-1. We
will have a non Draven champion here.
Ezreal versus the winner. It could be
Sebiku versus Allen as well. What a
finals that would be. Ghost of Driver
though trying to spoil it for a few of
the fans here in the arena trying to
upset the Apple Car.
>> Well, I'm a fan of Ghost of Driver. I
like the Victor deck very much. I think
it's doing a great job thus far. shown
some real strength in this event and
honestly I'm just excited to see who
manages to pull fourth and just gain
those last few points. We're coming up
to the end of this top four best of
three. We're in game three here in
Bologna and we are making these
battlefields big
>> that we are Volibar posing a hand a
fight or flight. We'll see where Sebu
decides to put that representing double
punch first in terms of runes
as we see the dazzling Aurora trigger go
off and Sebu will have to reveal the
fact there are no more units in the
deck.
>> This is where we're wrong and there is
another one.
>> I mean it would have been sideboarded
in. Like I'll be honest, I'm happy to
accept that my math was wrong once
because I forgot about the last rights.
>> I'm just kidding.
>> This time I am entirely correct. That
deck will be shuffled. Ghost driver
riding out what could be in the hand.
Can take their time about this as well.
Can work it out. We'll see
>> one Aurora sitting there, meaning the
other one must be in the hand. Can work
out if there's a fight or flight
available, too.
>> We have to remember this is open deck
list. They have had a chance to look at
each other's list. They know what counts
are in there. And if they were able to
kind of take a good glance and a
memorize of that, you could work out
what's in hand here. the the deduction
in method can be employed. The trash is
visible. We can look through that at any
time. The only thing you don't have
access to is their hands. So, those four
cards can be deducted if you're clever
enough.
>> Here we go. Ghost of Driver needs
something big this turn. A watcher might
be enough. An imperial decree will
definitely cause some problems. It is
the watcher.
>> Watcher. Okay, at the bottom we have 20.
Watcher goes down. Cheers coming out as
we see the maths being done.
I wonder is that just is it done? No.
Ghoster driver still paying for the
watcher. At the bottom we have 20 - 6 is
14. At the top we have 9 + 7 16 plus the
MF.
>> They've got a long way to go yet.
We need three more points to win because
of the extra climb. We'll put some dice
on here just to mark the fact that
everything is minus three.
>> We need to make sure that we remember
and do our mathematics correctly.
>> Yeah. The important thing is like Seb if
they hold both they go to nine, right?
So ghost driver wants to make sure they
don't do that and also wants to make
sure that the last rights doesn't hold
to bring something back because then you
are still trying to conquer the other
battlefield. Where are we going to go? I
think we have to try for the top
battlefield to
>> But when we do that, Volibear draws a
card cuz you're moving to the other
battlefield. Do you want to give seq
more card draw or do you go to this
bottom? Try and get through this 14
>> first. I don't We can't do both. But
then the last rights, what's riskier?
One card or a guaranteed recursion?
>> I mean, it's a great question. At the
top, it's 21 - 9 is 12. At the bottom is
14.
because of those minus threes to all
enemy units.
>> I think we got to go for the climb. I
think we got to go Aspirin's climb.
>> I'm wrong.
>> We're going to the void gate.
>> We're taking a journey. Taking a ride.
The recruits have been recruited. A
fight or flight remains in Seek's hand.
Can bounce this watcher.
Can take the trade. Volibear has to be
assigned damage first as well. Has that
tank keyword
on defense is 10.
Bounce the watcher. There's only eight
remaining. Fight or flight. That watcher
is returning whence it came.
>> Back you go.
>> And now you can't kill the volley. You
don't have the damage huge here for
Seeue as ghosted driver tried to play
around it but couldn't escape the fight
or flight.
>> The fight or flight. It might be a cheap
spell but it works a treat in scenarios
like this. Unfortunately, Ghoster Driver
just might not have enough this turn.
We've got to try and take over at least
one of these two battlefields. We still
have the Riptide Rex. We have how much
power otherwise? We have a Victor. We
have enough to go back in for another
swing, but whether Sebby Q can then pull
more tricks up their from up their
sleeve, we've still got the potential of
punches. We've still got the potential
of more throwbacks.
>> So, you're you're playing around that.
We know SeekQu doesn't have that.
>> Oh, yeah. We know SEQ just has the
imposing body there. The fist bump comes
out. See Q will be going to the finals.
>> A match made in heaven against Allen ZQ.
A destined arrival for the two in the
top two.
>> Gods do not beg. We take what is ours.
Volibear imposing amongst the absolute
treasure trove of misfortune has brought
victory.
>> Yes. And so many small things leading to
it as well. Getting rid of the salvage
early. Huge elation. See as the crowd
locks him high. Going to the finals
looking for
that blade of the ruin king prize and of
course the prize money will be facing
off against Allen ZQ. What a performance
all round. The finals will be live and
will be televised right here. I cannot
wait to see who brings home the trophy.
>> An exhilarating game with twists and
turns and many. We went to a game of
three with two really unlikely decks and
I love seeing it. I think it's one of
the magical things about Riftbound is
that we can actually have a really
diverse meta even when people think it's
a bit more closed off. And even though
we're in our fledgling event here in
Bologna in the uh Europe kind of region,
>> it doesn't feel like it. It feels like
we've been here for a very long time and
we have physically, but the game is
still quite new. So, there's still a
long way to go and that is in regards to
deck building and accomplishments, but
we're making some real history here
today.
>> Incredible performance all around by all
of the players. Obviously, commiseration
to go to Driver, bringing the Victor all
the way to the semi-finals. I think a a
a sequence not many people expected to
happen. We're going we're going through
the void gate. We're going into the
portals. We're going in and out. There
is your bracket for the top eight.
Allen's EQ going all the way with the
Ezreal. No Dravens in the semifinals.
Crows taken out by Allen's EQ. And I
think a lot of people would have been
surprised by this. I will say yesterday
when we did an interview, I did predict
the Ezreal winning the whole thing. So,
>> you did?
>> You know, I don't think anyone else
predicted Misfortune.
>> No, I've got to say that wasn't on my
bingo card, but there are some great
best of that we can see right here as
well. a really great diverse cast for